GOOD MORNING EVERYONE. ALL
RIGHT, SO WE HAVE ONE DEPARTMENT
TODAY, DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. WE'RE GOING TO BE
TALKING ABOUT SOME CHILD WELFARE
ISSUES, SOME CHILD CARE TOPICS,
AND THEN WE'LL DO PUBLIC COMMENT
ONCE AT THE END OF ALL THE
TOPICS THAT IN BETWEEN AND,
STRAP IN IS GOING TO BE A LONG
CONVERSATION. WE'RE ALREADY I'M
GONNA ASK FOR SOMEONE TO ORDER A
PIZZA LATER ON TO KEEP US GOING,
BUT LOOKING FORWARD TO SOME NEW
PROPOSALS. WE'RE HERE. WE'LL
HEAR TODAY SOME EXCITING NEWS,
WE'LL GET TO TALK ABOUT. AND
THEN SOME. NOT EXCITING NEWS
THAT I'M NOT LOOKING FORWARD TO
TALK ABOUT, BUT IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT. SO LET'S GET IT
STARTED. WE HAVE, AS ALWAYS, A
COUPLE OF PANELS THAT WILL HELP
US GUIDE THE CONVERSATION.
THÀNH. AND WE'RE GOING TO START
OFF WITH GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
CUTS TO CHILD WELFARE WELFARE
PROGRAMS. WE'RE GOING TO ASK,
THE JENNIFER, I SAID, I'M NOT
GOING TO SAY ANYONE'S NAME.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
INTRODUCE YOURSELVES BECAUSE I
KEEP BUTCHERING IT. WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE THE DEPARTMENT COME ON
UP, PLEASE. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, LÀ Ó. AND THEN I'M
GOING TO ASK BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH CHAIRS FOR ALL THE
PANELISTS. I KNOW SOME PANELISTS
ARE SPLITTING THEIR TIME BETWEEN
ANOTHER PERSON. I'M GOING TO ASK
THAT JB, THE FIRST SPEAKER, COME
UP. THE FIRST SPEAKER FOR L.A.
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF CHILDREN
AND FAMILY SERVICES COME UP. THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO COUNTY, AND I'M NOT
SURE IF WE'LL HAVE ROOM FROM
ANYONE ELSE. SO JB. I THINK WE
HAVE ROOM FOR EVERYONE. L.A.
COUNTY DCFS IS. FOSTER TO ADOPT
PARENT. CALIFORNIA YOUTH
CONNECTION. WE MIGHT HAVE ROOM
FOR EVERYONE THEN, OKAY, THEN.
OKAY, IF YOU'RE ON THIS PANEL,
YOU MAY COME FORWARD. GREAT.
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR, I'LL HAVE
YOU KICK US OFF. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, JENNIFER TROIA, ON
BEHALF OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. YOU'VE ASKED US
TO KICK OFF THIS MORNING TALKING
ABOUT THE PROPOSALS TO ELIMINATE
FUNDING FOR THE FAMILY URGENT
RESPONSE SYSTEM, REFERRED TO AS
FERS, THE SUPERVISED INDEPENDENT
LIVING PLACEMENT SUPPLEMENT, AND
THE L.A. PUBLIC HEALTH NURSING
PROGRAM. IN THE CASE OF THE SILK
BRAID, I'LL ALSO ADDRESS HOW THE
PROPOSED FOSTER CARE RATE REFORM
INVESTS IN THE SIBS. APPRECIATE
YOUR QUESTIONS ABOUT THESE
PROPOSALS AND YOUR RECOGNITION
THAT ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS AT CDSS
IMPACT PEOPLE EXPERIENCING NEED
OR VULNERABILITY. SO ANY
PROPOSED REDUCTIONS ARE VERY
DIFFICULT. THE CHOICES THAT WE
ARE FACING AS THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE LEGISLATURE, IN LIGHT OF
THE STATE'S FISCAL SITUATION,
ARE INDEED VERY DIFFICULT. AND
ULTIMATELY, WE'LL BE SUBJECT TO
THE FINAL NEGOTIATIONS OF THE
BUDGET PROCESS. YOU ASKED ABOUT
THE ANTICIPATED EFFECTS OF THE
PROPOSAL TO DEFUND FERS. AS A
REMINDER, FIRST, PROVIDES CRISIS
SUPPORTS IN THE FORM OF A 24
OVER SEVEN STATEWIDE HOTLINE AND
IN PERSON COUNTY MOBILE RESPONSE
UNITS. ANNUALLY, THE HOTLINE
RECEIVES AROUND 5000 CALLS FROM
CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
CAREGIVERS AND OTHER COMMUNITY
SUPPORTERS. WHAT WE WOULD
EMPHASIZE IS THAT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WOULD NEED TO
UTILIZE OTHER RESOURCES, SUCH AS
THOSE PROVIDED BY THEIR HEALTH
PLANS OR THOSE THAT ARE PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE IN LIEU OF UTILIZING
FERS. WHILE WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THESE RESOURCES ARE NOT SPECIFIC
TO FOSTER YOUTH AND THEIR
CAREGIVERS, IT MIGHT BE HELPFUL
TO POINT OUT THAT THEY COULD
INCLUDE RESOURCES LIKE CAL HOPE,
WHICH PROVIDES FREE SUPPORTS TO
INDIVIDUALS IN CRISIS. AND
WITHIN CAL HOPE, THERE'S A
PROGRAM CALLED BRIGHT LIFE KIDS,
WHICH PROVIDES MENTAL HEALTH
COACHING AND RESOURCES FOR
PARENTS OF CHILDREN AGES 0 TO
12, OR RESOURCES LIKE SOLUNA,
WHICH PROVIDES CONFIDENTIAL
SUPPORT LIKE COACHING AND
RESOURCES FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES FOR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH AGES 13 TO
25. MOVING TO THE SILP
SUPPLEMENT. THE SILP SUPPLEMENT
WAS ADOPTED IN 2023 TO BETTER
ALIGN THE SILP RATES WITH
COUNTY'S FAIR MARKET RENTS. THE
SUPPLEMENT HAS NOT YET TAKEN
EFFECT AND WILL REQUIRE
AUTOMATION BEFORE IT DOES SO.
PRESENTLY YOUTH AND SLPS RECEIVE
FUNDING EQUAL TO THE LEVEL OF
CARE BASIC RATE UNDER THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES OF CURRENT
LAW. SO $1,206 PER MONTH. THE
SUPPLEMENT WAS BUDGETED TO COST
AROUND AN ADDITIONAL $19 MILLION
IN GENERAL FUND. RESOURCES. IT'S
BASED ON A CALCULATION OF THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN FAIR MARKET
RENT FOR A TWO BEDROOM APARTMENT
AND 30% OF THAT BASIC RATE UNDER
CURRENT LAW, WHILE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET'S NO LONGER
PROPOSING TO FUND THE SILP
SUPPLEMENT IN THE OUT YEARS, OUR
BUDGET DOES PROPOSE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN SILP RATES ALONG
WITH OTHER RATES IN THE
PERMANENT FOSTER CARE RATE
STRUCTURE PROPOSAL, WHICH WE'LL
BE TALKING ABOUT ON THE NEXT
PANEL. THE PROPOSED SILP RATES
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
BECOME $1,788 FOR CARE AND
SUPERVISION AND ANOTHER 500 FOR
STRAKES BUILDING. SO THE TOTAL
IS 2288. AS A REMINDER, UNDER
THE PRESENT SYSTEM, IT'S 1206.
THE PROPOSED ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT IN SILP RATES UNDER
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS
APPROXIMATELY $33 MILLION.
GENERAL FUND. SO FOR THE VAST
MAJORITY OF YOUTH LIVING IN
SLPS, THE SILP RATE UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED RATE REFORM
IS A SIGNIFICANTLY LARGER
BENEFIT THAN THE CURRENT SILP
RATE. PLUS, THE SUPPLEMENT. AND
THE FINAL TOPIC IS THE LA COUNTY
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSING PROGRAM.
THE ENACTING LEGISLATION FOR
THAT PROGRAM IDENTIFIED US AT
CHS AS THE STATE AGENCY
RESPONSIBLE FOR PASSING THROUGH
GENERAL FUNDS TO LA COUNTY TO
CREATE THIS PREVENTION PROGRAM.
WE DON'T HAVE MORE ACTIVE
INVOLVEMENT IN OR OVERSIGHT IN
THE PROGRAM, BUT THE STATUTE
DOES SPECIFY HOW THE FUNDING IS
TO BE USED, INCLUDING FOR HIRING
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES,
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT STAFF.
TO DATE, WE'VE RECEIVED FIVE
INVOICES FOR A TOTAL OF AROUND
$600,000 IN THIS PROGRAM. UNDER
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL,
LA COUNTY WOULD NEED TO IDENTIFY
ALTERNATIVE FUNDING SOURCES TO
SUPPORT THE WORK THAT THEY BEGAN
IN 2023. THROUGH THAT FUNDING OR
TO REDUCE THE SERVICES BEING
PROVIDED. WITH THAT, I'LL
CONCLUDE, BUT I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. YOU MENTIONED,
I THINK, THREE PROGRAMS THAT
COULD BE REPLACEMENTS FOR FIRST
CHAU HOPE. WAS IT BRIGHT LIGHTS?
YEAH BRIGHT LIFE IS A PART OF
CAL HOPE, AND I AGAIN WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THEY ARE NOT
DIRECTLY TARGETED ONLY AT FOSTER
YOUTH AND CAREGIVERS AND THE WAY
THAT FORS ARE THERE MORE
GENERALLY PUBLICLY AVAILABLE.
BUT THEY DO PROVIDE RESOURCES.
SO IT WAS, BRIGHT, BRIGHT LIFE,
HOPE OR BRIGHT LIFE. KIDS WHICH
IS A CAL HOPE PROGRAM. IT'S
MENTAL HEALTH COACHING AND
RESOURCES FOR PARENTS AND
CHILDREN AGES 0 TO 12. SO LUNA,
WHICH IS CONFIDENTIAL, SUPPORTS
COACHING AND RESOURCES FOR TEENS
AND YOUTH UP TO AGE 25. AND CAL
HOPE IS A HOTLINE MORE BROADLY.
DO YOU KNOW IF THESE ARE, 24
OVER SEVEN? YES. CAL HOPE IS 24
SEVEN. IT IS OPERATED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. SO I CAN DO MY BEST TO
ANSWER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS YOU
HAVE ABOUT IT. ONE LAST QUESTION
ON THAT ONE. DO YOU KNOW, IS
THIS GRACE 24 OVER SEVEN? DO YOU
KNOW IF IT'S THEY HAVE TO GO TO
THE TO A BRICK AND MORTAR TYPE
OF FACILITY, OR THEY CAN CALL
IT'S A HOTLINE. IT'S A HOTLINE.
GREAT OKAY. THANK YOU. AND THEN
ON THE THIRD QUESTION FOR THE LA
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSING PROGRAM,
DID I HEAR CORRECTLY THAT LA HAS
SPENT APPROXIMATELY 600,000 OF
IT ALREADY? CORRECT. SO THEY
WOULD HAVE TO FIND FUNDING TO
COVER THAT BECAUSE WE'RE THE
PROPOSAL IS NOT TO COVER THAT.
OKAY. CORRECT. OKAY. THANK YOU,
OUR NEXT SPEAKER, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, WOULD YOU LIKE TO ADD
ANYTHING TO THAT? SURE. MARLENE
DAVIS, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE,
THE GOVERNOR'S 20 2425 BUDGET
PROPOSES VARIOUS SOLUTIONS IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS THE STATE'S
BUDGET DEFICIT, THE AGENDA
OUTLINES THE THREE BUDGET
SOLUTIONS PROPOSED IN THE CHILD
WELFARE POLICY AREA. AND ALL
THREE CASES. THE SOLUTIONS
REFLECT DIFFICULT DECISIONS IN
ORDER TO ACHIEVE A BALANCED
BUDGET. DESPITE THESE SOLUTIONS,
THE ADMINISTRATION REMAINS,
COMMITTED TO THE WELL-BEING OF
CHILDREN IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM, AS REFLECTED IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
ESTABLISH A NEW PERMANENT RATE
STRUCTURE FOR FOSTER YOUTH. AS
JENNIFER, ALREADY, SPOKE ABOUT,
WHICH IS IN THE NEXT AGENDA. AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUED
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ON HOW TO HOW WE CAN ADOPT A
BALANCED BUDGET. MR. DAVIS, I'M
WONDERING THERE ARE VERY FEW
PROGRAMS THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSED FOR COMPLETE CUTS
ELIMINATED. IT'S EXCEPT FOR
CHILD WELFARE AND CALWORKS WERE
VERY UNIQUE IN THE MATTER THAT
THESE WERE THE ONLY ALMOST THE
ONLY AREAS THAT HAVE COMPLETE
ELIMINATION. DO WE FEEL LIKE
YOUR YOUR BACKUP IS COMING TO BE
ABLE TO ANSWER THAT ONE? I JUST
WONDER WHY IT'S SO UNIQUE THAT
IT'S JUST THESE AREAS THAT ARE
BEING PROPOSED FOR JUST COMPLETE
ELIMINATION. I GET YOUR POINT
THAT AT THE SAME TIME,
SIMULTANEOUSLY, IN THE NEXT
TOPIC, WE'RE GOING TO BE HEARING
ABOUT THIS WONDERFUL RATE REFORM
OR THE INTENT IS REALLY
WONDERFUL, BUT NOT ALL OF IT
WILL COVER SOME OF THE CUTS THAT
WERE, WERE PROPOSING. WAS THERE
ANYTHING ELSE CONSIDERED IN THAT
, IN THAT THOUGHT PROCESS? GOOD
MORNING, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE,
SO I THINK, FOR THESE SPECIFIC
PROPOSALS, WE ARE PROPOSING
REDUCTION, ONGOING REDUCTIONS TO
REALLY HELP ADDRESS THE BUDGET
DEFICIT IN THE OUT YEARS,
BECAUSE, AS YOU ARE AWARE, IT'S
NOT ONLY JUST LIKE IN THE IN THE
BUDGET YEAR, BUT THE, YOU KNOW,
THE FOLLOWING SEVERAL FISCAL
YEARS ARE ALSO PROJECTED TO
HAVE, BUDGET DEFICITS. I
RECOGNIZE THAT. I GUESS I SHOULD
REFRAME, I SHOULD REPHRASE MY
QUESTION. I KNOW WE NEED TO MAKE
CUTS FOR ONGOING FOR THE NEXT
COUPLE OF YEARS, BECAUSE I DON'T
WANT TO PASS THE BUCK TO MY
FUTURE SELF, SINCE WE'LL HAVE TO
ADDRESS THAT PROBLEM IN THE
FUTURE. WITH THAT IN MIND, WHEN
WE'RE LOOKING AT WHAT WE NEED TO
CUT PERMANENTLY TO ADDRESS NOW
IN FUTURE YEARS, WHY WAS IT
UNIQUE THAT CHILD WELFARE AND
CALWORKS WERE ONE OF THE ONLY
ONES THAT GOT PERMANENT CUTS?
WHEN WE WERE DECIDING ON WHAT TO
PERMANENTLY CUT TO SAVE DOLLARS?
WHY IS IT, LIKE THE GENTLEMAN IN
HERE WITH THIS PIN? WHY THESE
CUTS AND WHY THESE KIDS? WOULD
JUST SAY THAT THESE REDUCTIONS
ARE PART OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
APPROACH TO ADDRESS THE BUDGET
SHORTFALL. BUT WE RECOGNIZE
THESE ARE DIFFICULT CUTS, AND
IT'S PROPOSED. IT'S NOT FINAL.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO ENGAGING WITH
YOU GUYS ON ALTERNATIVES, THAT
YOU GUYS MIGHT HAVE TO HELP
ADDRESS THE BUDGET DEFICIT. OKAY
OKAY. BECAUSE IN MY HEAD, I'M
JUST PICTURING IT WAS LIKE THE,
LIKE, WE'RE BLINDFOLDED, THERE'S
A DONKEY, AND WE'RE JUST PUTTING
THE PIN. AND WHEN WE WENT TO CUT
, TRYING TO MAKE LIGHT OF THIS
DIFFICULT SITUATION HERE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR RESPONSE.
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
NOW ALLOW. GOOD MORNING. ANGELA
SHORT WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE, BEFORE DIVING
INTO A FEW SPECIFIC COMMENTS,
I'LL START WITH JUST, SOME
GENERAL COMMENTS, WHICH ARE, I
THINK, REINFORCING THEMES THAT
HAVE ALREADY COME UP IN THIS
HEARING, AS THIS SUBCOMMITTEE IS
KEENLY AWARE, THE LEGISLATURE IS
FACING A VERY DIFFICULT, BUDGET
SITUATION THIS YEAR. AND LIKELY
MORE DIFFICULT CHOICES WILL NEED
TO BE MADE IN FUTURE YEARS GIVEN
PROJECTIONS OF ONGOING BUDGET
DEFICITS IN THE OUT YEARS. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PRESENTS ONE
COMBINATION OF SOLUTIONS
PROPOSED TO ADDRESS THE
ESTIMATED BUDGET PROBLEM.
HOWEVER, THE LEGISLATURE VERY
WELL MAY HAVE DIFFERENT
PRIORITIES IN TERMS OF MAKING
REDUCTIONS, USING RESERVES, AND
OTHERWISE TAKING ACTIONS TO HELP
ADDRESS THE BUDGET PROBLEM, AS
YOU JUST NOTED, CHAIR MENGIBAR,
WE WOULD ALSO UNDERSCORE THAT WE
FOUND IT NOTABLE THAT ACROSS THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET, THERE ARE
VERY FEW PROPOSED REDUCTIONS TO
ESTABLISHED ONGOING PROGRAMS.
THE PROPOSED CUTS TO CALWORKS
AND THE CHILD WELFARE PROGRAMS
WE'RE DISCUSSING TODAY DO APPEAR
TO BE UNIQUE IN THAT WAY, THAT
SAID, AT MAY REVISION AND IN
FINAL BUDGET DISCUSSIONS, MOST
LIKELY ONGOING REDUCTIONS WILL
NEED TO BE MADE TO SOME PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE BUDGET. BUT AGAIN,
THE LEGISLATURE MAY HAVE
DIFFERENT PRIORITIES IN TERMS OF
WHERE EXACTLY TO MAKE THOSE CUTS
AND HOW TO BALANCE, PROGRAMMATIC
REDUCTIONS WITH OTHER BUDGETARY
SOLUTIONS, THAT SAID, I'LL JUMP
INTO JUST A FEW SPECIFIC
COMMENTS ABOUT THE INDIVIDUAL
REDUCTION PROPOSALS HERE FOR
CHILD WELFARE. FIRST, IN TERMS
OF FUNDING FOR FERS, WE WOULD
NOTE THAT COUNTIES TO DATE HAVE
NOT BEEN FULLY EXPENDING THEIR
ALLOCATIONS, THIS COULD IN PART
BE BECAUSE THE PROGRAM HAS BEEN
RAMPING UP, BEGINNING IN 20
1920, OF COURSE, CORRESPONDING
WITH THE COVID PANDEMIC PERIOD.
THEREFORE, IT MIGHT BE A LITTLE
BIT OF AN ANOMALY, BUT EVEN IN
THE CURRENT YEAR, WE, BASED ON
THE INFORMATION WE HAVE, IT DOES
SEEM THAT COUNTIES ARE NOT ON
TRACK TO FULLY EXPEND THEIR
ALLOCATIONS. THEREFORE, THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO CONSIDER
POSSIBLY REDUCING FUNDING FOR
FERS RATHER THAN FULLY
ELIMINATING FUNDING, IF THAT
COULD BE POSSIBLE WITHOUT,
NEGATIVELY IMPACTING INTENDED
BENEFICIARIES. WE WOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT EXPENDITURE TRENDS ARE
OF COURSE DIFFERENT ACROSS
COUNTIES. SOME COUNTIES HAVE
BEEN SPENDING MORE OF THEIR
ALLOCATIONS THAN OTHERS, SO THAT
WOULD BE SOMETHING TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION, THE LEGISLATURE
MAY ALSO WISH TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
WHAT IS CAUSING THIS UNDERSPEND.
HAVE THERE BEEN PARTICULAR
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES OR
JUST IN OTHER WORDS, WHAT IS
HAPPENING? BASICALLY THAT THE
THAT THE FULL 30 MILLION GENERAL
FUND HAS NOT BEEN EXPENDED TO
DATE, SECOND, IN TERMS OF THE
SILK HOUSING RATE SUPPLEMENT, AS
YOU HEARD FROM THE DEPARTMENT,
THIS ISSUE VERY MUCH INTERACTS
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL FOR THE NEW PERMANENT
FOSTER CARE RATE STRUCTURE. SO I
THINK WE'LL PROBABLY GET INTO
MORE OF THAT IN THE NEXT ISSUE.
BUT JUST FLAGGING THAT
INTERACTION, WHILE THE REDUCTION
OF THE CURRENT RATE SUPPLEMENT
PROPOSAL IS INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET, THERE WOULD
BE NEW AUGMENTATION FOR SILK
FUNDING INCLUDED AS PART OF THAT
RATE SUPPLEMENT. IT'S NOT
EXACTLY 1 TO 1, BUT THERE IS
THERE IS THAT TRADE OFF THERE
AND THEN FINALLY, REGARDING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO ELIMINATE
THE HOUSING NAVIGATORS PROGRAM,
WE RECOGNIZE THIS IS NOT UNDER
DSS, SO THE DEPARTMENT LIKELY
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO SPEAK TO
THIS, TODAY. BUT WE DID JUST
WANT TO FLAG OUR UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT COUNTY CHILD WELFARE
AGENCIES DO USE FUNDING FROM
THAT PROGRAM, TO OR I SHOULD SAY
SOME OF THAT FUNDING FROM THAT
PROGRAM TO FUND FEDERALLY
REQUIRED CASE MANAGEMENT
SERVICES FOR FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
WHO RECEIVE FEDERAL HOUSING
VOUCHERS. THEREFORE WE WOULD
FLAG THAT ELIMINATING THE
GENERAL FUND RESOURCES FOR THAT
PROGRAM COULD ULTIMATELY RESULT
IN A LOSS OF FEDERAL DOLLARS AND
FEDERAL HOUSING VOUCHERS FOR
THOSE YOUTH, I'LL STOP THERE AND
HAPPY TO HELP ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. ANGELA, DO
YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON THE LÀ
PUBLIC NURSING PILOT PROGRAM,
FOR THAT PROGRAM, WE WOULD NOTE.
I MEAN, AS YOU'VE HEARD, IT'S
BEEN SLOW TO RAMP UP, AGAIN, IN
PART, THIS WAS BECAUSE OF THE
COVID PANDEMIC PERIOD. YOU KNOW,
RAMPING UP A PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE
PROGRAM WHEN PUBLIC HEALTH
RESOURCES NEEDED TO BE FOCUSED
AND DEDICATED TO THE PANDEMIC
CERTAINLY WAS A CHALLENGE, THAT
SAID, THE PROGRAM, YOU KNOW, HAS
SPENT LESS THAN $1 MILLION TO
DATE WITH AN ANNUAL ALLOCATION
OF 8.3 MILLION GENERAL FUNDS. I
THINK WE WOULD ALSO NOTE, THIS
PROGRAM WAS INTENDED TO BE A
PILOT, BUT WE HAVE PROVIDED OR
IN THE PAST, IN PAST BUDGETS, WE
HAVE PROVIDED ONGOING RESOURCES.
SO AGAIN, IT COULD JUST BE
SOMETHING FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER FOR, YOU KNOW, WHETHER
TO CONSIDER WHETHER TO CONTINUE
TO PRIORITIZE GENERAL FUND
RESOURCES DURING A VERY
DIFFICULT BUDGET SITUATION FOR
SUCH A PROGRAM. THANK YOU, CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR, IF THE SOAPS,
ENHANCEMENT WERE TO MOVE
FORWARD, WHEN WOULD BE THE
EARLIEST WE COULD SEE THOSE? THE
RATES PROPOSAL IS NOT, EXPECTED
TO TAKE EFFECT UNTIL 2627. SO
THAT'S BECAUSE OF AUTOMATION
GUIDANCE, A NUMBER OF THINGS
THAT ARE INVOLVED IN THE
COMPLEXITIES OF IMPLEMENTING THE
NEW RATES. BUT AGAIN, I WOULD
EMPHASIZE THAT THE SUPPLEMENT IS
ALSO NOT CURRENTLY IN EFFECT. SO
EVEN IF WE EVEN IF WE WERE ABLE
TO PUT THAT BACK IN, WHEN WOULD
WE SEE THE RATE REFORM KICK IN?
THAT INCLUDES INCREASES TO
SOAPS, THAT'S WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT. TAKING EFFECT IN 2627. SO
LET ME LET ME REPHRASE THAT. SO
WITHOUT THE RATE REFORM
IMPLEMENTATION PART OUT OF IT,
JUST IF WE'RE JUST LOOKING AT
THE SOAP SUPPLEMENT, YES. OH I
SEE I THINK THE SOAP SUPPLEMENT
IS IT 2526. WELL WE HAVEN'T
STARTED AUTOMATION YET. WE NEED
TO AUTOMATE FIRST. I THINK THE
PLAN SIX, THE ORIGINAL PLAN WAS
2526 IN THE IN LIGHT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THAT
AUTOMATION HAS BEEN A LITTLE BIT
PAUSED. SO I THINK WE WOULD HAVE
TO REASSESS WHETHER WE WOULD
STILL BE ON TRACK FOR 25, 26 OR
WHETHER THERE WOULD BE, BUT
POTENTIALLY IT WOULD BE AT THE
START TIME AS THE SAME AS THE
RATE REFORM, THE SAME OR JUST A
LITTLE BIT EARLIER. YES. OKAY
OKAY. OKAY. ALL RIGHT, MOVING ON
TO OUR ADVOCATE FROM JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH, WHO IS? I'M
NOT. OH, THERE WE GO. THERE WE
GO. IT WASN'T LIGHT UP. GOOD.
GOOD MORNING. NOT AFTERNOON, MY
NAME IS SIMONE TUREK LEE WITH
JOHN BURTON. ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH
. I'M HERE TO ASK YOU TO
PRESERVE. ASK THE COMMITTEE TO
PRESERVE THE SUPERVISED
INDEPENDENT LIVING PLACEMENT,
HOUSING SUPPLEMENT IN THE STATE
BUDGET. THE HOUSING SUPPLEMENT.
IT WOULD INCREASE MONTHLY
PAYMENTS THAT FOSTER YOUTH
RECEIVED WHO ARE PLACED IN SLPS.
AND IT WOULD BASE THAT INCREASE
ON THE LOCAL COST OF HOUSING.
THE SOCIAL HOUSING SUPPLEMENT
WAS ESTABLISHED LAST YEAR AND IS
DUE TO TAKE EFFECT IN 2025. AS
WE JUST SAID, PENDING AUTOMATION
CHANGES. AS BACKGROUND, THE SLP
IS THE ONLY PLACEMENT WHERE
YOUTH IDENTIFY AND SECURE THEIR
OWN HOUSING AND WHERE THEY
RECEIVE THEIR THEIR MONTHLY
FOSTER CARE RATE DIRECTLY, WHICH
IS CURRENTLY $1,206 PER MONTH.
THIS RATE IS INTENDED TO COVER
FOOD, CLOTHING, SHELTER, SCHOOL
SUPPLIES, PERSONAL INCIDENTALS,
AND REASONABLE TRAVEL. AS YOU
CAN IMAGINE, 1200 A MONTH
DOESN'T CUT IT MOST OF OUR STATE
TO COVER THOSE COSTS. THESE ARE
YOUTH WHO ARE OFTEN THEIR OWN
HEAD OF HOUSEHOLD. THEY ARE NOT
JOINING A CAREGIVERS HOME,
LEVERAGING THE EXISTING UTILITY
BILL, MEALS, TRANSPORTATION,
ETC. THEY'RE COVERING ALL THESE
COSTS ON THEIR OWN. THIS HOUSING
SUPPLEMENT WAS ADOPTED LAST YEAR
FOR THREE KEY REASONS. FIRST,
$1,200 IS NOT ENOUGH TO ACHIEVE
STABLE HOUSING. AT THIS RATE,
FOSTER YOUTH ARE LIVING IN DEEP
POVERTY ON AN ANNUAL INCOME OF
LESS THAN $15,000 A YEAR. THIS
IS A REASON THAT 81% OR EXCUSE
ME, THERE IS A REASON THAT 81%
OF 18 AND 19 YEAR OLDS IN THE
GENERAL POPULATION LIVE WITH
THEIR PARENTS. WE HAVE AN
EXTREMELY CHALLENGING HOUSING
MARKET IN OUR STATE. SECOND,
IT'S NOT AN EQUITABLE APPROACH
TO HAVE A STATEWIDE UNIFORM RATE
FOR A PLACEMENT WHERE YOUTH ARE
NAVIGATING THE RENTAL MARKET AS
HEAD OF THEIR OWN HOUSEHOLD.
WITH THE VAST RANGE OF RENTAL
PRICES ACROSS CALIFORNIA'S 58
COUNTIES. THIRD, THESE ARE
YOUTH. WE HAVE A CURRENT LEGAL
OBLIGATION TO NO DIFFERENT THAN
MINOR FOSTER YOUTH. 1 IN 5 OF
THEM EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS
BETWEEN 18 AND 20 WHILE IN CARE,
PUTTING THEM AT HEIGHTENED RISK
FOR CHRONIC ADULT HOMELESSNESS.
WE WOULD NOT ACCEPT THIS FOR OUR
OWN CHILDREN. NOW, WITH CDS'S
PROPOSED FOSTER CARE RATE REFORM
IS THE SOLE HOUSING SUPPLEMENT
STILL NEEDED? YES IT IS. WHILE
THE PROPOSED FOSTER CARE RATE
REFORM WOULD RAISE THE CARE AND
SUPERVISION RATE PAID TO YOUTH
IN SLPS FROM 1206 TO 1788. AND
THAT IS PROGRESS, AND THAT'S
MONTHLY. AND STARTING IN 2026,
27, THAT IS STILL NOT ADEQUATE
IN THE VAST MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S COUNTIES. ACCORDING
TO FAIR MARKET RENT AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING STANDARDS,
AND IS LESS THAN THE HOUSING
SUPPLEMENT WOULD HAVE PROVIDED
THEM AS IT STANDS IN CURRENT
LAW. BEFORE I CLOSE, I DO WANT
TO MENTION A SECOND INVESTMENT
IN OUR STATE'S BUDGET. ALSO
PROPOSED FOR ELIMINATION, THAT
PREVENTS HOMELESSNESS AMONG
THESE SAME YOUNG PEOPLE AFTER
THEY LEAVE FOSTER CARE. THE
HOUSING, NAVIGATION AND
MAINTENANCE PROGRAM MENTIONED,
BY LEO JUST NOW. IT'S NOT UNDER
THE JURISDICTION OF THIS
COMMITTEE, ALTHOUGH I WAS ASKED
TO TOUCH ON IT BECAUSE OF ITS
RELEVANCE. THIS IS A SMALL STATE
PROGRAM. $13.7 MILLION,
ADMINISTERED BY THE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT, TWO
COUNTY CHILD WELFARE AGENCIES.
IT PLAYS A CRITICAL ROLE IN
HELPING US ACCESS $22.6 MILLION
IN FEDERAL HOUSING ASSISTANCE
FROM HUD. THE HOUSING,
NAVIGATION AND MAINTENANCE
PROGRAM FUNDS THE SERVICES
PROVIDED TO FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
WITH FEDERAL HOUSING VOUCHERS.
THESE SERVICES ARE BOTH
NECESSARY IN ORDER FOR A YOUNG
ADULT TO TURN A VOUCHER INTO
ACTUAL HOUSING, AND ARE
FEDERALLY REQUIRED TO EVEN
REQUEST VOUCHERS. IN CLOSING, WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE COMMITTEE
TO PRESERVE THE HOUSING
SUPPLEMENT BY TYING IT TO THE
NEW SILK CARE AND SUPERVISION
RATE, AND WE ASK FOR A
RECOMMENDATION TO YOUR FELLOW
SENATORS SERVING ON SUBCOMMITTEE
FOUR TO PRESERVE THE HOUSING,
NAVIGATION AND MAINTENANCE
PROGRAM. I JUST WANT TO SHARE
ONE LAST THING. YOU'RE CUTTING
INTO YOUR OH, LET ME NOT DO
THAT. GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
WEDNESDAY POPE, AND I AM A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND
CURRENTLY A STUDENT AT FOLSOM
LAKE COMMUNITY COLLEGE. WHEN I
WAS AN EXTENDED FOSTER CARE, I
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS FOR A
YEAR WHILE PLACED IN A
SUPERVISED INDEPENDENT LIVING
PLACEMENT, OR SLP. WHEN I FIRST
TURNED 18 BACK IN 2018, A SLP
WAS MY ONLY OPTION. THERE WERE
WAITING LISTS FOR TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PLACEMENTS AND NO FOSTER
FAMILY OPTIONS AVAILABLE. WHEN
YOU'RE PLACED IN A SLP, YOU ARE
REQUIRED TO FIND YOUR OWN
HOUSING. SO I FIRST TRIED
FINDING PEOPLE I KNEW THAT I MAY
BE ABLE TO LIVE WITH AS MY SLP.
WHAT I FOUND IS THAT THERE WAS
NO ONE IN MY CIRCLE THAT I COULD
TRUST TO OBTAIN SAFE AND STABLE
HOUSING WITH AT THAT TIME. BACK
IN 2018, THE MONTHLY FOSTER CARE
PAYMENT FOR YOUTH AND SLPS WAS
$960. GIVEN THE COST OF
APARTMENTS, I FIRST LOOKED FOR
ROOM RENTALS, BUT FOUND THAT I
DIDN'T FEEL SAFE IN ANY OF THOSE
ARRANGEMENTS. I TRIED APARTMENT
RENTALS AND FOUND THAT I DIDN'T
MEET THE INCOME REQUIREMENTS FOR
THEM. DESPITE BOTH WORKING AND
RECEIVING MY STILT PAYMENT. I
THEN SEARCHED FOR APARTMENTS
THAT DIDN'T HAVE INCOME
REQUIREMENTS, BUT FOUND THAT
THEY WERE REQUESTING A 700 OR
BETTER CREDIT SCORE PLUS RENTAL
HISTORY BETWEEN INCOME AND OTHER
REQUIREMENTS. I LIKE MOST OTHER
FOSTER YOUTH AND FRANKLY, MOST
OTHER 18 YEAR OLDS COULD NOT
QUALIFY MY SAVING GRACE WAS THAT
I WAS LUCKY ENOUGH TO OWN A CAR.
I FIGURED LIVING IN MY CAR WOULD
BE SAFER THAN LIVING IN SOME OF
THE ARRANGEMENTS. I MAY HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO AFFORD SUCH AS
RENTING A ROOM FROM A MAN WHO
PLACED AN AD FOR AN 18 TO 25
YEAR OLD ROOMMATE AND SAID HE
DIDN'T LIKE CLOSED DOORS IN HIS
HOUSE. I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THIS
POINT AFTER BEING REMOVED FROM
MY HOME FOR NOT BEING KEPT SAFE,
I SHOULDN'T NOW BE FACED WITH A
LIVING ARRANGEMENT THAT FEELS
JUST AS UNSAFE. SO I LIVED IN MY
CAR FOR A WHOLE YEAR WHILE IN
FOSTER CARE, LIVING IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES, WE DON'T HAVE
ACCESSIBLE HOMELESS SHELTERS, SO
AT LEAST OWNING A CAR, YOU'RE
NOT FREEZING AT NIGHT. YOU CAN
STILL GET TO WORK OR SCHOOL.
MAYBE YOU CAN GET TO A FRIEND'S
HOUSE WHO WILL LET YOU STAY FOR
A NIGHT OR SHOWER. MY SOCIAL
WORKER DIDN'T KNOW I WAS
HOMELESS. I FEARED THAT IF I
TOLD HER I DIDN'T HAVE HOUSING,
I COULDN'T GET MY SILT PAYMENT
AND THEN I WOULD HAVE BEEN IN AN
EVEN WORSE SITUATION. I WISH I
COULD SAY THIS WAS A RARE
OCCURRENCE, BUT MANY OF THE
OTHER FOSTER YOUTH I KNEW WERE
ALSO FACING THIS REALITY. IF THE
SOLE HOUSING SUPPLEMENT WAS IN
PLACE WHEN I WAS IN FOSTER CARE,
I WOULD HAVE HAD A HIGHER
MONTHLY PAYMENT THAT WOULD HAVE
ENABLED ME TO SECURE SAFE,
STABLE HOUSING. I COULD HAVE
AVOIDED THE RETRAUMATIZATION OF
BEING HOMELESS WHILE IN FOSTER
CARE AFTER HAVING ALREADY
EXPERIENCED IT WITH MY FAMILY
BEFORE BEING PLACED IN CARE, I
COULD HAVE STAYED IN COLLEGE
FULL TIME. I WOULD BE FURTHER
ALONG IN MY PURSUIT OF A CAREER.
I'M ENCOURAGED BY THE
POSSIBILITY THAT THIS RATE WILL
INCREASE FROM THE $1,206 IT IS
NOW, TO THE $1,788 PROPOSED IN
RATE REFORM. BUT UNFORTUNATELY,
THIS DOES NOT ADDRESS THE RANGE
OF HOUSING COSTS ACROSS OUR
STATE'S 58 COUNTIES. AS A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH WHO EXPERIENCED THE
IMPACT OF AN INADEQUATE MONTHLY
PAYMENT TO COVER SHELTER, I
STRONGLY RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PRESERVE THE HOUSING
SUPPLEMENT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. ONCE I APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY. NOW WE'RE GOING TO
TURN OVER TO L.A. COUNTY DCFS.
JUST BE MINDFUL THAT YOU'RE
SPLITTING YOUR TIME WITH YOUR
COLLEAGUE THERE. THANK YOU, GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, GABRIEL SKYDANCER, THE
FIRST MANAGER FOR LOS ANGELES
COUNTY'S DEPARTMENT OF CHILDREN
AND FAMILY SERVICES, I AM
REQUESTING AND REPRESENTING THIS
TIME FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. FIRST IS A
UNIQUE ENTITY THAT PROVIDES 24
OVER SEVEN SUPPORT TO FOSTER
KIDS AND NON-MINOR DEPENDENTS UP
UNTIL THE AGE OF 21, AS WELL AS
THEIR CAREGIVERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. EMPHASIS ON 24 OVER
SEVEN AND ALL HOURS OF THE DAY.
FIRS IS ALSO AVAILABLE TO FOSTER
KIDS WHO ARE OUT OF THE SYSTEM
FOR ANY REASON, EVEN IF THEY
HAVE BEEN PUT INTO LEGAL
GUARDIANSHIP. ADOPTION CAN GAP
CLOSED CASES. FIRST IS A PROGRAM
THAT SIMPLY DOES NOT EXIST
ANYWHERE ELSE IN FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM. WHEN A KID OR CAREGIVER
CALLS US, THEY ARE ALMOST ALWAYS
IN GREAT NEED. THEY HAVE AN
URGENT AND IMMEDIATE NEED FOR
RESOURCES RELATED TO ANYTHING
FROM STRESS MANAGEMENT, JOB
INTERVIEWS, PREPARATION FOR
OTHER CRITICAL NEEDS, AND
HOUSING, SUICIDE AND
HOMELESSNESS IN L.A. COUNTY. I
AM THE PERSON ON THE OTHER END
OF THOSE CALLS. SO LET ME TELL
YOU WHAT HAPPENS NEXT. NO MATTER
THE TIME OF DAY OR NIGHT, THE
CALLS RECEIVED FIRST RESPONSE TO
THAT CALLER TYPICALLY WITHIN ONE
HOUR AND NO MORE THAN THREE. AND
BY RESPOND, I MEAN HEADING OUT
TO MEET THE FAMILY IN PERSON TO
OFFER SUPPORT, STABILIZATION,
CONFLICT MANAGEMENT, AND MORE.
YOU CAN IMAGINE HOW CHALLENGING
THIS IS. AND AS A COUNTY AS
LARGE AS L.A. COUNTY, HOWEVER,
IT DOES NOT STOP THERE. WE ALSO
HAVE MANDATORY FOLLOW UP CASE
MAINTENANCE FOR DAYS, EXTENDING
TO WEEKS AND SOMETIMES MONTHS
AFTER THE CALL TO ENSURE OUR
KIDS FAMILIES HAVE RECEIVED ALL
THE HELP THAT THEY NEED. IF
FIRST WAS NOT THERE, THESE CALLS
WOULD BE GOING TO 911 LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR FIRE, CREATING
MUCH MORE HAVOC FOR FOSTER KIDS
AND FAMILIES. WE'RE ALREADY
DEALING WITH INSTABILITY AND
TRAUMA FOR EVERY CALL THAT COMES
IN, THERE ARE 1 TO 2 FIRST
EMPLOYEES COMING OUT TO HELP
THESE FAMILIES. INSTEAD OF 2 TO
4 POLICE OFFICERS OR 4 TO 6
EMERGENCY RESPONDERS.
ADDITIONALLY, MANY OF OUR
FAMILIES ARE FROM THE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE FORMED A
BIAS AGAINST AUTHORITY. SO
WITHOUT FIRST, THEY WOULD NOT
HAVE ANYONE TO CALL AND WIND UP
IN A DISASTROUS SITUATION WHERE
THEY CAN REACH OUT TO NO ONE.
IT'S LIFE CHANGING FOR THEM TO
KNOW THAT THEY CAN CALL FIRST
ANY TIME, AND THERE WILL ALWAYS
BE SOMEONE LIKE MY PHENOMENAL
TEAM RESPONDING TO THEM IN
PERSON, ANY TIME OF NIGHT, ANY
NEIGHBORHOOD, AND THEY'RE GOING
TO COME TRAUMA INFORMED,
JUDGMENT FREE HELP WITHOUT BIAS
AND WITH AN OPEN HEART. I AM
PROUD AND HUMBLED TO INFORM YOU
THAT LA COUNTY FIRS HAS AN
UNPARALLELED SUCCESS RATE. WE
ACCOUNT FOR OVER 25% OF ALL
MOBILE RESPONSES IN THE STATE.
WE ARE RIGHT NOW AT 87% SUCCESS
RATE FOR KEEPING KIDS IN THE
SAFE IN THEIR HOMES AND
STABILIZATION WITHOUT HAVING TO
GO BACK INTO THE SYSTEM FIRST,
IS SO MUCH MORE THAN A HOTLINE.
IT SAVES THE STATE FROM THE
STRAIN THAT WOULD BE PLACED ON
POLICE, FIRE AND OTHER NON
FOSTER RELATED RESOURCES IF WE
WERE NOT THERE. MORE IMPORTANTLY
, FIRST PROTECTS KIDS FROM THE
COMPOUNDING ISSUES OF TRAUMA AND
MOVING IN AND OUT OF THE FOSTER
SYSTEM. WE KEEP THEM SAFE AND
OUT OF SHELTERS AND OUT OF THE
STREETS AND GIVING THEM
STABILITY. THEY NEED. ON BEHALF
OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS, I URGE YOU TO NOT
AGREE WITH THESE BUDGET
REDUCTIONS. THANK YOU. NOW,
TURNING IT OVER TO A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM CHILDREN'S
MEDICAL SERVICES, LA COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
OKAY. SO THIS. IF IT'S RED,
IT'S. YEAH, YEAH. THANK YOU,
CHAIR MENGIBAR. SENATOR ROTH.
STAFF AND COLLEAGUES, MY NAME IS
CRAIG VINCENT JONES. I'M THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF CHILDREN'S
MEDICAL SERVICES IN LA COUNTY'S
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ABOUT OUR PROGRAM, PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSING, EARLY
INTERVENTION PROGRAM, WHICH WE
REFER TO AS FNAI. I WILL ADDRESS
THE EXPENDITURE RATES THAT CAME
UP IN QUESTIONS IN A COUPLE OF
MOMENTS, BUT I'D LIKE TO JUST
OFFER A LITTLE BACKGROUND OF WHY
THIS PROGRAM CAME INTO PLACE IN
THE FIRST PLACE. FNAI IS A NEW
PROGRAM MODEL PILOTING PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSING INTERVENTIONS TO
KEEP CHILDREN AND YOUTH OUT OF
OR RETURNING TO THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM. RECOGNIZING THAT
CHILDREN, YOUTH FACE MYRIAD SEEN
AND UNSEEN HEALTH ACCESS
BARRIERS AND HEALTH CARE
CHALLENGES WHEN THEY'RE IN NEED,
WHEN THEY'RE IN THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM AND THEIR CHILD'S
MEDICAL COMPLEX CAN FULLY
DESTABILIZE THE FAMILY, CMS IS
CHILD WELFARE. PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSING PROGRAMS HELP CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES ADDRESS THEIR
HEALTH CARE NEEDS DURING THEIR
CHILD WELFARE INVOLVEMENT. IN
FISCAL YEAR 1718, THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED A PILOT
PROJECT TO EXPAND THOSE CHILD
WELFARE PUBLIC HEALTH NURSING
SERVICES TO CHILDREN AND YOUTH
AT IMMINENT RISK OF ENTERING THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM OR THOSE
WHO HAVE JUST LEFT THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM AND THAT ARE AT
RISK OF RETURNING TO IT. THIS
INNOVATION WILL HELP BREAK THE
CYCLE OF CHILDREN AND YOUTH WHO
REPEATEDLY ENTER AND REENTER THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM, AND IT WAS
INTENDED TO BE A MODEL THAT
COULD BE BROADENED ACROSS THE
STATE OF SUCCESSFUL. FOR FNAI IS
CLOSELY ALIGNED WITH LA COUNTY
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT AND
COMMITMENT TO FAMILIES FIRST
STRATEGIES. AND I CAN GIVE YOU
SOME OF THOSE EXAMPLES. BUT IN
BRIEF, PLANS OF SAFE CARE COULD
REFER INTO ANY REFERRALS THAT
DON'T TURN INTO INVESTIGATIONS
COULD BE REFERRED INTO FNAI, AND
WE COULD HELP DIVERT THOSE
FAMILIES INTO FNAI DRIVEN
SOLUTIONS THAT WILL HELP THEM
AVOID ENTRY INTO THE PUBLIC
HEALTH OR INTO THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM. PER STATUTE, FNAI WAS
GOING TO BE FINANCED THROUGH AN
ANNUAL 8.25 MILLION STATE
GENERAL FUND ALLOCATION FROM
CDFS, WHICH WOULD BE USED AS A
BASE FOR A FEDERAL MATCHING
TITLE 19 FUNDING STRATEGY THAT
WE'VE BEEN DEVELOPING WITH DCS,
THAT FUNDING STRATEGY COULD
YIELD 3 TO 4 TIMES MORE REVENUES
THAN SERVICES IN FUTURE YEARS
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC HAS BEEN
NOTED, PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION
WAS DELAYED UNTIL WE GOT OUR
FIRST CSF ALLOCATION LATE LAST
FISCAL YEAR. SINCE THEN, WE
INSTALLED OUR FIRST STAFF, BEGAN
BUILDING OUR DATA SYSTEM TO
DETERMINE REFERRAL PATHWAYS WITH
PARTNERS ASSIGNED. OUR FIRST
COHORT OF 12 NURSES TO THE
PROGRAM AND BEGAN RECRUITMENT
FOR TWICE AS MANY MORE. SADLY,
WITH THE NEWS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET CUTS, WE HAD TO
STOP RECRUITMENT AND MOVE THE
INITIAL NURSING STAFF INTO OTHER
PUBLIC HEALTH POSITIONS TO
ADDRESS THE 600,000, AS I'M SURE
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS, YOU DON'T
START A NEW PROGRAM, A FULLY NEW
PROGRAM FROM GROUND 0 TO 100. SO
WE HAVE A RAMPWAY, FOR THE
COUNTY. WE WERE MOVING AT LIGHT
SPEED AND WE HAD POSITIONS, AND
WE MADE POSITIONS AVAILABLE
VERY, VERY QUICKLY, MUCH FASTER
THAN USUAL COUNTY OPERATIONS, WE
HAD PLANNED TO BEGIN OUR FIRST
STAFFING AND SERVICES IN JANUARY
. THAT'S WHEN THE BUDGET, CUTS
WERE ANNOUNCED. WE HAD TO,
BECAUSE WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO
OUR STAFF, WE HAD TO MOVE THEM
INTO OTHER POSITIONS. WE ARE
EXPENDING MORE THAN 600,000.
WE'RE STILL WORKING WITH OUR
CONSULTANTS TO FINALIZE THE
PROTOCOLS WE NEVER EXPECTED IN
THE FIRST YEAR TO EXPEND THE
FULL 8.25 MILLION, BUT WE DO
EXPEND AND HAVE BUDGETED
APPROPRIATELY FOR FULLY
EXPANDING THAT. WHEN THE PROGRAM
IS LAUNCHED FULLY. SO WE'RE HERE
TODAY TO URGE YOU ALL TO
ADVOCATE FOR THE RESTORATION OF
THE ANNUAL 8.25 MILLION IN THE
NEXT FISCAL YEAR'S BUDGET, AND
TO INVEST IN PROMISING SOLUTIONS
THAT WE CAN EXPLORE TOGETHER TO
HELP FAMILIES STEER CLEAR OF THE
RISKS THAT JEOPARDIZE REPEATED
AND FURTHER CHILD WELFARE
INVOLVEMENT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WAS IT THIS WAS AN
ANNUAL ALLOCATION OR OR I HEAR
PILOT. I ALWAYS THINK IT'S
SHORT. SHORT LIVED, THAT'S.
THERE WE GO, IT'S CORRECT THAT
IT IS AN ANNUAL ALLOCATION, AS
THE LAO REFERENCED EARLIER. IT
IS THERE IS PILOT IN THE NAME AT
THE SAME TIME, THERE WAS AN
INTENTION AFTER THE INITIAL YEAR
THAT IT WAS IMPLEMENTED, WE DID
EXPRESS AN INTENTION MUTUALLY TO
HAVE THAT BE ONGOING. SO IT IS
REFERENCED AS A PILOT. BUT THERE
WAS AN INTENTION FOR ONGOING
FUNDING. IS THERE ROOM FOR A
WELL, I MEAN, WE'RE LOOKING AT
YEARS. WE WANT SAVINGS, BUT FOR
DELAY, I THINK I WOULD SORT OF
DEFER TO THE COUNTY ON WHAT THEY
WOULD DO IN THE IN THE FACE OF
THAT. BUT THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION. WE ARE CONTINUING TO
PLAN FOR FULL IMPLEMENTATION IN
HOPES THAT IF IT DOESN'T HAPPEN
NEXT FISCAL YEAR, THAT THERE
WILL BE A FUTURE IN WHICH WE CAN
LAUNCH THE PROGRAM PROPERLY. SO
AND WE HAVE WORKED OUT A FINANCE
STRATEGY FOR DCS. I KNOW THAT'S
ANOTHER DEPARTMENT FOR THE
TITLE, 19 MATCHING FUNDS. SO
THAT WOULD GREATLY ENHANCE WHAT
WE COULD ACCOMPLISH WITH THIS
PROGRAM. OKAY. THANK YOU. AND
THEN MR. SKYDANCER, DO YOU YOU
HEARD FROM THE DEPARTMENT SOME
POTENTIAL, REPLACEMENTS THAT
PROVIDE SIMILAR SERVICES TO
FIRST, I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE
HEARD ANY OF THEM. DO THEY EXIST
IN LA COUNTY? ARE THEY? WOULD
YOU SAY THAT THEY'RE. THERE WE
GO. I'M SORRY. I'M NOT TRYING TO
BUILD THE SUSPENSE ON YOU. I
KNOW IT SEEMED LIKE IT. NO NO.
I'M HERE. I'M HERE TO ILLUSTRATE
THAT. YES, I HAVE HEARD OF SOME
OF THESE PROGRAMS, BUT,
HONESTLY, WITH OVER 20 YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE IN THIS AREA AND
KNOWING HOW UNIQUE FIRS IS AND
EXISTS IN NO OTHER ELEMENT,
NOTHING CAN REPLACE THIS.
THERE'S NO PROGRAM THAT CAN KIND
OF SUPPLEMENT OR TAG TEAM IN TO
PROVIDE WHAT FIRS IS DOING. AND
I SEE THAT ECHOING ACROSS THE
STATE. I CAN SPEAK FOR L.A.
COUNTY, BUT I KNOW IT'S BEEN A
HUGE SUCCESS ACROSS ALL THE
REGIONS IN L.A. COUNTY FOR SUCH
A LARGE COUNTY. TO DISPLAY THIS
FOR OVER THREE YEARS, YEAH. I
MEAN, EVEN THE AGENDA FOR THE
BACKGROUND SPOKE TO ONE THAT'S
MOSTLY CAREGIVERS CALLING OVER
60% OF THEM CALLING FOR SUPPORT,
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO KEEP THE
KID RIGHT. THEY JUST NEED SOME
EXTRA SUPPORT, ENSURE THAT THE
KID DOESN'T GO BACK. THE YOUTH
DOESN'T GO BACK TO INTO THE
SYSTEM, AND, YOU KNOW, THE
NUMBERS SHOW THAT THIS PROGRAM
IS REALLY, REALLY SUCCESSFUL. I
MEAN, I THINK THAT'S WHY WAS MY
QUESTION TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. I WAS LIKE, THIS IS A
REALLY SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM THAT
THAT HELPS STABILIZE THESE
FAMILIES SO THAT WE CAN SAVE
MONEY DOWN THE LINE BY NOT
PUTTING THE YOUTH BACK INTO THE
SYSTEM. SO BOTH ON THE FISCAL
PART, IT SAVES US DOLLARS. IF WE
INVEST IN THIS, BUT IT'S ALSO ON
ITS FACE VALUE OF VERY,
WORTHWHILE PROGRAM. MADAM CHAIR,
YOU WERE PICKING UP WHAT I'M
PUTTING DOWN. IT'S EXACTLY IT.
IT MAKES SENSE ACROSS US. SO I'M
A GOOD CATCHER. SEE, I KNEW IT,
I KNEW IT, IT MAKES SENSE ON
BOTH SIDES. ONE. NUMBER ONE, THE
KIDDOS, THEIR FAMILIES. AND THEN
FROM THE EXPENDITURES THAT WE
HAVE TO PUT OUT FINANCIALLY
BECAUSE I TRIED TO BRIEFLY
DEMONSTRATE FOR YOU HOW MUCH
PERSONNEL ARE PULLED FROM OTHER
EMS SERVICES TO DEAL WITH CALLS
LIKE THIS AND POTENTIAL TRAUMA
AND REMOVAL TO THEN JUST SLIM IT
INTO VERY TRAUMA INFORMED,
SPECIALIZED PEOPLE THAT CAN TAKE
CARE OF THIS AND REALLY WANT
FAMILIES TO BE TOGETHER AND THEN
FOLLOW IT. IT'S DYNAMIC BECAUSE
IT STRETCHES ACROSS ALL THOSE
ELEMENTS FISCALLY. BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY FOR THE PEOPLE,
BECAUSE THE AGENDA IS A SHOW
THAT MAJORITY OF THE TIME
EVERYTHING CAN BE HANDLED. IT
WAS HANDLED IN THAT CONVERSATION
THAT A LOT OF THE TIMES YOUR
TEAM, OR AT LEAST EXAMPLES OF
YOUR TEAMS, DIDN'T HAVE TO GO
OUT. SO I THINK 41.2% ARE
STABILIZED AT THE HOTLINE. IS
THERE ROOM TO ADJUST THIS
PROGRAM WHERE IT DOESN'T REQUIRE
A LOT OF AVAILABLE TEAMS TO BE
RESPONDING? THE MAJORITY OF
SAYING NO OVER THERE, OKAY. NO,
NO, I SEE WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
AND THERE WAS A LEAD TO THAT.
WHAT I FOUND IN AND THIS IS FROM
A PERSONAL SIDE, BUT IT'S
ENCOMPASSING OUR WHOLE PROGRAM.
SO I SEE THE NUMBERS AND I WISH
I WOULD HAVE ALSO HAD THEM HERE
TO ILLUSTRATE FOR YOU THAT POST.
AND DURING COVID, A LOT OF
PEOPLE GOT USED TO THE ASPECTS
OF DOING EVERYTHING OVER THE
COMPUTER AND NOT HAVING A PERSON
TO PERSON. WELL, FAMILIES THAT
ARE IN TRAUMA, KIDS THAT ARE IN
TRAUMA, THEY DON'T NEED SOMEONE
ON THE COMPUTER. THEY DON'T NEED
A PHONE CALL. AND WHAT'S MADE
THIS SO SUCCESSFUL IS EVERY CALL
IS TREATED AS A NEED FOR MOBILE
RESPONSE. WHEN IT GETS TO US,
WE'RE GOING UNLESS EXPLICITLY
SAID NO, I JUST NEED YOU TO
SUPPORT ME OVER THE PHONE.
THAT'S WHY AT 2:00 IN THE
MORNING, WE'RE THERE. AND THIS
MAKES A DIFFERENCE BECAUSE
SOMEONE'S NOT GETTING ANOTHER
HOTLINE TO WAIT ON ANOTHER PASS
TO ANOTHER PERSON OR A
VOICEMAIL. THEY'RE GETTING
TELEPHONIC SUPPORT. JUST WANTS
TO LET YOU KNOW I DIDN'T GET TO
ILLUSTRATE THAT. BUT FROM THE
MOMENT THEY CALL, THEY GET
TELEPHONIC TELEPHONE SUPPORT
FROM US WHILE WE'RE DRIVING TO
THEM. SO THE DE-ESCALATION, THE
LEARNING PROCESS IS HAPPENING IN
REAL TIME. WE'RE GATHERING THAT
INFORMATION AT THE SAME TIME
SOMEONE IS GATHERING DATABASE
INFORMATION ABOUT CHILDREN'S
HISTORY. IF WE CAN PULL THAT UP
TO HELP BETTER DE-ESCALATE THE
SITUATION. AND THEN WE GO WITH
ALL THAT INFORMATION INTO THE
HOME SO WE'RE BETTER INFORMED TO
APPROACH THEM. AND NOW WE'RE IN
PERSON. IT MEANS A LOT MORE WHEN
YOU'RE IN PERSON. IT'S THE HUMAN
ASPECT. YEAH THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MOVING TOWARDS THE FOSTER TO
ADOPT PARENT FROM SAN FRANCISCO
COUNTY TH¤U MISTER CENTER. YES
SO MY NAME IS ED CENTER, AND I'M
HERE AS A DAD, AND I'M HERE TO
TELL YOU HOW FIRS SAVED MY
FAMILY. SO MY HUSBAND AND I
ADOPTED TWO SONS THROUGH THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. WE LED A
HAPPY ISH LIFE UNTIL OUR OLDER
SON'S MENTAL HEALTH CRUMBLED
UNDER THE STRESS OF THE PANDEMIC
. I'LL USE HIS MIDDLE NAME, HOKU
, IN JANUARY OF 2021. HE WAS TEN
YEARS OLD, AND HE WAS NOTHING
LIKE THE CHARMING, MISCHIEVOUS
KID THAT HE HAD BEEN A YEAR
BEFORE. HE WOULDN'T GO TO
SCHOOL. HE STAYED INSIDE FOR
DAYS, WAS SULLEN AND ADDICTED TO
YOUTUBE, IF WE ASKED HIM TO DO
ANYTHING INCONVENIENT, LIKE GET
OFF HIS IPAD OR TAKE A BATH, HE
WOULD DEVOLVE INTO FITS OF RAGE
THAT WOULD LAST HOURS. HIS
BEHAVIORS INCLUDED SCREAMING,
BREAKING THINGS, AND PAINTING. I
HATE YOU DAD ON THE WALLS, THE
ONE THAT HURT ME THE MOST WAS
WHEN HE TOOK A SHARPIE AND HE
BLACK OUT HIS FACE IN EVERY
FAMILY PORTRAIT IN THE HOUSE,
AND SO WE WERE REALLY
STRUGGLING, AND I'VE HEARD SOME
OF THE PROPOSALS FOR OTHER
HOTLINES AND COACHING AND
RESOURCES, AND WE NEEDED THAT.
BUT WHEN WE WERE IN CRISIS, WE
NEEDED WONDER WOMAN WITH A
SOCIAL WORK DEGREE. AND IT TURNS
OUT THAT LOOKS LIKE GABRIEL. AND
SO WE GOT MR. SKYDANCER. SO
ANDREW WAS JUST KIDDING. SO BUT
WE GOT THAT WHEN WE WERE FINALLY
CONNECTED TO THE FAMILY URGENT
RESPONSE SYSTEM, OR FIRS, WHICH
IN MY COUNTY IS OPERATED BY
SENECA CENTER, AND THEY'RE
AMAZING, THIS CHANGED EVERYTHING
FOR US. THE FIRST COUNSELORS
WOULD COME TO OUR HOUSE AS MR.
SKYDANCER SAID AT 1011 MIDNIGHT
AT. THESE CRISIS NEVER HAPPENED
DURING DAYLIGHT HOURS. THEY
WOULD HELP HOKU REGULATE AND
MAKE A SAFETY PLAN WITH HIM. ONE
NIGHT, I TOLD HOKU THAT HE
NEEDED TO BRUSH HIS TEETH BEFORE
WHERE HE WATCHED MORE TV, AND
THAT STARTED A TWO HOUR VIOLENT
TANTRUM AND WHEN THE COUNSELOR
SHOWED UP AT OUR HOUSE, SHE
PULLED OUT HER OWN TOOTHBRUSH
AND SAID, I'LL RACE YOU. AND SHE
HAD HIS TEETH BRUSHED. IN TWO
MINUTES, I WAS A LITTLE BIT
BITTER ABOUT THAT, AND I COULD
LIE. AND THEN SHE HELPED HIM
CALM DOWN AND GET TO BED,
ANOTHER NIGHT. I CALLED FIRS
FROM MY CAR I'D BEEN DRIVING FOR
THREE HOURS AND I ASKED THE
COUNSELOR A SIMPLE QUESTION WHY
SHOULD I GO BACK? AND I'LL NEVER
FORGET WHAT HE SAID. PROPS TO
JUNIOR, HE SAID. I CAN'T TELL
YOU NOT TO LEAVE. WHAT I CAN
TELL YOU IS WE HAVE SO MUCH
RESPECT FOR YOU, AND WE TALK ON
OUR TEAM ABOUT HOW AMAZING YOU
AND YOUR HUSBAND ARE, AND WE CAN
SEE HOW MUCH YOU MATTER TO HOKU,
EVEN THOUGH HE CAN'T SHOW YOU
THAT NOW. AND SO I BOUGHT SOME
CRAPPY GAS STATION COFFEE, AND I
TURNED AROUND FOR HOME. MY
FAMILY HEALED SLOWLY AND IT
AIN'T PERFECT. HOKU WAS 13 NOW
AND HE'S VERY 13, BUT WE ARE
STABLE AND MORE IMPORTANT THAN
ANYTHING. WE ARE HOPEFUL, THE
COST TO MY FAMILY, TO THE STATE
WOULD BE EGREGIOUS IF WE HAD HAD
TO TERMINATE THE ADOPTION AND
INSTITUTIONALIZE OUR KID, OR IF
I HAD KEPT DRIVING AND THOUSANDS
OF CALIFORNIA FAMILIES ARE
CURRENTLY BATTLING WITH MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES AND THE EMOTIONAL
WELLNESS OF THEIR FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN, AND SO I HOPE WE CAN
PROTECT FIRS TO HELP FAMILIES
HEAL FROM CRISES AND STAY
TOGETHER. THANK YOU. I NEED TO
INVITE THE CHAIRS OVER THE OTHER
SUBS TO COME SIT AND LISTEN TO
EVERY SINGLE HEARING WE HAVE
HERE EVERY THURSDAY, BECAUSE
WHILE THEY'RE FIGHTING TO SEE,
DO WE CUT EVS OR TRANSPORTATION?
LIKE I HAVE TO SIT HERE NOW THAT
I HAVE TO, I'M BLESSED TO SIT
HERE TO LISTEN TO THIS. AND IT'S
HARD. THAT WAS HARD TO LISTEN TO
. IT'S BEEN A TOUGH WEEK.
BEING A LEGISLATOR. AND LEADING
A SUBCOMMITTEE THAT HAS TO
FIGURE OUT WHO DO YOU CUT? AND
THE RESPONSES I GET FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS BECAUSE
WE HAVE A TOUGH BUDGET. YEAR IS
NOT ENOUGH. IT'S NOT ENOUGH. THE
THIS THIS SUBCOMMITTEE SHOULD
NEVER BE CUT, EVER. LIKE, THESE
ARE THE THINGS THAT IMPACT
PEOPLE'S ACTUAL LIVES IS BECAUSE
YOUR KID COULD HAVE BEEN A
STATISTIC, HAVE BEEN HOMELESS,
DIED BY SUICIDE, OR YOU WOULD
HAVE HAD A BROKEN FAMILY AND IT
WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN YOUR FAULT.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN BECAUSE THE
SYSTEM FAILED YOU. AND I'M PART
OF THE SYSTEM, AND I CAN'T
FIGURE OUT HOW EVEN BEING PART
OF THE SYSTEM, WE CAN'T GET TO
AN AGREEMENT THAT THIS SHOULD
NEVER BE ON A CHOPPING BLOCK.
NEVER SHOULD NEVER. I SHOULD
COME TO SOME THREE AND NOT HAVE
TO SAY A WORD. BUT I'M COMING
HERE AND HAVING TO FIGHT FOR
THIS EVERY SINGLE THURSDAY AND
IN BETWEEN. AND I DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW WE CAN GO BACK
AND LOOK AT THIS PLAN AND SAY,
YES, WE'RE JUSTIFYING THIS. CUT
TO FIRST COW WORKS FOSTER KIDS.
IT'S HARD UP HERE. AND TODAY MY
STRESS BALL DID NOT HELP. I
TRIED TO HOLD IT IN, BUT IT'S
HARD BECAUSE AND THEN EVERYTHING
ELSE GETS, GETS IT'S STILL IT'S
STILL OKAY OR DELAYED. LIKE
THESE ARE PERMANENT CUTS. THERE
MIGHT BE OTHER PROGRAMS THAT
EXIST, BUT THERE WILL NEVER BE
ENOUGH PROGRAMS FOR THESE KIDS.
BECAUSE AT THE SAME TIME, WHEN
I'M WORKING ON THIS, THEN I'M
ALSO WORKING ON OIC ISSUES
BECAUSE THESE KIDS THAT WE
FAILED ARE THEN IN OUR JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM. AND I'M LIKE,
WELL, IF WE WOULD HAVE STEPPED
IN BEFORE, THEY WOULDN'T BE HERE
IN MY DISTRICT AT ONE OF THE
WORST JUVENILE HALL CENTERS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND IT'S NOT THEIR
FAULT. IT'S BECAUSE WE FAILED
THEM. AND THEN WE SPENT SO MUCH
MONEY ON CDCR ON ON THOSE
PROGRAMS BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH
THEY'RE ADULTS, WE FAILED THEM
AS KIDS. HOW DO WE SAVE MONEY IN
CALIFORNIA? WE INVEST IN OUR
KIDS. WE INVEST IN STABILIZING
FAMILIES SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE
TO SPEND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON
CDCR AND JUVENILE HALLS, AND WE
ERADICATE EVERY SINGLE JUVENILE
HALL BECAUSE WE ARE NO LONGER
GOING TO HAVE KIDS IN THESE
CENTERS, BECAUSE IT'S NOT THEIR
FAULT THAT THEY GOT INTO THIS
SITUATION. I MEAN, I KEEP HAVING
THESE, THESE, THESE RAMBLINGS
AND SUB THREE, I DON'T KNOW WHO
IT'S FALLING ON. LIKE, I DON'T
UNDERSTAND IT, BUT IT WAS A
TOUGH WEEK FIGHTING FOR OUR
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES AND THE
BUREAUCRACY THAT EXISTS IN IN
THIS BLOCK HERE. AND I'M STILL
WONDERING HOW PEOPLE DON'T SEE
WHAT'S HAPPENING. BECAUSE I GET
YOU HEAR IT. I JUST HOPE
LEADERSHIP HEARS IT. THE
ADMINISTRATION HEARS IT, MY
COLLEAGUES HEAR IT BECAUSE I,
YOU KNOW, COLLEAGUES CAN CAN BE
ON THE FRONT LINE FOR
ELECTRIFICATION, FOR I STUFF I
CAN'T WRITE LEGISLATION IN. I
BECAUSE MY COMMUNITIES DON'T
HAVE FOOD ON THEIR TABLE. I'M
BARELY TRYING TO PASS
LEGISLATION TO MEET THE BASIC
NEEDS OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. I CAN'T I DON'T
HAVE THE ABILITY TO LOOK AT WHAT
CAN I DO ABOUT I BECAUSE I
HAVEN'T EVEN GOTTEN PAST STEP
ONE OF ENSURING MY COMMUNITY
MEMBERS HAVE ACCESS TO WATER,
CLEAN WATER, CLEAN AIR. OUR KIDS
ARE SUPPORTED THAT THEY HAVE
ENOUGH FUNDS TO SURVIVE, THAT
THEY'RE NOT LIVING IN CARS. AT
THE AGE OF 18. BUT WE'RE FOCUSED
ON ON OTHER ISSUES LIKE THAT'S
WHY I KEEP SAYING, LIKE, I'M SO
TIRED OF THE HEADLINES OF ALL
THIS, LOOK WHAT WE'RE DOING IN
THIS SPACE, BUT WE'RE FAILING
OUR KIDS LEFT AND RIGHT. OUR
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. SO
I APOLOGIZE FOR GETTING
EMOTIONAL. IT WAS JUST REALLY
HARD TO LISTEN TO. IT'S REALLY
HARD. OKAY, HANG IN THERE. WE
GOT ONE MORE PERSON ON THIS
PANEL. I THINK THAT WAS MORE FOR
ME THAN Y'ALL. I NEED TO HANG IN
THERE. ALL RIGHT. MR.
CHRISTOPHER HERNANDEZ FROM
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION,
JUST I THANK YOU. I THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR ADVOCACY AND YOUR
HEART, THANK YOU. I HELLO, MY
NAME IS CHRISTOPHER HERNANDEZ,
AND I RUN THE LEGISLATIVE
DEPARTMENT AT CALIFORNIA YOUTH
CONNECTION. CYC IS A YOUTH LED
ORGANIZATION THAT DEVELOPS
LEADERS WHO EMPOWER EACH OTHER
AND THEIR COMMUNITIES TO
TRANSFORM THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
THROUGH COMMUNITY ORGANIZING,
LEGISLATION, POLICY, AND
PRACTICE CHANGE. OUR MEMBERSHIP
BASE IS MADE UP OF 14 TO 24 YEAR
OLDS WHO ARE CURRENT AND FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH FROM ALL ACROSS THE
STATE. CYC IS A UNIQUE POSITION
IN CHILD WELFARE BECAUSE IT HAS
SUCH AN UNMATCHED DIRECT
CONNECTION TO YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
ARE CURRENTLY OR FORMERLY IN THE
SYSTEMS WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
TODAY. SO AS I URGE US TO
COLLECTIVELY REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET CUTS,
I DO SO NOT AS AN INDIVIDUAL,
BUT WITH THE WEIGHT OF SIX
ENTIRE STATEWIDE MEMBERSHIP. WE
SAY NOT THESE CUTS, NOT THESE
KIDS TODAY SPECIFICALLY, I'LL BE
SHARING ABOUT THE UNIQUENESS OF
THE FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE
SYSTEM, ALSO KNOWN AS FIRST
ELIMINATING RESOURCES FOR THE
FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE SYSTEM
LEAVES FOSTER YOUTH VULNERABLE
DURING EMERGENCIES, DEPRIVING
THEM OF RAPID ASSISTANCE AND A
SAFETY NET. THEY RELY ON REALLY
AMPLIFYING THEIR SENSE OF
INSECURITY AND ISOLATION. FORSS
VALUABLE IS A VALUABLE RESOURCE
FOR YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE BECAUSE
IT HAS CHILD WELFARE
PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE TRAINED
SPECIFICALLY TO SUPPORT FOSTER
YOUTH. FIRST IS UNIQUE TO YOUTH
BECAUSE IT HAS ON DEMAND SUPPORT
THAT IS READY TO SOFTLY SUPPORT
THEM AND ENSURE THEY ARE
PROTECTED WHEN NAVIGATING A
SCARY A SCARY SITUATION OR
ENVIRONMENT. FIRST IS
SPECIFICALLY CRAFTED THROUGH THE
WORK AND VALUES OF YOUTH AND
CAREGIVERS, A RESOURCE UNIQUE TO
FOSTER CARE FOR ITS TIMELY
RESPONSES AS ITS SPECIFIC LENS
AND ITS ABILITY TO SUPPORT
FAMILIES AT ANY MOMENT, ANYWHERE
. THIS RESOURCE IS UNIQUE, AND
IT'S IMPORTANT TO YOUTH DUE TO
ITS ABILITY TO STABILIZE
PLACEMENTS AND MINIMIZE THE
POTENTIAL UTILIZATION OF
CONGREGATE CARE. PSYCH HAS LED A
CAMPAIGN ON GROWING, PLACEMENT,
STABILITY, AND ALTHOUGH WE HAVE
SEEN A DECREASE IN NUMBER OF
PLACEMENT CHANGES OF 11 TO 17
YEAR OLDS, THERE'S STILL MORE
WORK TO BE DONE TO STABILIZE.
YOUTH FIRST HAS MADE STRIDES IN
THIS DIRECTION OF STABILIZATION.
YOUTH AND FAMILIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE ARE STILL LEARNING
ABOUT THIS AMAZING RESOURCE AND
AS WE SAVE IT FROM BEING CUT, WE
WILL CONTINUE TO EDUCATE YOUTH
AND FAMILIES ON HOW VALUABLE
THIS PROGRAM REALLY IS. THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM HAS RAISED
GENERATIONS OF YOUTH WHO SEE
MAKING MISTAKES AS A RISK. A
RISK THAT SHOULDN'T BE TAKEN
LIGHTLY. MISTAKES THAT MEAN
TRASH BAGS, MISTAKES THAT MEAN
NØ OR SEVEN DAY NOTICES AS
MISTAKES THAT MEAN SCHOOL
CHANGES. MISTAKES THAT MEAN
DIFFERENT FAMILY MISTAKES. THAT
MISTAKES ARE WHAT STAND BETWEEN
THE BEDS YOU SLEPT IN LAST NIGHT
AND THE BED YOU USED TONIGHT.
MOST IMPORTANTLY, MISTAKES
JEOPARDIZE YOUR ABILITY TO BE
PART OF A FAMILY. SO WHEN YOUTH
STAND FOR FURS, IT'S NOT TO
PRESERVE THEIR FAMILY OR
PLACEMENT BECAUSE SOMETIMES IT'S
NOT A GOOD FIT, RIGHT? BUT FURS
IS ALSO A PROGRAM THAT CAN
ENSURE THAT YOUTH HAVE THE HELP
AND SUPPORT DURING FAMILY AND
PLACEMENT TRANSITIONS, ENSURING
I, CHRISTOPHER, AT TEN, 12, 13
AND 17 WHEN MOVING BETWEEN
FAMILIES, KNEW THAT MAKING
MISTAKES WAS OKAY AND THAT
SOMETIMES FAMILIES NEED SUPPORT
TO BE EFFECTIVE, HAD FIRST BEEN
A RESOURCE I COULD HAVE UTILIZED
, I WOULDN'T HAVE WALKED THROUGH
LIFE OR PLACEMENT CHANGES ALONE,
CONSTANTLY FEARING MISTAKES. MY
MISTAKES WOULD HAVE BEEN MET
WITH GRACE AND FOSTER CARE
SPECIFIC PROFESSIONALS WHO COULD
HAVE EXPLAINED THE SITUATION TO
ME. I ASKED, PLEASE PROTECT
FIRST. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANKS, CHRISTOPHER. MISTER
SKYDANCER, DO YOU HAVE YOU
ENCOUNTERED ANY RAMP UP ISSUES
OR PROBLEMS WITH RUNNING THE
PROGRAM? WE HEARD FROM LAO THAT
NOT ALL COUNTIES ARE UTILIZING
THEIR FUNDS, AND I KNOW YOU CAN
ONLY SPEAK TO LA COUNTY. THE
BEST WAY FOR ME TO ANSWER THAT,
IS TO SAY WE'VE HAD AN AWESOME
SUPPORT FROM OUR ADMINISTRATION
THAT WE JUMPED IN BOTH FEET AND
JUST SAID, WE'RE DOING IT, AND
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE IT
SUCCESSFUL. AND FORTUNATELY, MY
ADMINISTRATION SAW THAT I CAME
FROM ANOTHER PROGRAM THAT WAS A
PILOT, AND IT SOLIDIFIED IN LA
COUNTY. IT'S ACTUALLY GROWN
THREE TIMES. SO WE BELIEVED IN A
LOT OF THE OVERLAPPING
PHILOSOPHIES THAT HAPPEN WITH
FORS AND HOW IT COULD BE
EFFECTIVE. AND WE'VE SEEN THE
REDUCTION IN IN SHELTER, CARE
FOR YOUTH, SHELTER CARE, UNDER
THAT UMBRELLA. SO WE KNEW HOW IT
WOULD CASCADE. AND WE JUMPED IN
FEET FIRST AS, AS QUICK AS WE
COULD AND JUST PULLED VERY
AWESOME PEOPLE INTO THE PROGRAM.
AND LUCKILY, THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE AND
HAVE SEEN THE FRUITS OF THE
LABOR. THE STATISTICS THAT GAVE
YOU. AND WHEN EVERYBODY CAN GET
BY THAT I SEE THAT REALLY AMPING
UP. AS EVERYBODY SAID,
INCREASINGLY NOW WE'RE GETTING
ON PRIVATE FACEBOOK MESSAGE
BOARDS THAT ARE JUST FOR
CAREGIVERS THAT WE'RE NOT
INVITED TO. WE'RE HEARING WE'RE
ON THERE AND THEY'RE SAYING,
CALL FIRST. THEY CAN HELP YOU
OUT. AND WE'RE GETTING INTO
ANOTHER ELEMENTS NOW WHERE IT'S
COMMUNITY, IT'S GRASSROOTS,
WHERE THEY'RE PROMOTING WITHIN
THEMSELVES, SAYING THIS IS A
NEWER PROGRAM, IT'S OUTSIDE OF
DCFS, AND THEY GO IN WITH WE GO
IN WITH THE LENS OF NOT
ACCUSATION OR INVESTIGATION.
IT'S SUPPORT. AND THAT'S HOW WE
STEP IN. AND REALLY, THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE COMMUNITY
HAS SEEN THAT'S WHY IT'S
SUCCESSFUL. SO IF THE SENORAS
ARE SHARING THE INFORMATION,
IT'S GOING TO SPREAD WIDE. YES,
EXACTLY, ANGELA, DO WE HAVE A
LIST OF THE COUNTIES THAT
UTILIZE THE FUNDING VERSUS THE
ONES THAT DON'T, WE WOULD NEED
TO WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION,
BUT I THINK THAT IS SOMETHING WE
COULD LOOK INTO COUNTY BY COUNTY
EXPENDITURE TABLE. AND I'M NOT
SURE FOR YOU OR MR. DAVIS, IS
THERE FLEXIBILITY IN THIS
FUNDING? WHEREAS WE SEE SOME
COUNTIES THAT DON'T UTILIZE IT
ALL AND WE CAN, READJUST THE
FUNDING IN THAT SENSE. LIKE WE
SEND IT TO SOME COUNTIES THAT
ARE ALWAYS MAXING OUT EACH TIME.
IS THERE A ROOM FOR THAT, OR IS
IT JUST SET IN STONE THAT EVERY
COUNTY IN THE PAST COUPLE OF
YEARS HAVE GOTTEN THE SAME
AMOUNT EACH TIME? MARLIN DAVIS,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, WE'RE
CONTINUING TO BE OPEN TO ANY
DISCUSSION TO BALANCE THE
BUDGET. NO, NO NO NO, I'M. YES,
I'M ASKING HOW IT'S BEEN DONE SO
FAR. IS HAS IN THE PAST COUPLE
OF YEARS IS THE PROGRAM HAS BEEN
RUNNING THE FUNDING THAT GOES
OUT. IF THERE'S SOME FUNDING
THAT ISN'T UTILIZED, DOES IT GET
CLAWED BACK, DOES IT GET
REALLOCATED IN A DIFFERENT
PROGRAM? DOES IT GET REALLOCATED
TO ANOTHER COUNTY THAT IS
UTILIZING OTHER FUNDS? OR MAYBE
YOU HAVE THE ANSWER. I WOULD
HAVE TO DEFER THAT TO, OKAY, I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION. AND WE
WHILE I DON'T HAVE A SORT OF
COUNTY BY COUNTY ACCOUNTING IN
FRONT OF ME DIRECTLY, I WILL SAY
THAT WE HAVE OBSERVED THAT THERE
ARE SOME LARGER COUNTIES LIKE
LA, WHERE, UTILIZATION HAS BEEN
HIGHER. WE HAVE SEEN SOME LARGER
COUNTIES AND, AND SORT OF MEDIUM
SIZED COUNTIES WHERE, IT HAS NOT
TAKEN OFF IN THE SAME WAY
RELATIVE TO THEIR NUMBERS OF
CHILDREN AND YOUTH, WE HAVE SEEN
THE PROGRAM IMPLEMENTED JULY
1ST, 2021. WE'VE SEEN AN UPTICK
IN IMPLEMENTATION EVERY YEAR
SINCE THAT TIME. SO SOME OF THIS
MAY BE THE SORT OF NATURAL
BEGINNINGS OF A NEWER PROGRAM,
AS IT IS TAKING OFF, WE DO HAVE
SOME PROGRAMS IN THE DEPARTMENT
WHERE THE KINDS OF
REDISTRIBUTION THAT YOU'RE
DESCRIBING DO OCCUR, WHERE WE
MIGHT HAVE COUNTIES THAT ARE
OVER UTILIZING, COUNTIES THAT
ARE UNDER. I'M NOT AWARE THAT WE
HAVE SPECIFICALLY HAD THAT
CONVERSATION WITH RESPECT TO
FORS. I'M HAPPY TO GO BACK AND
ASK THAT QUESTION AND BRING YOU
ANY ADDITIONAL INFORMATION, IF
THERE IS ANY, BUT IN, IN
GENERAL, IF THE FUNDING IS NOT
UTILIZED, IT WOULD REVERT TO THE
GENERAL FUND IN TIME. OKAY
EILEEN PINCH-HITTER. SO WE DO
HAVE A REDISTRIBUTION PROCESS
BEFORE IT WOULD REVERT TO THE
GENERAL FUND. FOR COUNTIES THAT
OVERSPEND THE ALLOCATION, IT IS
KIND OF MOVED ALL AROUND. THEY
USE AS MUCH OF IT AS THEY CAN.
AND THEN IF THERE'S ANY LEFT
OVER, IT DOES REVERT TO THE
GENERAL FUND, WE'VE WORKED VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND
THEY'VE BEEN GREAT ABOUT MOVING
MONEY AROUND EARLY. WE HAVEN'T
DONE THAT YET FOR FORS BECAUSE
WE IT HAS BEEN EARLY IN
IMPLEMENTATION. SO WE DON'T YOU
KNOW, WE WANT COUNTIES TO PLAN
FOR SPENDING IT ALL DURING THE
YEAR. BUT THERE ARE PROCESSES
THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE THAT CAN
MOVE MONEY AROUND. YOU KNOW,
SOONER THAN THAT, THAT NORMAL
TIME WHEN THAT HAPPENS, I THINK
FOR FORS, ONE OF THE OTHER
CHALLENGES IN IMPLEMENTATION HAS
REALLY BEEN BUILDING TRUST IN
THE COMMUNITIES. AND YOU'VE
HEARD MR. SKYDANCER TALK A LOT
ABOUT ABOUT IT. AND SO I THINK
IT HAS TAKEN LONGER TO BUILD UP
IN SOME COMMUNITIES, NOT JUST
FOR THE CAREGIVERS, BUT FOR THE
YOUTH THEMSELVES. AND SO THAT'S
BEEN AN ADDED LAYER, I THINK, OF
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGE AROUND
THIS PROGRAM. BUT THE WORD IS
GETTING OUT ABOUT FORS. AND SO I
DO THINK THAT THEY'LL THEY'LL
THE UPTICK IS GOING TO CONTINUE.
SO DID WANT TO DID WANT TO THROW
THAT PERSPECTIVE OUT THERE AS
WELL. THANK YOU. IN REGARDS TO
SOAPS AND I'D LIKE TO COME BACK
TO YOU, MISS, MISS POPE. DID YOU
I KNOW I HEARD YOU SPEAK ABOUT,
YOU KNOW, THE, THE AMOUNT WAS
MADE IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR YOU
TO FIND A LOCATION BECAUSE OF
THE COST AND SO FORTH. AT WHAT
POINT? AND I KNOW WE ONLY HEARD
YOUR PART OF YOUR STORY. WHAT
HELPED, WHAT ALLOWED YOU TO FIND
A LOCATION? WAS IT JUST GETTING
A LANDLORD THAT Ã THAT DIDN'T
LOOK AT ALL THE BACKGROUND, THE
FINANCES AND ALL THAT, OR WAS
THERE SOMETHING THAT CAME THAT
HELPED YOU FIND A PLACE? AT THAT
TIME WHEN I WAS LOOKING FOR
HOUSING, I WAS VERY AWARE OF THE
STARK REALITY THAT I WAS GOING
TO BE RELYING ON THE KINDNESS OF
STRANGERS AND JUST HOPING THAT I
COULD FIND SOMEONE WHO WOULD BE
WILLING TO ACCEPT ME, EVEN WITH
MY INCOME ISSUES, BECAUSE I AT
THAT TIME WAS, YOU KNOW,
CONSIDERED LOW INCOME, BUT A LOT
OF SUBSIDIZED HOUSING, LOW
INCOME APARTMENTS DON'T ACCEPT
COLLEGE GRANTS EITHER. SO I
STILL DIDN'T QUALIFY THERE, AND
IF I DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH, SAY,
WORK HISTORY, WHICH OFTENTIMES
FOSTER YOUTH MOVING AROUND A
LOT, DON'T EXACTLY HAVE STABLE
EMPLOYMENT EITHER. SO ON ALL
FRONTS, I DIDN'T HAVE THE
QUALIFICATIONS. SO IF I DIDN'T
FIND A LANDLORD WHO WAS
UNDERSTANDING OF MY SITUATION,
WHICH, CONSIDERING THE
PREVALENCE OF CORPORATE
LANDLORDS NOWADAYS THAT ARE MORE
ABOUT WHAT YOU LOOK LIKE ON
PAPER THAN ABOUT WHAT YOUR STORY
IS, LIKE I SAID, I WAS RELYING
ON THE KINDNESS OF PEOPLE THAT I
WAS JUST HOPEFUL WOULD BE
WILLING TO LISTEN. AND DO WE
HAVE ANYTHING, I DIDN'T DO ANY
WORK ON HOMEWORK ON THIS, BUT DO
WE IS THERE ANYTHING EXIST, KIND
OF LIKE SECTION EIGHT OR HOUSING
VOUCHERS. WHERE IS IT? THE SAME
TYPE OF APPROACH WHERE A
LANDLORD HAS TO ACCEPT IT? THEY
DON'T. IT'S NOT A MANDATE FOR
THEM TO ACCEPT IT, A CILP IS NOT
LIKE THAT. THERE IS A FOSTER
YOUTH TO INDEPENDENCE FYI
VOUCHER AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
THAT IS A VOUCHER THAT IS
SPECIFIC TO, FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH, CURRENT OR FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH. THAT SAID, WE HAVE
ENCOUNTERED WITH ALL OTHER
STATES IN THE NATION A LOT OF
DIFFICULTY IN UTILIZING THOSE
VOUCHERS AND HAVE HAD SOME
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ABOUT WAYS THAT WE
THINK THEY COULD RESTRUCTURE
THAT ARE NOT WITHIN OUR CONTROL,
BUT THAT VOUCHER DOES EXIST. THE
CILP ITSELF COULD BE, A VARIETY
OF KINDS OF PLACEMENTS. AND I
THINK THAT MISS POPE SORT OF
REFERENCED THIS. IT'S INTENDED
TO BE FOR NON-MINOR DEPENDENTS
WHO, ARE ARE READY FOR A LEVEL
OF INDEPENDENCE AND COULD LIVE
IN AN APARTMENT, A DORM, A
SINGLE ROOM. THEY COULD LIVE
WITH RELATIVES, THEY COULD LIVE
IN THE HOME OF THEIR PARENT OR
GUARDIAN. THEY COULD BE IN JOB
CORPS. THERE'S A WIDE VARIETY OF
PLACES. THE IDEA IS, IN THE LAW
IS THAT THE COUNTY IS SUPPOSED
TO BE ASSESSING THE YOUNG PERSON
FOR READINESS FOR THAT SITUATION
AND MAKING SURE THAT THERE IS
INDEED A SUITABLE PLACE FOR THEM
TO LIVE. AND THEN TO UTILIZE THE
SLP AS A PAYMENT TO SUPPORT THAT
PLACEMENT. AND WHEN I ONE OF THE
FIRST QUESTIONS I ASKED WAS WHEN
COULD WE ASSUME IT COULD GO IN?
THE REASON WHY I WAS ASKING IS
BECAUSE LATER WE'RE GOING TO BE
TALKING ABOUT THE RATE REFORM.
AND IT SEEMS LIKE, YOU KNOW,
EVEN IF WE MOVE FORWARD WITH
THIS INCREASE, IT'LL START
ALMOST AT THE SAME TIME AS THE
RATE REFORM. RIGHT OKAY. AND
THEN I'M WONDERING, THERE'S
ABOUT FIVE COUNTIES THAT EVEN
WITH THE RATE REFORM, CORRECT,
THEY WILL NOT MEET THE MINIMUM
REQUIREMENT TO, TO BE ABLE TO
FIND AN APARTMENT BECAUSE IT'S
SO EXPENSIVE, LIKE OUR BAY
COUNTY AREAS. THERE ARE. SO I
THINK PROBABLY WHAT YOU'RE
REFERENCING IS THE DIFFERENCE OF
THE CURRENT RATE WITH THE SOAP
SUPPLEMENT VERSUS THE RATE
REFORM RATE. SO THE WAY THAT
WE'VE DONE THAT CALCULATION,
IT'S ABOUT 96% OF YOUTH ACROSS
THE STATE WHO WOULD RECEIVE A
HIGHER RATE FOR SOAPS UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. AND ABOUT
4% OF YOUTH IN ABOUT FIVE BAY
AREA COUNTIES, WHICH YOU'RE
REFERENCING, FOR WHOM IT'S NOT
EXACTLY THAT SAME AMOUNT. YEAH.
MAY I ADD SOMETHING TO THAT? YES
I THINK ONE PROBLEM IS WE'RE
TALKING APPLES AND ORANGES. SO
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT, THE
FACTS THAT MISS TROIA IS
REFERENCING, THAT HAS TO DO WITH
THE CARE AND SUPERVISION RATE OF
$1,788 AND THEN ADDING ON $500
OF WHAT'S CALLED THE STRENGTHS
BUILDING PROGRAM THAT IS NOT
PROVIDED DIRECTLY TO A YOUNG
PERSON, ACCORDING TO THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE. SO IF YOU LOOK AT
THE CARE AND SUPERVISION RATE,
THAT'S ACTUALLY GOING TO BE THE
SOAP RATE PROVIDED TO YOUTH, 80%
OF YOUTH WOULD RECEIVE MORE
MONEY. UNDER THE CURRENT LAW OF
THE SOAP HOUSING SUPPLEMENT THAN
THEY WOULD UNDER THE RATES
PROPOSAL. SO IT DEPENDS WHAT
YOU'RE LOOKING AT. ARE YOU
LOOKING AT THAT IN-KIND? $500
WORTH OF SORT OF
EXTRACURRICULARS, ENRICHMENT
ACTIVITIES, OR ARE YOU LOOKING
AT THE MONEY INTENDED TO PROVIDE
THE CARE AND SUPERVISION THAT
GOES DIRECTLY TO YOUNG PEOPLE,
THAT COVERS SHELTER, FOOD, ALL
THE BASIC NEEDS? I THINK I WAS
LOOKING AND I THOUGHT THE CARE
AND SUPERVISION WAS STRAIGHT TO
THE CAREGIVER, NOT THE IN THE
CASE OF A SOAP, THE CARE AND
SUPERVISION IS STRAIGHT TO THE
YOUNG PERSON, SO I THINK THAT'S,
IT IS IT IS TRUE THAT WE'RE SORT
OF LOOKING AT THIS DIFFERENTLY
FROM THE DEPARTMENT'S
PERSPECTIVE. WE ARE CONSIDERING
ALL OF THAT TO BE THE SOAP RATE.
WE'RE LOOKING AT IT, AND
INCLUDING THE $500 THAT GOES
TOWARDS STRENGTHS BUILDING ON
THE ASSUMPTION THAT THAT CAN BE
BROADLY UTILIZED FOR THINGS THAT
THE YOUNG PERSON NEEDS, THERE'S
A LOT OF FLEXIBILITY. AND SO
THOSE RESOURCES ARE STILL
RELEVANT AND NOT ALL OF THE SOAP
RATE NORMALLY WOULD GO TO RENT
ANYWAY, RIGHT? SOME OF THE RATE
WOULD ALSO BE SUPPORTING OTHER
THINGS IN THE YOUTH'S LIFE THAT
$500 COULD OFFSET. SO WE ARE
VIEWING IT AS THE 1788 PLUS. THE
500 IS THE TOTAL AMOUNT THAT IS
AVAILABLE TO A YOUNG PERSON IN A
SOAP, AND I UNDERSTAND THAT JRB
IS TAKING A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE, THAT THE 500 IS A
SORT OF SEPARATE, SEPARATE, BUT
IT CAN OFFSET ADDITIONAL COSTS
TO THE YOUTH THAT CAN THEN THEY
CAN PULL THAT INTO THEIR RENT.
THAT IS OUR PERSPECTIVE, BUT
THEY DON'T GET IT DIRECTLY. IT'S
PAID BY A PAYMENT MANAGER. YES,
YES. YEAH. THOUGHTS ON THAT TO
COME? SO HAVE WE LOOKED AT
PERHAPS, AT MINIMUM THAT AT
MINIMUM AT LEAST MAKING HÌ THOSE
APPROXIMATELY FIVE COUNTIES THAT
WON'T MEET THAT THRESHOLD, IT'S
NOT A PART OF OUR PROPOSAL
PRESENTLY UNDER THE RATE REFORM
TO DO THAT, IT IS SOMETHING THAT
WE LOOKED AT AND RECOGNIZED THAT
IT WOULD TAKE ADDITIONAL GENERAL
FUND OF. I THINK IT'S SEVERAL
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS. OKAY
COULD WHEN WE HAVE AN EXACT
NUMBER, COULD YOU SEND THAT
OVER, PLEASE? WE SURE CAN. OKAY
SENATOR, YOU MISSED IT. I HAD A
BREAKDOWN. THERE IS NOTHING THAT
I COULD DO OR SAY TO MATCH THE
AMAZING CHAIR THAT I SERVE WITH
ON THIS BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE. I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAD ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING THAT I COULD DO TO ADD
TO YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK YOU FOR
ASKING. HOWEVER. OKAY. ANY FINAL
THOUGHTS FROM ANYONE? WE'RE
GOING TO WRAP UP THE PANEL HERE.
OKAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING OUT AND SPEAKING TO,
THESE VERY IMPORTANT ISSUES. I
APPRECIATE IT. WE'RE GOING TO
HOLD THE ITEMS, ITEMS OPEN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. YOU KNOW, I
JUST CARRY YOUR BRIEFCASE.
WILLINGLY HONORED TO SERVE.
WE'RE JUST ON ISSUE NUMBER TWO.
MOVING ON TO FOSTER CARE RATE
REFORM. WELCOME THE DEPARTMENT.
MR. DAVIS IS BACK WITH US.
ANGELA IS STICKING AROUND.
ANOTHER REPRESENTATIVE FROM
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION TO
COME UP. EILEEN CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES, CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
CAREGIVERS AND A REP FROM YOUTH
LAW CENTER. A TOTAL OF EIGHT
PEOPLE. I SEE 910. WE HAVE TWO
FINANCE PEOPLE HERE. OKAY, SO
IT'S THE FINANCE THAT WE HAVE TO
YES, WE DO SO 123456802 YES, OF
COURSE I KNEW THAT. OKAY JUST
MAKING SURE. ALL RIGHT. KICK US
OFF DIRECTOR. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, KIM JOHNSON,
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. AND JUST GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION THAT
JUST TOOK PLACE IN THE FIRST
PANEL, WE ARE REALLY AIMING TO
SUPPORT YOUTH AND FAMILIES IN
OUR FOSTER CARE SYSTEM AND CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM, BUILDING ON WHAT
WE KNOW HAS WORKED IN CONTINUUM
OF CARE, WHICH WAS FOUNDED UPON
THE COLLECTIVE BELIEF THAT ALL
CHILDREN SERVED BY THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM NEED, DESERVE AND
HAVE AN ABILITY TO BE PART OF A
LOVING FAMILY AND NOT TO GROW UP
IN CONGREGATE SETTINGS. AS YOU
KNOW, IN OUR CCR EFFORTS,
PLACEMENT STABILITY INDICATORS
FOR CHILDREN REMAINING IN THEIR
FIRST PLACEMENT HAVE ALSO
CONTINUED TO GROW. 75% OF YOUTH
THAT HAVE HAD THAT FIRST
PLACEMENT WITH A RELATIVE AND
ARE STILL IN CARE AT 12 MONTHS
ARE STILL WITH THAT RELATIVE. SO
AGAIN, WE'RE TRYING TO BUILD ON
LESSONS LEARNED AND PROGRESS
WE'VE MADE TO DATE IN THE CCR
PLACE. FUNDAMENTALLY, THIS RATE
REFORM PROPOSAL IS FOCUSED ON
KEEPING FAMILIES TOGETHER,
ASSESSING AND MEETING THE
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS OF EACH YOUTH
AND ADVANCING EQUITY. THE
PROPOSED PERMANENT RATE
STRUCTURE INVESTS IN STRENGTH
BUILDING AND ADDRESSING THE
IMMEDIATE NEEDS OF CHILDREN AND
YOUTH, ALLOWING US TO GREATLY
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN
LIVING WITH THEIR OWN FAMILY
MEMBERS AND TRIBES, WITH THE
SUPPORT NECESSARY TO ENSURE THE
SUCCESS OF THOSE PLACEMENTS AND
SETTINGS. THE POSITIVE
EXPERIENCES THAT YOUTH ARE MORE
LIKELY TO HAVE WHEN CARED FOR BY
THEIR OWN FAMILY AND WHEN THEY
HAVE CONNECTIONS TO ENRICHMENT
AND CULTURAL ACTIVITIES, HAVE
BEEN PROVEN TO HELP MITIGATE THE
MENTAL HEALTH DAMAGE CAUSED BY
ACES AND TO HELP THAT YOUTH
HEAL. WE WANT REIMBURSEMENT
RATES TO BE RESPONSIVE TO WHAT
YOUTH AND FAMILIES NEED TO
THRIVE, SO THAT THE PROPOSED
RATE STRUCTURE SUPPORT SERVICES
IN PLACE BASED ON THE CHILD'S
CANN'S ASSESSMENT AND IDENTIFIED
NEEDS. IF ADOPTED, CALIFORNIA
WOULD BE THE FIRST STATE IN THE
NATION TO TAKE THIS APPROACH.
THE PROPOSAL ALSO INVESTS IN NEW
APPROACHES TO RATES UP UNTIL
NOW, THE RATE STRUCTURE HAS ONLY
PAID FOR CARE AND SUPERVISION.
THIS PROPOSAL ADDS INVESTMENTS
FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER IN
STRENGTHS BUILDING AND
ADDRESSING A CHILD'S IMMEDIATE
NEED. IF THEIR CANS INDICATES
THAT THEY HAVE THOSE ACTIONABLE
NEEDS. PARTICIPATION IN
ENRICHMENT ACTIVITIES HAS BEEN
PROVEN TO HELP YOUNG PEOPLE
HEAL, PROMOTE SUPPORTIVE SOCIAL
CONNECTIONS, AND PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES TO DEVELOP
VALUABLE SKILLS AND IS
CONSISTENT. WHAT WE'VE HEARD
FROM YOUTH IN TERMS OF WHAT'S
NEEDED, WHAT'S NEEDED. THE
PROPOSAL MAKES SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES. I WANT TO JUST
UNDERSCORE YOUR AGENDA OUTLINES.
IT IS A SIGNIFICANT CHANGE FROM
THE STRUCTURE THAT WE HAVE
TODAY. AS SUCH, WE LOOK FORWARD
NOT TO NOT ONLY ENGAGING WITH
INTERESTED PARTIES IN THE SHORT
TERM, BUT ALSO HAVING FOCUSED
EFFORTS ON CAPACITY BUILDING AND
OTHER DETAILS THAT WILL SUPPORT
OUR COLLECTIVE SUCCESS IN
OPERATIONALIZING THIS PROPOSAL
OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS. AS
AGAIN, YOU HEARD FULL
IMPLEMENTATION IS EXPECTED TO
BEGIN IN 2627 AND I'LL TURN IT
OVER TO DEPUTY DIRECTOR SCHWARTZ
. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR, AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TODAY. MY NAME IS ANGIE
SCHWARTZ. I'M THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE CHILDREN AND
FAMILY SERVICES DIVISION, AND
I'LL FOCUS ON THE QUESTIONS IN
THE AGENDA. SINCE DIRECTOR
JOHNSON JUST PROVIDED A GOOD A
GREAT OVERVIEW IN RESPONSE TO
THE QUESTION REGARDING HOW THIS
COMPARES TO THE CURRENT RATES,
THE PROPOSAL PROVIDES NEW
FUNDING. AS DIRECTOR JOHNSON
NOTED, TO SUPPORT STRENGTH
BUILDING FOR YOUTH ACROSS ALL
PLACEMENT, INCLUDING YOUTH WITH
AN EXTENDED FOSTER CARE. AS YOU
WERE JUST HAVING THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT YOUTH AND
SLPS. ADDITIONALLY, AS NOTED,
UNDER OUR INTERIM RATES, YOUTH
WITH THE HIGHEST ACUITY OF NEEDS
ONLY QUALIFY FOR THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF FUNDING WHEN THEY'RE
WITHIN INSTITUTIONAL PLACEMENTS,
AND THIS PROPOSAL ALLOWS FOR
THOSE SUPPORTS TO BE PROVIDED TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF CHILDREN
WITHIN FAMILY SETTINGS OR FOR
OLDER YOUTH WITHIN THE
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING SETTINGS.
THAT ENABLES US TO SUPPORT
CHILDREN IN THE HOMES WHERE WE
KNOW THEY DO BEST. AS DIRECTOR
JOHNSON NOTED, THROUGH THE
STATISTICS IN THE HOMES OF THEIR
RELATIVES AND THEIR EXTENDED
FAMILY MEMBERS, THIS PROPOSAL
WAS NOT DESIGNED IN ISOLATION.
IT'S SINCERELY RESPONSIVE TO THE
STAKEHOLDER FEEDBACK WE SOUGHT
AND RECEIVED DURING THE COURSE
OF MORE THAN 24 WORKGROUP
MEETINGS HELD IN THE FALL OF
2022, THE CONSENSUS COMING FROM
THOSE WORKGROUPS WAS RATES
SHOULD BE BASED ON THE CHILD'S
ASSESSED NEEDS. USING A
VALIDATED ASSESSMENT TOOL. WE
HEARD CLEARLY THAT THERE NEEDS
TO BE FUNDING TO SUPPORT
SERVICES, THAT HAS NEVER BEEN
PART OF OUR SYSTEM BEFORE. AND
WE HEARD DIRECTLY FROM YOUNG
PEOPLE ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
INVESTING IN THEIR STRENGTHS AND
MAINTAINING THEIR STRENGTHS WHEN
THEY COME INTO CARE. IN TERMS OF
THE OVERVIEW, DIRECTOR JOHNSON
NOTED THE THREE KEY INNOVATIONS.
FIRST, THAT THE RATES WILL BE
BASED ON THE CHILD'S ASSESSED
LEVEL OF NEED, UTILIZING THE
CANS, WHICH IS A HIGHLY
VALIDATED FUNCTIONAL ASSESSMENT
TOOL THAT'S BEEN REQUIRED TO BE
UTILIZED WITHIN CHILD WELFARE
SINCE 2018. SECOND, THE TWO NEW
INVESTMENTS THAT DIRECTOR
JOHNSON NOTED STRENGTH BUILDING
AND IMMEDIATE NEEDS FOR THOSE
CHILDREN WHERE NEEDS HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED BY THE CANS. AND
FINALLY, THE FUNDING SHIFTS AWAY
FROM BEING CONNECTED TO THE
PLACEMENT AND IS INSTEAD
CONNECTED TO THE CHILD. IN
RESPONSE TO YOUR QUESTION ABOUT
HOW THIS ADDRESSES BARRIERS TO
SUPPORT YOUTH WITH COMPLEX CARE
NEEDS AND ENABLING CHILDREN TO
HAVE FUNDING CONNECTED TO THEIR
NEEDS IN ANY PLACEMENT SETTING
IS VERY RESPONSIVE. AS I
INDICATED RIGHT NOW, YOUTH WITH
THE HIGHEST LEVEL, THE MOST
COMPLEX NEEDS CAN ONLY HAVE
THOSE NEEDS MET WITHIN
INSTITUTIONAL SETTINGS WHERE
THERE'S DISCONNECTION FROM
FAMILY AND SUPPORTS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY CRITICAL TO THAT YOUNG
PERSON. HEALING AND THRIVING IN
TERMS OF THE ADMINISTRATIVE
COMPONENTS OF THE PROPOSAL THAT
YOU ASKED ABOUT. UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL, FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES
AND STRIPS WILL CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE FUNDING TO SUPPORT CARE
AND SUPERVISION, AS WELL AS
THEIR ADMINISTRATIVE EXPENSES AS
THEY DO NOW. UNDER THE CURRENT
RATES, HOWEVER, THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PORTION OF THE
RATE FOR YOUTH WITHIN TIERS TWO,
THREE AND THREE PLUS UNDER THE
PROPOSAL IS GOING TO BE
RESTRUCTURED TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS DEDICATED FUNDING TO
SUPPORT IMMEDIATE NEEDS INSTEAD
OF BUNDLING IT ALL TOGETHER AS
PART OF THE ADMINISTRATIVE RATE
STRUCTURING THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS
DOLLARS IN THIS WAY ENSURES THE
IMMEDIATE NEEDS FUNDING TRAVELS
WITH THE YOUTH IT ENABLES FOR
THOSE NEEDS TO BE MADE AND MET
EVEN WHEN THEY'RE NOT IN
FACILITIES LIKE HTTPS OR FAS. SO
WHEN WITHIN THEIR OWN FAMILY
SETTINGS, IT'S ALSO AN
INVESTMENT IN COMMUNITY SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS AND FACILITATES
PROVIDERS CREATING NEW MODELS IN
ORDER TO SERVE CHILDREN WITHIN
THEIR THE HOMES OF THEIR
RELATIVES AND EXTENDED FAMILY
MEMBERS AND HAVING DEDICATED
FUNDING FOR IMMEDIATE NEEDS ALSO
MEANS THERE WILL BE MORE STATE
WIDENESS AND CONTINUITY OF
SERVICES. FOR EXAMPLE, WHEN A
YOUTH TRANSITIONS FROM AN STREEP
INTO A HOME PLACEMENT, THE
SERVICES CAN TRAVEL WITH THEM
AND CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE
YOUTH IN THAT FAMILY SETTING. IN
TERMS OF THE TIMELINE AND
IMPLEMENTATION QUESTIONS SINCE
THE RELEASE OF THE TRAILER BILL
ON MARCH 5TH, WE'VE BEEN ENGAGED
IN EXTENSIVE STAKEHOLDER
FEEDBACK. THE TRAILER BILL IS
LENGTHY AND COMPLEX, AS THE
AGENDA NOTES, AND AS EXPECTED,
WITH SUCH COMPREHENSIVE REFORM,
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF FEEDBACK
THAT WE'RE RECEIVING. THERE HAVE
BEEN MANY QUESTIONS RAISED WHICH
WE ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING
THROUGH AND IMPLEMENTATION. AS
NOTED IN THE LAST PANEL, THE
PROPOSED RATES WOULD SET TO
IMPLEMENT IN JULY. YES JULY
26TH, FOLLOWING AUTOMATION OF
THE NEW RATE STRUCTURE LEADING
UP TO THAT OVER THE NEXT TWO
YEARS. AS WE APPROACH THAT DATE,
OUR INTENTION IS TO CONTINUE TO
WORK CLOSELY AND COLLABORATIVELY
WITH COUNTIES, TRIBES AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE NOT INCREASING THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN ON
COUNTIES OR ON PROVIDERS, AND
THAT WE ARE MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE NEW STRENGTH BUILDING
DOLLARS AND IMMEDIATE NEEDS
DOLLARS WOULD BE READILY
AVAILABLE ACROSS ALL PLACEMENT
SETTINGS IN ORDER TO SUPPORT ALL
OF OUR CHILDREN. AS TO YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT TIMELY AND
QUALITY CANS, WE ARE ALREADY
DOING WORK TO ENSURE FIDELITY TO
THE CANS AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL YOUTH ARE RECEIVING CANS
TIMELY. WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
CANS RESEARCHERS TO IDENTIFY THE
FIDELITY TOOLS AND ARE IN
DISCUSSION WITH COUNTIES AND
STAKEHOLDERS AND TRIBES ABOUT
HOW TO IMPLEMENT THOSE FIDELITY
TOOLS IN CALIFORNIA. FINALLY, AS
TO THE QUESTION ABOUT THE
MECHANICS OF THE STRENGTH
BUILDING DOLLARS, THIS IS ONE OF
THE ASPECTS OF THE PROPOSAL THAT
WE'RE MOST EXCITED ABOUT, AND IS
WHOLLY RESPONSIVE TO THE
ADVOCACY OF YOUTH OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL DECADES. WE BELIEVE IT
IS CRITICAL THAT THESE FUNDS BE
AVAILABLE THROUGH A
SELF-DETERMINATION MODEL, SO
THAT YOUTH ARE LEADING THE
DECISIONS ABOUT WHERE THESE
DOLLARS SHOULD GO AND THE
ACTIVITIES THAT THEY'LL BE ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE IN. THE GOAL OF
HAVING A FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT
COORDINATOR ASSIGNED TO EACH
YOUTH IS TO ENSURE THAT THESE
FUNDS ARE USED, CONSISTENT WITH
THAT SELF-DETERMINATION MODEL,
AND THAT THEY CAN GET OUT IN A
VERY TIMELY MANNER SO THAT THE
YOUNG PERSON HAS IMMEDIATE
ACCESS FOR THE VARIETY OF
ACTIVITIES THEY WOULD BE
CHOOSING TO PARTICIPATE IN. WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THIS IS A BIG SHIFT
WITH LEVELS OF COMPLEXITY, BUT
IT TAKES THIS TYPE OF SHIFT TO
ACCOMPLISH THE GOAL OF HAVING A
RATE THAT FOLLOWS THE CHILD.
THAT ENSURES CHILDREN CAN STAY
CONNECTED TO THEIR FAMILIES AND
THAT INVESTS IN THEIR NEEDS AND
STRENGTHS. AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. MR.
DAVIS, WOULD YOU LIKE TO ADD
ANYTHING? MARLON DAVIS,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOTHING
FURTHER TO ADD. OKAY. HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. SURE.
ANGELA SHORT LAO, AS YOU'VE
HEARD, THIS PROPOSAL TRULY DOES
REPRESENT A VERY SIGNIFICANT
REVAMPING OF THE CURRENT FOSTER
CARE RATE STRUCTURE AND OVERALL,
AT A HIGH LEVEL, WE WOULD AGREE
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION'S
ASSESSMENT THAT THIS PROPOSAL
DOES SEEM TRULY TO FURTHER TO,
BRING OUR FOSTER CARE RATES INTO
ALIGNMENT WITH THE OVERALL GOALS
OF THE CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM.
FOR EXAMPLE, ONE GOAL IS TO
IMPROVE ACCESS TO SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES REGARDLESS OF THE TYPE
OF FOSTER CARE PLACEMENT A CHILD
IS IN. THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSED NEW STRENGTH BUILDING
AND IMMEDIATE NEEDS AND
COMPONENTS OF THE RATES WE
BELIEVE WOULD DO THAT, ANOTHER
GOAL IS UTILIZING UNIVERSAL
CHILD AND FAMILY ASSESSMENTS TO
IMPROVE PLACEMENT, SERVICE AND
PAYMENT RATE DECISIONS. AND
AGAIN, IT SEEMS THAT UTILIZING
THE KANSEN TOOL COULD COULD HELP
ACHIEVE THAT GOAL, ALSO, AS
YOU'VE HEARD, THIS PROPOSAL IS
VERY MUCH ALIVE AND CONTINUING
TO EVOLVE, THE ADMINISTRATION
AND STAKEHOLDERS ARE CONTINUING
TO ENGAGE IN A NUMBER OF
FEEDBACK SESSIONS, WHICH WE ARE
VERY ACTIVELY MONITORING AND
TRYING TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
FULLY TRACKING ALL OF THE ISSUES
AS THE VARIOUS QUESTIONS,
CONCERNS, COMMENTS THAT VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE WITH SPECIFIC
ELEMENTS OF THE PROPOSAL AND
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE, WHICH I
BELIEVE YOU'LL BE HEARING MORE
ABOUT FROM OTHER SPEAKERS ON
THIS PANEL TODAY, WE ARE WE WILL
CONTINUE TO, YOU KNOW, FLAG ANY
ISSUES THAT WE SEE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AS THEY ARISE.
THAT'S AT A COUPLE OF COMMENTS
WE DID HAVE AT THIS TIME, FIRST,
IF THE LEGISLATURE AGREES WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED
TIMELINE, WHICH, AS WE HEARD,
WOULD BE TO BEGIN ROLLING OUT
THE NEW RATES JULY 20TH, 26. A
QUESTION WE HAVE IS, IN ORDER TO
MEET THAT TIMELINE, WHAT
ELEMENTS OF THE PROPOSAL TRULY
NEED TO BE FINALIZED AND LANDED
NOW AS PART OF THE CURRENT
BUDGET PROCESS VERSUS WHAT
ELEMENTS OF THE PROPOSAL MIGHT
BENEFIT FROM ADDITIONAL
ADDITIONAL TIME AND
CONSIDERATION GIVEN HOW
SIGNIFICANT OF A CHANGE THE
PROPOSAL WOULD BE, THIS IS
SOMETHING WE ARE ALSO OURSELVES
WORKING TO BETTER UNDERSTAND,
THROUGH DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND STAKEHOLDERS.
AND THEN ONE OTHER COMMENT WE
DID JUST WANT TO FLAG IS THAT WE
HAVE NOT YET RECEIVED BACK UP TO
BE ABLE TO REVIEW THE FISCAL
COST ESTIMATE, WHICH IS INCLUDED
IN YOUR AGENDA ON PAGE 11. SO WE
ARE WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO GET MORE
DETAILED INFORMATION ABOUT THE
COST ESTIMATE, PARTICULARLY FOR
THE OUT YEARS. AND ONCE WE HAVE
THAT INFORMATION, WE WILL BE
WORKING TO MAKE SURE WE
UNDERSTAND, ALL OF THAT FROM THE
FISCAL PERSPECTIVE. THANK YOU.
COMMISSIONER, WHAT KIND OF
TRACKING DO YOU THINK WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE FOR THE DEPARTMENT
TO REPORT ON TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE SUCCESSFUL? EXCUSE ME? FOR
US TO MONITOR REPORTING TO THE
LEGISLATURE, I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING WE'D PROBABLY HAVE TO
CONSIDER A BIT MORE, I MEAN,
CERTAINLY, AS WAS MENTIONED,
TIMELY CANS ASSESSMENT. SEEMS
LIKE THAT WOULD BE A KEY ELEMENT
GIVEN HOW CRITICAL, CANS
ASSESSMENTS ARE TO THE PROPOSAL
TO THE NEW RATE STRUCTURE, THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION DOES CURRENTLY
REPORT ON AS PART OF STATUTORILY
REQUIRED QUARTERLY CCR UPDATES.
SO I THINK CONTINUING TO MONITOR
THAT. AND THEN, YOU KNOW, WE'D
BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH STAFF AND
TO THINK MORE ABOUT OTHER
PARTICULAR, KIND OF REPORTING
AND OVERSIGHT ELEMENTS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, BEFORE WE MOVE ON
TO THE REST OF THE PANELISTS,
JUST A COUPLE QUESTIONS IN THE
TBL, THERE'S A SECTION REGARDING
TO DETERMINE A SCHEDULE FOR
TRANSITIONING CHILDREN IN
CURRENT FOSTER CARE PLACEMENTS.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN, A RETURN?
TRANSITION THEM OUT BECAUSE THEY
MIGHT BE TIERED IN A DIFFERENT
LOCATION OR WHAT? I GUESS I
DON'T KNOW. I THINK IT'S
REFERRING TO THAT SECTION OF THE
TRAILER. BILL JUST HOW THEY'LL
TRANSITION FROM THE INTERIM RATE
STRUCTURE TO THE NEW RATE
STRUCTURE, AND WANTING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE TRANSITIONS HAPPEN
WHEN THE CANS IS BEING DONE, BUT
THEN ALSO IN A WAY THAT DOESN'T
DISRUPT, YOU KNOW, CURRENT
PLACEMENTS. SO IF A YOUNG PERSON
WAS ASSESSED AT A LEVEL WHERE
THERE WOULD BE LESS MONEY, WE
WOULD WANT TO TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION AND, AND HAVE THE
SCHEDULE ADJUST FOR THAT. IS
THERE ANY PLACING AGENCY THAT
WOULD NEED TRAINING ON THE CANS
ASSESSMENT? YES. PROBATION IS
CURRENTLY NOT USING CANS OUTSIDE
OF USING IT WITHIN OAN FOR
YOUTH WITHIN THE STRIPS, WHICH
IS WHERE THE MAJORITY OF THEIR
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE PLACED, THEIR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PARTNERS DO
THE CANS FOR YOUTH WITHIN THE
STRIPS, BUT THIS INCLUDES AIDS,
LANGUAGE IN THE TRAILER BILL.
THAT WOULD REQUIRE THE CANS TO
BE COMPLETED FOR ALL YOUTH THAT
ARE SERVED BY ALL OF OUR FOSTER
YOUTH THAT ARE SERVED BY THE
PROBATION SYSTEM. DO YOU
ANTICIPATE ANY DIFFICULTY IN
PROBATION UTILIZING THE CANS
ASSESSMENT? WE HAVE STARTED
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM
ABOUT THAT AND DIFFERENT WAYS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY WOULD BE
ABLE TO GET THE RIGHT TRAINING
AND SUPPORT. RIGHT, IN ORDER TO
BE ABLE TO COME INTO COMPLIANCE
WITH THAT REQUIREMENT. KEEP ME
POSTED. IF THEY'RE HESITANT, DID
YOU WANT I'LL JUST BRIEFLY ADD
CHAIR IN TERMS OF YOUR QUESTION
AROUND TRAINING, THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL ALIGNMENT COMPONENTS
FOR THE CANS TO DO ACROSS
SYSTEM. SO AND I JUST SAY
ONGOING KIND OF TRAINING TO KEEP
FIDELITY IS SOMETHING THAT WE
WANT TO KEEP AN EYE ON AS WELL.
SO THOSE IN ADDITION TO WHAT
DEPUTY DIRECTOR SCHWARTZ
MENTIONED, RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF MAKING SURE THE
ASSESSMENT AND THE INPUTS AND
PROCESS BY WHICH WE'RE MAKING
THAT ASSESSMENT IS ALWAYS DONE
TO FIDELITY. THAT WILL BE AN
ONGOING EFFORT THAT WE'LL BE
WORKING TOWARDS IN IN TALKING
ABOUT WHEN WE'RE PUTTING
TOGETHER THIS STRENGTH BUILDING
SPENDING PLAN AND THE SPENDING
MANAGER REPORT, IN THE TBL, YOU
KNOW, OUR INTENT HERE IS TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION AND SUPPORTS
THE CHILD AND FAMILY UPON
REQUEST REGARDING AVAILABLE
GOODS, SERVICES AND SUPPORTS. I
WAS REMINDED OF WHAT WE SEE WITH
REGIONAL CENTERS WHERE NOT EVERY
SINGLE REGIONAL CENTER PROVIDES
THE SAME AVAILABLE RESOURCES TO
A FAMILY IN FRONT OF THEM. SO
WHAT CAN WE DO TO PREVENT THAT
FROM HAPPENING AND ENSURING THAT
WE HAVE A STANDARD GUIDE AID, OF
WHAT IS OFFERED TO EACH FAMILY
REGARDLESS OF X, Y, Z. SO I
WOULD SAY THAT OUR THE
SELF-DETERMINATION MODEL, WE DID
LOOK AT THE DDS SYSTEM, AND WE
ARE IN CONVERSATION WITH THEM TO
ADDRESS BARRIERS THAT THEY'VE
HAD IN IMPLEMENTING ON THEIR
SIDE, A SIMILAR TYPE OF
SELF-DETERMINATION MODEL FOR
CLIENTS OF THE REGIONAL CENTER.
BUT IT'S NOT COMPLETELY ALIGNED.
RIGHT. SO WE WANT THESE FUNDS TO
BE VERY FLEXIBLE, TO BE ABLE TO
BE UTILIZED BY YOUNG PEOPLE FOR
THE WHOLE RANGE OF KINDS OF
ACTIVITIES AND SERVICES AND
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND
CULTURAL ACTIVITIES, AND ALSO
WAYS JUST TO STAY CONNECTED WITH
THEIR FAMILY. THAT GOES WELL
BEYOND SORT OF A GUIDE. I THINK,
YOU KNOW, WE'VE HEARD THAT IT
WOULD BE HELPFUL TO HAVE SORT OF
THINGS THAT ARE ALREADY KNOWN TO
BE ACTIVITIES THAT THAT, OF
COURSE, ARE ALLOWABLE THINGS. SO
ANYTHING ASSOCIATED WITH SCHOOL
AND SCHOOL TRIPS AND, YOU KNOW,
SPORTING ACTIVITIES AND THEATER
AND. RIGHT, SO WE CAN THINK OF A
LARGE A LONG LIST OF THINGS THAT
WOULD BE INCLUDED, BUT WE DON'T
WANT IT. IT WOULD DEFINITELY BE
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO,
BECAUSE WE WANT YOUNG PEOPLE TO
BE DIRECTING THESE DOLLARS. AND
THAT STRENGTH BUILDING PLAN IS
REALLY INTENDED, INTENDED TO
SORT OF REFLECT WHAT THEY WANT
TO DO. AND SO IT COULD BE A LOT
OF OTHER THINGS THAT WE MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO COME UP WITH AS WE'RE
PUTTING THAT TOGETHER, BECAUSE,
YEAH, I WAS LIKE ONE OF MY
QUESTIONS AND THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION, WAS LIKE, IS IT
AN EXHAUSTIVE LIST? IT'S GOING
TO BE A LIVING DOCUMENT, BUT THE
YOUTH, THE YOUTH DECIDE THEY
THEMSELVES CAN COME AND SAY THIS
IS WHERE OKAY, GREAT. AWESOME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, AND STICKING
TO THE STRENGTHS, BUILDING
FUNDS, AS IT'S WRITTEN RIGHT NOW
, IT WILL END ONCE THEY EXIT
FOSTER CARE. BUT WE KNOW THAT
THE CASE IS OPEN UNTIL SIX
MONTHS. POST THAT, LET ME SEE IF
I'M SAYING FOR UNIT FOR
REUNIFICATION, THAT THE CASE IS
STILL OPEN FOR SIX MONTHS. THE
SOCIAL WORKER IS STILL WORKING
WITH THE FAMILY. I'M WONDERING
IF WE THOUGHT ABOUT MATCHING
THAT, BENEFIT TO THE EXTENDED
SIX MONTH, SINCE THE CASE IS
STILL OPEN. I DON'T KNOW IF
WE'VE HEARD THIS FROM ANY
STAKEHOLDERS. WE'VE CERTAINLY
HEARD IT FROM STAKEHOLDERS AND
THE WORKGROUP MEETINGS, AND WE
ARE TAKING ALL OF THE ALL OF THE
FEEDBACK THAT WE'VE GOTTEN UNDER
CONSIDERATION. BUT BUT WE HAVE
HEARD THAT YOU CAN SEE WHAT THE
PROPOSAL IS REFLECTED IN THE
TRAILER BILL. CURRENTLY. YES,
BUT I KNOW, YOU KNOW, FROM NOW
UNTIL IT'S GOING TO IT'S GOING
TO CHANGE A LOT. SO JUST WANT TO
KNOW IF WE WERE THINKING ABOUT
THAT AND THEN STICKING TO THAT
SAME THING. THE 500 TO 900,
DEPENDING ON THE TIER, IT DOES,
IT ROLL OVER. IF IT DOESN'T GET
UTILIZED. SO IN THE TRAILER,
BILL, I THINK IT CLARIFIES THAT
THE FUNDS HAVE TO BE SPENT
WITHIN THE FISCAL YEAR SO THEY
DON'T HAVE TO BE SPENT FULLY
MONTH TO MONTH. SO YOU CAN COME
UP WITH KIND OF YOUR ANNUAL
PLAN. BUT THEY DO HAVE TO BE
SPENT WITHIN THE FISCAL YEAR.
OKAY. THANK YOU. LET'S SEE. I
THINK THAT'S IT FOR OH, YES, ONE
OF THE LAST QUESTIONS I HAD IS I
KNOW WE'RE WAITING FOR THE
AUTOMATION PART. WHAT ELSE DO WE
KNOW? WE NEED TO DO THAT ONCE
THE AUTOMATION IS DONE, THE
DOLLARS ARE FLOWING OUT. DO WE
DO WE KNOW? ARE WE ACCOUNTING
FOR THAT? I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE ONCE AUTOMATION IS DONE,
IT'S NOT LIKE, HEY, WE NEED AN
EXTRA, RIGHT? YEAH. WE HAVE A
LONG LIST GOING OF THINGS THAT
HAVE TO BE DONE AS PART OF
IMPLEMENTATION. SO AUTOMATION IS
OBVIOUSLY A KEY PIECE OF THAT.
OBVIOUSLY MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE CONTRACT WITH WHOEVER
WOULD BE THE, SPENDING PLAN
MANAGER AND THAT THAT IS UP AND
RUNNING, AND THAT WE'VE ALSO
RELEASED GUIDANCE SPECIFIC TO
THOSE STRENGTH BUILDING DOLLARS.
THERE CLEARLY NEEDS TO ALSO BE
WORK AROUND IMPLEMENTATION WITH
REGARD TO THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS
DOLLARS AND MAKING SURE WE GET
OUT THE COUNTY FISCAL LETTERS.
AND THEN THERE'S A THERE'S A
BUNCH OF OTHER GUIDANCE THAT HAS
TO BE RELEASED, AS, AS PART OF
THE PROPOSAL LEADING UP TO
IMPLEMENTATION. SO IT'LL BE A
BUSY COUPLE OF YEARS. I'M REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT THIS. I REALLY AM
EXCITED. I THINK THE
EXTRACURRICULAR OR THE
STRENGTHS, STRENGTHS BUILDING.
YES. THAT PART I THINK IS REALLY
GREAT. I'M EXCITED THAT WITHIN
THIS REFORM, INDIVIDUALS WILL
GET AN HIGHER AMOUNT FOR SOAPS,
OR JUST IF YOU ACCUMULATE ALL
THAT FUNDING TOGETHER. I'M GLAD
THAT WE'RE FOLLOWING THE
INDIVIDUAL VERSUS THE PLACEMENT.
I KNOW WE'RE SHIFTING A LOT IN A
LOT OF OTHER DIFFERENT THINGS IN
THIS, UNDER THE HHS, JUST WHOLE
PERSON CENTERED, FOLLOWING THE
INDIVIDUAL, WHICH IS REALLY
PHENOMENAL. I DO WANT TO THANK
THE DEPARTMENT, BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK YOU HEAR THAT A LOT FROM
ME IN THIS SUBTREE. I DO WANT TO
THANK THE HARD WORK THAT WAS PUT
INTO THIS. AND I KNOW THAT'S
GOING TO BE ONGOING. YOU HAVE
ALL TAKEN ON A LOT OF DIFFERENT,
PROGRAMS, A LOT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS. WE'RE DOING. WE'RE GOING
TO BE TALKING ABOUT CHILD RATE
REFORM. IT'S A LOT OF THINGS. SO
I DO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
THE HARD WORK, AND I KNOW YOU'LL
CONTINUE TALKING TO THE
STAKEHOLDERS HERE AND BEYOND TO
ENSURE THAT THIS THE INTENT, OF
COURSE, IS THERE AND THAT WE
DON'T WE AVOID SOME OF THOSE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES IS MY
ASK IS TO ENSURE THAT, WE WANT,
WE WANT, WE WANT TO TREASURE,
TRACK OUR, OUR OUR OUR PROGRESS.
BECAUSE HOW WILL WE KNOW WE'RE
BEING SUCCESSFUL, SUCCESSFUL Ã
IN MEETING THIS 26? GUIDELINE,
BUT ALSO SUCCESSFUL IN PROVIDING
THE INTENDED RESOURCES TO THE
FOSTER YOUTH. HOW WILL WE BE
TRACKING OUR SUCCESS, SO THAT
WOULD BE MY ASK. SO LET'S MOVE
ON TO OUR NEXT PANELIST FROM THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION.
PERFECT. GOOD AFTERNOON.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA TANNER, AND I'M A
POLICY COORDINATOR REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION. I
DEEPLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT OUR
ORGANIZATION'S PERSPECTIVE ON
THE PROPOSED PERMANENT FOSTER
CARE RATE RESTRUCTURE,
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION IS A
YOUTH LED ORGANIZATION THAT IS
COMMITTED TO ADVOCATING FOR
MEANINGFUL REFORM WITHIN THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM,
PARTICULARLY FOR THE BENEFIT OF
FUTURE GENERATIONS OF FOSTER
YOUTH. AFTER CONDUCTING A
THOROUGH ANALYSIS OF THE
PROPOSED RATE STRUCTURE, OUR
MEMBERSHIP VIEWS THIS AS A
GROUNDBREAKING STEP BY
CALIFORNIA TO INVEST IN THE
WELL-BEING OF FOSTER YOUTH AND
THEIR FAMILIES. THIS PROPOSAL
ACCURATELY REFLECTS THE VALUES
AND VOICES OF CIC MEMBERS ACROSS
THE STATE, AND UNDERSCORES OUR A
COLLECTIVE COMMITMENT TO
ENSURING THAT YOUTH ARE BEING
PRIORITIZED ABOVE ALL ELSE. IF
IMPLEMENTED SUCCESSFULLY, THESE
RATES HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
USHER IN A FUNDING SYSTEM THAT
PRIORITIZES THE NEEDS AND THE
STRENGTHS OF YOUTH, REGARDLESS
OF THEIR PLACEMENT. BY
ALLOCATING SPECIFIC FUNDS FOR
USE STRENGTHS AND PROPERLY
ADDRESSING THEIR IMMEDIATE
NEEDS. THESE RATES REPRESENT A
SUBSTANTIAL SHIFT TOWARDS A MORE
COMPASSIONATE AND EFFICIENT
SUPPORT SYSTEM. THE RATE
STRUCTURE IS SET UP TO FUND
PLACEMENT TYPES. CURRENTLY WE
HAVE FOR THE CURRENT RATE
STRUCTURE IS SET UP TO FUND
PLACEMENT TYPES, WHICH IS FORCED
USE AND TO FIT INSIDE OF ONE
FITS ALL APPROACH. FOR DECADES,
UIC MEMBERS HAVE BROUGHT
COUNTLESS FOSTER YOUTH ADVOCATES
TO THE CAPITOL TO EDUCATE PEOPLE
AROUND HOW HARMFUL THIS PRACTICE
IS. FOSTER YOUTH ARE BEING
FORCED INTO STEEP SETTINGS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR LEVEL OF
NEED, BECAUSE THEY WERE SIMPLY
NOT ENOUGH BEDS AVAILABLE IN
HOMELIKE SETTINGS. THE TIER
SYSTEM THAT IS BEING PROPOSED
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO CREATE AN
ADDITIONAL CHECKS AND BALANCES
TO ENSURE THAT YOUNG PEOPLE LIVE
AT THE MOST, AT THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE PLACEMENT POSSIBLE,
WHILE PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
FINANCIAL SUPPORTS TO THE
PLACEMENTS THAT CAN EXIST. THIS
RATE STRUCTURE WOULD RETURN
TRANSITION THE FOCUS FROM
FUNDING PLACEMENT TYPES AND
INSTEAD FUND THE UNIQUE NEEDS
AND STRENGTHS OF YOUNG PEOPLE.
FURTHERMORE, THIS CREATES
AVENUES TO ACCESSING FEDERAL
RESOURCES, GRANTING COUNTIES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DEVELOP
PERSONALIZED SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS FOR YOUTH WITH GREATER
NEEDS. ULTIMATELY, THIS REPORT
AIMS TO INSTILL A SENSE OF
BELONGING WITHIN YOUTH, ENABLING
THEM TO REMAIN WITHIN THEIR
FAMILIES. WE ARE PARTICULARLY
EXCITED ABOUT THE INCLUSION OF
THE STRENGTH BUILDING FUNDS,
WHICH WILL BROADEN ACCESS TO
ENRICHMENT ACTIVITIES AND OTHER
SUPPORTS IDENTIFIED BY YOUNG
PEOPLE THEMSELVES. THESE
ACTIVITIES ARE CRUCIAL FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF YOUNG PEOPLE, AND
WILL FACILITATE COMPLIANCE WITH
FEDERAL LAWS REQUIRING SUCH
ACTIVITIES, ENSURING THESE FUNDS
DIRECTLY BENEFIT YOUTH FOR YOUTH
IN FOSTER CARE WHO ALREADY
GRAPPLE FOR SIGNIFICANT
UNCERTAINTY. THESE OPPORTUNITIES
ARE TRANSFORMATIVE, ENGAGING IN
ACTIVITIES LIKE JOINING A SPORTS
TEAM, LEARNING TO PLAY AN
INSTRUMENT, OR EVEN
PARTICIPATING IN AN ART CLASS
NOT ONLY OFFER ENJOYMENT, BUT
THEY ALSO SERVE AS A LIFELINE
FOR FOSTERING CONNECTIONS WITH
OTHERS AND COVERING THEIR OWN
STRENGTHS AND PASSIONS.
THEREFORE, WHEN DISCUSSING
FUNDING FOR ENRICHMENT
ACTIVITIES, WE ARE NOT MERELY
DISCUSSING BUDGET ALLOCATIONS.
WE ARE DISCUSSING AN OPPORTUNITY
TO RESTORE A SENSE OF NORMALCY
AND BELONGING TO THESE YOUTH. WE
COMMEND CGRTS FOR INCLUDING
LANGUAGE THAT CLEARLY STATES THE
MONEY DOESN'T GO TO COUNTIES OR
CAREGIVERS, BUT RATHER A THIRD
PARTY WHOSE SOLE OBJECTIVE IS TO
WORK WITH A YOUNG PERSON TO
DETERMINE HOW AND WHERE THESE
FUNDS WILL BE SPENT. THIS IS
RESPONSIVE TO THE CONCERNS THAT
WE HAVE RAISED AROUND NEEDING TO
CREATE SAFEGUARDS THAT GUARANTEE
THAT THIS MONEY MAKES IT TO
YOUTH IN WAYS THAT IS INTENDED.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT DURING
IMPLEMENTATION TO EXPLORE WAYS
TO PUSH FOR OVERSIGHT AND
MONITORING OF COUNTIES, TO
ENSURE THAT CAMS ASSESSMENTS AND
CHILD FAMILY TEAM MEETINGS ARE
OCCURRING ON A REGULAR BASIS AND
THAT YOUTH ARE INVOLVED IN THE
PROCESS EACH TIME THIS PROPOSAL
SUCCESS DEPENDS UPON THE
COUNTY'S ABILITY TO ABIDE BY
CURRENT STATUTE, AND DO SO WITH
FOSTER YOUTH BY THEIR SIDE.
ULTIMATELY WHAT MATTERS MOST IS
THE TANGIBLE IMPACTS THESE
CHANGES WILL HAVE ON THE LIVES
OF YOUTH. BY ENSURING THAT
FUNDING IS DIRECTED WHERE IT IS
NEEDED MOST, WE CAN GUARANTEE
THAT EVERY CHILD IN FOSTER CARE
RECEIVES THE SUPPORT NECESSARY
TO THRIVE, WHETHER IT ENTAILS
FUNDING FOR THERAPY, EDUCATIONAL
SUPPORTS OR SIMPLY PROVIDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOUTH TO ENJOY
CHILDHOOD ACTIVITIES. THESE
CHANGES HOLD THE POTENTIAL TO
AFFECT SUBSTANTIAL POSITIVE
CHANGE, AND IT IS MORE ABOUT
MORE THAN JUST FINANCIAL
RESOURCES. IT'S ABOUT EMPOWERING
THESE CHILDREN TO THRIVE, TO
GROW AND TO ENVISION A FUTURE
FILLED WITH HOPE AND
POSSIBILITY. AND MANY OF THESE
HEARINGS, WE HAVE LISTENED TO
PEOPLE SPEAK ABOUT THE COMPLEX
CARE NEEDS OF A SMALL POPULATION
OF FOSTER YOUTH. WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU TODAY
WILL DISRUPT THE SYSTEM THAT HAS
FAILED TO SERVE THE MOST
VULNERABLE, FOSTER YOUTH WITH
THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF NEED. IF
THIS PROPOSAL SEEMS LIKE IT
WOULD REDIRECT SERVICES, THAT'S
BECAUSE IT WILL. IF THIS
PROPOSAL SEEMS LIKE IT IS
SHIFTING A POWER DYNAMIC AND
GIVING FOSTER YOUTH MORE
AUTONOMY, THAT'S BECAUSE IT DOES
. CALIFORNIA HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY TO ASSURE THAT
YOUNG PEOPLE IN FOSTER CARE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO THRIVE, AND
WE AT CIC BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A
NECESSARY, NECESSARY STEP
TOWARDS A BETTER FUTURE FOR
FOSTER YOUTH. THEREFORE I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THE FOSTER CARE
RATES PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU. THANK
YOU FOR CONSIDERING THE WELFARE
OF OUR YOUTH. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR REMARKS, I APPRECIATE
IT. EILEEN, FROM OUR COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
C.W.D SUPPORTS THE OVERARCHING
GOALS OF THE PROPOSAL TO SUPPORT
FAMILY BASED CARE, PARTICULARLY
KINSHIP CARE, AND TO ESTABLISH A
NEW STRUCTURE DRIVEN BY THE
CHILD'S NEEDS RATHER THAN BY
THEIR PLACEMENT SETTING. WE'RE
ALSO GRATEFUL FOR THE PROPOSED
NEW STATE INVESTMENTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS PROPOSAL. AS NOTED,
IT'S COMPREHENSIVE AND COMPLEX,
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF OUTSTANDING QUESTIONS
AND ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED. SOME IN STATUTE AND
SOME THAT CAN BE DEFERRED TO
ADMINISTRATIVE GUIDANCE. BUT ALL
REQUIRING MORE DISCUSSION WITH
COUNTY PLACING AGENCIES, TRIBES,
PROVIDERS AND YOUTH AND
CAREGIVER REPRESENTATIVES. WE'VE
SUBMITTED A BUDGET MEMO AND
SUPPORTING ATTACHMENT ON APRIL
23RD, PROVIDING OUR DETAILED
RESPONSES AND RECOMMENDATIONS
RELATED TO THE PROPOSAL, AND WE
ENDEAVORED IN THAT TO HIGHLIGHT
THOSE ISSUES THAT WE BELIEVE
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED IN TBL
PRIOR TO THE END OF THIS
LEGISLATIVE SESSION IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT NECESSARY AUTOMATION
CAN BEGIN TO MEET THE DESIRED
2627 IMPLEMENTATION DATE, AND
WHICH ISSUES WE THINK CAN BE
DEFERRED FOR MORE DISCUSSION AND
SUBSEQUENT LEGISLATION, OUR
OVERARCHING GOAL, THOUGH, IS TO
KEEP THE BALL MOVING FORWARD ON
THIS IMPORTANT PROPOSAL, DUE TO
TIME CONSTRAINTS, I'M NOT GOING
TO GO THROUGH EVERY
RECOMMENDATION, BUT HIT THE
HIGHLIGHTS OF OUR BUDGET MEMO
HERE. AND I'VE GROUPED THE
ISSUES INTO A FEW MAJOR
CATEGORIES, THE FIRST OF WHICH
BEING THE CARE AND SUPERVISION
COMPONENT. SPECIFICALLY THE
TIERED RATES AND THE CANS, IT'S
PREDICATED ON THE CANS
INSTRUMENT. AND WHILE WE DON'T
NECESSARILY OBJECT TO THAT, AT
QUDAH, WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF CHALLENGES IN CANS
IMPLEMENTATION THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED FOR THE NEW RATE
SETTING PROCESS TO BE SUCCESSFUL
, ALL INCLUDING DATA ENTRY
INFORMATION COLLECTED THROUGH
THE CANS AND ALIGNMENT WITH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM CANS
TOOL. WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPT TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE, DIRECTING DSS TO WORK
WITH COUNTIES TO ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES, AND ENSURE ADEQUATE
FUNDING TO ENABLE COUNTY TO
COMPLETE THE CANS TO FIDELITY
AND ENSURE TIMELY CFT MEETINGS
AND REPORT BACK AS PART OF THE
2526 BUDGET PROCESS, WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THE CANS IS A HIGHLY
VALIDATED TOOL FOR ASSESSMENTS,
BUT IT'S NOT DESIGNED AS A RATE
SETTING TOOL. AND THE
STATISTICAL MODELING OR THE
LATENT CLASS ANALYSIS USING THE
CANS SCORES TO SET RATES, IT'S
COMPLETELY UNTESTED. USE OF A
LATENT CLASS ANALYSIS SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED IN THE FUTURE. WE
THINK, PENDING ADDITIONAL
TESTING AND VALIDATION. AND IN
THE MEANTIME, WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT THE USE OF
THAT STATISTICAL. STATISTICAL
MODELING OF CANS SCORES FOR RATE
SETTING AND INSTEAD DIRECT DSS
TO WORK WITH COUNTIES, TRIBES
AND STAKEHOLDERS TO IDENTIFY
WHAT INFORMATION FROM THE CANS
MATRIX AND OTHER ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION NOT CURRENTLY
CAPTURED ON THE CANS SHOULD BE
USED TO DETERMINE THE RATE
LEVELS WE ALSO RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECT DSS TO WORK
WITH COUNTIES AND STAKEHOLDERS
TO FINALIZE THE NUMBER OF TIERS
AND DETERMINE THE TRANSITION
FROM THE OTHER RATE STRUCTURE TO
THE NEW ONE, AND TO REFLECT THIS
, AN UPDATED TVL BY AUGUST OF
2024. THOSE ARE THE MOST
CRITICAL PIECES, WE THINK, TO
NAIL DOWN NOW TO ALLOW DSS TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH ISSUING THE
POLICY GUIDANCE THAT WE'D NEED
TO ALLOW FOR THE AUTOMATION, TO
PROCEED FOR THE TARGET
IMPLEMENTATION DATE OF 2627. THE
SECOND CATEGORY IS THE IMMEDIATE
NEEDS COMPONENT, AND WE SUPPORT
THIS COMPONENT. BUT WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS WITH THE
MULTIPLE, ONEROUS AND
DUPLICATIVE NEW PROPOSED
REQUIREMENTS IMPACTING COUNTIES
AND PROVIDERS. THESE NEW
REQUIREMENTS WILL RESULT IN
BARRIERS TO STANDING UP AND
ACCESSING SUPPORTS AND SERVICES.
WE THEREFORE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT THE
CERTIFICATION MODEL,
CONTRACTING, AUDITING AND DIRECT
CDSS ADMINISTRATOR OF THE
IMMEDIATE NEEDS COMPONENT. WE
RECOMMEND INSTEAD THAT THEY
DIRECT THAT YOU DIRECT DSS TO
WORK WITH COUNTIES AND
STAKEHOLDERS TO ARTICULATE THE
PROCESS FOR COUNTY PLAN
REQUIREMENTS, INCLUDING EXPECTED
DATA ELEMENTS TO BE SUBMITTED BY
COUNTIES AND LEVERAGE AND
STRENGTHEN IF NEEDED. THE
EXISTING CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICE REVIEW AND CASE REVIEW
PROCESSES, AND WE RECOMMEND
UPDATED TABLE TO THE
LEGISLATURE, INCLUDING PROPOSED
FUNDING TO COUNTIES TO ADDRESS
ANY NEW WORKLOAD AS PART OF THE
2526 BUDGET PROCESS. ALTHOUGH WE
HAVE OTHER RECOMMENDATIONS IN
OUR LETTER, I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT LASTLY HERE, THE
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE OF PROVIDING
CAPACITY BUILDING FUNDING TO
COUNTIES AND COMMUNITY BASED
PROVIDERS, WITHOUT WHICH THE
SYSTEMIC TRANSFORMATION AND
VISION BY THIS RATE PROPOSAL
WILL NOT BE FULLY ACHIEVED. AND
WE NEED ENGAGEMENT BY DSS AND
DHS AND COUNTIES AND PROVIDERS
ON STRATEGIES TO LEVERAGE
MEDI-CAL FUNDING AS WELL. AND
THE LAST PIECE IS THE STRENGTH
BUILDING AND MAINTENANCE
COMPONENT, AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS PIECE. AND ALTHOUGH
WE BELIEVE THAT COUNTY HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCIES CAN
SUCCESSFULLY ADMINISTER THIS
COMPONENT OF THE RATE, WE DO NOT
OBJECT TO THE PROPOSED STATE
LEVEL ADMINISTRATION OF IT.
WE'VE IDENTIFIED SEVERAL
OPERATIONAL AND IMPLEMENTATION
QUESTIONS RELATED TO THE
COMPONENT AS IT'S PROPOSED,
HOWEVER, THAT WE JUST WANT TO
IDENTIFY, WE, WE BELIEVE THAT
THERE SHOULD BE TRAILER BILL
AMENDED TO PRIORITIZE EASE OF
ACCESS FOR CHILDREN AND
CAREGIVERS TO THESE FUNDS TO
SIMPLIFY ADMINISTRATION. AND WE
RECOMMEND REMOVING COUNTIES KIND
OF COMPLETELY AS LIKE THE
MIDDLEMAN FROM THIS PROCESS,
BECAUSE WE FEEL THAT THAT JUST
ADDS A LAYER OF ADMINISTRATION
AND COMPLEXITY THAT WE'RE NOT
SURE ADDS VALUE HERE, I'LL JUST
CONCLUDE MY TESTIMONY BY NOTING
THAT THE AUTOMATION OF BOTH CAL
SAWS AND ORS CARES IS GOING TO
BE ESSENTIAL TO OUR ABILITY TO
IMPLEMENT THE NEW RATE
STRUCTURE. AND WE'VE GOT
SUGGESTIONS IN OUR BUDGET MEMO
AROUND CONCERNS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS HERE FOR HOW TO
ENSURE THAT THERE'S PLANNING,
SUFFICIENT PLANNING AND
CONTINGENCY PLANNING, SHOULD
THERE BE DELAYS THERE, AND WE
ALSO CONTINUE LIKE THE LÀ Þ TO
REQUEST A BACKUP FOR THE FUNDING
ESTIMATES, WITHOUT WHICH IT'S
DIFFICULT TO DO A COMPREHENSIVE
ANALYSIS COMPLETELY ON
EVERYTHING. BUT WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
THESE COMMENTS. LOOK FORWARD TO
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION, THEY'VE BEEN
VERY OPEN TO HEARING ALL OF OUR
MANY, MANY COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS, AND TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH YOU ALL IN THE
LEGISLATURE AS WELL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, THREE FOLLOW
UP QUESTIONS IN YOUR LETTER AND
I CAN'T REMEMBER IT SAID
SOMETHING AROUND BACKGROUND
CHECKS. CORRECT. CAN YOU SPEAK
TO THAT A LITTLE BIT? SURE. THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AS
PROPOSED REQUIRES THAT THERE BE
BACKGROUND CHECKS CONDUCTED FOR
THE PROVIDERS OF THE STRENGTH
BUILDING PIECES AS PLANNED TO
ENSURE ANY PROVIDER COMPLETED A
CRIMINAL BACKGROUND CHECK. WHAT
PART OF THAT IS WORRISOME,
OTHERS CAN PROBABLY SPEAK TO
THIS AS WELL, BUT WE FIND THAT
THAT'S WORRISOME IN THAT, THERE
COULD BE SITUATIONS WHERE HAVING
A BACKGROUND CHECK WOULD BE NOT
NORMALLY NECESSARY AS A PROCESS
OF, YOU KNOW, IT'S A NORMAL
PROCESS AND IT COULD JUST ADD A
ADD A LAYER OF BOTH TIMELINESS
IN TERMS OF ACCESSING THE
ACTIVITY, BUT ALSO JUST, COST
FOR THE PROVIDER AND BARRIER,
FOR EXAMPLE, IF, IF THE IDEA IS
THAT A YOUTH SHOULD HAVE PIANO
LESSONS OR SOMETHING, DOES A
PIANO TEACHER NEED TO BE
BACKGROUND CHECKED? IT'S UNCLEAR
WHETHER THAT IS ACTUALLY A
REQUIREMENT NOW OF THIS
LANGUAGE, OR IF IT WOULD JUST BE
IF THEY WERE OTHERWISE REQUIRED
TO BE. IT'S THOSE KINDS OF
ISSUES THAT ADD, COMPLEXITY AND
DIFFICULTY AND ACCESS THESE
ACCESSING THE FUNDS AND THE
SERVICES TIMELY. AND SO WE
SUGGEST THINKING THROUGH HOW WE
MIGHT, KIND OF CUT THROUGH SOME
OF THAT. THE CBO SPEAKS THAT IF
IT'S ALREADY REQUIRED. RIGHT,
EXACTLY. SO. OH, SORRY. THAT'S
RIGHT. IT'S INTENDED IF IT'S
ALREADY REQUIRED UNDER STATE OR
FEDERAL LAW TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
HAD OCCURRED. SO IT WASN'T
INTENDING TO REQUIRE KNEW
EXACTLY NOTHING NEW. OKAY. YEP
TWO OTHER THINGS. HOW DO YOU SEE
YOURSELF AS AS IT'S WRITTEN? THE
MIDDLE PERSON. WHAT PART WERE
YOU REFERRING TO THAT YOU WANT
TO BE REMOVED AS THE MIDDLE
PERSON. SO WE WOULD HAVE TO,
FIRST OF ALL, KIND OF HAVE A
CHILD AND FAMILY TEAM MEETING
FOR PURPOSES OF DISCUSSION OF
THE STRENGTHS BUILDING. NOT SURE
IF HAVING THAT ELABORATE PROCESS
, BUT, THOSE CAN BE DIFFICULT TO
ARRANGE. EVERYBODY GETTING
TOGETHER AND SO FORTH. SO
THERE'S, THERE'S THAT WHOLE
ELEMENT OF IT, IT'S UNCLEAR FOR
TO US, KIND OF HOW THE, WHAT
WHAT OUR ROLE IN THE PROCESS
WOULD BE IF THERE WERE,
DISAGREEMENTS BETWEEN THE
CAREGIVER AND THE YOUTH OR, OR,
THE PARENT AND THE YOUTH AND THE
CAREGIVER AROUND WHAT THE
STRENGTHS BUILDING ACTIVITY
COULD BE. I'M NOT SURE WHAT OUR
ROLE ROLE IS THERE, THERE'S TALK
ABOUT US ENSURING ACCESS TO
SERVICES AND SO FORTH. WE DON'T
HAVE CONTROL OVER THE FUNDING OR
HOW HOW WE ACCESS THAT FUNDING
TO ENSURE THAT SERVICES CAN BE
PROVIDED IN REAL TIME. IT'S AN
ODD KIND OF FOR US, ONE FOOT IN,
ONE FOOT OUT, AND SO IT'S JUST
IT'S NOT CLEAR WHAT OUR ROLE IS.
AND IF THE AND IF THIS FINANCIAL
MANAGEMENT COORDINATOR IS GOING
TO BE THE ENTITY THAT IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENSURING THAT
THE FUNDS ARE AVAILABLE
IMMEDIATELY AND SO FORTH, LIKE
LET'S HAVE WHAT IS YOUR PURPOSE?
GOT IT RIGHT, DEPUTY DIRECTOR
WHO IS INVOLVED IN THIS FAMILY
MEETING, BECAUSE I THINK YOU
ALSO SPOKE TO THE FAMILY MEETING
. SO WE DO HAVE THE CHILD AND
FAMILY TEAM ENVISIONED AS A
SUPPORT AT WHICH THEY SHOULD BE
ANYWAYS, TO THE YOUNG PERSON IN
IDENTIFYING HOW THEY WANT TO USE
THE STRENGTH BUILDING DOLLARS,
MAKING SURE THAT THEY KNOW THAT
THEY'RE THERE, AND HAVING A
CONVERSATION THÀNH WITH THE
YOUNG PERSON AND OTHER PEOPLE.
THAT WOULD BE PART OF THAT
MEETING, WHICH SHOULD INCLUDE
THEIR PARENT AND THEIR CAREGIVER
WHO WOULD OBVIOUSLY HAVE TO BE
TAKING THEM TO AND FROM
ACTIVITIES. AND SO WE THINK IT'S
AN IMPORTANT PLACE TO HAVE THE
CONVERSATION AND THE TRAILER
BILL PUTS THAT, SUPPORT ROLE ON
THE CFT. AS EILEEN SAID, THE
COUNTIES ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
FACILITATING THE CFT MEETINGS,
BUT THERE'S NOT REALLY INTENDED
TO BE THE ROLE OF A MIDDLEMAN
FOR THE COUNTIES. IT'S MAKING
SURE THAT THAT CONVERSATION IS
HAPPENING WITH YOUNG PEOPLE IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE CFT, WHICH IS
WHERE THESE KINDS OF DECISIONS
ARE HAPPENING ANYWAY. AND THEN
TO THE POINT ABOUT SORT OF HOW
DO YOU WORK THROUGH CONFLICTS?
THE CFT IS THE PLACE THAT
FAMILIES SHOULD BE ENGAGING IN
THOSE KINDS OF DISCUSSIONS EXIST
NOW. CFTS ALREADY EXIST, AND
IT'S AND WE THINK THAT THIS IS
VERY PART AND PARCEL TO WHAT
CFTS SHOULD BE DOING AND THE
KINDS OF CONVERSATIONS THEY
SHOULD BE HAVING. OKAY I'LL JUST
SAY THE REALITY IS, THOUGH, THE
CFT MEETINGS, THEY DON'T HAPPEN,
FOR ALL YOUTH IN PARTICULAR,
LIKE THAT. AND NOW WE'RE FUNDED.
THEY HAPPEN A COUPLE TIMES.
YEAH, RIGHT. EXACTLY SO WE JUST
NEED TO BE MINDFUL, I THINK,
WHICH IS WHY YOU WERE WORKLOAD.
EXACTLY. WE JUST WANT TO HAVE IF
THAT'S THE VENUE, THEN WE NEED
TO ENSURE THAT THEY ARE
HAPPENING TIMELY, THAT WE CAN
PULL ALL THE APPROPRIATE PEOPLE
TOGETHER TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND THAT, AND THAT
WE ARE WE ARE RESOURCE TO DO
THAT. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH, NOW MOVING ON TO THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES. GOOD MORNING, CHAIRMAN
MENGIBAR, CHRIS STONER, I'M THE
CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
OF CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES,
AND I REALLY WANT TO FIRST START
BY THANKING YOU FOR BRINGING
YOUR HEAD AND YOUR HEART TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. IT REALLY IS
REFRESHING. REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU, THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
MEMBER ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDE A
WIDE ARRAY OF SERVICES TO
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES AT RISK
OF, OR INVOLVED IN THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM. THEY RUN FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTERS, PROVIDES
SCHOOL BASED MENTAL HEALTH AND
IN-HOME SERVICES THAT KEEP
FAMILIES TOGETHER. OUR MEMBER
ORGANIZATIONS ALSO PROVIDE
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES THAT
RECRUIT, TRAIN, AND APPROVE
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES,
INCLUDING KIN, WHO ARE COMMITTED
TO SUPPORTING YOUTH UNTIL THEY
CAN RETURN TO BIOLOGICAL FAMILY.
OVER 70% OF CHILDREN IN ALLIANCE
FOR PROVIDE AND GET
REUNIFICATION SERVICES, AND OVER
60% ARE ULTIMATELY REUNITED.
REUNIFIED WITH FAMILY. WE
APPRECIATE THE VISION THAT
UNDERLIES THIS PERMANENT RATE
PROPOSAL. FOCUSING RESOURCES ON
FOSTER YOUTH AND THEIR FAMILIES
IS ESSENTIAL AND ALLOWING
FAMILIES AND CAREGIVERS TO
DETERMINE HOW TO BEST MEET THEIR
CHILDREN'S NEEDS PROVIDES A
PATHWAY TO LESS CHILDREN AND
YOUTH REQUIRING CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES. OVER TIME. THAT SAID,
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS PROPOSAL,
AS CURRENTLY SORRY, CURRENTLY
STRUCTURED, WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCE AND EVEN DECIMATE SOME
PROGRAMS THAT ARE WORKING WITH
OUR MOST VULNERABLE FOSTER YOUTH
AND THEIR FAMILIES. MANY OF
THESE YOUTH ARE, OF COURSE,
LGBTQ YOUTH AND YOUTH OF COLOR.
THESE PROGRAMS ARE ROOTED IN
COMMUNITIES AND STAFFED BY
PEOPLE LIVING IN THESE
COMMUNITIES, OFTEN WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE IN THE FOSTER CARE
AND PROBATION SYSTEMS. OUR
SPECIFIC CONCERNS INCLUDE. WE DO
NOT SEE A CLEAR METHOD OR
REQUIREMENT IN THE PROPOSAL FOR
YOUTH, BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS
TO BE MET AND TO SUPPORT
FAMILIES REMAINING TOGETHER
THROUGH RAP AND OTHER BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SUPPORTS. WITHOUT
INTENTIONAL INTEGRATION OF THESE
RESOURCES AT BOTH STATE AND
COUNTY LEVELS, OUR MOST
VULNERABLE YOUTH WILL CONTINUE
TO BE UNDERSERVED FOR THEIR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS. THERE'S
NO ACCOMPANYING TBL AND HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE OUTLINING
MINIMUM LEVELS OF SERVICES FOR
YOUTH BY TIER. MUCH MORE
DISCUSSION BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT AND STAKEHOLDERS IS
NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT YOUTH ARE
GETTING THOSE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES THEY ARE ENTITLED TO
RECEIVE. SECONDLY THE RATES FOR
THE ADMINISTRATIVE AND CARE AND
SUPERVISION COMPONENTS FOR YOUTH
WHO NEED SHORT TERM RESIDENTIAL
THERAPEUTIC PROGRAMS ARE WHOLLY
INADEQUATE TO SERVE YOUTH
DETERMINED TO HAVE NEEDS AT THE
TIER THREE PLUS LEVEL, WORKFORCE
SHORTAGES DUE TO WAGE
LIMITATIONS ARE IMPACTING THESE
PROGRAMS. NOW AND THE CURRENT
PROPOSAL WOULD RESULT IN STRIPS
RECEIVING OVER LESS. LESS. SORRY
OVER $3,000 LESS PER MONTH THAN
THEY RECEIVE TODAY, THIS RULE
WILL DEFINITELY RESULT IN
CLOSURE OF PROGRAMS AND
ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDING THESE
SERVICES, AND WE WILL FIND MORE
FOSTER YOUTH IN NEED OF
HOSPITALIZATION. WE DO NOT WANT
YOUTH IN STRIPS THAT DO NOT NEED
THIS LEVEL OF SERVICE. WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THOSE PROGRAMS ARE
FUNDED SO THAT THEY'RE GETTING
THE HIGHEST QUALITY SERVICES.
AND TREATMENT THAT THEY NEED.
THIRDLY, RATES FOR THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COMPONENTS AT ALL
LEVELS ARE INADEQUATE TO ENSURE
THAT FAMILY SERVICE AGENCIES CAN
PROVIDE THE HIGHEST QUALITY OF
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS TO
FAMILIES, PAY PAY COMPETITIVE
WAGES, BENEFITS COVER ESCALATING
INSURANCE COSTS AND BASIC
ORGANIZATIONAL COSTS FOR
PROVIDING THESE SERVICES. THE
ADMINISTRATIVE AND IMMEDIATE
NEEDS COMPONENTS OF THE RATE
ALSO DO NOT INCLUDE A COST OF
LIVING INCREASE, PROVIDING MORE
FUNDING TO FAMILIES WITHOUT
ENSURING THESE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT CAN SUPPORT THEM WILL BE
SUSTAINED, IS NOT GOING TO BE IN
THEIR BEST INTEREST. FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCIES ARE ALREADY
UNDERFUND AND HAVE RECEIVED ONLY
TWO COST OF LIVING INCREASES IN
THE PAST 15 YEARS. THEY'RE
FACING AN 8% CUT THIS JULY,
UNLESS THE LEGISLATURE APPROVES
THE CONTINUATION OF A COLA
APPROVED IN THE 20 2324 BUDGET
PROCESS. THE ALLIANCE'S BUDGET
REQUEST TO SUSTAIN THESE
ORGANIZATIONS IS ESSENTIAL TO
KEEPING THEM AFLOAT FOR THE NEXT
YEAR. WITHOUT THIS IMMEDIATE
SUPPORT, THERE WILL BE FAR LESS
SERVICE PROVIDERS AVAILABLE IN
26 AND 27. WE'VE NOT SEEN THE
DETAILS OF THE FINANCING MODEL
OF THE MOST RECENT LATENT CLASS
ANALYSIS, OR OR THE FINANCING
MODEL OF THE TIERS. WE FEEL THAT
THERE'S MUCH MORE DISCUSSION
NEEDED WITH STAKEHOLDERS IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT YOUTH,
FAMILIES AND THE PROGRAMS THAT
SUPPORT THEIR REUNIFICATION AND
PERMANENCY HAVE THE RESOURCES
NEEDED TO BE SUCCESSFUL. WE
REALLY DO NOT WANT THIS PROPOSAL
TO PIT CHILDREN AND YOUTH AND
FAMILIES AGAINST THE PROVIDERS
THAT THAT ARE WORKING WITH THEM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR REMARKS, YOU SPOKE ABOUT
THE BEHAVIORAL NEEDS, YOU FEEL
LIKE THERE'S NO CLEAR METHOD OF
MEETING A BARE MINIMUM. SO ARE
YOU SAYING THEY MEET IN UNDER
THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS? THAT'S
WHERE THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
NEEDS OF THE YOUTH WOULD BE MET,
ARE YOU SAYING THAT IT COULD BE,
BUT EVEN SEPARATE FROM THIS RATE
PROPOSAL, ALL YOUTH IN FOSTER
CARE AND IN PROBATION ARE
ENTITLED TO MEDICAID EARLY
PERIODIC SCREENING AND TREATMENT
AND DIAGNOSIS SERVICES. AND WE
DO NOT SEE THOSE CONSISTENTLY
BUILT IN AND INTEGRATED INTO THE
INTO THIS PROPOSAL OR, OR INTO
HOW WE STRUCTURE THIS AS IT
RELATES TO THE TIERS. I THINK,
AS I NOTED AT THE BEGINNING, WE
HEARD STRONGLY DURING OUR,
SESSIONS TO DEVELOP THIS
PROPOSAL THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
FUNDING WITHIN THE CHILD WELFARE
PORTION, FOR SERVICES AND FOR
ADDRESSING THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS.
THAT'S NOT TO SAY THAT THIS
WOULD SUPPLANT THE EXISTING
OBLIGATION ON THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SIDE AND MENTAL HEALTH
SIDE, AND THE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
ON THAT SIDE. AND SO WE REMAIN
THAT WOULD ALL REMAIN. AND SO
ALL OF THIS IS REALLY INTENDED
TO BE ADDITIVE AND RECOGNIZING
THE ROLE THAT CHILD WELFARE
NEEDS TO PLAY IN IDENTIFYING AND
ADDRESSING URGENT NEEDS THAT
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED THROUGH THE
CANS. AND SO IT IS, YOU KNOW,
INCUMBENT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE PARTNERING WITH DCS, WHICH
WE ARE ALREADY DOING, TO HAVE
THE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW TO
BEST UTILIZE ALL OF THESE
DOLLARS AND RESOURCES TOGETHER.
BUT THIS IS REALLY ABOUT THE
CHILD WELFARE PIECE OF THE
OBLIGATION. IF THAT'S ALREADY
THERE. AND IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S
NOT HAPPENING, HOW CAN WE THEN
ENSURE THAT THIS PART WILL MAYBE
DID I MISS THAT? LIKE, HOW THEN
ARE WE CERTAIN THAT I THINK WE
FEEL LIKE THESE DOLLARS ARE
CRITICAL TO MAKING SURE THAT WE
ARE FULLY MEETING THE NEED, AND
THAT WE ARE PARTNERING WITH OUR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PARTNERS AND
OUR MENTAL HEALTH PARTNERS IN
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE LEVERAGE
MATCHING DOLLARS APPROPRIATELY.
AGAIN, NOT SUPPLANTING, BUT
SUPPLEMENTING THE DOLLARS THAT
ARE ALREADY AVAILABLE BEALL AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE BEING
MORE RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE. HOW DOES
THAT WORK? THE YOUTH COMES UP
AND SAYS, I NEED X, Y, Z. WE
LOOK AT THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS.
DOLLARS ARE INTENDED TO BE AN
ALLOCATION TO THE COUNTIES THAT
ARE BASED ON THE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN THAT THEY HAVE WITHIN
THEIR SYSTEM, THAT ARE WITHIN
TIERS TWO, THREE AND THREE PLUS.
AND THEN THEY WOULD BE UTILIZING
THOSE DOLLARS TO DEVELOP AN
INDIVIDUALIZED, IMMEDIATE NEEDS
PLAN FOR THE YOUNG PERSON. THEY
COULD BE THE CERTIFIED IMMEDIATE
NEEDS PROVIDER THEMSELVES AND
MEETING THOSE NEEDS OR HAVING
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS THAT THEY
SUBCONTRACT WITH TO MEET THOSE
NEEDS. THEY COULD ALSO HAVE AN
FFA OR AN STP, WHO'S THE
IMMEDIATE NEEDS PROVIDER, AND SO
THEY COULD ALSO BE HAVING THAT
ORGANIZATION. BUT IT BECOMES
MORE FLEXIBLE. INSTEAD OF SAYING
LIKE, ONCE YOU PLACE INTO THE
FFA, IT'S WHATEVER THAT FFA
OFFERS, IT'S WHATEVER THE
CHILD'S IMMEDIATE NEEDS ARE SO
THAT WHEN THEY'RE PLACED WITHIN
THAT FFA OR THE FFA COULD BE THE
IMMEDIATE NEEDS PROVIDER, OR
THERE COULD BE OTHER ENTITIES
THAT ARE BEING BROUGHT IN IN
ORDER TO SERVE THE YOUNG PERSON.
IF THAT WOULD BE MORE RESPONSIVE
TO WHAT THOSE IMMEDIATE NEEDS
ARE. OKAY, ON ON THE TOPIC OF
STREEP'S AND MAYBE I NEED HELP
FROM THE DEPARTMENT ON THIS, I
WAS UNDER THE IMPRESSION THAT
THERE WERE GOING TO GET MORE
FUNDING THROUGH THIS RATE REFORM
PER CHILD. THE WAY THAT THE
DOLLARS WORK IS THE CARE AND
SUPERVISION DOLLARS AND THE
ADMIN DOLLARS ASSOCIATED WITH
TIER THREE. PLUS, IF A CHILD WAS
ASSESSED AT TIER THREE PLUS AND
THEN PLACED IN AN STREEP, THE
STREEP WOULD BE GUARANTEED TO
GET THE CARE AND SUPERVISION AND
THE ADMIN PORTION IF THEY WERE
ALSO IN IMMEDIATE NEEDS PROVIDER
THAT WAS CERTIFIED, THEY COULD
ALSO RECEIVE THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS
FUNDING. IF THOSE DOLLARS DIDN'T
GO TO THE STREEP. I THINK THAT'S
TO CHRIS'S POINT THAT THAT WOULD
BE AN OVERALL REDUCTION. AND SO
SHE I THINK, IS NOTING THAT THEY
WOULD NEED THOSE DOLLARS IN
ORDER TO BE AT CURRENT LEVELS.
THAT SAID, IF THEY WEREN'T
RECEIVING THOSE DOLLARS, THERE
WOULD BE REDUCED WORK AS WELL.
THAT'S EXPECTED OF THE STREEP'S
AS OTHER ORGANIZATIONS ARE
COMING IN TO PROVIDE THAT
IMMEDIATE NEED SUPPORT. EXACTLY.
SO, OKAY, ANYTHING ON THAT?
WELL, IF I MIGHT, I ONE THERE IS
IT'S NOT A GUARANTEED AMOUNT.
RIGHT. BASED ON LIKE IT IS FOR
TODAY IN TERMS OF THE WAY THE
RATE STRUCTURE, THE CARE
SUPERVISION AND THE ADMIN WOULD
BE A GUARANTEED AMOUNT. RIGHT,
RIGHT. WHICH IS 13,000 COMPARED
TO WHAT IS TODAY, 16,000. SO AND
, WE'RE, YOU KNOW, WE'RE LOOKING
TWO YEARS FROM NOW WITH
INFLATION ETC. AND, AND MOST OF
OUR ORGANIZATIONS TODAY ARE
PAYING STAFF ABOUT 18 TO $19,
WHICH IS COMPLETELY
INSUFFICIENT. AND RESULTS IN
SIGNIFICANT WORKFORCE SHORTAGES.
SO JUST TO MEET THE REQUIREMENTS
THAT THEY HAVE IN TERMS OF
STAFFING, BOTH ON THE CHILD
WELFARE SIDE, BUT ALSO ON THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SIDE, THEY'VE
GOT THEY'VE GOT TO HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT AND CLEAR AMOUNT OF
MONEY TO BE ABLE TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT CCL HAS OF
THEM. OKAY. THANK YOU. NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS ON ON THIS
PANELIST. MOVING ON TO OUR NEXT
ONE FROM CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
CAREGIVERS. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATOR ROTH. I'M JEN
REXROAD, A FORMER FOSTER PARENT
AND THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
CAREGIVERS, CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
OF CAREGIVERS REPRESENTS THE
VOICES OF FOSTER KINSHIP,
GUARDIAN AND ADOPTIVE FAMILIES
TO PROMOTE THE WELL-BEING OF
CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE AND IS
PROUD TO STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
NEW PERMANENT FOSTER CARE RATE
STRUCTURE PROPOSAL. IT IS
UNDENIABLE THAT CHILDREN AND
YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE FACE
IMMENSE CHALLENGES, AND WE HAVE
BEEN UNABLE, AS A STATE, TO
PROVIDE ADEQUATE SUPPORT AND
CARE FOR THESE YOUTH. THE
PROPOSED CHANGES OUTLINED IN THE
FOSTER CARE RATE PROPOSAL
PROVIDE SO MANY INNOVATIVE
OPPORTUNITIES TO HELP CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES. I WILL FOCUS ON A
FEW HIGHLIGHTS. THE FOSTER CARE
RATE PROPOSAL FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGES HOW CHILDREN AND YOUTH
WILL BE ASSESSED TO DETERMINE
THEIR LEVEL OF NEED FOR SUPPORT
AND SERVICES BY USING A
VALIDATED FUNCTIONAL ASSESSMENT
TOOL FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER.
THE CANS. THE CANS WILL REPLACE
THE CURRENT LEVEL OF CARE
PROTOCOL TOOL OR THE LCP. IT IS
A KEY CHANGE BECAUSE THE CURRENT
LCP IS NOT A VALIDATED
ASSESSMENT TOOL AND IS USED
UNEQUALLY THROUGHOUT THE 58
COUNTIES BY USING THE CANS. IS
THE ASSESSMENT TOOL. IT IS
ESTIMATED THAT 19% OF CHILDREN
AND YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE OR
8000, WILL RESULT IN A TIER TWO
PLACEMENT, WHICH IS THE
EQUIVALENT OF THE CURRENT
INTENSIVE SERVICES FOSTER CARE
RATE OR THE ISFSI RATE.
CURRENTLY, ONLY 3.5% OR
APPROXIMATELY 1400 CHILDREN AND
YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE ARE
RECEIVING THE ISFSI RATE. THIS
MEANS THAT ON ANY GIVEN DAY,
THOUSANDS. CURRENTLY 6500
CHILDREN AND YOUTH WHO QUALIFY
FOR INTENSIVE SERVICES FOSTER
CARE ARE NOT RECEIVING IT.
THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN AND YOUTH
ARE CURRENTLY NOT BEING GIVEN
THE APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF SUPPORT
AND SERVICES THAT THEY NEED IN
ORDER TO KEEP THEM FROM
EXPERIENCING MORE TRAUMATIC
EVENTS, AS THEY FAIL FROM
PLACEMENT TO PLACEMENT, OR FAIL
TO STAY IN A FAMILY HOME DUE TO
THE LACK OF ASSISTANCE THEY NEED
TO THRIVE. INVESTING IN FAMILIES
WITH SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER RATES
TO CAREGIVERS REFLECTS THE TRUE
NEED FOR GREATER SUPPORT AND
SERVICES IN FAMILY BASED
SETTINGS THAN IS PROVIDED UNDER
THE CURRENT INTERIM FOSTER CARE
RATE STRUCTURE. THE NEW FOSTER
CARE RATES PROPOSAL IS A ONCE IN
A GENERATION OPPORTUNITY TO
FINALLY RECOGNIZE THAT OUR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES NEED
GREATER SUPPORT AND SERVICES IN
ORDER TO STABILIZE AND IMPROVE
THE LIVES OF VULNERABLE
CHILDREN. FURTHERMORE, BY
RECOGNIZING AND ADEQUATELY
FUNDING CAREGIVERS, THIS
PROPOSAL FUNDS THE OUTCOMES WE
ALL WANT TO ACHIEVE. CHILDREN
SHOULD LIVE WITH FAMILY IN A
SAFE AND SUPPORTED HOME SETTING,
RECEIVING THE APPROPRIATE LEVEL
OF SUPPORT AND SERVICES IN ORDER
TO KEEP CONNECTED TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES OF ORIGIN. THIS
PROPOSAL DOES THAT BY HAVING THE
FUNDING FOLLOW THE CHILD
WHEREVER THEY ARE, RATHER THAN
THE PLACEMENT THEY ARE IN. ALL
CHILDREN AND YOUTH ENTER AT TIER
TWO TEMPORARILY, INCLUDING WHEN
THEY ARE PLACED WITH EMERGENCY
CAREGIVERS OR RELATIVES. FOR TOO
LONG, THE STATE'S FOSTER CARE
RATE SYSTEM HAS MISSED THE MARK
BY NOT SUPPORTING CAREGIVERS
UPFRONT UPON THE PLACEMENT OF A
CHILD. THIS PROPOSAL REVERSES
THE HISTORICAL INEQUALITY
EXPERIENCED BY RELATIVES WHO ARE
ASKED TO CARE FOR KIN, BUT
WITHOUT RECEIVING THE SAME LEVEL
OF SERVICES OFFERED TO OTHER
FAMILIES WHO HAVE BEEN
PRE-APPROVED AS A RESOURCE
PARENT. THIS PROPOSAL TREATS ALL
CAREGIVERS EQUALLY, NOT ONLY
DOES IT REVERSE HISTORICAL
INEQUALITY IN HOW RELATIVES ARE
SUPPORTED, BUT THE NEW PROPOSAL
RECOGNIZES THAT SUBSTANTIAL
SUPPORT IS NEEDED UP FRONT FROM
DAY ONE, REGARDLESS OF WHERE THE
CHILD OR YOUTH IS PLACED. IN
ADDITION, WE CELEBRATE THE NEW
FUNDING TO SUPPORT STRENGTH
BUILDING AND TO ADDRESS A CHILD
OR YOUTH IMMEDIATE NEEDS,
INCLUDING THOSE FOR YOUNG ADULTS
AND FOSTER CARE WHO ARE 18 TO
21. BOTH OF THESE UNPRECEDENTED
NEW FUNDS WILL ALLOW YOUTH TO
DEEPEN CONNECTIONS TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND INCREASE THEIR
OVERALL WELL-BEING, IN
PARTICULAR, EXTRACURRICULAR AND
ENRICHMENT ACTIVITIES CAN
PROVIDE POSITIVE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES TO HELP MITIGATE THE
EFFECTS OF TRAUMA IN A COUNTY
ADMINISTERED CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM, IT IS COMMON TO HAVE
SIGNIFICANT INCONSISTENCIES IN
SERVICE DELIVERY. VARYING LEVELS
OF SUPPORT FOR CHILDREN, YOUTH,
AND FAMILIES, AND GAPS IN
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
ENSURING THAT THERE IS STATE
OVERSIGHT, ACCOUNTABILITY WITH
OUTCOME DATA, AND A MODEL
CONTRACT WITH STANDARD STANDARDS
OF CARE. WITH THIS NEW INFUSION
OF INVESTMENT WILL HELP PROVIDE
EQUITABLE SUPPORT AND SERVICES
IN ALL COUNTIES TO ALL CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES. FOR ALL OF THESE
REASONS, CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
CAREGIVERS STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE
NEW INVESTMENTS IN THE FUTURE OF
OUR VULNERABLE CHILDREN AND
YOUTH OUTLINED IN THIS PROPOSAL.
IN CONCLUSION, WE THANK OUR
COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR COMMENTS.
MANY OF THEIR CONCERNS CAN AND
WILL BE ADDRESSED IN
IMPLEMENTATION AND SOME CAN BE
ADDRESSED IN TBL. CONCERNS ABOUT
THE PROPOSAL HAVE TO BE WEIGHED
AGAINST THE ENORMOUS LIFE
CHANGING BENEFITS FOR CHILDREN,
YOUTH AND FAMILIES. THIS
PROPOSAL OVERALL IS EXCEPTIONAL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MISS MISS
REXFORD ROAD, REX ROAD, YOU TALK
ABOUT, I WANTED TO ON THE 18 TO
21 YEAR OLDS YOU SPOKE ABOUT.
IT'S SO GREAT FOR THEM TO BE
ABLE TO GET THE STRENGTH,
BUILDING PORTION. THEY'RE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR IMMEDIATE NEEDS
UNDER THIS NEW RATE REFORM
PROPOSAL, AND YOU SPOKE ABOUT
NEEDING TO MITIGATE THE EFFECTS
OF TRAUMA. DO YOU DO YOU SEE
THAT THERE'S A NEED THERE FOR
THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS FOR THEM OR.
IT'S OKAY TO MOVE? NOT THAT IT'S
OKAY. MEANING CAN I CLARIFY THEY
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR TIER TWO AND
TIER THREE FUNDING IN ANY
SETTING OTHER THAN THE SLP. THE
SLP IS REALLY INTENDED FOR THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF READINESS, AND
I THINK CHIEF DEPUTY TROYA IN
THE LAST PANEL SPOKE ABOUT THE
NEED FOR THAT READINESS
ASSESSMENT. SO THE SLP RATE HAS
ALWAYS BEEN LIMITED TO THE BASIC
RATE IN RECOGNITION OF THAT. AND
IN THIS CASE THAT WOULD BE TIER
ONE. BUT FOR ANY OTHER SETTINGS.
SO FOR YOUTH IN OUR TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING, PROGRAMS, THEY COULD
ALSO RECEIVE THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS
THEY WOULD RECEIVE THE IMMEDIATE
NEEDS DOLLARS IF THEY WERE
ASSESSED INTO TIER TWO AND TIER
THREE. SO IT SHOULD BE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR YOUTH IN
THAT SETTING. THAT'S ALREADY
SUPPOSED TO BE PROVIDING THAT
ADDITIONAL LEVEL OF SUPPORT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE BEING
RESPONSIVE TO THE IMMEDIATE
NEEDS OF THOSE YOUTH AND
ADDRESSING THEIR TRANSITION.
WHAT ABOUT FOR THOSE THAT
PERHAPS ARE PREGNANT, THEY'RE
STILL GOING TO BE THE EXPECTANT
PARENTING PAYMENT AND THE INFANT
SUPPLEMENT. NOW, THERE ARE
PROPOSED NO CHANGES TO THOSE
DOLLARS. EXACTLY. THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOOD. YEAH. AND
FURTHERMORE, I, WE DO BELIEVE
THAT, THAT 18 TO 21 YEAR OLDS
WHO, WOULD BE ASSESSED AT THE
LEVEL TWO OR LEVEL THREE SHOULD
BE IN A MORE SUPPORTIVE NOT
ENVIRONMENT. AND WE DO NEED MORE
CAPACITY FOR THP. WHAT'S THP.
OH, SORRY. TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
PROGRAMS OKAY. THANK YOU. YEAH.
OUR FINAL PANELIST, FROM YOUTH
LAW CENTER. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND SENATOR
ROTH AND I JUST WANT TO START BY
SAYING THAT YOUR BREAKDOWN WAS
ACTUALLY THE MOST RATIONAL,
STATEMENT ON THE CURRENT STATE
OF AFFAIRS IN THE STATE THAT
I'VE HEARD. YOU KNOW, IN TIMES
OF CRISIS, THE LOGICAL AND
RATIONAL APPROACH WOULD BE TO
IDENTIFY WHO IS MOST VULNERABLE
AND WHO'S MOST AT RISK AND
PROTECT THEM. THEY ARE YOUNG
PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, HAVE THE MOST
TO LOSE FROM ALL OF THE CUTS AND
THE MOST TO GAIN FROM ALL OF THE
INTERVENTIONS. SO I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND JUST SAY THAT YOU HAVE ME
BELIEVING IN DEMOCRACY OVER
HERE. IF WE HAD ADVOCATES, AS WE
DO RIGHT NOW IN THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE DEPARTMENT SORT OF
WIDESPREAD, WE'D BE HAVING A
VERY DIFFERENT CONVERSATION. SO
I WANT MORE SOCIAL WORKERS TO
RUN FOR OFFICE. YES YES. SIGN ME
UP. SUPPORT YOU IN ANY WAY, SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING ALL
THE TIME TO FOCUS ON THIS REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. MY NAME IS
JENNIFER RODRIGUEZ, AND I'M
SEVERAL, RELEVANT ROLES. I
THINK, FOR THE DISCUSSION THAT
WE HAVE TODAY, I'M A LAWYER. I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
YOUTH LAW CENTER. WE ARE A
NATIONAL LEGAL, ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION FOCUSED ON BOTH
PROTECTING CHILDREN AND YOUTH
AND FOSTER CARE AND JUVENILE
JUSTICE FROM HARM AND MAKING
SURE THAT THEY GET THE SUPPORTS
THEY NEED TO THRIVE. AND I'M
SOMEBODY WHO GREW UP IN FOSTER
CARE MYSELF AND HAVE SPENT THE
LAST 25 YEARS WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE LEGISLATURE, WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION, WITH COUNTIES,
AND WITH OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO
TRY TO REFORM FOSTER CARE SO
THAT IT IS CHILD AND YOUTH
FOCUSED, NOT FOCUSED ON THE
NEEDS OF ADULTS OR BUREAUCRACIES
, OR PLACEMENTS, BUT REALLY
FOCUSED ON CHILDREN AND YOUTH,
AND I BELIEVE THAT THE PROPOSAL
THAT YOU'RE HAVING, THAT YOU'RE
SEEING IN FRONT OF YOU, LIKE
YOU'VE HEARD FROM OTHER SPEAKERS
THAT THIS IS REALLY A ONCE IN A
GENERATION, UNPRECEDENTED
OPPORTUNITY FOR AN ENTIRELY NEW
APPROACH THAT IS STRENGTH BASED,
YOU KNOW, I WON'T REPEAT THE
THINGS THAT OTHER FOLKS HAVE
SAID, BUT I WILL SAY THAT WE FOR
A LONG TIME HAVE HAD A RATE
SYSTEM THAT INCENTIVIZES US
IDENTIFYING WHAT'S WRONG WITH
CHILDREN AND YOUTH AND SORT OF
BEING ABLE TO RESOURCE ONLY AT
THE POINT WHERE THINGS HAVE
COMPLETELY FALLEN APART AND
WHERE WE'VE FAILED YOU TO THE
POINT OF CRISIS, SO THAT'S ONE
AREA THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
ME. AND THE OTHER IS THAT THIS
PROPOSAL MAKES GOOD ON THE
DIRECTIVE THAT THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE, PROPOSALS GAVE TO US TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR FISCAL
FUNDING AND OUR POLICIES ARE
ALIGNED WITH THIS GOAL OF MAKING
SURE THAT OUR SYSTEM IS
REVOLVING AROUND FAMILIES AND
THAT EVERY SINGLE CHILD AND
YOUTH WHO'S IN FOSTER CARE HAS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE IN A
FAMILY. AND YOU HEARD MR.
SENATOR EARLIER, I DON'T HAVE TO
TELL YOU THAT, MR. CENTER AND
ALL OF THE FAMILIES, WHETHER
THEY'RE KIN OR RESOURCE PARENTS
IN OUR SYSTEM WHO ARE CARING FOR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH, THEY ARE NOT
BEDS, THEY ARE NOT PLACEMENTS.
THEY ARE THE MOST POWERFUL
INTERVENTION THAT WE HAVE TO
OFFER. WHEN WE HAVE TO BRING A
CHILD INTO FOSTER CARE. AND SO
WE NEED TO BE DOING EVERYTHING
IN OUR POWER TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR DOLLARS ARE SUPPORTING THEM
IN THIS WORK THEY HAVE HELD
THROUGH THROUGH COVID, WHEN ALL
THE REST OF OUR SYSTEMS SHUT
DOWN, THEY ARE HOLDING THROUGH
NOW. I LOVE THAT WHEN HE
DESCRIBED HIS SON THAT HE SAID
HE IS SO 13 BECAUSE THEY ARE
BASICALLY THE ONLY FOLKS IN OUR
SYSTEM WHO WILL SEE OUR CHILDREN
AND YOUTH AS TEENAGERS, AS 13
YEAR OLDS. NOT A COLLECTION OF
THE WORST THINGS THAT THEY DID
OR THE WORST THINGS THAT
HAPPENED TO THEM ON THEIR WORST
DAY. SO ALL OF THAT TO SAY, I
DON'T WANT TO REPEAT WHAT OTHER
FOLKS HAVE SAID, BUT I DO JUST
WANT TO GIVE SOME CONTEXT FOR
WHY WE ARE SO EXCITED AND WHY
THIS HAS BEEN OUR NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY. MOVING THE RATE
STRUCTURE FORWARD THIS YEAR,
WHICH IS THAT I REALLY WANT TO
EMPHASIZE HOW DRASTICALLY
DIFFERENT THIS PROPOSAL IS FROM
THE ONE THAT GOT US WHERE WE
CURRENTLY ARE TODAY IN FOSTER
CARE, WHICH IS A LOT OF CRISIS
WHERE WE ARE SEEING, YOU KNOW,
FAMILIES STRUGGLING WITH THE
DESPERATION OF NOT BEING ABLE TO
GET THE RESOURCES THEY NEED
UNTIL THINGS HAVE COMPLETELY
FALLEN APART OR WE'RE AT THE
POINT OF CRISIS WITH FAMILIES
NOT BEING TREATED AS THE PRIMARY
INTERVENTION. AND PARTNER WITH
CHILD WELFARE AGENCIES, BUT
REALLY AS A AS A BED THAT YOU
CAN MOVE CHILDREN IN AND OUT OF
OR AT BEST, A GLORIFIED
BABYSITTER, I BEGAN MY ADVOCACY
AS A YOUTH MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION 25
YEARS AGO NOW, AND WHEN I
STARTED, I WAS REALLY DETERMINED
TO WORK SO THAT IF A CHILD OR
YOUTH HAD TO ENTER FOSTER CARE,
THAT EXPERIENCE WOULDN'T CAUSE
ADDITIONAL PAIN, DEVASTATION AND
HARM. AND AT THAT TIME, WHEN I
STARTED MY ADVOCACY, IT WAS
WIDELY ACCEPTED THAT BASICALLY,
ONCE YOU GRADUATED ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL AND PARTICULARLY IF YOU
WERE BLACK OR BROWN, THAT THE
PLAN WAS GOING TO BE FOR YOU TO
LIVE IN CONGREGATE CARE, PERIOD,
AND OUR SYSTEM. AND THAT MEANT
THAT WE WOULD MISS OUT ON THE
EXPERIENCE OF BEING PART OF A
FAMILY AND ALL OF THE STABILITY
AND RELATIONSHIPS AND REGULAR
CHILD EXPERIENCES THAT INVOLVED.
WHEN I ACTUALLY WORKED ON MY
FIRST BILL IN CIC, WHICH WAS
BACK IN 1999, THE FOSTER CARE
BILL OF RIGHTS, WE BELIEVE THAT
WE NEEDED THE LAW TO FORCE
SYSTEMS TO RECOGNIZE OUR RIGHT
TO LIVE IN A FAMILY, TO HAVE OUR
RELATIONSHIPS PROTECTED, TO BE
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES.
BECAUSE THE FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES, THE PRACTICES AND
THE POLICIES THAT WERE IN PLACE,
THEY ACTUALLY MADE IT EASIER TO
INSTITUTIONALIZE US AND TO NOT
DO THOSE THINGS THEN TO DO THEM.
AND SO AS SOMEONE WHO, AS A
RESULT, SPENT ALL MY YEARS IN
FOSTER CARE, IN INSTITUTIONAL
PLACEMENTS, GROUP HOMES,
SHELTERS, PSYCH HOSPITALS, BY
THE TIME I WAS A TEENAGER,
JUVENILE HALL AND PREDICTABLY
EXITED COMPLETELY ALONE TO
HOMELESSNESS AND LOTS OF
STRUGGLE. IT WAS REALLY HARD FOR
ME TO IMAGINE, WHEN I STARTED MY
ADVOCACY, THAT THERE WOULD BE A
DAY WHEN THE SYSTEM WOULD LIKE
LOUDLY AND PROUDLY PROCLAIM THAT
EVERY CHILD AND YOUTH SHOULD
LIVE IN A FAMILY, AND THAT OUR
POLICY AND FISCAL FRAMEWORK
SHOULD REFLECT THAT GOAL,
ENSURING THAT WE RESOURCE
FAMILIES WITH THE SUPPORTS THAT
CHILDREN AND YOUTH NEED, AND
THAT WILL ALLOW THEM TO THRIVE
IN A FAMILY FROM DAY ONE, NOT ON
THE DAY WHEN EVERYTHING FALLS
APART. AND WE SUDDENLY DECIDED
THAT THERE ARE TOO COMPLEX TO
SERVE, BUT FROM DAY ONE, SO THAT
THEY CAN HEAL AND FIND
STABILITY. AND THIS IS WHY I'M
SO HOPEFUL AND EXCITED ABOUT
THIS NEW PROPOSED RATE
STRUCTURE. IT CREATES OUR LONG
AWAITED FIRST ATTEMPT AT A
FISCAL STRUCTURE THAT ALLOWS US
TO FINALLY START BUILDING THE
SYSTEM'S CAPACITY TO PUT NEEDS
FIRST. WE'RE DEEPLY GRATEFUL TO
THE DEPARTMENT'S LEADERSHIP IN
DOING THE WORK TO CREATE AN
INCLUSIVE PROCESS. OVER THE LAST
TWO YEARS TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS. I KNOW THAT MANY
OF THE AREAS THAT WE'RE EXCITED
ABOUT DEPEND ON HOW
IMPLEMENTATION ROLLS OUT. I CAN
ASSURE YOU, WE, AS WELL AS OTHER
ADVOCATES, WILL BE RIGHT THERE
IN IMPLEMENTATION. WE WILL BE
RAISING OUR HAND AND COMING TO
YOU ALL, TO HOLD THE DEPARTMENT
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
ACCOUNTABLE. IF IMPLEMENTATION
DOES NOT ROLL OUT WITH THE
VALUES THAT WE HAD IN MIND, BUT
WE ARE OVERALL VERY, VERY
EXCITED AT THIS, YOU KNOW, REAL,
REAL EFFORT TO TRY TO PRIORITIZE
CHILDREN BEING IN FAMILIES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, I HAD SOME
OTHER QUESTIONS I FORGOT TO ASK
ON THE SPENDING PLANNING MANAGER
WHO IS ELIGIBLE TO BE THAT. SO
IN THE TRAILER, BILL, IT'S VERY
BROAD BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WHEN WE PUT THE RFP
OUT THAT WE CAN SORT OF HAVE
SOLICITATIONS OR BIDS FROM LIKE
A LOT SO THAT WE CAN REALLY FIND
THE RIGHT ENTITY AND
ORGANIZATION. SO A NONPROFIT
WOULD IT COULD BE A NONPROFIT.
EXACTLY. YEAH. OKAY GREAT, I
THINK THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN MY
LAST QUESTION. I JUST WANT TO I
KNOW, AND WE SPOKE ABOUT THIS.
IT'S VERY SIMILAR. WE'RE TAKING
NOTES FROM OUR OTHER DEPARTMENT,
DOES ENSURING BECAUSE THIS IS
SIMILAR TO THEIR, THEIR
SELF-DETERMINATION PROGRAMS AND
THE IEP MEETINGS THAT THEY HAVE
AND ENSURING THAT THE SPENDING
PLAN MANAGER OR IN THIS CASE, A
NONPROFIT. POTENTIALLY A
NONPROFIT, HOPEFULLY WE CAN
AVOID SOME OF THE PROBLEMS WE
SEE THERE, IS REALLY JUST
GETTING THE DOLLARS OUT, TO THE
INDIVIDUALS SO THEY CAN HAVE
THEIR RESOURCES, THEIR
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES, UP
FRONT AND NOT BE STUCK WITH THE
BILL THAT WE'RE SEEING IN THAT
SITUATION. I THINK THAT WOULD BE
MY ONLY. YOU'RE DESCRIBING OUR
VISION. YEAH. PERFECT GREAT. NØ
AGAIN, REALLY EXCITED ABOUT
THIS. I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE,
WE'VE I HEARD YOU, YOU KNOW, AND
ADDED LANGUAGE. LET'S SEE HOW WE
CAN CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
COUNTIES ON THOSE POINTS ON
RFPS. I HEARD YOU AS WELL. THANK
YOU SO, SO MUCH FOR COMING AND
SPEAKING ABOUT HOW THIS WILL BE
TRANSFORMATIVE FOR, PEOPLE WHO
WHO ARE EXPERIENCING WHAT YOU
EXPERIENCED BEFORE. SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR SHARING YOUR
STORIES. THAT CONCLUDES OUR
PANEL FOR THIS TOPIC. MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER THREE. AND,
DIRECTOR, YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS.
KIM JOHNSON, CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
SO HERE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME PROGRAM,
WHICH PROVIDES HOUSING RELATED
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE AND
WRAPAROUND SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
TO SOME OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA. THOSE
EXPERIENCING OR AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS WHO ARE INVOLVED IN
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM, THE
GOAL IS TWOFOLD TO KEEP FAMILIES
TOGETHER AS WELL AS SUPPORT THEM
IN REMAINING AND BECOMING STABLY
HOUSED. THE BUDGET ACTS OF 21
AND 22 PROVIDED A TOTAL OF $185
MILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDING TO
THIS PROGRAM THROUGH THE
EXPANDED ONE TIME FUNDS, THE
PROGRAM SCALED FROM 22 COUNTIES
AND ONE TRIBE. IN 2019 2020 TO
53 COUNTIES AND 25 TRIBES IN
2223. IN FISCAL YEAR 2223, THE
PROGRAM SERVED 1996 FAMILIES.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY 2855 ACTIVE
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE. AS OF
DECEMBER OF LAST YEAR. IN FISCAL
YEAR 22, 23 FAMILIES EXITING THE
PROGRAM OVER HALF EXITED TO
PERMANENT HOUSING. ACCORDING TO
PRELIMINARY FINDINGS FROM THE
EVALUATION CONDUCTED BY UC
BERKELEY, CALIFORNIA POLICY LAB
AND UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S DATA
NETWORK, ENROLLMENT IN THIS
PROGRAM REDUCED THE USE OF
EMERGENCY SHELTER AND
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING BY 50, AND
DOUBLED THE USE OF EVIDENCE
BASED RAPID REHOUSING SERVICES
IN THE SIX MONTHS FOLLOWING
PROGRAM ENTRY. MOST FAMILIES 52%
THAT EXITED THE PROGRAM BY THE
END OF THE PROGRAM'S SECOND
YEAR, LEFT TO PERMANENT HOUSING,
ONLY 3% REPORTED EXITING TO
HOMELESSNESS. BRINGING FILMS,
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME, FAMILIES
WITH A CHILD IN FOSTER CARE AND
RECEIVING FAMILY REUNIFICATION.
SERVICES WERE 68% MORE LIKELY TO
HAVE A FAMILY REUNIFICATION THAN
NON PARTICIPATING FAMILIES AT
SIX MONTHS FOLLOWING PROGRAM
ENTRY. ADDITIONALLY, ACCORDING
TO A RECENT STUDY PUBLISHED BY
CHAPIN HALL AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CHICAGO ON SAN FRANCISCO, 86% OF
THE 145 CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
REFERRED TO BRINGING FAMILIES
HOME WITH A FAMILY REUNIFICATION
CASE HAD EXITED CARE BY DECEMBER
1ST OF 2022. A MAJORITY OF
CHILDREN WERE REUNIFIED WITH
FAMILY, AND MOST OTHERS EXITED
VIA ADOPTION OR LEGAL
GUARDIANSHIP. FURTHERMORE, A
LARGE MAJORITY OF PARTICIPANTS
THAT EXITED THE PROGRAM WITHIN
THE STUDY'S OBSERVATION PERIOD
WERE ABLE TO OBTAIN HOUSING.
ADDITIONALLY, 81% OF THOSE
PARTICIPANTS WHO OBTAINED
HOUSING WERE STABLY HOUSED SIX
MONTHS AFTER PROGRAM EXIT IN
TERMS OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL, AND I WANT TO JUST
NOTE ALL PROGRAM FUNDS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE AVAILABLE FOR LOCAL
ASSISTANCE HAVE BEEN ALLOCATED
TO GRANTEES. OF THE $185 MILLION
ALLOCATED, 165,750,000 HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED IN A TOTAL OF 53
COUNTIES IN 25 TRIBES AS OF JUNE
OF LAST YEAR, $23.9 MILLION HAD
BEEN EXPENDED AT THAT SAME TIME
PERIOD, THE AMOUNT REMAINING
FROM 2223 AND 2122 IS 141.8
MILLION. SO AGAIN, THE PROPOSAL
IS TO DELAY $80 MILLION OF
FUNDING, AND IT'S INTENDED TO
SMOOTH OUT FUNDING INTO FISCAL
YEAR 2526 BASED ON HOW
EXPENDITURES HAVE BEEN TRENDING
TO DATE AND PROVIDING GRANTEES
AN ADDITIONAL YEAR FOR
EXPENDITURE. WE'RE EXTENDING THE
TIMELINES FOR INITIAL YEAR. IT'S
WHERE NORMALLY IT WOULD HAVE
ENDED IN JUNE OF 2025 TO JUNE OF
2026. WE ARE NOT PROPOSING TO
REDUCE FUNDING FOR THESE
PROGRAMS. WE'RE NOT INTENDING TO
LIMIT SERVICE DELIVERY FOR
PARTICIPANTS, AS YOU JUST HEARD
ME LIST THE OUTCOMES AND SUCCESS
TO DATE, AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THE PROPOSAL IN THE DOLLAR
AMOUNTS INCLUDED WERE BASED ON
ONE TIME POINT IN TIME DATA. WE
PLAN TO REVISIT THAT IN THE MAY
REVISION AND UPDATE ACCORDINGLY.
WE ARE WORKING WITH COUNTIES AND
WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AS WELL.
AND SO AS WE'RE GETTING MORE
FINE TUNED ON THE ACTUAL
NUMBERS, THOSE WOULD BE UPDATED
AND MAY REVISE. AND LOOKING AT
REDISTRIBUTION. OAN ALSO THAT
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT EARLIER IN
THIS HEARING TODAY, DEPARTMENT
FINANCE AND ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
MARLENE DAVIS, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
AT THIS TIME. SHORTS THANK YOU,
ANGELA SHORT LAO, AS YOU JUST
HEARD FROM THE DEPARTMENT, OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE INTENT
OF THIS PROPOSED DELAY REALLY IS
TO REFLECT ACTUAL EXPENDITURES
AND ACHIEVE SOME SAVINGS IN THE
BUDGET YEAR, NOT ACTUALLY TO
REDUCE, OVERALL FUNDING FOR THE
PROGRAM. SO WE AGREE THAT IF
THIS DELAY CAN BE IMPLEMENTED
WITHOUT NEGATIVELY IMPACTING
BENEFICIARY OR DISRUPTING
SERVICE LEVELS, THAT IT
CERTAINLY SEEMS TO MAKE SENSE
GIVEN THE CURRENT BUDGET
SITUATION, AS YOU ALSO HEARD
FROM DIRECTOR JOHNSON, SOMETHING
WE'VE ALSO BEEN WONDERING ABOUT
IS, GIVEN THAT DIFFERENT
COUNTIES ARE ARE SPENDING THEIR
ALLOCATIONS AT DIFFERENT RATES,
JUST IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE,
PERHAPS WITH THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL TO ENSURE THAT, ANY,
ANY REDISTRIBUTION THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO ENSURE THAT SMOOTH
CONTINUATION OF EXPENDITURE IS
OCCURRING. SO THAT'S SOMETHING
WE'LL BE LOOKING FOR AT MAY
REVISION. BUT OVERALL WE AGREE
THE DELAY PROPOSAL SEEMS TO MAKE
SENSE. DIRECTOR I WAS GOING TO
THAT WAS GOING TO BE ONE OF MY
QUESTIONS. IF WE WERE LOOKING AT
REDISTRIBUTING FUNDING ACROSS
THE COUNTIES TO BALANCE IT ALL
OUT. THAT'S RIGHT. AND WE HAVE
BEEN IN THE CONVERSATION WITH
KDA AND COUNTIES RELATED TO
THAT. SO AS WE SEE ANY
PARTICULAR GIVEN COUNTY REACHING
THEIR EXPENDITURES AT A HIGHER
RATE SOONER, WE'D WANT TO HAVE
SOME ABILITY TO MAKE SURE WE CAN
MOVE RESOURCES AROUND WITHIN THE
APPROPRIATION. AND THIS WAS
ALWAYS A ONE TIME FUND
APPROPRIATION. SO WE SHOULD WE
ARE ANTICIPATING A CLIFF
HAPPENING. WHAT'S THE PLAN FOR
THE PARTICIPANTS IN THE PROGRAM,
AGAIN, YOU HEARD ME GIVE THE
OUTCOMES IN TERMS OF STABILITY
AND WHERE WE ARE TRANSITIONING
PEOPLE. I THINK WHAT WE'VE
HEARD, AND EVEN IN THIS PROPOSAL
THAT THE COUNTIES ARE WANTING TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND APPROPRIATION
ALLOCATION, TO BE ABLE TO
DETERMINE WHO THEY CAN NEWLY
ACCEPT. I MEAN, I THINK THAT'S
THAT'S THE CONSIDERATION GOING
FORWARD. WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE ARE ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE
TO THE LEGISLATURE AND, AND
PUBLIC MORE BROADLY, THE
OUTCOMES OF THE PROGRAM AND
WHAT'S WORKING, TO DETERMINE IF
THERE ARE OTHER WAYS THAT WE
COULD SUSTAIN ANY LEVEL OF
RESOURCE AND OR LOOK AT OTHER
FUNDING COMPONENTS THAT EXIST
THAT COULD BE MODIFIED TO MEET
IN TAILORED, BE TAILORED TO THE
NEEDS OF THIS POPULATION. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WE'RE GOING TO HOLD
THE ITEM UP AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR.
HIÂU ZIPPING DOWN. WE'RE GOING.
AMAZING THE SECOND PART.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. JESSICA.
YES. OKAY GOOD, GOOD AFTERNOON,
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK HERE TODAY.
MY NAME IS JESSICA ROUGEAU. I'M
THE BRANCH CHIEF OF THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM BRANCH AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. I'LL BE SPEAKING THIS
MORNING ABOUT THE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL FOR THE CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES. CALIFORNIA. AUTOMATING
THE MC AND RIGHT IN FRONT OF
YOU. YES. THANK YOU. IS THAT
BETTER? I'LL BE SPEAKING THIS
AFTERNOON ABOUT THE BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL FOR CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES FOR CALIFORNIA
AUTOMATED RESPONSE AND
ENGAGEMENT SYSTEM, ALSO KNOWN AS
AWS CARES. THE AWS CALIFORNIA
AUTOMATED AND RESPONSE
ENGAGEMENT SYSTEM PROJECT IS TO
IMPLEMENT AND MODERNIZE THE
SYSTEM TO SUPPORT CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES STATEWIDE. CARES WILL
BE A STATEWIDE CASE MANAGEMENT
AND DATA SOLUTION THAT
INCORPORATES CAPABILITIES NOT
ACHIEVABLE THROUGH THE EXISTING
CHILD WELFARE SERVICES CASE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM, ALSO KNOWN AS
AWS CMS. ESSENTIAL TO THE
DELIVERY OF TAILORED, HIGH
QUALITY CHILD WELFARE SERVICES
AND TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH
THE COMPREHENSIVE CHILD WELFARE
INFORMATION SYSTEM REQUIREMENTS
AND TO MAINTAIN OUR FEDERAL
FINANCIAL PARTICIPATION AND
RELATED REQUIREMENTS. THIS
MODERNIZATION WILL ASSIST IN
IMPROVING DATA COLLECTION AND
MONITORING OF CHILD AND FAMILY
OUTCOMES, SERVICE DELIVERY AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF NEW CHILD
WELFARE INITIATIVES STATEWIDE.
IT DIRECTLY BENEFITS CHILD
WELFARE WORKERS BY REMOVING
DUPLICATION OF EFFORTS,
STREAMLINING BUSINESS PROCESSES,
AND ENSURING THAT CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES WON'T HAVE TO REPEAT
INFORMATION OVER AND OVER AGAIN
AND FEEL HEARD AND ENGAGED AND
DECREASING THE IMPACT OF THE
TRAUMA THEY'VE ALREADY
EXPERIENCED. I'M GOING TO HAND
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE. HI, MY
NAME IS CYNTHIA TUCKER. I'M WITH
THE OFFICE OF TECHNOLOGY
SOLUTIONS INTEGRATION, AND I'M A
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OVER THIS
PROJECT. AND SO IN THE SUPPORT
OF THESE PROGRAMMATIC GOALS,
THIS PROPOSAL REQUESTS SUPPORT
TO CONTINUE WITH THESE ESSENTIAL
WORK ON AWS CARE SOLUTION AND
WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF AWS
CARES, THE STATE WOULD BE ABLE
TO DECOMMISSION THE LEGACY
SYSTEM ALREADY STATED AWS CMS.
THIS IS THIS PROJECT OR THIS
PROPOSAL HAS REQUESTED 225
MILLION IN TOTAL FUNDS. INCLUDES
FUNDING AUTHORIZED IN THE
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE FOR THE
STATE FISCAL YEAR OF 2425, WHICH
INCLUDES LIKE FIVE NEW POSITIONS
TO SUPPORT STATE, COUNTY AND
VENDOR ACTIVITIES FOR THE
CONTINUED DESIGN DEVELOPMENT.
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS SYSTEM.
SO THAT IS FOR OUR FIRST. OOPS,
GOT A SCROLL. AND THEN WITH
REGARDS TO THE 2023 BUDGET ACT,
APPROPRIATION AND SPENDING, ETC.
SO AS OF THE END OF MARCH, MARCH
22ND, THE PROJECT ACTUAL
EXPENDITURES AND APPROVE
INVOICES ARE ABOUT 77 MILLION,
FOR THE BUDGET ACT APPROPRIATION
AS OF NOW, WE DO EXPECT TO USE
THE FULL BUDGET BASED ON ONGOING
CURRENT WORK AND THE TIMING OF
WHEN WE EXPECT TO RECEIVE THOSE
INVOICES, THE AMOUNT OF TIME IT
TAKES TO DO PASTURE CLOSE, AS
WELL AS THE INVOICE PROCESSING
TIMELINE, AFFECTS FINALIZATION
OF OUR ACTUALS, THE TIMING OF
THEM FOR A FISCAL YEAR. YEAH,
OKAY. AND THEN IN TERMS IN TERMS
OF THE TIMELINE FOR THE PROJECT,
SO AWS CARES VERSION ONE IS
PLANNED FOR A STATEWIDE GO LIVE
IN OCTOBER OF 2026, WHICH IS
ALIGNED WITH THE SPECIAL PROJECT
REPORT, OR SPR SIX, APPROVED BY
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY ON MAY 12TH, 2023.
AND WE THINK THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
TO SHARE WITH YOU, ADDITIONALLY,
BASED ON THE QUESTIONS THAT HAD
BEEN ASKED, IS, FOCUS ON THAT?
AWS CARES IS BEING LEVERAGED TO
SUPPORT STATEWIDE INITIATIVES
SUCH AS THE FOSTER CARE RATES
PROPOSAL. WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING
TODAY, FSA PREVENTION SERVICES,
FEDERAL CLAIMING, AND OTHER
CHILD WELFARE IMPROVEMENTS THAT
ARE BEING TIMED FOR
IMPLEMENTATION WITH THE
AUTOMATION. THIS SUPPORTS THE
PROGRAM AND PROVIDING REQUIRED
TIME TO DEVELOP PROGRAM POLICY
EVALUATION CRITERIA. ENSURE
OPERATIONAL IMPLEMENTATION IS
READY TO GO AND THAT WE HAVE
MORE THAN ADEQUATE TIME TO MEET
WITH ALL SYSTEM PARTNERS IN
PREPARATION FOR THAT WORK, CS
HAS WORKED TO AVOID DELAYS IN
PROGRAM INITIATIVES BY
DEVELOPING INTERIM SOLUTIONS. SO
AS AN EXAMPLE, IN THE CASE OF
FSA PART ONE PREVENTION
SERVICES, WE HAVE INCLUDED IN
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THE BLOCK
GRANT, EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY
BEING MOVED OUT THROUGH JUNE
30TH, 2028, IN THE TOTAL AMOUNT
OF THE BLOCK GRANT IS 2220 2.4
MILLION TO SUPPORT FSA
IMPLEMENTATION THÀNH AMONG THE
COUNTIES AS AN INTERIM SOLUTION
UNTIL FEDERAL CLAIMING CAN BEGIN
WITH THE COINCIDING WITH THE
VERSION ONE OF CARES BEING
RELEASED. THE VERSION ONE OF
CARES IS GOING TO BE RELEASED IN
2026. IT'S SET FOR OCTOBER 2026,
AND YOU NEED THIS TO GO UNTIL
2028. WHY PASS THE BLOCK GRANT
EXTENSION, I THINK, AND I CAN,
YOU KNOW, REFER TO ANGIE, IF SHE
WOULD LIKE TO, BUT THE INTENTION
BEHIND THE EXTENSION WAS TO MAKE
SURE THERE'S MORE THAN ADEQUATE
TIME. SO IN THE EVENT THERE WAS
ANY TRANSITIONARY PERIOD THAT
WAS NEEDED TO SUPPORT COUNTIES
AND THAT CLAIMING, NOT BECAUSE
WE THINK PART ONE IS GOING TO BE
NEED TO EXTEND TO 2028. CORRECT?
I THINK IT'S MEANT AS A SAFETY,
A SAFETY NET OR A STOP GAP IN
THE TRANSITION PERIOD. OKAY
LET'S SEE. AND WITH THE CARES VÆ
ONE STATEWIDE IMPLEMENTATION IN
THE STATE WILL BE ABLE TO DRAW
DOWN THE FEDERAL FUNDS, FOR THE
MATCHING FOR, FOR, FOR, FOR Â
AND FOR BE. MR. DAVIS, ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENT? MARLENE
DAVIS, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENT. MR. OR MR.
METZGER YES. BRIAN METZGER LAO,
BASED ON OUR REVIEW OF THE
ANNUAL PROGRESS DEMONSTRATION
THAT WAS HELD EARLIER THIS
MONTH, AS WELL AS PROJECT
OVERSIGHT DOCUMENTS, WE FIND
THAT THE PROJECT IS MAKING
PROGRESS LARGELY IN LINE WITH
THE BASELINE COST, SCHEDULE AND
SCOPE, HOWEVER, THERE HAVE BEEN
RECENT INDICATIONS THAT, THE
PROJECT MAY BE VEERING A LITTLE
BIT OFF COURSE, THERE ARE SOME
ISSUES AND RISKS THAT COULD
IMPACT THE PROJECT SCHEDULE, BUT
THOSE ARE STILL BEING MITIGATED
AND STILL BEING, YOU KNOW,
DISCUSSED AT THE PROJECT LEVEL.
AND THERE'S ACTIVE NEGOTIATIONS
AND DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THOSE, I
WAS GLAD TO HEAR TODAY THE
UPDATED NUMBERS ON EXPENDITURES,
THE 77 MILLION WE STILL WOULD,
ASK THAT THE PROJECT PROVIDE A
MONTHLY KIND OF PLAN FOR THOSE
EXPENDITURES BECAUSE RIGHT NOW,
THOSE EXPENDITURES ARE STILL
QUITE LOW RELATIVE TO WHAT'S
BUDGETED. WE UNDERSTAND THERE
ARE MONTH TO MONTH CHANGES THAT
COULD AFFECT THOSE EXPENDITURE
NUMBERS. BUT GIVEN THE IMMEDIATE
BUDGET PROBLEM, IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO HAVE THOSE PROJECTED
EXPENDITURES FOR THE REST OF THE
CURRENT FISCAL YEAR. WE HAVE
REQUESTED THAT, HAVEN'T WE? WE
HAVE, BUT I HAVE NOT SEEN THAT
TO DATE. SO THAT IS SOMETHING I
THINK WOULD BENEFIT THE
LEGISLATURE, RIGHT? YEAH BECAUSE
I MEAN, I DID READ WE HAVE
REQUESTED, MONTHLY SPENDING
PROJECTIONS. AND FOR THE CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR, WHEN DO WE
ANTICIPATE GETTING OUR FIRST
ONE? YES, WE'RE. Þ. MAYBE SO.
OKAY, SO, WE ARE WORKING WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WITH
REGARDS TO OUR OVERALL, ALL THE
WORK THAT IS GOING ON FOR THIS
CURRENT FISCAL YEAR, AND WE
CURRENTLY DO EXPECT TO EXPEND
ALL OF THE FUNDING FOR IT.
RIGHT. BUT WHEN DO WE GET WHEN
ARE WE GETTING THE WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE GETTING MONTHLY
SPENDING PROJECTIONS ONCE AND WE
HAVEN'T RECEIVED ONE C¯
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. LET US
GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT. AND
YEAH. AND JUST, ONE ADDITIONAL
COMMENT IS THAT, AS PART OF LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET ACT, THERE WAS
PROVISIONAL BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
THAT WAS ADOPTED THAT WAS
CONDITIONING A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
FUNDING, 35.1 MILLION ON THE
DEMONSTRATION OF VERIFIED,
SATISFACTORY PROGRESS. THAT WAS
THE TERMINOLOGY THAT WAS USED
WITH SPECIFIC KIND OF PARTS OF
THAT. WHAT DOES THAT MEAN? RIGHT
AND TO OUR KNOWLEDGE, THAT HAS
NOT BEEN REQUESTED, THAT
AUGMENTATION OF THE 35.1 MILLION
HAS NOT BEEN REQUESTED YET, SO
WE WOULD ASK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REQUEST AN UPDATE ON
WHETHER THAT MONEY WILL BE
REQUESTED AND WHEN, BECAUSE IT
WILL BE IMPORTANT FOR US TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION DEEMS
SATISFACTORY, PROGRESS BASED ON
WHAT WAS ADOPTED LAST YEAR. CAN
YOU CAN YOU SAY THAT TO ME AGAIN
IN A DIFFERENT WAY? SURE. YEAH
BASICALLY LAST YEAR THERE WAS A
DISCUSSION WHERE OAN CARES CAME
BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE AT MAY
REVISION ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE SPENT HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS ON THIS PROJECT AND
WE HAVE NOT ACHIEVED COMPLETION
OF THE PROJECT. AND SO THERE WAS
AN INTEREST IN THE LEGISLATURE
ADOPTING A WAY OF DEFINING WHAT
IT MEANS TO MAKE SATISFACTORY
PROGRESS TOWARDS COMPLETION.
RIGHT. AND SO THERE WAS LANGUAGE
DRAFTED, AND A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
MONEY WAS CONDITIONED ON SHOWING
US WHAT THAT PROGRESS LOOKED
LIKE, TO DATE, THAT AMOUNT OF
MONEY HAS NOT BEEN REQUESTED.
AND IT SEEMS BECAUSE THE
EXPENDITURES ARE NOT TRACKING
LIKE ON BUDGET, THAT THAT IS
CAUSING POTENTIALLY A DELAY IN
THEM REQUESTING THAT MONEY. AND
SO AND WE DON'T KNOW WHEN THAT
REQUEST IS GOING TO GO CORRECT.
DO WE KNOW WHEN THAT REQUEST IS
GOING TO COME IN? I WOULD DEFER
TO MY COLLEAGUES. YEAH.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
STILL LOOKING AT. SO THAT'LL BE
FORTHCOMING OKAY OKAY. SO WE'RE
WAITING ON THE REPORTS WHEN THE
FIRST ONE IS GOING TO COME IN.
AND A TIMELINE ON WHEN THE
POTENTIAL REQUESTS IF THIS OR
NEXT BUDGET YEAR, WOULD IT BE
THIS WE'RE, WE'RE WE'RE KIND OF
WORKING THROUGH THAT NOW. SO
WE'RE HOPING TO GET YOU GUYS AN
UPDATE. OKAY. YEAH. WOULD IT BE
A. DO YOU ANTICIPATE DURING THE
MAY REVISION REVISE. I, I CAN'T
SAY WITH CERTAINTY. YEAH OKAY.
THANK YOU. WERE YOU DONE WITH
YOUR COMMENTS? GREAT ANGELA
SHORT WITH THE LÀ. ONE OTHER
COMMENT WE DID WANT TO MAKE HERE
IS RELATED TO THE FOSTER CARE
RATE REFORM, WHICH WE WERE JUST
TALKING ABOUT IN A PREVIOUS
ISSUE OF THIS AGENDA, AS WE
DISCUSSED, THERE ARE MANY
DETAILS THAT ARE STILL VERY MUCH
ALIVE AND BEING WORKED ON
CURRENTLY IN TERMS OF THE
SPECIFIC DETAILS OF THAT
PROPOSAL. THAT SAID, WE DID WANT
TO FLAG, IT'S POSSIBLE THAT NEW
FUNCTIONALITIES COULD BE
REQUIRED OF ORTEZ CARES
DEPENDING ON THE DETAILS OF THE
NEW FOSTER CARE RATE STRUCTURE
FOR EXAMPLE, YOU KNOW THE
STRENGTH BUILDING COMPONENT.
THIS IS A BRAND NEW COMPONENT
THAT IS NOT CURRENTLY A PART OF
FOSTER CARE RATES. SO WE DO HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS AROUND WHETHER
ADDITIONAL DEVELOPMENT
AUTOMATION THÀNH COULD BE
REQUIRED TO BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT
THE NEW RATE STRUCTURE. WE WOULD
NOTE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DID
INCLUDE $12 MILLION GENERAL FUND
TO BEGIN NEW AUTOMATION IN AWS
CARES, AS WELL AS CAL SOLS
RELATED TO THE NEW RATE
STRUCTURE, BUT IT'S UNCLEAR TO
US AT THIS TIME IF THAT IS
INTENDED TO COVER THE FULL
EXTENT OF NEW REQUIRED
AUTOMATION, SO THAT'S JUST
SOMETHING THAT WE WILL BE
WORKING TO FULLY UNDERSTAND.
AND, AND IT WILL ALSO DEPEND
ULTIMATELY ON THE FINAL DETAILS
OF THE CCR PERMANENT RATE
STRUCTURE PROPOSAL. OKAY AND
DIRECTOR JOHNSON, MAYBE THIS IS
A QUESTION FOR YOU. THAT 12
MILLION REQUEST IS THAT FOR ALL
ANTICIPATED AUTOMATED NEEDS.
YES. OKAY. COULD HAVE JUST
NODDED. THERE WE GO. ALSO WANTED
TO CLARIFY THAT THAT THAT IS A
PLACEHOLDER, AND THE AUTOMATION
COSTS REALLY CAN'T WON'T BE
FINALIZED UNTIL WE KIND OF
FINALIZE THE FRAMEWORK. SO.
OKAY. OKAY. THANK YOU FOR THAT.
OKAY. NO FURTHER QUESTIONS.
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THE ITEM
OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE. FAMILY'S FIRST PREVENTION
SERVICE PROGRAM EXTENSION. OKAY.
GREAT. OKAY. WELCOME BACK. WHAT
IS NOW? GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
ANGIE SCHWARTZ, DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OVER THE CHILDREN AND FAMILY
SERVICES DIVISION AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
THIS PROPOSAL REQUEST TO EXTEND
THE EXPENDITURE DEADLINE FROM
JUNE 30TH, 2024 FOR THE STATE
BLOCK GRANT FOR THE FAMILY FIRST
PREVENTION SERVICES ACT TO JUNE
30TH, 2028. IT'S IN SUPPORT OF
IMPLEMENTATION OF THOSE
PREVENTION SERVICES. THE BUDGET
ACT OF 2021 PROVIDED 222.4
MILLION IN GENERAL FUND, WITH
THREE YEARS OF EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY TO SUPPORT ACTIVITIES
RELATED TO THE PERIOD OF TIME IN
WHICH WE'LL BE ABLE TO START
CLAIMING FOR FEDERAL DOLLARS
UNDER PART ONE OF THE FAMILY
FIRST PREVENTION SERVICES ACT.
CALIFORNIA HAS ALLOCATED THAT
BLOCK GRANT TO ALL 58 COUNTIES
TO SUPPORT COUNTY CHILD WELFARE
AND PROBATION AND TRIBES, WITH
40 AGREEMENTS IN THEIR EFFORTS
TO ESTABLISH NEW COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES AND TO LEVERAGE
EXISTING COLLABORATIVE CROSS
SECTOR APPROACHES TO PREVENTION
SERVICES. WE ANTICIPATE THAT
COUNTIES WILL UTILIZE SOME OF
THE STATE BLOCK GRANT ALLOCATION
TO FUND SERVICES THAT WERE
INCLUDED WITHIN THEIR LOCAL
COUNTY PREVENTION PLANS AND
SUBMITTED TO CDSS FOR REVIEW AND
APPROVAL. AS OF APRIL 22ND,
2024, WE'VE APPROVED 51 LOCAL
COUNTY PREVENTION PLANS,
INCLUDING TWO SUBMITTED FROM THE
KARUK AND YUROK TRIBES. THIS
ALLOCATION OF RESOURCES
STRENGTHENS THE STATE'S
COMMITMENT TO PREVENT CHILD
ABUSE AND NEGLECT, AND ENTRY
INTO FOSTER CARE BY EMPOWERING
FAMILIES AND PROVIDING THEM WITH
THE NECESSARY SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS FOR THEIR COMMUNITIES.
THE EXTENSION OF THE BLOCK GRANT
FUNDING EXPENDITURE DEADLINE IS
CRUCIAL TO UPHOLD OUR COMMITMENT
AND VISION FOR PREVENTION
EFFORTS. IF IT'S NOT EXTENDED
EXTENDED OUR COMMITMENT TO
COUNTIES, FAMILIES AND PARENTS,
YOUTH AND CHILDREN WILL BE
JEOPARDIZED, WE KNOW THAT THE
THAT THE TIMING FOR BEING ABLE
TO CLAIM FUNDS UNDER PART ONE IS
COMMENSURATE WITH WHEN CARES
WILL BE IMPLEMENTING AND YOU'RE
JUST HEARING FROM THAT ON THE
PANEL. AND THEN THIS EXTENSION
OF THE EXPENDITURE DEADLINE WILL
GIVE THAT ADDITIONAL COUPLE OF
YEARS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
SORT OF BRIDGE THAT PERIOD OF
TIME FROM THE BLOCK GRANT OVER
TO THOSE 40 CLAIMS. HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS,
I KNOW YOU GAVE AN OVERVIEW, BUT
WHAT KIND OF PROGRAMS DO WE
KNOW? THERE ARE NEW PROGRAMS. DO
WE HAVE ANY IDEA WHAT KIND OF
PROGRAMS THAT THIS BLOCK GRANT
IS FUNDING? THERE'S ALL KINDS OF
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THAT COUNTIES
HAVE PUT INTO THEIR
COMPREHENSIVE PREVENTION PLANS.
SO IT'S LIKE STRENGTHENING
FAMILIES OR HEALTHY OR PARENTS
AS PARTNERS, I THINK ARE TWO
THAT ARE IN MANY, MANY COUNTY
PLANS, BUT DIFFERENT COUNTIES
HAVE IDENTIFIED SORT OF A
DIFFERENT ARRAY OF DIFFERENT
KINDS OF PREVENTION SERVICES.
COULD LÀ COUNTY FUND THEIR LÀ
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSING
INTERVENTION PROGRAM WITH THESE
FUNDS? SO THESE ARE INTENDED FOR
PREVENTION PROGRAMS. AND SO, THE
IT'S POSSIBLE THIS IS ONE TIME
DOLLARS. AND SO WHILE WE'RE
ASKING FOR AN EXTENSION OF THE
EXPENDITURE TIMELINE, THESE ARE
DOLLARS THAT ARE NOT ONGOING, IT
WAS A BLOCK GRANT THAT, LIKE I
SAID, HAD THREE YEARS OF
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY. AND THEN
OUR PROPOSAL IS THAT IT GETS
EXTENDED. OKAY? OKAY AND WHY
HAVEN'T COUNTY SPENT ALL THE
MONEY COUNTIES HAD TO PUT
TOGETHER THE COMPREHENSIVE THEIR
COMPREHENSIVE PREVENTION PLANS,
AND THEY HAD TO DO SO IN
CONSULTATION WITH THEIR
INTERAGENCY, LEADERSHIP TEAMS.
AND INCLUSIVE OF CONSULTATION
WITH THEIR TRIBES. AND I THINK
THAT WAS A REALLY IMPORTANT
PROCESS OF ENGAGING WITH THE
COMMUNITY IN ORDER TO PUT
TOGETHER THOSE COMPREHENSIVE
PREVENTION PLANS. IT ALSO MEANT
THERE WAS A DELAY IN GETTING
THOSE SUBMITTED AS I SAID, AT
THIS POINT, WE'VE HAD 51
APPROVED. AND SO WE ARE SEEING
THE CLAIMS STARTING TO HAPPEN.
BUT I THINK SOME OF THAT'S JUST
THE NATURAL RAMP UP TO,
DEVELOPING THESE KINDS OF
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES. OKAY.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE, ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENT? MARLON DAVIS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENT. YOU DON'T
HAVE TO SAY YOUR NAME. OKAY
OKAY. I GOT NO COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME. OKAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THE ITEM UP
AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER SIX.
ALL RIGHT. THIS PROPOSAL IS FOR
AN INCREASE IN REIMBURSEMENT
AUTHORITY OF 1.1 MILLION IN 20
2425. AND 1.1, IN 2526 AND
ONGOING TO ADDRESS THE WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH FEDERAL
FEDERALLY MANDATED ACTIVITIES
FOR THE CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES REVIEW, CASE REVIEW,
ALLOCATION ADJUSTMENTS IS FOR
THE FUNDING AUTHORITY. THE
PROPOSAL IS FOR SIX NEW
POSITIONS THAT WILL BE
COMPLETING THE KFSR CASE REVIEWS
AND QUALITY ASSURANCE FOR SMALL
RURAL COUNTIES WHO ARE CURRENTLY
CONTRACTING BACK, PLUS AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE COUNTIES WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN CONTRACTING BACK
WITH US IN ORDER TO COMPLETE THE
REVIEWS ON THEIR BEHALF. THESE
POSITIONS WILL DEVELOP RESOURCES
AND DESK GUIDES FOR COMPLETING
ON SITE REVIEWS WITHOUT THE
REQUESTED RESOURCES. WE RISK
BEING OUT OF COMPLIANCE AND
RISKING FEDERAL PENALTIES, AND
WE WILL MANAGE POSITIONS WITHIN
THE EXISTING AUTHORIZED
POSITIONS UNTIL THE MAJORITY OF
OUR VACANT POSITIONS ARE FILLED.
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS. ANY
FURTHER COMMENT? NO FURTHER
COMMENTS. WE WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT THIS PROPOSAL HAS NO
GENERAL FUND IMPACT, BUT NO
CONCERNS TO RAISE AT THIS TIME,
SO I DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. I'M GOING
TO HOLD THE ITEM OPEN NOW. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE. MOVING ON TO
CHILD CARE. ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN.
I PUT EIGHT, WE'RE STARTING WITH
. AND THEN REFORM IS EIGHT.
I EVEN GAVE MYSELF AN ELEMENTARY
. DEPARTMENT YES. WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH THE OVERVIEW. SO IF
DEPARTMENT CAN JOIN US
.
GOOD AFTERNOON. I'M DOCTOR LUPE
MILAM, DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
CHILD CARE AND DEVELOPMENT
DIVISION AT CGRTS, THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL BUDGET
INCLUDES 6.7 MILLION FOR CHILD
CARE PROGRAMS AND 2425. THESE
FUNDS REMAIN INCLUDE THE
REMAINDER OF FEDERAL PANDEMIC
RELIEF FUNDS. THE ADMINISTRATION
IS ALIGNED WITH THE LEGISLATURE
TO PRIORITIZE THE SPENDING OF
THESE TEMPORARY COVID 19 FUNDS,
AND AS SUCH, THE PANDEMIC RELIEF
FUNDS HAVE BEEN OBLIGATED
THROUGH CONTRACTS IN RESPONSE TO
QUESTION NUMBER THREE ON THE
AGENDA, KDSS HAS OBLIGATED AND
INTENDED TO LIQUIDATE ALL
AVAILABLE FEDERAL FUNDS BY THEIR
LIQUIDATED DATE. THE DEPARTMENT
WILL CONTINUE TO PRIORITIZE THE
STABILIZATION DOLLARS
DISCRETIONARY FUNDS THAT ARE
REQUIRED TO BE LIQUIDATED BY
SEPTEMBER 30TH OF 2024. NEW
CGRTS FUNDS WILL NOT YET BE
RECEIVED AND WILL BE ACCOUNTED
FOR IN THE STATE BUDGET UPON
FINAL AWARD ANTICIPATED IN
SUMMER OF 2024. FOR THE RESPONSE
TO QUESTIONS ONE AND TWO. SINCE
ALL FUNDS ARE OBLIGATED, THEY
HAVE BEEN PLACED INTO CONTRACTS.
THE CDSS WILL CONTRACT CONDUCT.
I'M SORRY. CDSS WILL CONDUCT AN
UPDATED EXPENDITURE ANALYSIS AND
MAY OF 2024 TO PROJECT THE
AMOUNT OF REMAINING FUNDS BY
SOURCE. THE DEPARTMENT WILL THEN
PERFORM EXPENDITURE SHIFTS IN
AUGUST OF 2024 TO FINALIZE AND
ENSURE THAT FEDERAL FUNDS ARE
LIQUIDATED BEFORE SEPTEMBER 30TH
OF 2024. THESE THIS CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS IN REGARDS TO THE
QUESTIONS. PERMANENT FINANCE.
TAMARA WEBER, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, I JUST WANT TO
UNDERSCORE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION SHARES THE
LEGISLATIVE, THE LEGISLATURE'S
PRIORITY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
SPEND, DOWN ALL OF THE ANY OR
ALL OF THE FEDERAL FUNDS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE, AND LIKE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR SAID, WE'RE WORKING
RIGHT NOW ON GETTING AN UPDATE
FOR THE MAY REVISION. OKAY. FOR
THE BUT WE I WAS HEARING DATES
OF AUGUST AND SEPTEMBER. IT
SEEMS LIKE THAT WOULD BE PAST US
POTENTIALLY GETTING SOME SAVINGS
THIS FISCAL YEAR. RIGHT. IF
WE'RE LOOKING AT AUGUST AND
SEPTEMBER. GABBY SANTORO,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, JUST TO
CLARIFY WHAT WE'RE ANTICIPATING
TO DO IS TO ANTICIPATE THOSE
SAVINGS AS PART OF THE MAY
REVISION THAT WOULD BE OCCURRING
AFTER. BUT WE WANT TO ANTICIPATE
THEM WITH ESTIMATES FOR THE MAY
REVISION. GREAT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THAT CLARIFICATION.
JACKIE BURROWS, A LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST OFFICE, AS PART OF THE
OVERVIEW, I'LL JUST WALK THROUGH
THE TABLE THAT'S ON PAGE 39 OF
THE AGENDA FOR YOUR FOR THAT
REFLECTS BASED OFF OF OUR
ANALYSIS, THIS POTENTIAL ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND SAVINGS THAT
WOULD BE BEYOND WHAT'S INCLUDED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
OVERALL, WE'VE IDENTIFIED
POTENTIALLY $1 BILLION IN ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND SAVINGS WITHIN
THE CHILD CARE PROGRAM. MOST OF
THESE FUNDS ARE JUST DUE TO
ACTUAL PROGRAM COSTS COMING IN
LOWER THAN BUDGETED LEVELS, A
LOT OF THAT HAS TO DO WITH JUST,
RAMP UP OF THE NEW SLOTS, TAKING
TIME, I'LL JUST COMMENT ON A FEW
OF THE LISTED ITEMS THAT ARE IN
THE TABLE. FIRST, WITH THE
PROPOSITION 64 CARRYOVER FUNDS,
THERE IS A BALANCE OF UNSPENT
FUNDS OF THE DOLLAR OF DOLLARS
FROM PROPOSITION 64 THAT HAVE
BEEN APPROPRIATED TO CHILD CARE,
I WILL FLAG THAT THESE FUNDS ARE
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED,
MEANING THAT THEY'RE NOT
ALLOCATED THROUGH THE ANNUAL
BUDGET PROCESS. THE LEGISLATURE,
BECAUSE OF THAT, THEY WOULD JUST
HAVE TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO HAVE ANY OF
THESE DOLLARS, BE
ADMINISTRATIVELY ALLOCATED TO
POTENTIALLY OFFSET ANY GENERAL
FUND COSTS THAT ARE WITHIN THE
CHILD CARE PROGRAM. AND THEN
THAT WOULD ACHIEVE I JUST DON'T
KNOW HOW MUCH HASN'T BEEN SPENT.
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE SAYING, OR
IS IT? NO, 15 HASN'T BEEN SPENT,
OUR UNDERSTANDING IS BASED OFF
OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S ESTIMATE
OF POTENTIAL PROPOSITION 64
CARRYOVER BALANCE. BY THE END OF
2324, IT'S 415. OKAY IT'S JUST A
MATTER OF HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU
GO ABOUT ALLOCATING THOSE
DOLLARS? IT WOULDN'T BE THROUGH
THE BUDGET PROCESS. IT WOULD
HAVE TO BE DONE
ADMINISTRATIVELY. GOT IT. THANK
YOU, ALSO INCLUDED IN OUR TABLE
AND AS WAS MENTIONED BY THE
DEPARTMENT, THERE'S ALSO
POTENTIAL TO DO EXPENDITURE
SHIFTS OF UNSPENT FEDERAL FUNDS,
INCLUDING THOSE TEMPORARY COVID
$19 THAT WOULD OTHERWISE GO
UNSPENT AND REVERT BACK TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. WE CAN JUST
REPLACE AN OFFSET THAT FEDERAL
FUND FOR A GENERAL FUND DOLLAR.
WE COULD ALSO TO THE EXTENT THAT
THERE ARE SAVINGS IN OTHER FUND
SOURCES LIKE THE GENERAL FUND,
JUST REVERT THOSE DOLLARS, THAT
ARE, ARE EITHER HAVE GONE
UNSPENT OR ARE PROJECTED TO GO
UNSPENT. FOR EXAMPLE, IN THE
TABLE, WE DO FLAG THAT LAST YEAR
AS A PART OF THE LAST YEAR OR IN
22, 23, $40 MILLION OF EMERGENCY
CHILD CARE BRIDGE FUNDS WENT
UNSPENT, SO THE LEGISLATURE
COULD REVERT THOSE DOLLARS, AND
THEN ALSO JUST FLAGGING WITHIN
THE EMERGENCY CHILD CARE BRIDGE
FUND A POTENTIAL FOR ANOTHER $30
MILLION, THAT MAY GO AND SPENT
IN 2324 JUST BECAUSE ACTUAL
SERVICE LEVELS ARE STILL COMING
IN BELOW BUDGETED LEVELS. BUT IT
SOUNDS LIKE, OF COURSE, THAT MAY
BE A PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S MAY REVISION
UPDATE ABOUT IN THEIR OVERALL
UNSPENT CALCULATION, WHICH WE
WILL ANALYZE AND PROVIDE
COMMENTS TO THE LEGISLATURE AT
THAT TIME, I WILL ALSO NOTE,
BECAUSE YOUR AGENDA DOES TOUCH
ON IT, SOME CHANGE IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE AS IT
RELATES TO THE ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENTS LOTS. SO I DID JUST
WANT TO TOUCH ON IT AND TO
PROVIDE CONTEXT. JUST LAST YEAR
WE DELAYED, ADDING ANY
ADDITIONAL SLOTS TO PROGRAMS,
INCLUDING THE ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENTS, IN ORDER FOR THE FIELD
TO CATCH UP AND FILL PREVIOUSLY
BUDGETED SLOTS. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET DOES ASSUME THAT FOR THE
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM,
THEY ARE ON TRACK TO FILL ALL
PREVIOUSLY AWARDED OR BUDGETED
SLOTS. SO THEN THEY'RE SCHEDULED
TO RELEASE THE AGREED UPON
16,000 IN ADDITIONAL SLOTS NEXT
YEAR. HOWEVER, THEY ARE ASSUMING
, AN EARLIER IMPLEMENTATION DATE
OF JULY ONE, 2024, WHERE IN THE
PAST, WE'VE ALWAYS ASSUMED THAT
NEW ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT SLOTS
WOULD BE IMPLEMENTED. OCTOBER
1ST. SO BY ASSUMING A THREE
MONTH EARLIER IMPLEMENTATION
DATE, THIS INCREASES GENERAL
FUND COST BY $46 MILLION, BUT
THIS FOR THIS FOR 2425. AND THEN
THEY WOULD CONTINUE THIS EARLIER
IMPLEMENTATION DATE IN FUTURE
YEARS. SO THAT WOULD ALSO BE AN
ANNUAL INCREASE IN FUTURE YEARS
WHEN WE DO ADD SLOTS, WHILE THE
EARLY IMPLEMENTATION DATE MAY
HAVE SOME ADMINISTRATIVE
EFFICIENCIES, WE JUST FLAGGED
THAT ONE. THE NEW SLOTS LIKELY
WOULD NOT TAKE EFFECT JULY 1ST,
BECAUSE IT JUST ALWAYS NATURALLY
TAKES TIME FOR AGENCIES TO
RECEIVE PAYMENTS. AND ONCE THEY
RECEIVE PAYMENTS TO THEN RECRUIT
FAMILIES TO FILL THOSE SLOTS,
BUT THEN ALSO, IF WE'RE ASSUMING
A JULY 1ST DATE MOVING FORWARD,
AND THAT ESSENTIALLY MEANS THAT
THE DEPARTMENT WILL HAVE TO
START AWARDING AND ALLOCATING
THESE SLOTS IN CONTRACTS PRIOR
TO JULY 1ST, WHICH IS ALSO PRIOR
TO THE LEGISLATIVE APPROVAL OF
THE BUDGET AND THE FUNDS THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO START
COMMITTING, SO FOR THAT REASON,
WE JUST FIND THAT, THEY MAY BE
GETTING AHEAD OF THE LEGISLATIVE
APPROPRIATION AUTHORITY. SO IT'D
BE BETTER FOR US TO JUST KEEP
THE THREE THE AUGUST. YES. SO
THAT GETS ME TO OUR
RECOMMENDATION, BECAUSE AGAIN,
WE'RE ALSO THIS IS RESULTING IN
AN ADDED COST IN THE TIME IN
WHICH REVENUES ARE COMING IN,
WHERE WE MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
AFFORD EXISTING COMMITMENTS. SO
FOR ALL OF THOSE REASONS, WE
JUST RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CONTINUE TO ASSUME
THE OCTOBER 1ST IMPLEMENTATION
DATE, AND THEN THAT WOULD ALSO
RESULT IN ADDITIONAL $46 MILLION
IN GENERAL FUND SAVINGS. OKAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, $1
BILLION. THAT'S A LOT. DID WE
KNOW THIS? I HOPE WE KNEW THIS,
SO WE'RE WORKING ON TRYING TO
TRACK EXACTLY HOW MUCH MONEY IS
AVAILABLE FOR THOSE SHIFTS, AND
THEN HOW MUCH GENERAL FUND WILL
BE AVAILABLE, BECAUSE WE'VE
SHIFTED IN THE COVID RELIEF
FUNDS. OKAY. AND, YOU KNOW,
OBVIOUSLY OUR GOAL IS TO USE ALL
THOSE FUNDS FIRST BEFORE GOING
AND THEN DO DO WE ANTICIPATE A
ROBUST UNDERSTANDING OF THIS IN
THE MAY REVISE? YES. OKAY GREAT.
AND THEN I'D LIKE TO HEAR A
RESPONSE FROM THE DEPARTMENT
REGARDING THE THREE MONTH, THE
NEED OR OUR PERCEPTION OF WHY WE
NEEDED TO DO THREE MONTHS
EARLIER. YEAH SO A COUPLE
REASONS IN REGARDS TO THE THREE
MONTHS EARLIER. ONE IS BY
KEEPING OCTOBER 1ST OF 20,
OCTOBER FIRST AS THE DATE, THEN
WHAT WAS OUTLINED BY THE LAO
WOULD APPLY THEN FOR OCTOBER
1ST, MEANING CONTRACTS WILL
STILL NEED TO BE RELEASED, HAVE
TO BE RAMPED UP AND ETC. SO IN A
SENSE, CONTRACTORS ARE NOT
ENROLLING FAMILIES UNTIL MONTHS
LATER BY SHIFTING IT TO JULY
1ST. THAT PROVIDES THEN FOR US
TO BE ABLE TO WORK ON ALLOCATION
SOONER, SUBJECT TO OF COURSE,
BUDGET NEGOTIATION. WE DON'T
WANT TO GET IN FRONT OF WHAT, IN
REGARDS TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION, PROCESS, BUT
IT DOES HELP US GET THOSE
DOLLARS OUT A LOT SOONER, WHICH
WE KNOW FAMILIES ARE WAITING
FOR. THESE FUNDS, BUT HOW WOULD
WE DO THAT IF WE CAN'T GET A
HOLE IN FRONT OF THE BUDGET
PROCESS? AND WE YOU WOULD ONLY
HAVE WHAT, WEEKS, TWO, TWO WEEKS
OF THAT? YEAH. IT HAS TO DO WITH
PRE-PLANNING. OKAY. MAKING SURE
THAT WE ARE PRE-PLANNING FOR
THIS FOR THE BEST SCENARIO. BUT
CONTRACTS WILL NOT BE RELEASED
UNTIL THAT IS FINALIZED IN
REGARDS TO THE PROCESS. OKAY. SO
YOU YOU BELIEVE IN KEEPING THE
JULY DATE THAT BY THAT DATE ON
JULY 1ST, IF IT'S JULY 1ST, THAT
THE FUNDING WILL GO OUT. THE
INTENT IS TO WORK TOWARDS HAVING
IT WRAPPED UP IN THE MONTH OF
JULY. CORRECT. SO THE SOONER THE
BETTER. AND THIS IS ALL BASED ON
WHAT WE RECEIVED AS FEEDBACK
FROM THE FIELD WHEN WE WERE
LOOKING AT WHY SLOTS WERE GOING
OUT THE DOOR LATER, WE WANTED TO
MAKE SURE TO MEET THAT NEED BY
THEN IN A SENSE, GETTING THESE
CONTRACTS OUT SOONER TO THEM. SO
IT DOES IS, LIKE YOU MENTIONED,
BECOME A LITTLE TRICKY IN
REGARDS TO MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT GETTING IN FRONT OF
IT, AND THAT IS NOT OUR INTENT
NOR WE WANT TO PROCESS ANY, GET
ANY RELEASE ANY CONTRACTS BEFORE
THIS PROCESS IS OVER. BUT THERE
IS A LOT OF PRE WORK THAT WE CAN
DO TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF THAT
ALIGNS NICELY. OKAY. I JUST I
WANT TO MAKE SURE IF WE'RE
TELLING THE PROVIDERS JULY AND
YOU KNOW, THE CRUNCH OF THE
BUDGET PROCESS THAT LIMITS OUR
TIME AND PROVIDERS THEN COME
BACK. HEY YOU SAID JULY, WE'RE
ANTICIPATING FOR JULY. AND THEN
IT COMES OUT TO BE AUGUST OR
SEPTEMBER. YEAH, I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE PREPARED
FOR THAT OR TO AVOID THAT.
RIGHT. EXACTLY EXACTLY. AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE RAISING
TO, RECOGNIZE THOUGH, KEEPING
OCTOBER WOULD BE EXACTLY THE
SAME TYPE OF CONVERSATION.
RIGHT, MAKING SURE THAT THOSE
WHAT HAPPENS IN OCTOBER IS THAT
NOW WE'RE NOT WE'RE DOING
AMENDMENTS VERSUS CONTRACTS,
WHICH NOW REQUIRES A WHOLE
NOTHER PROCESS TO AUGMENT THEIR
CURRENT CONTRACTS AND NOW THAT
ADDS MORE TIME AND ALSO DELAYS
THE PAYMENT TO THE TO
CONTRACTORS. OKAY. HOW MUCH TIME
IS NEEDED FOR THE RAMP? LIKE YOU
SAID, THE PRE-WORK, THE RAMP, IT
VARIES. THERE ARE SOME
CONTRACTORS THAT ARE EQUIPPED TO
BE ABLE TO START ENROLLING AS
SOON AS THEY KNOW THE BUDGET IS
SIGNED IN GOOD FAITH, RIGHT. AND
THERE'S OTHERS BECAUSE OF BOARDS
AND OTHER REASONS, MAY TAKE A
LITTLE BIT OF TIME TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY RECEIVE CONTRACT IN
HAND IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO MAKE THESE
ENROLLMENTS. OKAY, JACKIE, I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAD ANY
ADDITIONAL THOUGHTS TO THAT. I
DID JUST WANT TO PROVIDE CONTEXT
IN TERMS OF JULY 1ST, OCTOBER
1ST, IN TERMS OF WHAT
PRACTICALLY HAPPENS, REGARDLESS
OF WHAT DATE YOU CHOOSE. I THINK
WHAT WE'VE ALSO HEARD FROM THE
FIELD IS THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY
A GUARANTEE OF WHEN YOU'LL
ACTUALLY GET THE MONEY, A LOT OF
THIS, IT'S JUST FOR BUDGETING
PURPOSES OF HOW WE DISPLAY THE
DOLLARS, WHEN YOU ACTUALLY GET
THE MONEY DOES DEPEND ON WHEN
AMENDMENTS OR CONTRACTS ARE
FINALIZED. AND THERE COULD BE
DELAYS TO THAT, BUT THERE ALSO
COULD BE DELAYS TO RECEIVING
PAYMENT AS WELL. SO EVEN UNDER
AN OCTOBER ONE DATE, WHAT WE'VE
HEARD FROM PROVIDERS IS IF, IF
EVERYTHING GOES IDEALLY WELL,
SOMETIMES THERE IS EVEN A DELAY
IN STILL RECEIVING THE CONTRACT.
SO THEY WOULD EVEN LIKE OCTOBER
1ST ISN'T NECESSARILY A
REALISTIC DATE, BUT WHAT WE'VE
HEARD FROM THEM IS AT LEAST
OCTOBER 1ST DOES SEEM TO BE A
BIT MORE OF A REALISTIC DATE
BECAUSE YES, YOU HAVE TO AMEND
CONTRACTS WHERE IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN EASIER TO BAKE THEM INTO
INITIAL CONTRACTS THAT YOU'RE
FINALIZING IN THE SPRING AND
THEN RELEASING IN THE SUMMER.
BUT AT LEAST THAT AMENDMENT IS
FROM THE LEGISLATURE'S
PERSPECTIVE. IT'S ACTUALLY BASED
OFF OF APPROVED DOLLARS. SO TO
THE EXTENT THAT THE BUDGET LAGS
AND JULY 1ST, WE'RE STILL
PROCESS ARE IN NEGOTIATIONS OF
HOW TO FINALIZE THE CHILD CARE
BUDGET LIKE WE WERE LAST YEAR. I
THINK WE JUST HAVE QUESTIONS OF
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN FOR THE
RELEASE OF CONTRACTS? ESPECIALLY
IF THERE'S A SCENARIO IN WHICH
WE'RE A DIFFERENT DOLLAR AMOUNT
IS APPROVED THAN WHAT'S BEEN
PROPOSED, TO WHAT EXTENT DO WE
THEN STILL HAVE TO AMEND
CONTRACTS OR HOW DO WE GO ABOUT
THAT PROCESS? WE JUST FIND IT.
IT'S A CLEANER PROCESS, IF THOSE
DECISIONS ARE FINALIZED BEFORE
ANY CONTRACTING ACTIONS TAKE
PLACE, OKAY. THANKS, JACKIE. AND
SO THE LAST I DON'T HAVE ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS ON THAT PART,
BUT THE LAST THING I JUST WANT
TO SAY, I JUST WANT TO CONFIRM
CLARIFY THAT IN MAY, REVISE,
WE'RE GOING TO LOOK AT HOW MUCH
WE CAN SCORE FROM THIS
APPROXIMATE $1 BILLION SAVINGS
IN THE CHILD CARE SPACE. AND
WE'LL SEE AND MAY REVISE YOUR
PROPOSED PLAN ON HOW TO
REALLOCATE SOME OF THAT FUNDING,
THAT BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO
SCORE ALL THE SAVINGS THIS
FISCAL YEAR, THAT IS WHAT WE'RE
EVALUATING, TRYING TO DO RIGHT
NOW. OKAY, OKAY. AND THEN I WILL
FLAG THAT OUR ESTIMATE WAS BASED
OFF OF JANUARY EXPENDITURE
TRENDS. SO IT IS POSSIBLE THAT
THEIR MAY ESTIMATE MAY BE
DIFFERENT. BUT WE'LL OF COURSE,
IN OUR ANALYSIS TRY TO IDENTIFY
THE REASONS BEHIND THAT TO HELP
THE LEGISLATURE UNDERSTAND OKAY.
SO WE OKAY. YEP GREAT. LET'S
MAKE SURE. OKAY. WE'RE NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS ON ISSUE
NUMBER SEVEN. MOVING ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER EIGHT, OUR CHILD CARE
RATE REFORM UPDATE CONVERSATION
ON. I WELCOME THE I WELCOME US
DIRECTOR JOYNER. YES. IT'S
DIRECTOR JOHNSON. OKAY. WE HAVE
A BRAND NEW DEPARTMENT.
DEPARTMENT SPEAKING TO US HERE
TODAY. WELCOME TO SUB THREE
WHERE WE ROCK AND ROLL. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR MEMBERS KIM
JOHNSON, CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES. OUR SECOND
CONVERSATION RELATED TO HOW WE
ARE REFORMING THE RATE
STRUCTURES OF SYSTEMS FOR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES THIS
MORNING, AND JUST REALLY WANT TO
APPRECIATE THAT THIS IS ANOTHER
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE THAT WE HAVE.
MANY OF US HAVE BEEN WORKING FOR
MANY, MANY YEARS, SO
HISTORICALLY, JUST VERY BRIEFLY,
CALIFORNIA'S CONDUCTED THE
REGIONAL MARKET RATE STUDY AND
HAS TWO DIFFERENT UNALIGNED
SYSTEMS FOR REIMBURSING EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE PROGRAMS THE
STANDARD REIMBURSEMENT RATE, THE
REGIONAL MARKET RATE. AS A
CONDITION OF RECEIVING FEDERAL
FUNDS, WE HAVE TO REASSESS THE
ADEQUACY OF RATES EVERY THREE
YEARS, AND AGAIN, OUR MARKET
RATE SURVEYS HAVE TYPICALLY
COLLECTED THE DATA ABOUT PRICES
THAT PROGRAMS CHARGE TO PAY
PRIVATE PAY. FAMILIES AND THEN
WE USE THAT INFORMATION FOR RATE
SETTING. IT IS WIDELY RECOGNIZED
THAT MARKET RATES REFLECT WHAT
PARENTS CAN AFFORD TO PAY AND
NOT THE ACTUAL COST OF RUNNING
THESE PROGRAMS. AND SO TO
ADDRESS THE INEQUITIES OF THE
MARKET RATE STUDY APPROACH IN
2023, CALIFORNIA SUCCESSFULLY
SOUGHT FEDERAL APPROVAL TO USE
AN ALTERNATIVE METHODOLOGY AS IT
MOVES TO A SINGLE RATE
STRUCTURE. WITH THE ADOPTION OF
ASSEMBLY BILL 116, THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR
COMMITTED TO THE STATE COMMITTED
THE STATE TO DEVELOP AND USE
THIS ALTERNATIVE METHODOLOGY.
TÊ, IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND WITH
INTENSIVE PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT,
WE'VE BEEN WORKING HARD TO MAKE
THIS DECADES LONG DREAM A
REALITY, AND I WANT TO ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND RECOGNIZE THAT
THIS IS A PATH CHARTED IN THE
SUCCESSOR AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
STATE AND THE CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS. UNITED, WE UNDERSTAND
THAT IMPLEMENTING RATES INFORMED
BY THE NEW CUSTOM COST
ESTIMATION MODEL WILL REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS. AND SO,
AS YOU'VE OUTLINED ON PAGE 44,
SOME OF THE INVESTMENTS THAT
WE'VE PUT FORWARD IN THE PRIOR
YEARS TO SUPPLEMENTS AND
AUGMENTATIONS TO THE EXISTING
RATE STRUCTURE TO SUPPORT
PROGRAMS AND PROVIDERS IN THE
FIELD, WE ALSO, HAVE BEEN
THINKING THROUGH AGAIN OUR
IMPLEMENTATION PIECE, WHICH I'LL
SPEAK TO IN JUST A SECOND. SO
JUST IN TERMS OF THE COMMITTEE'S
QUESTIONS RELATED TO THE
PROCESS, WE'VE UNDERTAKEN,
AGAIN, EXTENSIVE PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT. IT'S BEEN ONGOING
SINCE APRIL OF LAST YEAR AND
WILL CONTINUE TO ENGAGE THE
COMMUNITY AND PUBLIC THROUGHOUT
THE PROCESS. WE HAVE COMPLETED
THE COST STUDY THAT OCCURRED
JULY TO OCTOBER OF LAST YEAR,
AND THIS IS ACTUALLY COLLECTING
DATA FROM PROVIDERS AND PROGRAMS
THE WORKFORCE ON THEIR CURRENT
COSTS OF OPERATING AND MEETING
THE HIGHER QUALITY STANDARDS.
AND THEN, NOVEMBER OF LAST YEAR
THROUGH MARCH OF THIS YEAR HAS
WHEN WE'VE ACTUALLY WORKED WITH
OUR CONTRACTOR TO DEVELOP THE
ACTUAL COST MODEL. THIS IS THE
TOOL THAT USES THE GATHERED
INFORMATION FROM THE SURVEYS
THAT WERE CONDUCTED, AND LOOKS
AT THE COST DRIVERS TO ESTIMATE
THE COSTS UNDER VARIOUS
SCENARIOS, AND SO, SO IN TERMS
OF NEXT STEPS, ONE JUST SAY THIS
MONTH, APRIL 1ST, THE DEPARTMENT
PROVIDED THE REVISED CHILD CARE
AND DEVELOPMENT FUND PLAN AND
DESCRIPTION OF CHANGES TO DRAFT
TO THE LEGISLATURE. THAT'S ONE
OF OUR STEPS. AND OF COURSE, THE
ALTERNATIVE RATE METHODOLOGY AND
COSTS ARE CONTAINED WITHIN THIS
PLAN, WE HAVE ALSO MET WITH THE
RATE AND QUALITY ADVISORY PANEL
TO DISCUSS AND TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE BASE AND ENHANCED
RATES DEFINITIONS THAT THE JOINT
LABOR MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE,
ADOPTED IN MARCH WITH CPU. AND
THAT'S ALSO, OF COURSE, A PUBLIC
MEETING WITH THE PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT WILL MEET AGAIN WITH
THAT PANEL IN MAY. SO THE
COMMITTEE ASKS QUESTIONS ABOUT
HOW SPECIFICALLY ARE WE ENGAGING
AND DISCUSSING COMPONENTS FOR
CENTER BASED PROGRAMS. AND OF
COURSE, WE RECOGNIZE THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN CENTERS AND
FAMILY CHILD CARE PROGRAMS, AS
WELL AS WHERE THEY ARE ALIGNED.
BUT IN TERMS OF HAVING INPUT IN
ENGAGEMENT ON LOOKING AT THE
STRUCTURES AND ELEMENTS FOR
CENTERS, THE RATE AND QUALITY
ADVISORY PANEL IS ONE WAY WE ARE
CONTINUING TO ENGAGE, AND WE
HAVE AGAIN UTILIZED AND
CONTINUOUSLY SOLICITED INPUT
FROM A FULL UNIVERSE OF THE
WORKFORCE AND PROGRAMS ALONG THE
WAY, AND WE'LL CONTINUE TO DO
SO, ON MAY 15TH, WE WILL SUBMIT
A REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE ON
THE STATUS OF THAT DRAFT PLAN
THAT I REFERENCED WAS SUBMITTED
APRIL 1ST. WE OF COURSE, THEN
WERE ARE AIMING TO ACTUALLY
FINALIZE AND SUBMIT OUR PLAN TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BY JULY
1ST OF THIS YEAR, AND, I WOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT AFTER THAT, WE
EXPECT APPROVAL, FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN THE FALL
OF THIS YEAR, IN OUR AGREEMENT
WITH THE STATE, WITH THE CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS UNITED, WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED THAT THE OUTLINE OF
IMPLEMENTATION COMPONENTS MUST
OCCUR 60 DAYS AFTER WE RECEIVE
THAT APPROVAL FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. SO THAT'S WHERE THAT
MORE DETAILED, SPECIFICS WILL BE
LAID OUT, THEN THERE WILL BE 30
DAYS THAT CPU AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO REVIEW AND PROVIDE FEEDBACK
ON WHAT IS SUBMITTED FOLLOWING
SUBMISSION OF THE IMPLEMENTATION
OUTLINE RATE SETTING IS THE NEXT
STEP. SO WE ALL OF THIS WORK IS
TO LEAD US TO A SPACE WHERE WE
AGAIN ARE INFORMED BY THE COST
OF CARE IN OUR APPROACH TO RATE
SETTING VERSUS. WHAT I
REFERENCED IS THE REGIONAL
MARKET RATE SURVEY. AND LOOKING
AT THE WHAT FAMILIES CAN AFFORD
TO PAY. SO THE MOU REQUIRES US
THAT WITHIN 90 DAYS OF FEDERAL
APPROVAL, THE STATE AND THE
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS UNITED WILL
REOPEN RELEVANT SECTIONS OF THE
AGREEMENT FOR NEGOTIATIONS TO
RESTRUCTURE THE CURRENT SUBSIDY
RATE FOR THOSE THAT ARE
REPRESENTED THROUGH CPU, THOSE
THAT ARE NOT REPRESENTED THROUGH
CPU. WE ARE ALSO GOING TO, OF
COURSE, ENGAGE AND HOLD SEVERAL
CONVERSATIONS RELATED TO THE
RATE SETTING PROCESS. AND THEN,
OF COURSE, THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE WILL NEED TO
ACTUALLY HAVE THE DISCUSSION AND
CONVERSATION AROUND OPERATIONAL
OPERATIONALIZING EVERYTHING THAT
HAD HAPPENED TO DATE, JUST IN
TERMS OF SOME OF THE STEPS OF
THE IMPLEMENTATION PLAN. AGAIN,
THAT'S HAPPENING POST APPROVAL
AND YOU'LL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SEE THAT. BUT WE ARE LOOKING
AT A VARIETY OF COMPONENTS TO
OPERATIONALIZE THIS, STRUCTURE.
AND SO IT'S EVERYTHING FROM
BEING ABLE TO, SAY MORE ABOUT
POLICY GUIDANCE, AUTOMATION
SYSTEMS, JUST A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT, COMPONENTS THAT WILL
BE NEEDED, REGULATORY POLICY
GUIDANCE, ANY CONTRACT
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE NEEDED FOR
THOSE WHO ADMINISTER THE
PROGRAM. AND THEN OF COURSE,
AUTOMATION. SO ALL OF THAT
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN WILL WILL BE
OUTLINED IN THAT STEP OF THE
PROCESS. SO THAT'S A SHORT
VERSION OF WHERE WE ARE WHERE
WE'RE GOING. BUT AGAIN OVERALL
JUST REALLY EXCITED IN A MUCH
NEEDED LONG STANDING CHANGE
NEEDED TO ADDRESS INEQUITIES IN
THE CHILD CARE AND EARLY
LEARNING SYSTEM. SO ALL THE WORK
WE'VE DONE WITH, YOU KNOW, WE
HIRED P5 AND ALL THAT, THE END
GOAL IS NOT JUST TO HAVE
VARIABLES THAT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED, BUT TO ACTUALLY HAVE
A DOLLAR AMOUNT. RIGHT. SO ONE
OF THE DELIVERABLES THAT WAS
PART OF THE CONVERSATION WITH
THE JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEE WAS TO ACTUALLY DEFINE
BASE RATE ELEMENTS. SO THESE ARE
THINGS LIKE RATIOS AND GROUP
SIZE STAFFING PATTERNS SALARY
COMPENSATION. AND THE NUMBER OF
OTHER ELEMENTS. AND SO WITHIN
THE, INFORMATION THAT WE'VE
OUTLINED, WE ESSENTIALLY HAVE
THE UNIVERSE OF OPTIONS THAT
WE'LL BE LOOKING TO. THERE IS
ANOTHER STEP. AND THIS IS PART
OF OUR CONVERSATION AND RATE
SETTING IS WHAT ARE WE GOING TO
SELECT OF THE THINGS THAT WE
HAVE IDENTIFIED TOGETHER? WHAT
WILL BE THE FINAL DECISION
POINTS THAT WILL BE SELECTED. SO
THE TOOL ITSELF ALLOWS YOU TO
SELECT DIFFERENT COMPONENTS
WITHIN IT THAT THAT WORK IS
ESTABLISHED FOR REPRESENTED
PROVIDERS. AND OF COURSE WE'RE
HAVING THAT CONVERSATION ON THE
CENTER FRONT RIGHT NOW, AND THEN
WE'LL USE THE TOOL TO ACTUALLY
THEN IDENTIFY AND THE
NEGOTIATIONS TO ESTABLISH RATES.
OKAY. I'D LIKE TO WELCOME OUR
GUESTS HERE. DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. WELCOME. JUST
KIDDING. THAT'S I WAS LIKE, WHY
DO YOU LOOK SO FAMILIAR? YOU'RE
NOT FROM THE DEPARTMENT. IT'S
LIKE I'VE SEEN YOU BEFORE HERE
BECAUSE WE HAD DINNER TOGETHER.
D¯ÚI. I WAS LIKE, OKAY, THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MADAM CHAIR. WERE
WITH CPU BECAUSE YOU'RE WEARING
PURPLE. I WAS JUST ASSUMING,
PURPLE IS THE COLOR THAT I
PULLED OUT OF THE CLOSET THIS
MORNING. WELCOME. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS.
VIRGINIA EARLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND. SO IN
LINE WITH THE REMARKS MADE AT
THE CLOSING OF THE SENATE'S
REGULAR SESSION TODAY, I WOULD
LIKE TO DEDICATE THIS TESTIMONY
TO DYLAN EASTON, WHO PASSED AWAY
YESTERDAY. DYLAN EASTON WAS A
TRAILBLAZER AND AN EDUCATION
LEADER WHO WILL FOREVER INSPIRE
US AS OUR FIRST AND ONLY STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
EDUCATION. WHO WAS A WOMAN SHE
WAS A CHAMPION FOR CHILDREN,
EARLY EDUCATION AND UNIVERSAL
PRESCHOOL AND LEFT A LASTING
MARK ON CALIFORNIA'S EDUCATION
SYSTEM. WE WILL SORELY MISS HER.
THANK YOU FOR THAT. IN TERMS OF
RATES, CTE HAS BEEN
COLLABORATING WITH DSS IN EVERY
STEP OF THE PROCESS THAT
DIRECTOR JOHNSON JUST MENTIONED
TO ENSURE THAT THE EXPERTISE ON
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM, WHICH CTE ADMINISTERS,
IS INCLUDED IN THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING A NEW STRUCTURE THAT
WILL APPLY TO BOTH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM AS WELL AS CHILD CARE
PROGRAMS. WE ARE HAPPY THIS WORK
IS ONGOING BECAUSE WE REGULARLY
HEAR FROM OUR CONTRACTORS THAT
THE LOW RATE AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM IS
MAKING IT CHALLENGING FOR THEM
TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN QUALIFIED
STAFF AND RECOVER FROM THE
PANDEMIC'S IMPACTS ON
ENROLLMENT. WHILE THE ONE TIME
COST OF CARE PLUS RATES THAT WE
HAVE NOW ARE HELPFUL,
CONTRACTORS HAVE SHARED THAT IT
IS CHALLENGING FOR THEM TO
INCREASE SALARIES WITH FUNDS
THAT ARE NOT ONGOING TO TRULY
INCREASE SALARIES REQUIRES AN
ONGOING COMMITMENT TO FUND TO
FUNDING INCREASES. WE'VE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH DSS
STARTING ON THE 2022 RATE AND
QUALITY WORKGROUP THAT DIRECTOR
JOHNSON MENTIONED, WHICH
PRODUCED RECOMMENDATIONS ON
CREATING A SINGLE RATE STRUCTURE
THAT ADDRESSES QUALITY STANDARDS
FOR EQUITY AND ACCESSIBILITY.
AND WE'VE CONTINUED THIS WORK AS
A MEMBER OF THE JOINT LABOR
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE ON RATE AND
QUALITY AND THE ONGOING RATE AND
QUALITY ADVISORY PANEL, WHOSE
CHARGES TO, OF COURSE, BUILD ON.
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS PROVIDE
PANEL MEMBER INPUT AND PUBLIC
INPUT ON ALTERNATIVE
METHODOLOGY, PROCESS, ESPECIALLY
INCORPORATING CENTER VOICES AS
THOSE ARE NOT PART OF THE JOINT
LABOR MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE. IN
THE COMING MONTHS, CTE IS
FOCUSED ON ENSURING THAT ANY
RATE STRUCTURE CAPTURE THE TRUE
COST OF CARE, AND THAT REFLECTS
THE COST OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS,
WHICH IN SOME AREAS ARE
DIFFERENT FROM THOSE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
PROGRAMS AND DIFFERENT FROM
VOUCHER AND PRIVATE PAY CENTERS
AND FAMILY CHILD CARE HOMES.
THIS MAY MEAN THAT THE RATES FOR
CTE AND DSS PROGRAMS WILL NEED
TO BE DIFFERENT TO CAPTURE THE
DIFFERENTIATION AND REQUIREMENTS
, WHILE THE FINAL STRUCTURE AND
RATES ARE STILL UP IN THE AIR,
WE DID WANT TO HIGHLIGHT BRIEFLY
THAT CTE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
MAKE DATA SYSTEM CHANGES
IMMEDIATELY, AND THE TIMELINE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE DATA SYSTEM
CHANGES AND THE ADDITIONAL CTE
RESOURCES NEEDED TO ACCOMPLISH
THESE CHANGES WILL DEPEND ON THE
EXACT NATURE OF THE CHANGES
REQUIRED BY THE AGREEMENT, WHICH
ARE UNKNOWN AT THIS TIME. SO,
FOR EXAMPLE, IF THE FINAL RATE
STRUCTURE REQUIRES DATA THAT THE
CURRENT DATA SYSTEM DOES NOT
COLLECT, IT MAY BE NECESSARY TO
CREATE A NEW FISCAL DATA SYSTEM
RATHER THAN ADAPTING THE ONE
THAT THE STATE ALREADY HAS,
WHICH WOULD TAKE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. OKAY JACKIE, I JUST LIKE
TO PROVIDE A BIT MORE CONTEXT ON
WHAT WE COULD EXPECT. JULY 1ST,
2025 I THINK SPECIFICALLY JULY
ONE, 2025. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOES REQUIRE STATES
TO DETERMINE PAYMENT RATES BASED
OFF OF ALTERNATIVE METHODOLOGIES
, THEN SUBMIT AN IMPLEMENTATION
TIMELINE ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE
RATES. THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY
MEAN THAT THE RATES WOULD TAKE
EFFECT JULY 1ST, 2025, AS OTHER
PANELISTS HAVE ALLUDED TO, THE
TIMING, THE IMPLEMENTATION, AND
THE TIMING IN WHICH THE RATES
WOULD GO LIVE REALLY WOULD
DEPEND ON THE RESULTS OF
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING. ALSO, THE
TIME IT MAY TAKE TO MAKE ANY
NECESSARY SYSTEM CHANGES AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION THÀNH
NOTED, FOR THEIR OWN PURPOSES
AND ALSO POTENTIALLY ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
SIDE. AND THEN LASTLY, IF AND
HOW MUCH FUNDING IS PROVIDED IN
FUTURE BUDGETS, TO SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NEW RATES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NOW FROM
CPU. GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM
CHAIR. AND SENATOR ROTH, GOOD TO
SEE YOU, I'M DION ARONER AND I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS UNITED, WHICH IS A
JOINT ORGANIZING EFFORT OF
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION LOCALS 99 AND 5 TO 1 AND
OF UNITED DOMESTIC WORKERS, WHO
ARE AFFILIATED WITH AFSCME. IT'S
THE ONLY JOINT ORGANIZING EFFORT
IN THE COUNTRY, RIGHT, AND
CARRIES WITH IT THAT SPECIAL
ROLE. RIGHT, IN REPRESENTING THE
40,000 FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS THAT ARE IN OUR UNIT,
IN TERMS OF CCPA'S ROLE IN THIS
PROCESS, WE'VE INCLUDED OUR JMC,
AS YOU'VE HEARD SHORTLY AFTER
THE MARCH HEARING IN OUR JMC, WE
DEFINED KEY ELEMENTS, INCLUDING
ADDITIONAL CONSIDERATIONS FOR
FAMILY, FRIEND AND NEIGHBOR. THE
P5 SURVEY. RIGHT. WHICH IS HERE
OKAY, INCREDIBLY LENGTHY
DOCUMENT. WHICH GIVES US
INCREDIBLE AMOUNTS OF
INFORMATION ON PROVIDERS, ON THE
COMMUNITY STATUS, ON FAMILIES
USING CARE WHERE CHILDREN ARE
CARED FOR, ETC, IT HAS MORE
INFORMATION THAN WE'VE EVER HAD
ACTUALLY ON THE FAMILIES THAT WE
SERVE, LET ALONE THE PROVIDERS
THAT PROVIDE THE SERVICES. THERE
ARE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE JMC
ON THE BASE RATE ELEMENTS AND
HOW TO APPLY THEM TO TITLE 22,
TITLE FIVE, AND TO FAMILY,
FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS. YOU HEARD
MISS JOHNSON REFER TO THAT. THE
JMC DEVELOPED A LIST OF
VARIABLES, WHAT YOU CAN CALL
THAT FACTORS. WE CAN ALL USE
DIFFERENT NAMES THAT SHOULD BE
TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT WHEN FIGURING
OUT THE ACTUAL COST OF CARE.
THESE INCLUDE, BUT ARE NOT
LIMITED TO WAGES, BENEFITS,
HOURS OF OPERATION, TRAINING
NEEDS, FAMILY ENGAGEMENT,
EDUCATIONAL DEVELOPMENT, CHILD
HEALTH, OPERATIONAL COSTS, ETC.
THERE ARE NO ACTUAL VALUES IN
DOLLAR AMOUNTS ATTACHED TO ANY
OF THESE FACTORS. THERE IS
MENTION OF A DIFFERENTIAL
BETWEEN ONE TIME ONLY COSTS AND
ONGOING COST. THERE ARE THREE
ENHANCEMENT FACTORS NON
TRADITIONAL HOURS, SPECIAL NEEDS
AND TRANSPORTATION. BUT NO
DOLLAR AMOUNTS HAVE BEEN HAVE
BEEN ASSIGNED TO ANYTHING YET.
IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
STATE WOULD CONTINUE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR PARTNERS
IN THE EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
COMMUNITY, SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
VARIABLES AND SELECTION POINTS
THAT MAY AFFECT CENTER BASED
CARE. THESE CONVERSATIONS HAVE
NOT BEEN LIMITED. WE HAVE WORKED
REALLY CLOSELY WITH WITH OUR
PARTNERS RIGHT IN THE COMMUNITY
FOR YEARS TO WORK TOGETHER
RATHER THAN AGAINST EACH OTHER.
CHILD CARE IS STRUGGLING IN
CALIFORNIA. IT IS CRUCIAL THAT
WE ALL BE ALIGNED AND WORKING
TOGETHER. THE PROCESS FOR OUR
PARTNERS HAS NOT BEEN AS ROBUST
AND OUR UNDERSTANDING IS THAT WE
HAVE NOT BEEN. THEY HAVE NOT
BEEN GIVEN THE CONSIDERATION ON
THAT. WE HAVE HAD THAT WE'VE
EXPECTED IN THIS PROCESS. WE DO
NOT WANT THIS PROCESS TO
UNDERMINE THAT RELATIONSHIP. AND
WE WOULD ENCOURAGE THE STATE TO
ENSURE STAKEHOLDERS AND
MEANINGFULLY HEARD AND
MEANINGFULLY HEARD, KNOWING THAT
WE HAVE A JULY 1ST, 2024
DEADLINE WHILE THE ELEMENTS ARE
MOSTLY DEFINED, A NUMBER OF
CRUCIAL CONSIDERATIONS ARE
SIMPLY EARMARKED TO BE
DETERMINED, INCLUDING HOURS OF
PREPARATION, HOURS OF TRAINING
AND DOLLARS ATTACHED. THESE DO
NOT NEED TO BE SETTLED TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH A FEDERAL PLAN.
HOWEVER, WE BELIEVE AND URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO IMPRESS UPON THE
STATE THE IMPORTANCE OF
FINALIZING THESE DETAILS WITH
CPU NO LATER THAN OCTOBER SO
THAT WE CAN MOVE FORWARD WITH
BARGAINING IN EARNEST, BECAUSE
THAT'S WHEN BARGAINING CAN
BEGIN. THE REOPENER CAN BEGIN,
YOU'VE ASKED US KIND OF LIKE,
WHAT? WHAT DO WE THINK IS
MISSING? ALL RIGHT. THERE'S SO
MUCH WIGGLE ROOM IN THE
ALTERNATIVE METHODOLOGY AT THIS
TIME TO ENSURE WE MEET THE
FEDERAL TIMELINE. HOWEVER BEFORE
WE BEGIN THE REOPENER, WE NEED
TO BE MORE PRECISE IN OUR
DEFINITIONS OF APPROPRIATELY TO
APPROPRIATELY EMPOWER THE STATE
AGENCIES, CPU AND OUR
STAKEHOLDERS TO BEST IMPLEMENT
THIS METHODOLOGY, WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF QUESTIONS. FIRSTLY, WE
KNOW WHAT THE FACTORS ARE THAT
MAY BE CONSIDERED, BUT WE DON'T
KNOW HOW MUCH WEIGHT IS ATTACHED
TO THOSE ELEMENTS. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THAT'S NEW
METHODOLOGY IS SUCCESSFUL AND
ACHIEVES THE GOALS WE SHARE IN
REBUILDING OUR CHILD CARE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND EXPANDING THE
REACH TO ULTIMATELY INCLUDE ALL
ELIGIBLE CHILDREN. HOWEVER, WE
KNOW THAT THERE ARE CURRENT
BUDGET CHALLENGES AND WANT TO BE
THOUGHTFUL IN HOW WE MOVE
FORWARD TO ACHIEVE OUR GOAL
WHILE ENSURING STABILITY WITHOUT
KNOWING ANY COST FACTORS, IT'S
DIFFICULT TO PREPARE FOR FUTURE
BARGAINING TO MAKE MEANINGFUL
CONSIDERATIONS IN WHAT WE
PRIORITIZE AND TO PREPARE OUR
MEMBERS. WE BELIEVE WE SHOULD
FILL IN THE TBD. THE TO BE
DETERMINES WITH ACTUAL VALUES.
NOW, TO BETTER PREPARE EVERYONE
FOR BARGAINING OVER AND PHASING
IN THAT MAY BE NEEDED TO GET TO
FULLY FUNDING. WE'RE GOING TO
ASK YOU TO START WRAPPING UP,
PLEASE. SURE, ADDITIONALLY, WE
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT TIMELY
IMPLEMENTATION. IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE STATE HAS
ALREADY ASKED FOR WAIVERS FOR
NEW FEDERAL GUIDELINES MEANT TO
IMPROVE CHILD CARE, TIMELY
PAYMENTS AND PARTICIPATION. WHY
WOULDN'T THE STATE IMPLEMENT
THIS OVER THE NEXT YEAR AS WE
DETERMINE AND IMPLEMENT NEW
PAYMENTS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
COST OF CARE? OTHER FEDERAL
CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDE DELINKING
PRIVATE PAY FROM SUBSIDIES. IS
THE STATE GOING TO MOVE FORWARD
ON THIS IN A TIMELY FASHION THAT
THAT TAKES A STATUTORY CHANGE TO
HAPPEN, MOST, MOST IMPORTANTLY,
UNDER THE CURRENT UNDER CURRENT
STATUTE, THE RATES WILL GO BACK
TO THE PREVIOUS CONTRACT DATES
ON JULY. ON JUNE 30TH OF 2025,
WE CANNOT AFFORD TO HAVE OUR
PROVIDERS TAKE A PAY CUT, RIGHT?
THAT'S WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT
THAT WE HAVE THINGS IN PLACE SO
THAT WE CAN ENSURE, AS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS SUGGESTED
, THAT PROVIDERS ACTUALLY GET A
RATE INCREASE PURSUANT TO THE
ALTERNATIVE METHODOLOGY. SO OUR
EXPECTATIONS ARE THAT THE
CURRENT THE CURRENT MOU WOULD
SERVE AS A FLOOR FOR FUTURE
RATES. THE STATE WE DON'T WANT
THE STATE TO BE ABLE TO REDUCE
THE PAYMENT TO PROVIDERS, WHICH
WILL DESTABILIZE, TO SAY THE
LEAST, THE ACT, THE INDUSTRY, I
HAVE SOME FINAL, FINAL THOUGHT.
I HAVE SOME SPECIFIC TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE WHICH I'LL SHARE
WITH STAFF. RIGHT. WHICH COVERS
MANY OF THE ISSUES BECAUSE WE
ARE HOPEFUL, HOPEFUL THAT YOU
WILL PUT DIRECTIONS IN THE
TRAILER. BILL, IN REGARD TO THE
TIMING OF ALL OF THIS, THIS
HAPPENING SO THAT WE CAN ENSURE
THAT PROVIDERS ARE GOING TO ARE
GOING TO SEE A PAY INCREASE AT
SOME POINT ON A TIMELY AND A
TIMELY FASHION PURSUANT TO THE
CONTRACT. THANK YOU SO MUCH. OUR
FINAL SPEAKER HERE. SPEAKER HERE
FROM THE FROM CHILD CARE
RESOURCE CENTER. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR AND AS SENATOR ROTH, MY
NAME IS DONNA SNEERINGER. AND AS
MENTIONED, I'M WITH THE CHILD
CARE RESOURCE CENTER. AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY ABOUT SOMETHING THAT
I'VE WORKED ON FOR WELL OVER A
DECADE, I, I'M GOING TO SKIP
SOME OF WHAT YOU KNOW, WHICH IS
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS ARE POORLY
PAID, AND THE PAC JUST RELEASED
A REPORT ESTIMATING THE AVERAGE
CHILD CARE WAGE AT $18 AN HOUR.
AND WE ARE LOSING CAREGIVERS
TODAY TO FAST FOOD, WHO ARE
BEING PAID AT 20. AND THAT IS
HAPPENING. AND IN SENATOR
MENGIBAR IN YOUR DISTRICT, WHICH
IS PART OF OUR SERVICE AREA,
WE'VE HAD LARGE NUMBERS OF
CLASSROOMS, DARK, NOT BECAUSE
THERE ARE NOT CHILDREN TO SERVE,
BUT BECAUSE WE CAN'T FIND STAFF.
SO THAT IS WHY THIS IS SO
CRITICAL, THE STAFF ASKED ME TO
ADDRESS A FEW THINGS. I DO WANT
TO SAY THAT WE HAVE ALL WORKED
TOGETHER ON THIS FOR MANY, MANY
YEARS AND WE ARE AT A HISTORIC
MOMENT. WE ARE READY TO WORK
TOGETHER TO SUBMIT A PLAN TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. BUT OUR OUR
WORK IS FAR FROM OVER. WE HAVE A
LOT TO DO, AND I SPECIFICALLY
WANT TO LIFT UP SOME OF THE
CONCERNS FROM THE CENTER BASED
COMMUNITY WHO HAVE NOT
NECESSARILY BEEN INCLUDED IN THE
WAY THAT THEY COULD BE, AS YOU
KNOW, THE PLAN WAS SUBMITTED
WITH A LOT OF VARIABLES, BUT
NONE OF THOSE WERE REALLY
INCLUSIVE OF CENTER BASED
PROGRAMS. RAIMES THEY WERE
INCLUDED IN A WORK GROUP A YEAR
AGO, BUT MUCH OF THE DISCUSSION
HAS BEEN FRAMEWORK AND SURVEY
RELATED, NOT SPECIFIC TO UNIQUE
NEEDS OF CENTERS. THE JOINT
LABOR MANAGEMENT, THE RATE AND
QUALITY ADVISORY PANEL DID
REVIEW THE GMC AGREEMENT, AS
DIRECTOR JOHNSON MENTIONED, AND
THERE WERE QUITE A FEW CONCERNS
THAT CAME UP IN PUBLIC COMMENT.
THE DETERMINATIONS RELATED TO
HOW WAGES WOULD BE CONSIDERED
FOR THE FIRST TIME, THE CONCEPT
OF USING BUREAU OF LABOR
STATISTICS NUMBERS WAS
INTRODUCED. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT THOSE ARE BASED ON
CURRENT WAGES. HIS AND WE
ALREADY KNOW THE WAGES ARE
INADEQUATE. SO USING THAT AS A
BASELINE, WE BELIEVE WOULD
ARTIFICIALLY DEFLATE OUT WHAT IS
IN THE BASE OF THE PROGRAM, WE
ALSO KNOW THAT THE CENTER BASED
PROGRAMS HAVE FACTORS THAT ARE
VERY DIFFERENT THAN FAMILY CHILD
CARE AND COMPLETELY IN IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH CCU, WE HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSING IT, BUT THERE
ARE ISSUES RELATED TO
FACILITIES, ZONING, INSURANCE,
FACILITIES COSTS, FIRE CLEARANCE
THAT ARE MUCH DIFFERENT. AND AS,
AS MISS EARLY MENTIONED FOR THE
CONTRACTED CENTER BASED
PROGRAMS, THERE ARE ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS TO MEET TITLE FIVE
EDUCATION STANDARDS, WHICH ARE A
DIFFERENT REQUIREMENT AS WELL,
THOUGH I WOULD ENCOURAGE NOT TO
BASE PAYMENT ON THE COLOR OF
MONEY FROM WHICH DEPARTMENT, BUT
ON THE SERVICE BEING PROVIDED.
IT MAKES ME NERVOUS HEARING
THERE MIGHT BE TWO DIFFERENT
RATES. AS SOMEONE WHO
ADMINISTERS BOTH, I ALSO AM VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE TIMELINE, AS
MISS TURNER MENTIONED, WE ARE
WE'RE GOING TO RUN UP AGAINST A
CLOCK NEXT YEAR. AND ON JUNE
30TH OF 2025, WE WILL BE ON THE
PRECIPICE OF A CLIFF. IF WE
DON'T HAVE A PLAN IN PLACE. SO
WE REALLY ENCOURAGE THAT. THERE
BE SOME DISCUSSION THIS YEAR
ABOUT WHAT IT WOULD LOOK LIKE TO
ENSURE THAT THE CURRENT DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IS PROTECTED, AND
THAT PROVIDERS DON'T FACE THAT
CLIFF, AND THAT WE PUT A SAFETY
NET OF SORTS IN PLACE, EVEN IF
WE ARE SUCCESSFUL IN GETTING
EVERYTHING THROUGH BY JUNE 30TH,
THERE WILL BE AN IMPLEMENTATION
LAG AND WE CAN'T HAVE A LAG IN
THE MONEY THAT GOES ALONG WITH
THAT. SO WE'LL BE EAGER TO WORK
WITH STAFF TO TALK ABOUT TRAILER
BILL, JUST AS MENTIONED. AND I
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE A ROLE IN
SETTING CLEAR STATUTORY
GUIDELINES AROUND REPORT BACKS
AND OVERSIGHT, WE ALL NEED A
CLEAR ROADMAP, AND WE ALL NEED
TO BE WORKING FROM THE SAME SET
OF RULES. AND I THINK THE MORE
THAT COULD BE DONE TO SET
EXPECTATIONS AND UNDERSTANDING
OF THOSE TIMELINES IS GOING TO
BE IMPORTANT. IT DOES NEED TO
INCLUDE INTERIM STEPS TO ADDRESS
ANY GAPS THAT MAY HAPPEN, JUST
BECAUSE OF THE TIME THAT IT
TAKES TO MAKE SUCH A HUGE CHANGE
IN OUR SYSTEM. AND IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT, AS MENTIONED, TO
REALLY LOOK AT OTHER POLICY
REYES THAT NEED TO BE ADOPTED,
INCLUDING DELINKING WITH THE
STATE PAYS FROM PRIVATE PAY
FAMILIES AND A WHOLE HOST OF
PAYMENT RULES THAT HAVE JUST
COME DOWN FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. LASTLY, AND I'M
GOING TO CLOSE BECAUSE I KNOW
YOU'VE ALL HAD A LONG DAY, WE
KNOW THIS IS A VERY CHALLENGING
BUDGET ENVIRONMENT, AND THAT
FULL IMPLEMENTATION TO DO THIS
IS GOING TO TAKE QUITE A LONG
TIME, MANY YEARS. BUT WE ARE
REALLY HOPING THAT YOU'LL WORK
WITH ALL OF US TO ENSURE THAT
THE DECISIONS BEING MADE ARE TO
CREATE A VISIONARY SYSTEM THAT
REALLY SETS CALIFORNIA'S CHILD
CARE INDUSTRY UP FOR DECADES TO
COME, IT'S A LOT OF WORK TO PUT
ONE OF THESE TOGETHER, SO LET'S
DO IT RIGHT. AND I, I REALLY
HOPE THAT WE AREN'T STIFLED BY
THE CURRENT BUDGET ENVIRONMENT
TO NOT EMBRACE REALLY LONG TERM
VISIONARY POLICIES. AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANKS. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
DIRECTOR, WE KNOW I MEAN,
JACKIE, YOU SPOKE TO IT. I THINK
IT WAS YOU AND DOESN'T THE
STATUTE DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN
THAT STARTING JULY 2025, THE
RATES WERE GOING. BUT WE DO KNOW
THAT, THERE COULD BE POTENTIALLY
A CLIFF. SO TWOFOLD QUESTION
HERE. ONE, AND MAYBE THIS IS TOO
EARLY AND MAYBE THIS IS A
QUESTION FOR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. BUT ARE WE THINKING
THAT OUR NEXT FOR THE 2025,
WE'RE GOING TO BE LOOKING AT
POTENTIALLY ADDING SOME FUNDING
TO SET THE RATES? THE
ALTERNATIVE METHODOLOGY I'LL
START WITH THE RESPONSE TO THAT.
NO, I MEAN, I THINK WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED, AS WE'VE
SET FORTH IN OUR MOUS AND OUR
AGREEMENTS TO DATE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE, TO LOOK AT THAT,
IMPLEMENTATION OF WHAT WE ARE
GOING FORWARD WITH, WITH THIS
ALTERNATIVE METHODOLOGY. WE'RE
NOT DOING IT FOR THE SAKE OF THE
EXERCISE. WE ARE ABSOLUTELY
COMMITTED TO UTILIZING IT TO
INFORM THE WAYS IN WHICH ARE
BEING SET. RATES ARE BEING SET.
IT'S THE NEGOTIATION THAT'S
GOING TO DICTATE OUR ABILITY TO
ACTUALLY FIGURE OUT THE
OPERATIONAL PLAN. THAT'S WHY WE
CAN'T GIVE YOU A DATE CERTAIN OF
IMPLEMENTATION. OBVIOUSLY THE
ALL OF THE WORK THAT HAD BEEN
HAS BEEN LAID OUT BY MY FELLOW
PANELISTS. HERE IS WORK WE HAVE
TO DO OVER THE COMING MONTHS TO
GET CLEAR ON THAT AND HAVE
CLARITY ABOUT, WHAT 2526 LOOKS
LIKE FOR RATES AND HOW DO WE AND
MAYBE YOU HAVE A CALCULATOR THAT
DOES THIS. I GUESS I DON'T SEE
THAT PART WHERE IF RIGHT NOW
EACH EACH ELIGIBLE ITEM THAT CAN
BE CONSIDERED FOR THE FINAL
TOTAL IS JUST A WORD AND NOT A
DOLLAR VALUE. HOW DO WE GET TO A
DOLLAR VALUE AT THE END? THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY PART OF OUR
COMMITMENT TO WORK THROUGH, WITH
THE FIELD IN OUR NEXT STEPS OF
THE WORK THAT I'M REFERENCING
ABOVE. SO LET ME BE CLEAR, AND I
AND I DON'T THINK I'D HAVE ANY
DISAGREEMENT HERE FOR THE
PANELISTS, THE WORK THAT WE'VE
DONE TO DATE TO GET TO A SPACE
WHERE WE HAVE THAT UNIVERSE
DEFINED WAS SIGNIFICANT AND
QUITE A BIT OF ROBUST
CONVERSATION TO GET THERE. AND
COMPLETELY APPRECIATE MORE IS
NEEDED IN THE CENTER BASE, AND
WE'RE COMMITTED TO DOING THAT,
SO THAT IS PART OF OUR NEXT
STEPS TO GET MORE SPECIFIC ON
THE VALUES ASSOCIATED WITH THE
ELEMENTS OR POSSIBLE UNIVERSE OF
ELEMENTS FOR EACH OF THE
VARIABLES. SO WE'RE COMMITTED TO
DO THAT IN THE COMING MONTHS.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS I LEARNED
ABOUT LAST YEAR IS REGARDING THE
I APOLOGIZE IF I'M SAYING THIS
INCORRECTLY. THE REIMBURSE RATES
FOR FOOD IS DIFFERENT FOR
CENTERS VERSUS FAMILY LED OR SO.
THIS IS THE CHILD AND ADULT CARE
FOOD PROGRAM. MAYBE YOU'RE
REFERENCING. YES, THIS IS A
FEDERAL PROGRAM THAT IS, AND
THEY THE FAMILY CENTERS PAY
MORE. THEY HAVE TO PAY OUT OF
POCKET OR WHICH ONE PAYS OUT OF
POCKET, I FORGET WHICH ONE.
THERE'S A REIMBURSEMENT RATE SET
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL FOR ADULT,
BASICALLY PROGRAMS SERVING
ADULTS, PROGRAMS SERVING
CHILDREN. IT'S AN OPTIONAL
PROGRAM FOR THESE PROGRAMS TO
PARTICIPATE IN. WE ALSO
ADMINISTER THIS PROGRAM, IT'S
FEDERALLY FUNDED. THERE'S NOT A,
WHAT THE REIMBURSEMENT RATE
LOOKS LIKE OVER TIME. AND
HISTORICALLY, CALIFORNIA HAS
ACTUALLY CREATED A SUPPLEMENT TO
THAT RATE, WHICH HAS CHANGED
OVER TIME. THAT MIGHT BE WHAT
YOU'RE REFERENCING, BUT IT IS
DIFFERENT BASED ON THE
POPULATION BEING SERVED IN THE
PROGRAM TYPE. I GUESS MAYBE I
DIDN'T NEED TO BRING THAT UP TO
LEAD INTO MY QUESTION, BUT I'M
ASSUMING I'M PRETTY SURE.
ANOTHER TWOFOLD. YOU MENTIONED
YOU DON'T WANT TWO DIFFERENT
RATES. MISS DONNA, YOU DON'T
WANT TWO DIFFERENT RATES, BUT
THESE TWO CENTERS HAVE DIFFERENT
COSTS ASSOCIATED TO THEM. SO HOW
DO YOU ANTICIPATE GETTING AROUND
THE VARIOUS DIFFERENT COSTS WITH
ONE RATE? I THINK THEY HAVE TO
BE TIED TO THE REQUIREMENTS, NOT
NECESSARILY TO WHICH AGENCY THE
FUNDING COMES FROM. SO CURRENTLY
AT MY AGENCY, WE RUN A GENERAL
CHILD CARE CONTRACT FUNDED BY
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
ALONGSIDE A CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL CONTRACT, WHICH COMES
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. THEY HAVE THE SAME
TITLE FIVE REQUIREMENTS. SO WHAT
I WAS CAUTIONING IS WE DON'T
WANT A CDE RATE AND A CDSS RATE.
WHAT WE WANT IS A RATE BASED ON
THE REQUIREMENTS THAT THE
PROGRAMS HAVE TO IMPLEMENT. SO
OBVIOUSLY ACROSS YOUR SYSTEM YOU
HAVE FAMILY, FRIEND AND NEIGHBOR
PROVIDER WAS LICENSED FAMILY
CHILD CARE, PRIVATE CENTERS AND
THEN CENTERS THAT ARE CONTRACTED
WITH THE STATE WITH A HIGHER
LEVEL OF REQUIREMENT S THE
CURRENT RATE SYSTEM DOES DOES
SCALE BASED ON THOSE
REQUIREMENTS. AND WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
SCALE BASED ON REQUIREMENTS.
WHAT I AM CAUTIONING AGAINST IS
NOT HAVING IT BEING BASED ON
WHICH DEPARTMENT THE CONTRACT
COMES FROM, BUT ON THE SERVICE
BEING PROVIDED TO THE
DEPARTMENTS. IS THAT OUR INTENT?
CAN I JUST ADD SOMETHING TO
CLARIFY MY REMARKS FROM EARLIER?
SO IT'S TRUE, AS MISS SNEERINGER
SAID, THAT THE STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS AND CCAR
REQUIREMENTS ARE SIMILAR THERE,
BUT THEY'RE NOT IDENTICAL. SO
ONE DIFFERENCE, FOR EXAMPLE, IS
THAT IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM, WE'RE WORKING
ON REQUIRING PROGRAMS TO SERVE A
CERTAIN PERCENTAGE OF CHILDREN
WITH DISABILITIES. WE'RE PHASING
THAT IN RIGHT NOW. THERE'S A
REQUIREMENT THAT 5% OF
ENROLLMENT OF FUNDED ENROLLMENT
HAS TO BE CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES, AND THAT'S
INCREASING OVER TIME TO 10. SO
THE K¾T PROGRAM, WHICH IN OTHER
AREAS HAS SOME HAS MANY SIMILAR
REQUIREMENTS, DOES NOT HAVE THAT
REQUIREMENT. ANOTHER AREA OF
DIFFERENCE IS THAT IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET, THERE WAS A
DIRECTIVE FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO IMPLEMENT THE CLASS
TOOL, WHICH IS THE CLASSROOM
ASSESSMENT, SCORING SYSTEM,
WHICH IS A DIFFERENT WAY OF SORT
OF MEASURING, MEASURING QUALITY
IN THE CLASSROOM AND LOOKING AT
TEACHER CHILD INTERACTIONS,
WHICH HAS DIFFERENT COSTS THAN,
THE TOOL THAT THAT HAD BEEN
PREVIOUSLY USED, WHICH IS THE
ECKER'S TOOL, WHICH IS EARLY
CHILDHOOD ENVIRONMENTAL RATING
SYSTEM, WHICH IS STILL USED IN
DSS PROGRAMS BUT IS NO STARTING
IN IN JULY WILL NO LONGER BE
USED IN STATE PRESCHOOL. SO I
JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT
WHILE THERE, THERE ARE MANY
AREAS WHERE REQUIREMENTS ARE
SIMILAR, THEY'RE NOT IDENTICAL.
AND SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT,
YOU KNOW, TO THE EXTENT THAT
DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS RESULT IN
DIFFERENT COSTS, WE WANT IN LINE
WITH THE RATE AND QUALITY
WORKGROUP RECOMMENDATIONS, WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT STATE
PRESCHOOL CONTRACTORS ARE PAID
ACCORDING TO WHAT THEY'RE
REQUIRED TO DO. I'LL JUST ADD,
JUST TO YOUR YOUR BROADER
QUESTION HERE. SO EVEN THE
AGREEMENT THAT WE'VE, AGREED
UPON WITH CCPU DIFFERENTIATES
WHAT'S IN THE UNIVERSE OF
OPTIONS BETWEEN A LICENSE EXEMPT
OR A FAMILY FRIEND AND NEIGHBOR
PROVIDER WHO HAS DIFFERENT
REQUIREMENTS TO MISS DERRINGER'S
POINT THAN DOES A LICENSED
FAMILY CHILD CARE REQUIREMENT
REQUIRED TO TITLE 22
REGULATIONS, WHICH ALSO HAS
DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS THAN DOES
A TITLE FIVE WHEN THAT'S WORKING
IN THE TITLE FIVE SPACE. SO THEY
DO HAVE DIFFERENT STANDARDS AND
REQUIREMENTS DEPENDING ON THE
PROGRAM TYPE. SO, AND THAT
DIFFERENTIATION EXISTS TODAY
WITHIN OUR EXISTING RATE
STRUCTURE. THERE'S ACTUALLY A
DIFFERENT RATE PAID BY THOSE
DIFFERENT STANDARDS AND PROGRAM
TYPES. THAT'S THAT'S THE
CONSIDERATION THAT I THINK WE'RE
LOOKING TO, LET ME JUST ADD
SOMETHING ALSO, WHICH IS IN THE
IN THE JMC AGREEMENT. OKAY.
THERE'S THE BASE RATE. RIGHT.
BUT THEN THERE'S ALSO
ENHANCEMENTS AND ENHANCEMENTS
CAN BE USED. I THINK I WAS
THINKING ABOUT IN CDE, RIGHT.
THAT TO DIFFERENTIATE. RIGHT. SO
WE WE'VE COME UP WITH SOME
AGREEMENTS REGARDING
ENHANCEMENTS. RIGHT. AND THERE
MIGHT BE FURTHER AGREEMENTS AS
WE GO THROUGH NEGOTIATIONS. BUT
THAT'S A WAY OF DEALING WITH THE
DIFFERENTIAL. SOME DIFFERENTIALS
RIGHT BETWEEN DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
TO BE ABLE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THEM.
IF WE DON'T HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE BEFORE
FOR THIS, JUNE 30TH, 2025, 2025,
IS THERE AN IS THERE AN THERE'S
NO WAIVERS? IS THERE A IS THERE
NOT AN OPTION? BUT I DON'T KNOW
WHAT I'M LOOKING FOR, IS THERE A
POSSIBILITY FOR THEM TO FALL
BACK TO THE PREVIOUS TWO YEAR
AGREEMENT RATE? I'M GOING TO
RESTATE OUR INTENT, WHICH IS TO
UTILIZE THE PROGRESS WE'VE MADE,
THE WORK WE'VE DONE TO UTILIZE
THE ALTERNATIVE RATE STRUCTURE
IN OUR RATE SETTING PROCESS.
GOING FORWARD. THE OPERATIONAL
TIME PERIOD IS A CONSIDERATION
THAT WE HAVE TO LOOK AT. AND I
THINK THE ISSUES RELATED TO WHAT
WE DO. IF THERE IS A GAP, IF YOU
WILL, THIS IS A JANUARY
QUESTION, JUST TO SEE AS WE GET
CLOSER TO SEE WHERE WE'RE AT,
MORE IT IS THAT'S THAT'S WHEN
WE'LL HAVE A LITTLE MORE CLARITY
ON ON THE TIMELINE. IS THERE
SOMETHING WE NEED TO DO NOW
WHILE WE WAIT FOR SYSTEM CHANGES
WE ARE DOING? YES. YEAH JUST
SIMILAR TO OUR CONVERSATION, OUR
CHILD WELFARE RATES PROPOSAL, WE
ABSOLUTELY NEED TO GET
OPERATIONAL CONSIDERATIONS. NOW,
THESE ARE THE KIND OF
CONVERSATIONS AS WE'RE, RIGHT
NOW, RIGHT, FOCUSED ON HAVING
THE CONVERSATION WITH THE
NON-REPRESENTED WORKFORCE ON
WHAT ELEMENTS WE SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED, GET OUR PLAN
TOGETHER FOR JULY SUBMISSION.
BUT WE ABSOLUTELY NEED TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS RELATED TO
OPERATIONAL CONSIDERATIONS,
REALLY UNDERSTANDING THE
AUTOMATION CHANGES THAT WILL BE
NEEDED TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE.
AND THEN OBVIOUSLY THE RATES AND
THAT AUTOMATION CDE WOULD ALSO
BE INTO THE SAME. THAT'S RIGHT.
WE'LL SEE. WE HAVE AUTOMATION
SYSTEMS ARE DIFFERENT. SO WE
HAVE WE HAVE AUTOMATION AT THE
STATE LEVEL. WE HAVE AUTOMATION
AT THE PROGRAM ADMINISTRATOR
LEVEL OKAY. SO THE ACTUAL
PROGRAMS WHO ARE ADMINISTERING
AND ACTUALLY ISSUING VOUCHERS TO
FAMILIES ON BASED ON A RATE THAT
THOSE ARE AUTOMATION SYSTEMS AS
WELL. SO WE'LL NEED TO BE
LOOKING AT THOSE. AND THAT IS
THE ONE YOU BOTH WILL BE USING
THAT THE PROGRAM AT THE PROGRAM
LEVEL, NØ AT THE STATE LEVEL. SO
THE STATE THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HAS ITS SYSTEM, THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
HAS THE SYSTEM WILL BE
ADMINISTERED SEPARATELY. THAT'S
RIGHT OKAY. THAT'S RIGHT. YOU
DON'T HAVE TO INTERNALLY JOIN
ANY SYSTEM OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT. RIGHT. SO CURRENTLY AS AN
ADMINISTRATOR WHO RUNS MULTIPLE
DIFFERENT FUNDING STREAMS, WE
GATHER ALL OF THOSE DIFFERENT
CONTRACTS AND ADMINISTER THEM AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL AND HAVE OUR OWN
DATA SYSTEMS, WHICH WE HAVE,
THAT ARE AUTOMATED TO PROVIDE
SERVICES. AND, I WILL SAY PART
OF MY REASON FOR BRINGING UP NOT
HAVING DIFFERENT RATES IS RIGHT
NOW IN THE SAME FACILITIES, SIDE
BY SIDE. WE RUN HEAD START,
STATE PRESCHOOL AND GENERAL
CHILD CARE TOGETHER AND THE MORE
COMPLICATED WE MAKE IT FROM
PROGRAM TO PROGRAM, THE HARDER
IT IS FOR US ADMINISTRATIVELY TO
TRY TO KEEP IT ALL STRAIGHT, TO
BE HONEST, BUT YES, THERE THERE
WILL BE SOME TIME NEEDED FOR US
TO CHANGE OUR SYSTEM RAIMES AND
TO ADAPT. TYPICALLY WHEN WE'VE
DONE REIMBURSEMENT RATE CHANGES
IN THE PAST, WE'VE SAID WE NEED
ABOUT 90 DAYS, TO BE ABLE TO
REVIEW. WE HAVE TO ACTUALLY
MANUALLY REVIEW EVERY FAMILY'S
FILE, TO MAKE A RATE CHANGE. SO
I MEAN THAT THAT IS PART OF WHY
I THINK AT LEAST HAVING IN OUR
MIND A PROACTIVE PLAN OF WHAT
THAT INTERIM IMPLEMENTATION WILL
LOOK LIKE IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
AND, JACKIE, TO YOU, DO YOU SEE
ANYTHING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CAN DO TO HELP AS WE PREPARE FOR
THE IMPLEMENTATION OR
INFRASTRUCTURE, I WILL FLAG THAT
IN TERMS OF STATUTE, WHERE IT
KIND OF LAYS OUT LEGISLATIVE
REPORT, BACKS THE LAST
LEGISLATIVE REPORT BACK IS
REALLY TIED TO THAT. JULY 1ST,
2024 DATE. SO I THINK WHAT
YOU'RE GETTING TO IS ABSENT ANY
OTHER REPORT BACKS, WHEN IS THE
EARLIEST WE WOULD BE NOTIFIED OF
ANY POTENTIAL CHANGES? JANUARY
NEXT YEAR MAY BE A POINT, BUT TO
THE EXTENT THAT COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING IS STILL TAKING
PLACE, THERE IS NO GUARANTEED
TIME FRAME FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO BE MADE AWARE OF ANY
POTENTIAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
OPERATIONAL CHANGES THAT ARE
NEEDED. I KNOW SOME COMMENTS
WERE MADE SIMILAR TO THE CHILD
WELFARE RATE REFORM RAMP UP. I
THINK WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT WHAT
ARE POTENTIAL IMPLEMENTATION
ACTIVITIES THAT THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD BE MADE AWARE OF, EITHER
IN JANUARY OR EARLIER, TO HELP
FACILITATE THAT IMPLEMENTATION
TIMELINE. HÌNH, AND IT SOUNDS
LIKE FROM THE PANEL, IT SOUNDS
LIKE PROVIDERS HAVE GIVEN SOME
THOUGHT ON WHAT THOSE ELEMENTS
COULD BE. SO WE'LL BE DEFINITELY
REACHING OUT AND, GETTING THAT
DETAIL AND REPORTING BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE. THANK YOU. SO MUCH.
DO YOU NEED ANYTHING FROM US,
DIRECTOR AND SUPPORT? I GOT A
LONG LIST. ALWAYS, ALWAYS
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION, CHAIR.
SENATOR YOU KNOW, I THINK WE
WILL ABSOLUTELY BE ENGAGED WITH
YOU AS AS HAS BEEN REFERENCED,
WE HAVE A FEW SIGNIFICANT DATES
COMING UP IN CONVERSATIONS TO BE
HAD. AND WE ARE ABSOLUTELY. WE
WILL ABSOLUTELY KEEP YOU
APPRIZED OF OUR EFFORTS ALONG
THE WAY. SO APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU. BUT THERE ARE SOME
THINGS THAT WE THINK NEED TO
HAPPEN THAT YOU YOU NEED
SOMETHING FROM US, OKAY? WE NEED
SOMETHING FROM YOU. OKAY WE NEED
TO ENSURE THAT THE ISSUE BRING
NÓ PROVIDERS LOSING FUNDS.
RIGHT. AND OUR IDEA OF LOSING
FUNDS MEANS THAT YOU YOU ADJUST
FOR INFLATION IN THE CPI. OKAY
BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T DO THAT,
THEN OUR PROVIDERS WILL LOSE
FUNDS, RIGHT? THEY WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
KIDS THAT THEY'RE SERVING, WE
NEED WE NEED TO BE SURE THAT
THERE'S FUNDING FOR THE FISCAL
INTERMEDIARIES, MEANING MEANING
THE AGENCIES THAT THAT PAY, YOU
KNOW, TO DO THE PAY ROLLING,
RIGHT, THAT KIND OF THING FOR
THEIR TECHNOLOGY SO THAT MAYBE
WE DON'T FACE THE CLIFF RIGHT ON
THAT. THEY'RE READY TO GO. WE
ALSO NEED TO KNOW WHAT THE NEEDS
OF THE DEPARTMENT ARE REGARDING
STAFFING WISE AND FINANCING WISE
TO CARRY OUT THE CARRY OUT THE
JOBS THAT THEY'RE ALL TALKING
ABOUT, THERE'S BEEN AS YOU KNOW,
THERE'S A PCP ON THAT LATER
COMING ON. ARE OKAY. THAT'S NICE
TO HEAR, WE NEED THE WE NEED
THAT THE CONTRACT FOR P5 BE
CONTINUED. IT IS OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT IT'S UP ON
JUNE 30TH OF THIS YEAR, THEY ARE
THE ONES THAT HAVE THE EXPERTISE
TO BE ABLE TO DO WHAT I CALL THE
MUSHING, RIGHT. OF ALL OF THESE
FACTORS, I DON'T I DON'T HAVE A
LEGAL TERM OF ART. SORRY, BUT WE
NEED SOMEONE. THEY'RE THE ONES
WHO HAVE THAT THAT INFORMATION
AND KNOW HOW TO DO THAT, TO BE
ABLE TO HELP US FILL IN THE
BLANKS FOR THE CHART AND THEN
ADD ALL OF THAT UP THAT YOU
ASKED ABOUT. AT SOME POINT, IT
HAS TO BE ADDED UP, RIGHT? AND
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT DO THAT.
AND SO WE BELIEVE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO DIRECT THE
DEPARTMENT TO CONTINUE THAT
CONTRACT FOR ANOTHER YEAR, AND
THE OTHER THING, WHICH IS
SOMETHING YOU KIND OF ALLUDED
TO. SO THIS HAPPENS EVERY AT
LEAST WHAT WE'VE LEARNED FROM
OTHER STATES THAT HAVE DONE THIS
ALREADY, RIGHT, IS THAT THIS,
THIS AND THE FEDS REQUIRE IT,
THAT EVERY THREE YEARS YOU HAVE
TO GO THROUGH THIS PROCESS.
RIGHT. AND SO THE QUESTION IS,
IS DO WE WANT TO GIVE SOME
INSTRUCTION RIGHT NOW? RIGHT.
MAYBE IN THIS BUDGET YEAR
REGARDING WHAT THE FUTURE RULES
SHOULD LOOK LIKE IN REGARDS TO
ESTABLISHING THE NEW ALTERNATIVE
RATE. RIGHT. IT'S NOT THAT WE
HAVE TO COME UP WITH A NEW
METHODOLOGY, BUT WE HAVE TO GO
PLUGGING IN THE NUMBERS AGAIN,
HAVE TO DO A SURVEY, THAT KIND
OF THING, AS WE'VE DONE THIS
TIME. AND SO IT MIGHT BE
WORTHWHILE TO HAVE SOME
DISCUSSION REGARDING LAYING OUT
WHAT THE RULES ARE FOR THE
FUTURE, BECAUSE IT'LL BE IT'LL
BE HERE BEFORE WE EVEN KNOW IT,
THE UNION GOES STARTS. WE HAVE
AS WE'VE MENTIONED, THE
REOPENER, BUT WE ALSO START ON
CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS FOR WHEN
THE 2025 JUNE 30TH DATE. RIGHT
THAT STARTS PROBABLY IN JANUARY
OF 20 OF 2025. SO WE NEED TO BE
PREPARED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THESE KINDS OF DISCUSSIONS THAT
WE HOPE WILL WILL, WILL LEAD US
RIGHT DOWN THE ROAD FURTHER, IN
ORDER TO IMPROVE THIS. ONE THING
I DO WANT TO ADD VERY CLEARLY IN
TERMS OF YOUR REQUEST, MUCH OF
WHAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH, HISTORIC AND
UNPRECEDENTED INVESTMENTS IN
THIS SYSTEM OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS HAS, IN PART, BEEN
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. SO I JUST WANT TO
MAKE IT VERY CLEAR THAT WHILE WE
ARE GRATEFUL FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE AN
ALTERNATIVE METHODOLOGY THAT THE
FEDERAL RULES ALLOW FOR THIS, IT
IS ALSO TRUE THAT WE KNOW THAT
THE DELTA BETWEEN WHAT WE PAY
TODAY AND WHAT THIS IS LIKELY TO
YIELD IN TERMS OF OVERALL COST
IS IN BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. THERE
HAVE BEEN PREVIOUS ESTIMATES
THAT HAVE BEEN PUT FORWARD. SO
THE CONTRIBUTIONS FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO HELP US
REALIZE THE VISION THAT WE ARE
STRIVING FOR IS SOMETHING THAT
WE SHOULD WE SHOULD CERTAINLY
HOLD HANDS ALONG THE WAY. OKAY.
CAN I CAN I JUST SAY ONE THING
BECAUSE I FORGOT REALLY QUICKLY,
REALLY, REALLY, REALLY QUICKLY?
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT THE ONE
THERE WAS A GROUP THAT WAS HERE
TODAY THAT HAD TO LEAVE EARLY,
THE BLACK EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION GROUP, AND THAT THEY
WANTED TO BE ALIGNED WITH OUR
REMARKS. AND I THINK ALSO WITH
DONNA'S REMARKS. OKAY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU, HOLDING OPEN. WELL, I THINK
THIS WAS A YEAH, WE'RE GOING TO
HOLD, ITEM NUMBER EIGHT OPEN AND
MOVE ON TO OUR LAST BIG TOPIC.
ON THE PROPOSED METHODOLOGY FOR
THE GENERAL CHILD CARE SLOTS.
WE'RE. I WAS ON IT ALREADY.
WELCOME BACK, DOCTOR LUPE
PROGRAM FINANCE. AND THEN OUR
TWO PANELISTS, OUR PARENT VOICES
FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AND
NUTRITION REPRESENTATIVE. WE'LL
HEAR. NO, I THINK WE'RE MISSING
ONE PERSON. THERE WE GO. DOCTOR.
LUPE, YOU MAY YOU MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU. SO AGAIN, GOOD
AFTERNOON, I APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION IN REGARDS TO THIS
TOPIC. AS A REMINDER, THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES 6.7
BILLION TOTAL FUNDING FOR CHILD
CARE PROGRAMS IN FISCAL YEAR 24,
25. AND AS A REFERENCE EARLIER,
THIS IS A TREMENDOUS GROWTH FROM
THE 1.7 BILLION IN FUNDING
AROUND TEN YEARS AGO. SO AND
2122 BUDGET AGREEMENT INCLUDED
AN AGREEMENT TO FUND 200,000 NEW
SUBSIDIZED SLOTS OVER A MULTI
YEAR PERIOD OF TIME AND SO I'M
GOING TO MOVE TO NOW THE
QUESTIONS REGARDING, WHAT IS ON
OUR AGENDA HERE. THE FIRST
QUESTION TALKS ABOUT HOW THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET CHANGED THE
NUMBER OF CTR SLOTS, ADDING IN
THE FUTURE YEARS PER THE CURRENT
EXPANSION OF THE PLAN. AND SO
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET MAINTAINS
THE COMMITMENT OF THE INITIAL
SLOT EXPANSIONS OF THE 200,000
FUNDS OVER THE MULTI YEAR PERIOD
OF 2627, THE PROJECTED NUMBER OF
CTR IN THE FUTURE YEARS IS BASED
ON PRIOR YEARS APPLICATION DATA,
AND WILL BE ADJUSTED TO REFLECT
THE ACTUAL AWARDS. SO, AND ALSO
RECOGNIZING THAT IN FISCAL YEAR
2425 FOR 277. 7 MILLION GENERAL
FUND IS ESTIMATED TO SUPPORT THE
SLOTS EXPANSION OF THE
ADDITIONAL ESTIMATED 2000 SLOTS.
SO IN QUESTION NUMBER TWO, DOES
THE ADMINISTRATION MAINTAIN ITS
COMMITMENT TO THE FUNDING OF
200,000 NEW STABILIZED CHILD
CARE SLOTS BY 2026? YES, WE DO,
THE MULTIYEAR AGREEMENT ASSUMES
THE 200,000 ADDITIONAL SLOTS
WILL BE IN FUNDING YEAR FOR
2627. AND THEN HOW WOULD THE
ADMINISTRATION ENSURE LEGISLATOR
INPUT OVER THE NUMBER OF CTR
SLOTS ADDED IN THE FUTURE YEARS
FOR EXPANSION? THE
ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO BE
COMMITTED TO PROVIDE THE MULTI
YEAR ACTUALS FOR FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS. THIS PROPOSED
BUDGET ALIGNMENT, IMPLEMENTS THE
MULTI YEAR EXPANSIONS PLAN
AGREED BY THE LEGISLATOR AND THE
ADMINISTRATION, AND DSS IS
RECOMMENDING THE BUDGET REFLECTS
ACTUAL APPLICATIONS TO THE
PROGRAM TO ENSURE REALISTIC
REFLECTIONS ON PROGRAMS TOWARDS
THAT MULTI YEAR SLOT EXPANSION
PLAN. IF THE FINAL APPROPRIATION
PROVIDED BY THE LEGISLATOR AND
THE GOVERNOR IN THE BUDGET
DIFFERS FROM WHAT IS ANTICIPATED
, THE CONTRACTS WILL NEED TO BE
AMENDED, AND THE LAST QUESTION
ON THE AGENDA, I'M GOING TO TURN
IT OVER TO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
. NUMBER FOUR, YES. SO TAMAR
WEBER, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE,
NUMBER FOUR ASKS WHERE IS THE
ADMINISTRATION DERIVING THE
FISCAL AUTHORITY TO ISSUE RFAS
FOR NEW SLOTS PRIOR TO THE
FUNDING FOR THOSE SLOTS BEING
APPROPRIATED IN NEXT YEAR'S
BUDGET ACT? AND, I CAN JUST
REITERATE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WAS DEVELOPED TO ALIGN
WITH THE MULTI YEAR SLOT
EXPANSION PLAN THAT ORIGINATED
IN THE 2021 BUDGET ACT, AND THEN
WAS MODIFIED IN THE 2023 BUDGET
ACT, THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
REFLECTS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
ESTIMATED FUNDING LEVEL THAT THE
CHILD CARE FIELD HAS THE
CAPACITY TO TAKE ON. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE THAT ALLOWS
THE ADMINISTRATION TO ADJUST THE
BUDGET AUTHORITY IF IT IS
PROJECTED AFTER BUDGET
ENACTMENT, THAT CENTER BASED
PROVIDERS HAVE MORE CAPACITY TO
FILL NEW SLOTS THAN WHAT IS
APPROPRIATE FOR IN THE BUDGET
ACT, THIS WOULD PROVIDE THE
FISCAL AUTHORITY FOR AN
ADDITIONAL RFA. HOWEVER, I JUST
WANT TO EMPHASIZE AGAIN THAT
WHAT IS CURRENTLY IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALREADY
REFLECTS THE ESTIMATE OF WHAT
THE FIELD CAN TAKE ON. JACKIE
YOUR AGENDA KIND OF OUTLINES OUR
ANALYSIS THAT I'LL JUST WALK
THROUGH BECAUSE THERE ARE
VARIOUS MOVING PIECES HERE THAT
ARE KIND OF BAKED INTO THE
BASELINE. SO WE'RE NOT
NECESSARILY SEEING SAVINGS THAT
ARE BEING SCORED WITHIN THE
PROGRAM, AGAIN, WITH THE GENERAL
CHILD CARE, SINCE THESE ARE
DIRECT CONTRACTS, SLOTS, THE WAY
THAT WE WOULD AWARD OR ALLOCATE
NEW SLOTS WOULD BE THROUGH AN
ANNUAL APPLICATION PROCESS, AS
OPPOSED TO WITH THE ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT PROGRAM. THOSE ARE JUST
ADMINISTRATIVELY ADDED TO EVERY
CONTRACT. AND WE MOVE FORWARD,
SO SINCE APPLICATIONS
TRADITIONALLY ONLY HAPPEN ONCE A
YEAR, IT MAY TAKE MULTIPLE YEARS
IN ORDER TO AWARD ALL NEW SLOTS,
BECAUSE IT JUST DEPENDS ON HOW
MANY APPLICATIONS DO WE GET AND
WHAT'S THE TOTAL ASK, SO AS A
PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET,
THEY IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT
WHILE THEY MAINTAIN THE
COMMITMENT TO THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF NEW GENERAL CHILD CARE SLOTS
THAT WILL BE ADDED TO REACH THAT
OVERALL $200,000 OR 200,000
SLOTS, THERE ARE CHANGES IN THE
NUMBER OF SLOTS THAT ARE ADDED
EACH YEAR TO GET TO THAT GOAL.
AND BECAUSE OF THOSE CHANGES,
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET, WE
ESTIMATE INCLUDES ABOUT $580
MILLION IN GENERAL FUND NET
SAVINGS IN 23, 24, AND ABOUT
$320 MILLION GENERAL FUND NET
SAVINGS IN 2425. AND THESE
SAVINGS ARE GENERALLY THE RESULT
OF FOUR CHANGES. THEY AND AGAIN,
THESE FOUR CHANGES, SOME OF THEM
INCREASE COSTS, SOME OF THEM
DECREASE COSTS. SO IT'S A NET
EFFECT, THE FOUR CHANGES INCLUDE
CHANGING THE SLOT RAMP UP
SCHEDULE, ADOPTING OR PROPOSING
ADDITIONAL PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE,
ASSUMING A LATER IMPLEMENTATION
DATE, AND THEN ALSO ASSUMING A
HIGHER COST PER CASE OR PER SLOT
. I'LL START WITH THE HIGHER
COST PER SLOT JUST BECAUSE IT'S
A BIT FASTER. IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ASSUMING A
HIGHER COST PER SLOT FOR NEW
GENERAL CHILD CARE, JUST BASED
OFF OF MORE UP TO DATE ACTUAL
PROGRAM EXPENDITURE DATA THAT'S
SHOWING THAT ACTUALS ARE COMING
IN HIGHER. WE DON'T HAVE ANY
IMMEDIATE CONCERNS WITH THIS
CHANGE AND WE ARE EXPECTING MORE
DETAIL, FROM THE DEPARTMENT, ON
SPECIFICALLY ON WHAT DATA
INFORMED THIS CHANGE. SO WE HAVE
NO CONCERNS AT THIS TIME. BUT
FOR THE REMAINING THREE CHANGES,
I JUST WANT TO FLAG THAT OUR
OVERALL TAKEAWAY IS THAT WE DO
HAVE CONCERNS THAT THE COMBINED
IMPACT ULTIMATELY DOES GET AHEAD
OF THE LEGISLATURE'S
APPROPRIATION AUTHORITY. SO I'LL
START FIRST BY WALKING THROUGH
THE SLOT RAMP UP SCHEDULE
CHANGES OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS,
ABOUT 50,000 NEW GENERAL CHILD
CARE SLOTS WERE ADDED TO THE
PROGRAM. THIS TIME LAST YEAR,
MORE THAN HALF OF THOSE SLOTS
REMAINED UNAWARDED. SO WHAT WE
DID IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET IS
THAT WE DELAYED ADDING ANY
ADDITIONAL SLOTS BY ONE YEAR AND
MAINTAINED THE FUNDING FOR ALL
OF THOSE 50,000 PREVIOUSLY
PROVIDED SLOTS. SO THAT THEN THE
DEPARTMENT COULD CATCH UP AND
APPLICATIONS COULD CATCH UP, AND
WE COULD FILL ALL OF THOSE
SLOTS. AND IN TERMS OF
MAINTAINING THE FUNDING, THAT'S
WHAT WE'VE TRADITIONALLY DONE IN
PAST YEARS, TO THE EXTENT THAT
NOT ALL MAXIMUM AVAILABLE SLOTS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE
ADMINISTRATION AGREED TO WERE
AWARDED, WE WOULD KEEP THE MONEY
IN THE BUDGET SO THAT IN FUTURE
YEARS THEY COULD JUST
CONTINUOUSLY BE AWARDED THROUGH
APPLICATIONS. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET CONTINUES TO ASSUME THAT
NOT ALL OF THOSE 50,000
PREVIOUSLY PROVIDED SLOTS WOULD
BE FILLED, BUT AS SHOWN IN
FIGURES SIX, THAT'S ON PAGE 52
OF THE AGENDA. RATHER THAN
KEEPING FUNDING FOR THOSE
UNAWARDED SLOTS IN 2324, WHICH
WE'VE DONE IN PAST BUDGETS, THE
BUDGET PROPOSES TO PUSH OUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION, BUT ALSO THE
ASSOCIATED FUNDING FOR THOSE
UNAWARDED SLOTS INTO FUTURE
YEARS. AND THAT'S ABOUT 29,000
UNAWARDED SLOTS. THAT IS BEING
PUSHED TO FUTURE YEARS. THIS
THEN REDUCES THE MAXIMUM NUMBER
OF SLOTS THAT ARE BEING BUDGETED
IN 2324 TO ONLY REFLECT THE
ESTIMATED NUMBER OF AWARDED
SLOTS AND, AND THEN OF COURSE,
BECAUSE OF THAT, IT'S REDUCING
CURRENT YEAR FUNDING AND AGAIN
PUSHING THAT OUT INTO FUTURE
YEARS, THIS BUDGETING PROCESS,
OUR UNDERSTANDING IS THAT IT
WOULD BE PERMANENT AND ONGOING,
MEANING THAT FOR THE GENERAL
CHILD CARE PROGRAM, FUNDING
LEVELS IN ANY GIVEN YEAR MOVING
FORWARD WOULD NOT NECESSARILY
REFLECT THE MAXIMUM NUMBER OF
AVAILABLE SLOTS. BUT INSTEAD
WOULD BE BASED OFF OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ESTIMATE OF HOW
MANY SLOTS CAN BE AWARDED IN
THAT YEAR, WHICH WHICH THEY'LL
PRESENT TO THE LEGISLATURE AS A
PART OF THE ANNUAL BUDGET
PROCESS. BUT AGAIN, THAT MEANS
THAT THIS NUMBER COULD CHANGE
DEPENDING ON THE ADMINISTRATION
ESTIMATE OF APPLICATION TRENDS.
WHEREAS IN THE PAST WE'VE ALWAYS
AGREED ON A MAXIMUM NUMBER OF
SLOTS THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE,
AND THAT WOULD BE A FIXED NUMBER
. I'LL MOVE ON TO THE SECOND
CHANGE. THAT'S, THAT'S INCLUDED
IN THE GENERAL CHILD CARE
PROGRAM. THIS PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD ALLOW THE
ADMINISTRATION TO INCREASE
GENERAL CHILD CARE FUNDING
LEVELS TO THE EXTENT THAT THEY
ESTIMATE EXPENDITURES WOULD
EXCEED BUDGETED LEVELS. AND OUR
ANALYSIS WE FLAGGED THAT IS
UNCLEAR UNDER WHAT CONDITIONS
THE ADMINISTRATION, THE
ADMINISTRATION WOULD ACT UPON
THIS PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE, AT
BASED OFF OUR CONVERSATIONS, IT
SEEMS LIKE THIS LANGUAGE COULD
BE USED TO POTENTIALLY, ISSUE
ANOTHER REQUEST FOR
APPLICATIONS. IT COULD BE USED
TO THE EXTENT THAT SLOTS THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN AWARDED, THEY
HAVE A HIGHER COST PER SLOT
ESTIMATE, BUT WE DO NOT
NECESSARILY KNOW WHAT PROCESS
WILL THEY GO TO ESTIMATE, LIKE
HOW BIG DOES THE NEED NEED TO BE
TO THEN INCREASE FUNDING LEVELS?
AND I WOULD JUST FLAG THAT THE
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE WOULD JUST
REQUIRE NOTIFICATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE, NOT NECESSARILY
LEGISLATURE. THE LEGISLATIVE
APPROVAL TO DO THIS MID-YEAR
ADJUSTMENT INCREASE, LASTLY, THE
BUDGET ALSO ASSUMES A LATER
IMPLEMENTATION DATE FOR THESE
NEW SLOTS. IN THE PAST, WE'VE
ASSUMED AN APRIL 1ST, 2024
IMPLEMENTATION DATE. HOWEVER,
NOW THE GOVERNOR BUDGET IS
ASSUMING A JULY 1ST, 2024
IMPLEMENTATION DATE, AND THEN
THIS, LATER IMPLEMENTATION DATE
WOULD CARRY FORWARD, WOULD CARRY
FORWARD IN FUTURE YEARS, THE
ISSUE WITH THIS NEW
IMPLEMENTATION DATE, WHEN YOU
COUPLE IT WITH ALL THESE OTHER
CHANGES, IS THAT IT ULTIMATELY
GETS AHEAD OF THE LEGISLATURE'S
APPROPRIATION AUTHORITY. AGAIN
AGAIN, THE REASON WHY WE'VE
PROVIDED THREE MONTHS OF FUNDING
WITHIN THE BUDGET YEAR IS
BECAUSE THEN THAT OFF THAT THAT
AUTHORIZED AND GUARANTEED AN
AMOUNT OF FUNDING THAT THEN THE
DEPARTMENT IN THE FALL COULD
START, COLLECTING APPLICATIONS
TO ULTIMATELY AWARD THOSE
DOLLARS IN THE SPRING AND THEN
START PUTTING THOSE DOLLARS INTO
CONTRACTS AS EARLY AS THE
SPRING. BY NOW, ASSUMING A JULY
1ST IMPLEMENTATION DATE, THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL STILL
RELEASE THEIR REQUEST FOR
APPLICATIONS IN THE FALL, AND
THEN IN JANUARY, WILL SEEK THE
FUNDING ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE
APPLICATIONS. THEY WILL START
AWARDING THE SLOTS IN THE SPRING
AGAIN, PRIOR TO WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE WILL ULTIMATELY
APPROVE THOSE DOLLARS IN THE
BUDGET. AND IN JULY AT THE
LATEST, SO BECAUSE OF THAT,
THERE'S BEING AN IMPLEMENTATION.
STEPS ARE BEING TAKEN, TO COMMIT
THESE DOLLARS PRIOR TO THE
LEGISLATURE. ULTIMATELY
APPROVING THOSE DOLLARS AND ALSO
SIGNING OFF ON THE FINAL, THE
ESTIMATE OF THE SLOTS THAT ARE
UP THAT ARE POSSIBLE TO BE
AWARDED IN THAT YEAR. SO
OVERALL, OUR RECOMMENDATION IS,
GIVEN THE PROJECTED BUDGET
SHORTFALL, WE DO RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE ADOPT THE
PROPOSED SAVINGS, RESULTING FROM
, A GENERAL CHILD CARE SLOTS
STILL BEING A GOING UNAWARDED.
HOWEVER, WE WOULD RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE GO ABOUT
ACHIEVING THESE SAVINGS IN A
DIFFERENT WAY, NOT THE WAY THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED,
INSTEAD, IN ORDER TO PRESERVE
LEGISLATIVE APPROPRIATION
AUTHORITY, THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER AN ALTERNATIVE APPROACH
TO ACHIEVE THESE SAVINGS OF. ONE
EXAMPLE THAT WE HIGHLIGHT IN OUR
REPORT IS CODIFYING BUYING THE
SLOT EXPANSION PLAN. AND THEN
ALSO THE APPLICATION PROCESS AND
TIMELINE ITSELF. SO AT LEAST
THAT GIVES THE DEPARTMENT THE
STATUTORY AUTHORITY, TO AWARD
THESE SLOTS AND RELEASE THE
APPLICATION AS OPPOSED TO THE
FUNDING AUTHORITY THAT THEY'VE
TRADITIONALLY BEEN GIVEN THROUGH
PRIOR BUDGET PRACTICES AS. THANK
YOU. I'M SAD I MISSED YOUR WHOLE
THING, BUT I'LL GET WE'LL GET A
RUNDOWN AFTER. OKAY. MOVING ON
TO OUR NEXT SPEAKER. OUR PARENT
VOICES SAN FRANCISCO. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MY NAME IS YVONNE
JUAREZ BALTODANO. I AM A SINGLE
MOM TO TWO CHILDREN. MY SON
DIEGO IS SEVEN AND MY DAUGHTER
SARA IS TWO. I LIVE IN SOUTH SAN
FRANCISCO, WHERE I. WHERE I LIVE
FOR THE LAST FOUR YEARS. I'M A
LEADER WITH VOICE SAN FRANCISCO
AND I'M FROM MEXICO. SO IN MY
COUNTRY I STUDIED PSYCHOLOGY.
BUT WHEN I MOVED HERE, I WORK, I
WORK JOBS IN RESTAURANTS OR GOT
CLEANING JOBS. I DIDN'T REALLY
KNOW ABOUT MY RIGHTS OR ABOUT
DIFFERENT OPPORTUNITIES. I START
TO LEARN MORE FROM DIFFERENT
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS. I START
TO ADVOCATE. I START TO STUDY. I
GOT CERTIFIED AS A DOULA TO
SUPPORT MOMS IN PRENATAL DURING
BIRTH AND POSTPARTUM. I GOT
CERTIFICATION CERTIFIED AS A
PROMOTORA FOR HEALTH PROGRAMS. I
STAY ACTIVE IN MY COMMUNITY, AND
I'M PROUD TO SUPPORT OTHER
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES LIKE MINE TO
UNDERSTAND THEIR RIGHTS AND HOW
TO USE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS LIKE
CHILDCARE. EVEN THOUGH WE ARE
IMMIGRANTS, WE HAVE RIGHTS WHEN
MY DAUGHTER SARA WAS BORN, I WAS
WITH DIEGO AND SARA'S FATHER.
OUR INTENTION WAS THAT I WOULD
STAY AT HOME WITH HER FOR THE
FIRST SEVERAL MONTHS, AND THEN
WE WILL LOOK FOR CHILDCARE. AND
TWO WEEKS AFTER I HAD MY
C-SECTION, THEIR DAD WAS
ARRESTED AND PUT IN JAIL. HE IS
STILL IN PRISON. HE. WAS
SENTENCED FOR 13 YEARS, THIS WAS
A SHOCK TO ME. I WAS STILL
RECOVERING FROM GIVING BIRTH AND
ALL, AND ALL OF A SUDDEN I HAD
TO DO EVERYTHING FOR THEM. DIEGO
WAS ALREADY IN SCHOOL, SO I HAD
TO START LOOKING FOR JOBS WHERE
I COULD TAKE SARA WITH ME. IT
WAS VERY HARD, AND THE WORK WAS
VERY INCONSISTENT. ONE DAY I
WOULD WORK, BUT THEN NOT HAVE
ANY WORK FOR A WEEK. THESE
MONTHS WERE REALLY, REALLY HARD
FOR US. DIEGO ALSO REALLY
SUFFERED DURING. DURING THAT
TIME HE STARTED TO HAVE A Ã
LOST A LOT OF STRESS AFTER WHAT
HAPPENED TO HIS DAD, HIS HAIR
STARTED TO FALL OUT. THE DOCTOR
TOLD ME HE HAD ALOPECIA AND
DIDN'T BELIEVE IT BECAUSE I
THOUGHT ONLY OLDER PEOPLE GOT
THAT. HE STARTED TO HAVE
AGGRESSIVE EPISODES AT SCHOOL.
THEY WOULD ALWAYS CALL ME TO
COME GET HIM. I HAD TO DEDICATE
MYSELF TO HIM, BUT ALSO TO MY
BABY. WHEN I FINALLY GOT
CHILDCARE FOR SARA, SHE WAS
EIGHT MONTHS OLD. IT WAS A HUGE
RELIEF TO FINALLY HAVE A
CHILDCARE. I COULD LOOK FOR A
JOB AND I COULD FOCUS MORE ON
FINDING HEREDITARY COURT FOR
DIEGO. WE TRIED FOUR DIFFERENT
THERAPIES UNTIL WE FINALLY FOUND
THE RIGHT ONE. SHE WORKS REALLY
WELL WITH HIM. SHE WORKS REALLY
WELL WITH ME AND HE FINALLY
STARTED TO IMPROVE JUST A FEW
WEEKS AFTER SHE STARTED WORKING
WITH HIM. I WAS ABLE TO GET A
PART TIME JOB AND FINALLY WE HAD
A LITTLE MORE STABILITY. AFTER
SO MUCH TIME. EVEN THOUGH I'M
CRYING, I'M GRATEFUL TO HAVE
CHILDCARE. THE PROCESS IS VERY
HARD. PEOPLE DON'T HAVE EMPATHY
THAT WE HAVE TO DO SO MUCH
PAPERWORK JUST TO FIND CARE IN
MY COMMUNITY. AND THERE ARE A
LOT OF PEOPLE WHO GOT FRUSTRATED
BY THE PROCESS. MANY PEOPLE
DON'T KNOW HOW TO USE EMAIL, HOW
TO SCAN DOCUMENTS, HOW TO DO
PAPERWORK LIKE THIS. AT THE END
OF THE DAY, THEY GIVE UP AND
LEAVE THEIR CHILDREN WITH THE
CHEAPEST OPTION THEY CAN FIND
BECAUSE THEY BECAUSE THEY STILL
NEED TO WORK TO SURVIVE, JUST
RECENTLY IN THE NEWS, THERE WAS
A CASE ABOUT CHILD ABUSE AND
HAPPENING AT DAYCARE WITH NO
LICENSE, JUST TWO BLOCKS FROM MY
HOUSE. IT'S A HORRIBLE THAT THIS
HAPPENS, BUT THE FAMILIES FEEL
LIKE THEY HAVE NO OTHER CHOICE
FOR CHILDCARE. THIS IS WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN WE DON'T INVEST IN
CHILDCARE AND WE DON'T PAY THE
CHILDCARE PROVIDERS A GOOD WAGE.
FAMILIES STAY ON WAITING LIST
AND HAVE TO TAKE CHILDCARE THEY
DON'T WANT BECAUSE IF THEY
DON'T, HOW WILL THEY MAKE MONEY
TO PAY THE RENT? I'M NOT. I'M
NOT ABLE TO WORK AS A DOULA
BECAUSE THE HOURS I WILL HAVE TO
WORK ARE NOT NORMAL WORK HOURS.
SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO WORK AT
NIGHT, SOMETIMES ON THE
WEEKENDS. I CAN FIND CHILDCARE
THAT IS OPEN DURING THOSE HOURS,
SO I HAVE TO WORK A JOB THAT I
DON'T REALLY ENJOY, AND, AND
THAT REALLY IMPACTS IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE MANY TIMES
WE HAVE TO WORK AT NIGHT. ON THE
WEEKENDS, IF WE HAD, IF WE HAD A
CHILDCARE SYSTEM THAT PAID
PROVIDERS WHAT THEY DESERVE, IT
WOULD BE EASIER FOR CHILDCARE
PROVIDERS TO STAY IN BUSINESS
AND OPERATE DURING THOSE HOURS.
WE HAVE SO MANY FAMILIES THAT
NEED THOSE HOURS OF CARE AND NOT
ENOUGH PROVIDERS. IF I HAD A
CHILDCARE AT NIGHT AND ON ON THE
WEEKENDS AND PLACED FOR MY BRAIN
TO MY KIDS WHEN I NEEDED TO WORK
AS A DOULA, I WOULD BE SO MUCH
HAPPIER AND WOULD BE MAKING MORE
MONEY AND DOING MY JOB. THAT IS
MY PASSION. THAT IS WHY I'M HERE
TODAY. I'M ASKING THAT THIS
COMMITTEE MAKE IT A PRIORITY IN
THE BUDGET TO MAKE SURE WE ARE
INVESTING IN MORE CHILD CARE
SPACES, AND WE ARE INVESTING IN
PROVIDERS SO THEY GET A SALARY
THAT THEY DESERVE. WE ARE ASKING
THE COMMITTEE, NOT JUST IF YOU
COULD START WRAPPING UP, PLEASE,
TO REJECT 20,000 SLOT PLUS. AND
WE ARE ASKING THE LEGISLATURE TO
CODIFY THE SLOT EXPANSION IN THE
TRAILER LANGUAGE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. OUR FINALISTS,
OUR FINAL PANELIST. THANK YOU,
CHAIRMAN JABBAR AND SENATOR ROTH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS
THE ISSUE OF EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION, AND SPECIFICALLY THE
GENERAL CHILD CARE K¾T
EXPANSION. MY NAME IS CHRISTINA
MOORE, AND I'M THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION AND NUTRITION AT
MARYVALE. I'M A FORMER BOARD
MEMBER OF EVERY CHILD
CALIFORNIA, WHICH I'M
REPRESENTING HERE TODAY. MY
COMMUNITY BASED AGENCY, LOCATED
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY, SERVES
APPROXIMATELY 300 CHILDREN EACH
DAY, 29 INFANTS, 91 TODDLERS,
158 PRESCHOOLERS, AND 23 SCHOOL
AGED CHILDREN. IN EXPANSION IN
K¾T IS A VERY DIFFERENT PROCESS
THAN AWARDING NEW CAP SLOTS TO
EXISTING ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAMS. NEW FUND DISTRIBUTION
FOR APS IS VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD.
EXISTING CONTRACTORS RECEIVE
FUNDS DIRECTLY BASED ON
COMMUNITY NEED. THIS IS NOT THE
CASE WITH EXISTING CENTER
CONTRACTORS. MY AGENCY HAS TO
APPLY FOR K¾T EXPANSION FUNDS
EXACTLY THE SAME WAY AS IF I WAS
A BRAND NEW CONTRACTOR, NEVER
HAVING A RELATIONSHIP OR A
CONTRACT WITH THE STATE THROUGH
A COMPETITIVE RFP PROCESS. THIS
RFA PROCESS IS A DOZEN PAGES
LONG AND REQUIRES INFORMATION.
CGRTS ALREADY KNOWS ABOUT MY
PROGRAM, INCLUDING OUR
PHILOSOPHY, STAFFING,
FACILITIES, FAMILY ENGAGEMENT,
AND FINANCES. ALL OF THIS
INFORMATION IS SUBMITTED TO THE
STATE TWICE A YEAR BY EXISTING
CONTRACTORS OUTSIDE OF AN RFA.
IN THE CONTINUED FUNDING
APPLICATION AND IN THE PROGRAM,
SELF-EVALUATION. OUR PROGRAM IS
UNIQUE IN THAT WE SERVE INFANTS
FROM BIRTH AS WE CATER TO A HIGH
POPULATION OF FOSTER YOUTH AND
FAMILIES SEEKING PERMANENT
HOUSING. IF A PREGNANT MOTHER
PUTS HER NAME DOWN ON MY
WAITLIST TODAY, WHEN HER CHILD
IS BORN, IT IS LIKELY THAT I'M
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO SERVE
HER CHILD. ALL BECAUSE THE
PAPERWORK TO RECEIVE THE FUNDING
TAKES THAT LONG. AND IN ORDER TO
EXPAND OUR K¾T SLOTS, WE NEED TO
LICENSE ADDITIONAL CLASSROOMS.
BUT I CANNOT PREPARE TO HAVE A
CLASSROOM LICENSED WITHOUT
CERTAINTY OF FUNDS. AND HOW MANY
SLOTS MY CONTRACT WILL BE
INCREASED BY MY PROGRAM.
CURRENTLY HAS A WAITING LIST OF
20 INFANTS, AND WITH A RAMP UP
TIME FROM THE RFA BEING RELEASED
TO APPROVED AND OUR OBTAINING
START UP FUNDS TO LICENSE
ADDITIONAL SPACE, THOSE INFANTS
WILL BE AT LEAST A YEAR OLDER
BEFORE WE CAN PROVIDE SERVICES
TO THEM. BY THAT TIME, THE
FAMILY THAT PUT THEMSELVES ON
THE WAITLIST HAS A ONE YEAR OLD,
AND THEY HAVE HAD TO STOP
WORKING OR GOING TO SCHOOL, ALL
BECAUSE THEY COULD NOT AFFORD TO
PAY THE HIGH COST OF INFANT
CARE. AND THERE WERE NO OTHER
AGENCIES IN THEIR COMMUNITY THAT
COULD PROVIDE A SUBSIDIZED SPOT.
OUR INFANT TODDLER LICENSES ARE
CURRENTLY AT MAX CAPACITY. OUR
AGENCY HAS SPACE TO EXPAND ON
OUR CAMPUS. HOWEVER, I CANNOT
JUSTIFY THE EXPENSE OF LICENSING
A NEW CLASSROOM WITHOUT AN
EXPANSION OF MY CONTRACT IN REAL
TIME. IN THE ZIP CODE OF MY
ROSEMEAD CENTER, THERE ARE 90
SPACES LICENSED FOR INFANTS, 40
OF THOSE INFANT SPACES COME FROM
MY PROGRAM, AND THOSE 40 SPACES
ARE THE ONLY K¾T ARE SUBSIDIZED
SPOTS. THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
DEMONSTRATES THE BELIEF THAT
CENTERS CANNOT UTILIZE THESE
FUNDS BY SLOWING DOWN THE
EXPANSION OF K¾T. OUR. THIS IS
NOT THE CASE. THE PAUSE ON SLOT
EXPANSION WILL RESULT IN FEWER
NEEDY INFANTS AND TODDLERS
GETTING THE QUALITY CARE THAT
THEY NEED. NOW, ON BEHALF OF ALL
THE DIRECT CONTRACTING K¾T
AGENCIES IN EVERY CHILD
CALIFORNIA, I WOULD LIKE TO
PRESENT THE FOLLOWING
RECOMMENDATIONS. EXPAND THE
NUMBER OF CGRTS SLOTS RELEASED.
DO NOT SLOW DOWN THE RELEASE OF
K¾T EXPANSION FUNDS. THE SLOW
UPTAKE IS A REFLECTION OF A SLOW
RFA PROCESS, NOT REFLECTIVE OF
THE FOUR OUT OF FIVE INFANTS AND
TODDLERS WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
CARE AND DO NOT RECEIVE IT. TAKE
ACTION TO ENSURE THAT THESE
YOUNG, DEVELOPING BRAINS ARE IN
AN ENRICHING ENVIRONMENT TO HELP
THEM SUCCEED IN LIFE. CREATE A
SIMPLE AND EASY FORM TO RELEASE
FUNDS QUICKLY, TO GET CHILDREN
SERVED SOONER, AND FAMILIES OFF
OF THOSE WAIT LISTS ALLOW
FLEXIBILITY WHEN APPLYING FOR
FUNDS. CURRENTLY, PROGRAMS
CANNOT APPLY FOR FUNDING WITHOUT
A FACILITY AND STAFF TO SERVE
THE CHILDREN. BUT HOW DO YOU
SECURE A LEASE OR ADAPT AN
EXISTING SPACE ON YOUR CAMPUS
AND HIRE STAFF WITHOUT A
CONTRACT TO PAY FOR THEM? AWARD
NEW CGRTS CGRTS SLOTS TO
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE A PLAN AND
REASONABLE, REASONABLE TIMELINE
TO START SERVING CHILDREN,
CHILDREN AND LASTLY, INCLUDE NEW
SLOTS WITH CONTINUED FUNDING
APPLICATIONS AT THE CLOSE OF THE
FISCAL YEAR. CENTER SUBMIT
CONTINUED FUNDING APPLICATIONS
TO CDSS INCLUDE A NEW BOX UNDER
THE CONTRACT TYPE SECTION AND
ALLOW AGENCIES IN GOOD STANDING
TO LIST THE NUMBER OF NEW K¾T
SPACES THAT THEY CAN USE IN THE
FOLLOWING YEAR. THIS IS AN
OFFICIAL DOCUMENT AND CAN BE AN
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT WAY TO
AWARD NEW SLOTS TO EXISTING
CONTRACTORS. MY FEAR IS THAT
DELAYING FUNDING PLACES
CALIFORNIA'S BABIES AT RISK, NOT
ONLY BECAUSE THE FIRST YEARS ARE
SO CRITICAL, BUT ALSO BECAUSE
WHILE THESE BABIES WAIT, THEY'RE
BEING EXPOSED TO UNSTABLE AND
UNREGULATED CHILDCARE WHEREVER
THEIR FAMILIES CAN FIND IT.
WAITING PLACES BABIES AT RISK OF
ABUSE, TRAUMA AND CERTAINLY DOES
NOT PROVIDE A HIGH QUALITY EARLY
LEARNING FOUNDATION WHERE THEIR
INDIVIDUAL DEVELOPMENTAL,
DEVELOPMENTAL NEEDS ARE BEING
MET BY PROFESSIONALS IN THE
FIELD OF Â, S¼. OUR INFANTS
CANNOT AFFORD TO SIT ON A WAIT
LIST WHILE STATE AGENCIES WORK
THROUGH BUREAUCRACY. THERE HAS
TO BE A BETTER WAY. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
CONTEXT FOR MY 28 YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE AS AN EARLY EDUCATOR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IT'S A CATCH 22 FOR YOU. ALL
RIGHT, DOCTOR LUPE AND THE
ENTIRE RFA. IS THERE SOMETHING
THERE FEDERALLY THAT WE'VE ADDED
THAT IS A REQUIREMENT FOR THESE
FUNDS THAT WE HAVE TO ADD TO
THIS APPLICATION, OR DO YOU SEE
IT? DO YOU SEE PLACES WHERE WE
CAN TRIM THIS? YES. SO FOR THE
PAST COUPLE OF YEARS THAT WE
HAVE BEEN ADMINISTRATED THE RFA,
WE CONTINUE TO TAKE FEEDBACK AND
TRIM ACCORDINGLY TO THAT
FEEDBACK. THE FIELD IS QUITE
HONEST AND I APPRECIATE THAT IN
EVERY ASPECT BECAUSE THAT'S HOW
WE DO BETTER TOGETHER. RIGHT SO
I REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
AS WE'RE WORKING TOGETHER, THAT
IS, HEARING WHAT IS BEING SAID
AS FAR AS FUTURE RECOMMENDATIONS
WILL CONTINUE TO BE EXPLORED.
NOW GOING BACK TO YOUR QUESTION
IN REGARDS TO THE FUNDS, THE
FUNDS ARE FEDERALLY FUNDED AND
THERE IS REQUIREMENTS IN REGARDS
TO THE TYPE OF CONTRACTOR THAT
HAS TO SHOW CERTAIN LEVEL OF
KNOWLEDGE IN REGARDS TO
OPERATING THESE FUNDS. AND SO
THOSE THOSE QUESTIONS ARE GEARED
TO TARGET THAT, UNDERSTAND THAT
THE CURRENT CONTRACTORS DO YOU
HAVE TO HAVE TO SHOW THAT YEAR
AFTER YEAR IN THEIR CURRENT
FUNDS, HOWEVER, BECAUSE THERE
COMPETITIVE THEN WE HAVE TO BE
WE HAVE TO GO THROUGH THIS
PROCESS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
TRULY GIVING EVERYONE THE
FAIREST OPPORTUNITY TO ACCESS
THESE DOLLARS. SO THEY'RE
COMPETITIVE, BUT NOT ENOUGH
SLOTS ARE BEING TAKEN UP,
CORRECT? CORRECT. AND WE DON'T
HAVE A WAY TO KNOW WHETHER THERE
WOULD BE ENOUGH SLOTS TAKEN UP.
RIGHT. SO WE HAVE TO TREAT IT AS
A COMPETITIVE PIECE WHERE THEY
COME IN AND THERE'S A CERTAIN
SCORE THAT IS, THAT IS APPLIED
TO THE RFA. SO THEY SCORE A 70
OR HIGHER AND THEN ACCORDINGLY
TO THE FUNDS AND, AND THEIR
RANKING, THEN WE RELEASE THE
FUNDING ACCORDINGLY TO THAT. IF
WE HAVE MORE ASK THAN WHAT IS
ALLOCATED, THEN THAT'S WHERE WE
HAVE LANGUAGE IN REGARDS TO
COMING BACK. AND THAT IS NEW, TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN CONSIDER
THAT. BUT EACH YEAR ARE WE
UTILIZING UP ALL THE SLOTS THAT
WE ALLOCATE? WE HAVE NOT. OKAY
SO IT'S A COMPETITIVE PROCESS,
BUT WE'RE NOT UTILIZING ALL THE
SLOTS. IS IT BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH PEOPLE TO APPLY. SO
IF WE GO BY THE NUMBER OF RFAS
RECEIVED, WE ARE RECEIVING LESS
RFAS THAN DOLLARS. SO WOULD YOU
SAY THAT IT'S NO LONGER A
COMPETITIVE PROCESS? I HATE TO
SAY THAT BECAUSE I HATE TO SAY
THAT A COUPLE OF REASONS WHY
IT'S ONE IS WE CONTINUE TO LEARN
IN REGARDS TO THE RFA AND HOW TO
CONTINUE TO MAKE THAT
SIMPLIFIED. SO WE KNOW THAT IF
THAT IS A BARRIER, WE WANT TO
ADDRESS IT, AND THAT MAY THEN
CREATE THEN MORE
COMPETITIVENESS. IF THAT'S WHAT
THE HESITATION IS FOR
CONTRACTORS TO APPLY. SO THAT'S
MY HESITATION TO SAY, YOU KNOW,
TO GIVE YOU THE YOU KNOW, I KNOW
THAT WAS ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE LÀ Þ TO
SEE HOW WE CAN STREAMLINE THIS,
THIS PROCESS. RIGHT, BECAUSE I
THINK WE KEEP GOING. I FORGOT
WHERE I SAW A REPORT EARLIER
TODAY, THAT WE'RE GOING THE
TREND IS GOING BACKWARDS. AND IN
TERMS OF LIKE THERE'S A HIGHER
PERCENTAGE OF KIDS WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS FOR THESE
SLOTS, AND WE'RE NOT SEEING
THEM, IN THESE SPACES. MY SECOND
QUESTION FOR YOU IS REGARDING
THE SUGGESTION FROM LAO TO
CODIFY THE TIMELINE ON, FOR THE
200,000 SLOTS, MAYBE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. TAMAR
WEBER, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOESN'T
INCLUDE A PROPOSAL TO CODIFY
THIS PLAN, THAT WE HAVE ITERATED
OUR COMMITMENT TO REACHING THAT
OVER 200,000 SLOT GOAL. AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO LOOK AT ANY
LANGUAGE OR PROPOSALS FROM THE
LEGISLATURE. PERFECT THANK YOU
SO MUCH. ALL RIGHT. NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING OUT TO OUR TWO ADVOCATES.
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
PERSPECTIVE AND YOU SHARING YOUR
STORY. THANK YOU SO MUCH. MOVING
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TEN, CHILD
CARE PROGRAM STAFFING. SALAS
CITY. A GREAT JOB ALMOST DONE.
SO FOR ISSUE TEN, AGAIN, LUPE
MILAM CGRTS. OH GO AHEAD DOCTOR.
OH, SORRY. I WAS READY TO GET
STARTED, SO, IT'S TO PLEASE
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THIS
PROPOSAL, SO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
REQUEST 42 FEDERALLY FUNDED
POSITIONS TO PROVIDE POLICY
PROGRAM ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT
TO THE CHILD CARE AND
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS TO
APPROPRIATELY MEET THE NEEDS OF
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES THAT WE
SERVE. SINCE THE TRANSITION OF
THESE PROGRAMS, EFFECTIVE JULY
FIRST OF 2021, THE CD CHILD CARE
AND DEVELOPMENT DIVISION BUDGET
HAS GROWN FROM 4.3 BILLION TO
BUDGET YEAR OF 2425, PROPOSE OF
6.7 BILLION, WHICH IS ABOUT 64%
GROWTH. WITH THE EXPANSION OF
THESE CHILD CARE PROGRAMS IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS, WE HAVE
CONTRACTED WITH 148 NEW AGENCIES
, ADDRESSING THESE SLOTS OUT IN
THESE DESERTS AND GETTING THIS
OUT TO OUR MOST NEEDIEST
FAMILIES AND ADDING TO THE 368
AGENCIES WHO TRANSFERRED OVER ON
JULY 1ST OF 2021, THAT'S ABOUT
AN INCREASE OF ABOUT 40% OR SO.
AND TO CONTINUE TO ADDRESS
ACCESS ACROSS THE STATE AND
FURTHER THE GOVERNOR'S
COMMITMENT OF THE 200,000 SLOTS
THROUGH FISCAL YEAR 2627, WE
EXPECT THAT NUMBER TO CONTINUE
TO GROW AS WE ARE ACCEPTING RFAS
AS THE RESULT OF THESE FUNDS
NEEDED TO ACHIEVE APPROPRIATE
LEVELS OF SUPPORT AND THE RECENT
HISTORIC INVESTMENTS AND
POLICIES INCLUDED IN THE PCP, A
SUPPORT OF BARGAINING AND THE
CHILD CARE PROVIDER UNITED CPU
SUPPORTS FOR THAT TEAM.
SUPPORTING THE OUTCOME OF THOSE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS.
IMPLEMENTATION OF THOSE ELEVATE
RESPONSES TO CRITICALLY MEET
FAMILIES NEEDS, WHICH INCLUDES
AND SUPPORTING IN THE RFA
PROCESS. SUPPORTING THE
INCREASED NUMBER OF CHILD CARE
CONTRACTORS. THAT INCLUDES
MONITORING, TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE, TRAINING, AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE IN COMPLIANCE
WITH FEDERAL REGULATIONS.
CONTINUING TO SUPPORT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT, WHICH IS
BOTH, MINOR RENOVATION, REPAIRS
OF THE COMPETITIVE. RFA FOR THAT
AND THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE
PRESCHOOL DEVELOPMENT GRANT THAT
JUST THAT TRANSFERRED OVER TO US
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES.
WITHOUT THESE POSITION, WE RISK
BEING OUT OF COMPLIANCE WITH THE
FEDERAL REGULATIONS, WHICH THEN
IN RETURN WILL, POSSIBLY COULD
BRING PENALTIES TO US. THAT
CONCLUDES MY RESPONSE TO THIS
QUESTION. IS THIS, FOR THESE TWO
BLOCK GRANTS ON THE FEDERAL
LEVEL, IS THIS IS THERE A CAP
AND HOW MUCH WE CAN ASK FOR?
THERE IS, YEAH. SO CALIFORNIA IS
ALLOTTED, GENERALLY IN AVERAGE,
ABOUT 10% OF WHAT IS FEDERALLY
APPROVED. I SAY GENERALLY
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, THAT COULD BE
DIFFERENT MORE OR LESS PER YEAR
OR PER YEAR PER YEAR FOR FEDERAL
APPROVAL, BUT YES, THERE IS A
CAP. SO IT IS. SO ONCE IT IS,
ONCE IT IS IN BUDGET, THEN BY
SIGNED BY THE BIDEN-HARRIS
ADMINISTRATION, THEN THOSE
DOLLARS ROLL OUT TO US. GREAT.
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENT? YOU
COULD DO ADDITIONAL. ALL RIGHT.
NO CONCERNS. OKAY. GREAT I'M
MOVING ON TO ISSUE NUMBER 11,
CHILD AND ADULT CARE FOOD
PROGRAM STAFFING.
GOOD AFTERNOON, JENNIFER TROY,
ON BEHALF OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES, ISSUE NUMBER 11
IS RELATED TO THE CHILD AND
ADULT CARE FOOD PROGRAM. AND THE
STAFFING FOR THAT PROGRAM. CDS'S
REQUESTING AUTHORITY FOR 26
POSITIONS TO SUPPORT FEDERALLY
REQUIRED PROGRAM INTEGRITY
FUNCTIONS IN THIS PROGRAM.
IMPORTANTLY WE WANT TO EMPHASIZE
AT THE OUTSET THAT THERE IS NO
GENERAL FUND IMPACT FROM THIS
BCP. THE PROGRAM, AS YOU WERE
DISCUSSING EARLIER, PROVIDES
REIMBURSEMENT FOR MEALS AND
SNACKS SERVED TO BOTH CHILDREN
AND ADULTS WITH LOW INCOME IN A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT CARE
SETTINGS, INCLUDING DAY CARE
HOMES. OUR FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATIVE RESPONSIBILITIES
INCLUDE MONITORING,
PARTICIPATING ORGANIZATIONS AND
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO THEM IN THEIR OPERATIONS OF
THE PROGRAM. WITH THE TRANSFER
OF THE PROGRAM FROM CDE TO CDSS
IN 2021, WE IDENTIFIED THE NEED
FOR ADDITIONAL STAFFING FOR
THESE SPECIFIC PROGRAM INTEGRITY
ACTIVITIES, WHICH AGAIN ARE 100%
FEDERALLY FUNDED. SO JUST TO
REITERATE, THIS WOULD SUPPORT
THE PROGRAM ACTIVITIES, PROGRAM
INTEGRITY, ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
FEDERALLY REQUIRED AND WOULD
HAVE NO GENERAL FUND IMPACT FOR
THE, THE 5.1 MILLION UNSPENT IN
THE LAST FISCAL YEAR. IS THAT
GETTING ROLLED OVER TO ALSO MEET
THE POSITION NEEDS? MAYBE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS AN
ANSWER, WE HAVE UNDERSPENT FUNDS
FOR USDA, AND WE HAVE SOME OF
THOSE ARE FUNDS THAT WE'VE JUST
NOT BEEN ABLE TO ACCESS, AS
WELL. AND THAT WE BELIEVE THAT
THE CCP IS GOING TO ALLOW US TO
STAFF UP IN ORDER TO BETTER AND
MORE FULLY ACCESS THE FEDERAL
FUNDING. OKAY. I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU HAVE ANYTHING YOU WANT TO
ADD, BUT, I THE ONLY THING I
WOULD ADD IS JUST TO CLARIFY
THAT THE FUNDING IN QUESTION
HERE IS FEDERAL FUNDING. THAT IS
FOR THE PURPOSE OF DOING THESE
AUDITS. RIGHT? SO IT'S REALLY
JUST IT'S A THEY'VE NOT HAD THE
POSITIONS OF STAFFING AVAILABLE
TO USE ALL THE FUNDING THAT THEY
NEED TO DO, THE AUDITS THAT
THEY'RE DOING. NO CONCERNS.
OKAY, GREAT. THAT CONCLUDES ALL
OUR, MATTERS WITH THE
DEPARTMENTS WE HAVE ON ISSUE 12
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS, ONE FOR
PRESENTATION. WANT TO NOTE THERE
IS ANOTHER ITEM FOR NON
PRESENTATION WHICH IS THE
GUARANTEED INCOME PROGRAM. FOR
OUR PRESENTATION ITEM. WE'RE
GIVING THREE MINUTES FOR THE
STAKEHOLDER PRESENT ON FOOD WITH
CARE ON THE NOURISH CALIFORNIA.
THE CHILD AND ADULT CARE FOOD
PROGRAM. WHAT I WAS TRYING TO
TALK ABOUT THIS THIS IS. YEAH
FORGOT THE NAME OF IT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, CHAIRMAN
GUEVARA. AND OTHER SUBCOMMITTEE
MEMBERS. I WON'T BE NEEDING THAT
TIME. IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY FOR
YOU ALL, AND I DO APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS A
PRESSING ISSUE. THE UNJUST
REIMBURSEMENT GAP OF FAMILY
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS PARTICIPATE
IN THE CHILD ADULT CARE FOOD
PROGRAM POST-COVID, THE DEMAND
FOR CHILD CARE SERVICES HAS
SURGED, EXACERBATING DISPARITIES
WITHIN OUR SYSTEM, ESTABLISHED
IN 1976, CURRENT POLICY
REIMBURSES FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS FOR ONLY 75% OF THE
MEALS SERVED, FAILING TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THIS IS A MEANS
TESTED PROGRAM, THIS LEAVES
FAMILY CARE PROVIDERS COVERING
THE COST OF ONE OUT OF EVERY
FOUR MEALS, TOTALING HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS ANNUALLY. THIS POLICY
DISPROPORTION IMPACTS PROVIDERS
WHO IDENTIFY AS WOMEN OF COLOR,
FROM HOUSEHOLDS WITH LOW
INCOMES, WITH ONE THIRD OF OUR
PROVIDERS ALSO FACING FOOD
INSECURITY. THIS IS JUST THIS IS
AN INSUFFICIENT REIMBURSEMENT
RATE, AND IT PUSHES MANY TO
CONSIDER OFFERING FEWER MEALS OR
LEAVING THE PROGRAM ENTIRELY,
EXACERBATING FOOD INSECURITY
AMONG OUR VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
. I URGE THE COMMITTEE TO A
SUBCOMMITTEE TO ALLOCATE THE
MODEST FUNDING NEEDED TO
ELIMINATE THIS GAP. THIS WOULD
PRIORITIZE INITIATIVES THAT
ADDRESS SYSTEMIC INEQUALITIES
AND SUPPORT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES, COMMUNITIES,
INVESTING IN EQUITABLE CHILD
CARE REIMBURSEMENT RATES ENSURES
MORE CHILDREN HAVE ACCESS TO
NUTRITIOUS MEALS AND RECOGNIZES
THE INVALUABLE CONTRIBUTIONS
THAT WE'VE HEARD SO MUCH ABOUT
FROM OUR CHILD CARE PROVIDERS. I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION,
AND I REALLY, REALLY DO
APPRECIATE YOUR CONTINUED
SUPPORT ON ON THIS ISSUE AND YOU
ALLOWING US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BRING IT BEFORE YOU IN SUCH A
VERY BUSY DAY THAT YOU'VE HAD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. I APPRECIATE
THAT, AND I THE REASON WHY I
BROUGHT THIS UP EARLIER. AND AS
WE'RE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, AS
WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT MAYBE $1
BILLION, WE DON'T KNOW THE
NUMBERS YET, A LOT OF
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE SHARED THAT
WITH THE SAVINGS. SO I KNOW
WE'RE GOING TO WANT TO BALANCE
THE BUDGET. YOU DON'T HAVE TO. I
KNOW WE'RE GOING TO WANT TO
BALANCE THE BUDGET, AND IF
THERE'S SAVINGS, MAYBE GO INTO
THE GENERAL FUND. STAKEHOLDERS
WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME OF THAT
CHILD CARE SAVINGS TO STAY
WITHIN THE CHILD CARE, ARENA. I
WOULD LIKE IF WE COULD JUST
CONSIDER AT LEAST SOME BRIDGE
FUNDING IF THERE'S OPPORTUNITY
FOR THIS AREA, FOR THE FOOD WITH
CARE, OUT OF THE CHILD CARE
SAVINGS. JUST TO MAKE SURE WE
KEEP IT WITHIN THE REALM. SOME
OF IT, AS WE'RE ALSO LOOKING TO
BALANCE THE BUDGET. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. NOW IS PUBLIC COMMENT. AND
YOU'RE GOING TO. WELL, GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR. SENATOR
ROTH. HELLO, CHRISTINA HAMILTON
HERE, REPRESENTING ECONOMIC
SECURITY, CALIFORNIA, ALSO
GIVING COMMENT ON BEHALF OF END
POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA. EPIC, WE
ARE SPONSORS WITH THE SECOND
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSAL FOR
INVESTMENT THAT ISN'T BEING
PRESENTED TODAY. BUT WE DO WANT
TO URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
INVESTMENT AND TO CREATE THE CAL
SAU PROGRAM, WHICH WOULD BE A
GUARANTEED INCOME PILOT PROGRAM
TARGETING HOMELESS HIGH SCHOOL
SENIORS IN THE FOUR MONTH PERIOD
BETWEEN GRADUATION AND WHEN
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO ENROLL IN
THEIR FIRST DAY OF HIGHER
EDUCATION. WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS IMPORTANT PROGRAM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, JUST IF
YOU CAN KEEP IT TO 30S TO 45,
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON. MARISSA
VISMARA, REPRESENTING STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND, THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK ABOUT CAL SAU PROGRAM,
PROUD SPONSOR AND IN SUPPORT OF
IT. AND JUST ACKNOWLEDGING THAT
A QUARTER OF A MILLION YOUTH
ENROLLED IN K THROUGH 12 SCHOOLS
ARE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS,
WHICH HAS BEEN EXACERBATED BY
THE COVID 19 PANDEMIC, THANK
YOU, CHAIRMAN GUEVARA, FOR YOUR
COMMENTS EARLIER ABOUT SOCIAL
WORKERS AND LEADERSHIP AND FOR
YOUR VULNERABILITY THIS
AFTERNOON. WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
OF THIS INITIATIVE. THANK YOU.
SIMONE, TAREK LEE, JOHN BURTON
FOR YOUTH HERE TO ASK THE
COMMITTEE TO PRESERVE FUNDING
FOR THE SOCIAL HOUSING
SUPPLEMENT AND FURS COVERED IN
ISSUE ONE. ALSO HERE TO SAY THAT
THIS NEW RATE REFORM DISCUSSED
IN ISSUE TWO IS A TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY TO DO BETTER AND TO
WE ALL WANT TO GET IT RIGHT FOR
ALL YOUTH. AND WE WANT TO GET IT
RIGHT FOR ALSO YOUTH NOT NOT
ONLY FOR YOUTH THAT ARE PLACED
IN FAMILY SETTINGS, BUT FOR ALL
YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE. WE REQUEST
THE LANGUAGE BE AMENDED SO THAT
PARENTING, YOUTH, FOSTER YOUTH
CAN ACCESS THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS
PROGRAM EVEN IF THEY'RE PLACED
IN A SILP. BECAUSE SOMETIMES
SLPS ARE THE ONLY PLACEMENT
AVAILABLE, EVEN FOR HIGHER NEEDS
YOUTH. THANK YOU. I APOLOGIZE IN
ADVANCE. I WILL CUT YOU OFF AT
30S. IT'S A LONG LINE. HELLO, MY
NAME IS CODY VAN VELDEN. I
MYSELF HAVE EXPERIENCED A FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM. I AM HERE TO ASK
THE COMMITTEE TO PRESERVE
FUNDING FOR THE SLP HOUSING
SUPPLEMENT AND HOUSING
NAVIGATION AND MAINTENANCE
PROGRAM, AND FIRST HEARD ON
ISSUE ONE OF THE AGENDA. I
REMEMBER WHEN I WAS 16, OFFICERS
HAD COME TO MY HOME BECAUSE I
HAD EXPERIENCED PHYSICAL
VIOLENCE FROM MY ADOPTED
PARENTS, AND INSTEAD OF HELPING
ME, THEY IDENTIFIED ME AS THE
PROBLEM. MY SCHOOLS DID NOT
INTERVENE, THESE ARE CRITICAL
PROGRAMS THAT ARE NEEDED TO
SECURE OUR FOSTER YOUTH. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HELLO. MY NAME
IS ALVARO LAGUNA AND I
EXPERIENCED THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM FOR 13 YEARS. I'M
CURRENTLY A COMMUNITY RESOURCE
NAVIGATOR WITH A SENSE OF HOME.
AND I'M HERE TO ASK THE
COMMITTEE TO PRESERVE FUNDING
FOR THE SLP HOUSING SUPPLEMENT
SPECIFICALLY FOR ME. IT REALLY
CHANGED THE TRAJECTORY OF MY
LIFE. I AM NOW HERE BEATING THE
STATISTICS AND OBTAINED A
COLLEGE DEGREE WORKING ON MY
MASTER'S, AND THAT WAS PIVOTAL
WITH SILP. SO AMAZING. THANK YOU
FOR SHARING. HI, MY NAME IS
ESPERANZA SAGADA. I AM THE
POLICY ADVOCATE WITH SENECA
FAMILY OF AGENCIES, AS A FOSTER
CARE OR FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY, WE
DO AGREE WITH CDS'S PROPOSAL AND
THEIR OVERALL GOAL. I SHOULD
SAY, WE DO REALLY LOVE THE
INCREASED PAYMENTS TO FOSTER
FAMILIES AND ALSO THE STRENGTHS
BASED, BUILDING FUNDS FOR YOUTH
THAT THEY CAN, YOU KNOW, GUIDE
THEMSELVES. WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT, WE DO URGE YOU TO, OR WE
RECOMMEND TO CDSS. I APOLOGIZE
TO INCLUDE A ADDING REQUIREMENTS
THAT IMMEDIATE NEEDS FUNDS BE
USED TO SUPPORT ESSENTIAL CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES THAT ARE NOT
COVERED BY MEDI-CAL, WE ARE ALSO
HERE TO URGE YOU TO CONTINUE THE
FFA BRIDGE FUNDING, AND WE ALSO
WANT YOU TO OPPOSE THE FIRS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT, LITTLE ONE. YOU HAVE
ONE HOUR. JOHNNY AUGUSTUS.
JOHNNY JOHNNY AUGUSTUS MCKINLEY,
A BUDGET IS A STATEMENT OF
VALUES. AND WE BELIEVE CHILDREN,
FAMILIES AND THOSE WHO CARE FOR
CHILDREN SHOULD BE AMONG OUR
HIGHEST PRIORITIES. THANK YOU
FOR SUPPORTING OUR CHILD CARE.
YOU CAN HAVE MY JOB. YOU'RE
READY. HELLO, MY NAME IS ZACHARY
SHEPP. I AM HERE TO SUPPORT MY
MOM. I WANT TO GO TO CHILDCARE
SO I CAN LEARN AND MAKE FRIENDS.
WHEN I AM IN CHILDCARE, MY MOM
GOT WORK AND SHE CAN SUPPORT MY
SISTER AND MY FAMILY. TODAY I
ASKED TO HAVE CHILDCARE FOR ALL.
THANK YOU WORKING ON IT. MY NAME
IS DIEGO AND I'M SEVEN YEARS OLD
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
CHILDCARE. YES THANK YOU DIEGO.
MY NAME IS EDUARDO. I SUPPORT
CHILDCARE FOR. THANKS, EDUARDO.
HI, MY NAME IS ABIGAIL. I'M FROM
PERU AND VOICES. WE NEED
CHILDCARE. YOU DO? MY NAME IS
ARZU SHAHEED AND I AM HERE TO
FIGHT FOR QUALITY CHILDCARE FOR
ALL FROM PARENT VOICES. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING. I'M
MOHAMMED SHAHEED WITH PARENT
VOICES OF SAN FRANCISCO. I WANT
TO ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH THOSE
OF THE MEMBERS OF THE EC
COALITION. ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET AND POLICY
CENTER, ONLY 11% OF ELIGIBLE
CHILDREN CURRENTLY HAVE ACCESS
TO PROGRAMS. CLOSE TO 2 MILLION
CHILDREN ARE WAITING TO RECEIVE
CARE. ACCESS TO Â PROGRAMS CAN
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE A FAMILY'S
ABILITY TO WORK, ATTEND SCHOOL,
AND IMPROVE ITS OVERALL QUALITY
OF LIFE. WE REQUEST THAT YOU
FUND THE REMAINING 50,000 SPACES
FROM THE 2021 TO 22 BUDGET,
LASTLY, I WOULD JUST LIKE TO SEE
IF WE CAN FIND WAYS TO PREVENT
REVENUE LOSS. SO I'LL LEAVE THIS
WITH HER. THANK YOU. HELLO, MY
NAME IS SALAM JASER. I AM FROM
SAN FRANCISCO. I HAVE TWO
CHILDREN, SIX AND EIGHT YEARS
OLD. I WENT TO ALIGN MY COMMENTS
WITH THOSE TO THOSE OF MEMBERS
OF THE COALITION. THE REASON I
AM HERE IS I NEED CHILDCARE,
ESPECIALLY BEFORE AND AFTER
CARE. OKAY I REALLY WANT TO WORK
FULL TIME JOB, BUT I WANT
CHILDCARE. WE UNDERSTAND THE
FISCAL OUTLOOK, A BUDGET IS A
STATEMENT OF VALUES, AND WE
BELIEVE CHILDREN, FAMILIES AND
THOSE WHO CARE IN CHILDREN
SHOULD BE AMONG OUR HIGHEST
PRIORITIES. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. HI. MY NAME IS APRIL
FROM PARENT VOICES SAN
FRANCISCO. WELL, MY DAUGHTER
NEED CHILD CARE. I WAS PLACED ON
THE WAITING LIST ALONG WITH THE
2 MILLION OTHER CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA. I HOPED, AND I PRAY
TO BE CALLED, BUT UNFORTUNATELY
I WAS NEVER CALLED. THIS LEFT ME
WITH A DECISION OF PUTTING MY
EDUCATION ON HOLD OR TO STRUGGLE
AND FIND ALTERNATIVE CARE, WHICH
OFTEN LEFT ME WITH NO CHOICES,
WITH LOW QUALITY AND SAFETY FOR
MY CHILD. TOGETHER WE CAN CREATE
A FUTURE WHERE NO PARENT HAS TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN CARING FOR THEIR
CHILD OR PURSUING THEIR DREAMS.
THANKS SO MUCH. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. MY NAME
IS MARIA JANDRIS. I AM ALSO WITH
PARENT VOICES SAN FRANCISCO AND
I WANT TO ALIGN AND, WITH THE EC
COMMENTS, BUT ALSO TELL YOU THAT
DUE TO CHILD CARE, I WAS ABLE TO
GO TO SCHOOL, GRADUATE NOW, ABLE
TO WORK, PROVIDE FOR MY FAMILY,
AND ALSO BE ABLE TO GIVE BACK TO
MY COMMUNITY. CHILD CARE IS
ESSENTIAL. IT'S A PRIORITY.
THAT'S WHY WE ARE HERE TODAY
WITH OUR KIDS, BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE IN THE CHILDREN ARE THE
FUTURE FOR THIS COUNTRY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS CORONA. I'M AN ENGINEER
FATHER AND I WANNA TALK TO YOU
ABOUT THE PRESSING ISSUE. TODAY
AFFECTS US, EVERYBODY. AS A
2,022% OF CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN
ELIGIBLE FOR SUBSIDIZED CHILD
CARE ARE ENROLLED, AND THE RATE
HAS UNFORTUNATELY DECLINED OVER
THE PREVIOUS YEARS, WHERE IT WAS
HIGHER AND THIS IS AN ALARMING
RATE. AND I WANT TO BRING IT TO
YOUR ATTENTION THAT, TODAY WE
SEND THAT, YOU KNOW, THE BUDGET
IS IMPORTANT AND YOU GUYS SHOULD
SUPPORT CHILD CARE. AND THANK
YOU MUCH. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS ELVIA
MCKINLEY. AND I JUST WANT TO SAY
CHILD CARE HAS BEEN A SAVIOR FOR
ME AND MY FAMILY. I HAVE TWO
JOBS. I GET UP AT 3:00 IN THE
MORNING TO GO TO WORK FOR MY
FAMILY, AND IT JUST SAVED Ã. IT
JUST SAVED OUR LIFE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU
DO HAVE TO FOLLOW THAT. KIM
LEWIS, REPRESENTING ASPIRANT.
AND WE SERVE 35 DIFFERENT
COUNTIES. AND I JUST WANT TO
NOTE THAT WE URGE REJECTION OF
THE FIRST CUTS AND THE SOCIAL
HOUSING SUPPLEMENT, WE'VE
SUBMITTED EXTENSIVE COMMENTS ON
THE PROPOSED RATE STRUCTURE FOR
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM. AND WE
KNOW THAT IT'S A GREAT START FOR
THIS, AND WE KNOW THAT WE NEED
THE SYSTEM TO ADDRESS HISTORIC
INEQUITIES IN IT AND BRING DCS,
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM, TO
THE TABLE. AND WE KNOW THAT YOUR
HOUSING FUND WOULD BE A GREAT
WAY THAT WE CAN ENSURE THAT
HOUSING IS CREATED FOR YOUTH,
AND THEY CAN UTILIZE THE
VOUCHERS THAT THEY HAVE. AND ON
BEHALF OF THE YMCA OF SAN DIEGO,
THEY ALIGN THEIR COMMENTS WITH
THE COALITION TO THANK THANK YOU
. HI, EMERALD EVANS WITH GRACE
AND CHILD POVERTY, CALIFORNIA.
FIRST, I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR BOLDNESS AND YOUR YOUR
FIERCE LEADERSHIP IN ADDRESSING
THESE PROPOSED CUTS, THESE VERY
DISAPPOINTING PROPOSED CUTS, WE
WANT TO STRONGLY OPPOSE PARDON
ME, OPPOSE THE PROPOSED CUTS TO
ALL FIVE CHILD WELFARE PROGRAMS
DOMINATING THE AGENDA TODAY. AND
WE WOULD LIKE TO ALSO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THE COALITION.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. THE PEOPLE
TALK REALLY FAST. WE'RE DOING
GREAT. YEAH. HI. MY NAME IS
TANYA MCMILLAN, AND I AM THE
WOMAN WHO SHAKES THINGS UP AT
BLACK CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION. AND WE
STAND IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE S¼
COALITION. I AM BLACK AND I AM A
PROUD EARLY EDUCATOR. I STAND
HERE AS PROOF OF THE ROLES THAT
OUR ANCESTORS DIED FOR, COUNTED
ON, AND DREAMED OF. I REALIZED
THAT I WOULD PROBABLY BE BE THE
ONLY BLACK EARLY EDUCATOR THAT
ANY CHILD WILL SEE AS THEY START
THROUGH SCHOOL. SO I AM THE
PROMISE TO ALL BLACK CHILDREN
THAT IF THEY CAN SEE IT, THEY
CAN BE IT. AND WHERE IS THE $464
MILLION THAT IS MENTIONED IN
PROP 64? THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. GOOD. WE'LL GET AN ANSWER
FOR YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME
IS GINA JACKSON. I'M HERE TO
UPLIFT THE LEGACY OF MY
CAREGIVERS. ANCESTORS ENSLAVED
BLACK WOMEN WHO WERE FORCED TO
CARE FOR THEIR ENSLAVERS
CHILDREN. MY GREAT GRANDMOTHER,
S¼, WHO TRAVELED FAMILY TO
FAMILY TO CARE FOR ALL CHILDREN
IN NEED. MY GRANDMOTHER, WHO
ALWAYS MADE US FEEL SAFE AND
LOVED IN HER CARE. MY MOTHER
MOZELLA, AND AUNT BERNICE, WHO
FOSTERED THEIR YOUNG SIBLINGS
AFTER THE PASSING OF MY
GRANDMOTHER. ONE THING THAT YOU
NEED TO KNOW ABOUT ME I AM A
PROUD BLACK CHILD CARE PROVIDER.
I'M A MOTHER, GRANDMOTHER, AUNT,
RESOURCE MOM AND I'M THE BIGGEST
FAN OF THE PHRASE UNCONDITIONAL
LOVE. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MONIQUE RAMOS. ON BEHALF OF THE
EC COALITION, WE WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO THANK YOU ALL IN THIS
COMMITTEE FOR BEING CHAMPIONS
FOR CHILDREN AND FAMILY, BECAUSE
WE KNOW THIS IS HARD AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE TIME YOU
SPEND ON THIS. WE'D LIKE TO
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH THE
PARENTS AND PROVIDERS WHO SPOKE
TODAY. THE EC SYSTEM THAT YOU
HEARD NEEDS, SPACES, NEEDS TO
ENSURE WE DON'T HAVE A CUT NEXT
YEAR. IT NEEDS THE ALTERNATIVE
METHODOLOGY ADOPTED NEXT YEAR
ALONG WITH THE TIMELINE FOR
IMPLEMENTATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. HI, JUSTIN GARRETT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES. WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE
CUTS TO FORS AND THE HOUSING THE
HOUSING SUPPLEMENT. THESE
PROVIDE ESSENTIAL SERVICES FOR
FOSTER YOUTH AND WE URGE YOU TO
PRESERVE THESE PROGRAMS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HI. AMANDA
MILLER MCKINNEY WITH CHILDREN.
NOW I WANT TO FIRST THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND YOUR
COURAGE TODAY, SUPPORTING
CHILDREN, YOUTH AND FAMILIES AND
WANT TO SAY THAT WE ARE OPPOSED
TO ALL OF THE CHILD WELFARE
BUDGET CUTS AND ASK THAT THE
COMMITTEE ALSO OPPOSE THOSE AS
WELL. THANK YOU. THANKS CHAIR
AND MEMBERS KATHY MOSSBERG WITH
THE FIRST FIVE ASSOCIATION. I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THIS
HEARING. WANT TO UPLIFT,
OBVIOUSLY UPLIFTING ALL THE
VOICES OF THE PARENTS AND
CHILDREN AND REALLY SUPPORT
CHILD CARE AND ALL THE COMMENTS
MADE BY THE FOLKS. THANKS HI.
MICHAEL WILLIAMS, REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY RESOURCE
ASSOCIATION AND PREVENT CHILD
ABUSE CALIFORNIA TO THANK THIS
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND
SENATOR MENGIBAR FOR YOUR
PASSIONATE LEADERSHIP IN
OPPOSING THE CUTS TO THE SILK
PROGRAM AS WELL AS THE FIRST
PROGRAM. AND I WANT TO ADD A
PERSONAL NOTE. AS A FOSTER
PARENT, I WENT THROUGH THE SAME
SITUATIONS THAT MR. CENTER DID
PRIOR TO PREFERS, AND IT DID
INVOLVE EMERGENCY SERVICES. AND
IN, YOU KNOW, OUT OF HOME MENTAL
HEALTH. AND IT DIDN'T NEED TO.
SO URGE YOU TO, OPPOSE THOSE
CUTS. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
ERIC PETERSON FROM BANANAS.
WE'RE A CHILD CARE RESOURCE AND
REFERRAL AND HELP PAY PARENTS
SUBSIDIES, SO I'M JUST HERE TO
SUPPORT. I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF
THE RATE AND QUALITY WORK GROUP.
AND SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE GET THOSE THINGS PUSHED
THROUGH ON TIME. WE'D HATE TO
SEE OUR PROVIDERS BACKSLIDE ON
THEIR RATES. WE'RE ALREADY
LOSING A LOT OF PROVIDERS. AND
ALSO THE CENTER BASED CUTS. WE
NEED TO MAKE THOSE EASIER TO GET
THOSE SLOTS OPEN. WE HAVE 2
MILLION PEOPLE WAITING AND OUR
AGENCY IS EAGER TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN ENROLL MORE PARENTS
IN OUR SUBSIDIES. SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANKS GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS GLORIA
JACKSON, AND I'M A PROUD BLACK
FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDER AND A
MEMBER OF THE BLACK SEA. I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT I WANT YOU TO
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN THE INCOME
RATES, EQUITABLE INCOME RATES
FOR FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS,
AND ALSO TO OPEN UP MORE SPACES
FOR PARENTS TO RECEIVE SERVICES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. I'M MICHELLE BLAKEY
WITH ESPERANZA FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCY, AND I'M HERE JUST TO
SERVE AS A REMINDER OF THE
NECESSARY NECESSITY FOR THE
CONTINUED OF THE BRIDGE FUNDING
IN ORDER TO SUBMIT, TO BE ABLE
TO CONTINUE WITH OUR
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS, AS THE
REFORM WILL NOT PROVIDE ANY
ADDITIONAL FUNDING UNTIL THE
2627 BUDGET. THANK YOU. FUNDING
FOR THE FOSTER CARE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS WENDY WANG, REPRESENTING
SYCAMORES AND AS AN OPERATOR OF
AN SDCP AND FFA. SYCAMORES
BELIEVES THAT THE PERMANENT STOP
RATE AND SUPERVISION RATE MUST
COVER THE TOTAL COST OF HIRING,
TRAINING AND PAYING STAFF
COMPETITIVE WAGES. AN ANNUAL
ADJUSTMENT BASED ON THE CNI MUST
BE APPLIED TO THE TOTALITY OF
THE COMPONENTS THAT GO INTO THE
OPERATIONS OF A HIGH QUALITY
RESIDENTIAL INTERVENTION,
INCLUDING THE ADMINISTRATIVE
COMPONENT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. VICTORIA KELLY WITH
REDWOOD COMMUNITY SERVICES
SERVING RURAL NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. WE OPPOSE THE CUTS
TO FERS PROGRAMS. WE URGE
SUPPORT FOR THE FFA BRIDGE
FUNDING, ALTHOUGH WE DO SUPPORT
THE RATE PROPOSAL FOR FFA, WE
HAVE CONCERNS REGARDING THE
PROPOSAL'S IMPACTS ON STRIPS.
MANY STOP PROVIDERS HAVE ALREADY
CLOSED THEIR DOORS AND MANY FACE
CLOSING. WITH THIS PROPOSAL, WE
SERVE AS AN INTEGRAL COMPONENT
TO THE SYSTEM SAFETY NET AND OUR
STATE'S YOUTH WITH THE MOST
COMPLEX NEEDS, AND WE HOPE TO
WORK TOWARD A PROPOSAL THAT
SUPPORTS FAMILIES AS WELL AS
PROVIDERS, TO SERVE THE CHILDREN
AND YOUTH IN PROGRAMS THAT MEET
THEIR NEEDS. FROM KINSHIP HOMES
TO TWO STRIPS. AS WE ARE ALL
ESSENTIAL TO THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE FOR. HELLO. POORVA
BHATTACHARJEE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES, WE REPRESENT
165 DIFFERENT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDING SERVICES
TO FOSTER YOUTH. WE SPOKE
EARLIER ON ISSUE TWO REGARDING
CDS PERMANENT RATES PROPOSAL. WE
WANT TO ECHO THAT THERE SHOULD
NOT BE AN 8.8% CUT TO FHFA'S, IN
ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT PHA'S
ARE ABLE TO BE A PART OF THE
CONTINUING CARE REFORM IN 2026,
WE ALSO OPPOSE THE CUTS TO FERS
AND SOAPS WITH 5000 CALLS PER
YEAR FOR FERS. WE ARE WORRIED
THAT THE HOTLINES THAT CURRENTLY
EXIST WILL BE OVERLOADED. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. KARINA
LEGAULT, STAFF ATTORNEY WITH THE
CHILD CARE LAW CENTER.
CALIFORNIA LAWMAKERS UPHOLD THE
LEGACY OF RACISM OF ENSLAVED
BLACK WOMEN BY PAYING CHILDCARE
PROVIDERS POVERTY WAGES. WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO IMPLEMENT AND
FUND RATE REFORM AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. IT'S THE FIRST
CRITICAL STEP TO PAYING
PROVIDERS FAIRLY. ADDITIONALLY,
WE ASK THAT THE LEGISLATURE
ENSURE THE 20,000 SPACES,
200,000 SPACES GO OUT IN TIME
FOR THE 2627 TIMELINE TO ENSURE
THAT ALL FAMILIES GET CARE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
RAQUEL YOFFIE ON BEHALF OF
THRIVING FAMILIES, CALIFORNIA.
FIRST OFF, WE'D LIKE TO ALIGN
OUR COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF THE
Â COALITION. ADDITIONALLY, I
WOULD LIKE TO UNDERSCORE THE
NEED TO HAVE A PLAN BY SEPTEMBER
30TH, 2024 FOR CALIFORNIA TO
KEEP 700 MILLION IN FEDERAL
DOLLARS SET TO BE RETURNED.
ADDITIONALLY, IT'S CRITICAL THAT
WE PRIORITIZE BETTER
IMPLEMENTATION AND COORDINATION
OF THE FOSTER CARE BRIDGE
PROGRAM. FINALLY WE ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORT BOTH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS EQUALLY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HELLO,
MACKENZIE RICHARDSON WITH READY
NATION CALIFORNIA READY NATION
CHILDREN NOW AND THE CALIFORNIA
CHILD CARE RESOURCE AND REFERRAL
NETWORK ALL ALIGN THEIR COMMENTS
WITH THE COALITION. READY
NATION'S NEW REPORT FINDS THAT
THE LACK OF RELIABLE CHILD CARE
FOR WORKING PARENTS OF YOUNG
CHILDREN UNDER AGE THREE COST
CALIFORNIA $17 BILLION A YEAR IN
LOST EARNINGS PRODUCTIVITY AND
REVENUE A FAILURE, A FAILURE TO
STRENGTHEN THE FRAGILE CHILD
CARE INFRASTRUCTURE WILL LEAD TO
MORE AND MORE ECONOMIC DAMAGE
FOR EMPLOYERS, WORKERS AND
TAXPAYERS. WE NEED RATE REFORM.
WE NEED SPACES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. ANDREW
AVILA OF EARLY AGE CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU, CHAIRMAN JABBAR, FOR
YOUR DEDICATION TO EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE. WE WANT. WE
ARE PROUD MEMBERS OF THE BUDGET
COALITION, AND WE WANT TO UPLIFT
THE PRIORITIES OF AWARDING AND
DISTRIBUTING THE SLOTS THAT WERE
IN THE 23 TO 24 BUDGET BY JUNE
20TH. JUNE 30TH, 2024, AND TO
ALSO, DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT THE
ALTERNATIVE RATE, STRUCTURE. BUT
BY JUNE 30TH, 2024, WE KNOW THAT
IT'S A REALLY HARD BUDGET YEAR,
BUT WE WANT TO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK
YOU FOR ALL YOU DO TO SUPPORT
OUR CHILDREN AND FAMILIES. MY
NAME IS GLORIA SANTOYO AND I
WORK FOR MARYVILLE. WE SERVE
APPROXIMATELY 300 CHILDREN
THROUGHOUT THE SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY. I'M HERE TODAY WITH
EVERY CHILD CALIFORNIA AND SEIU
VOICES AT MARYVILLE. I WORK IN
THE ELIGIBILITY DEPARTMENT
CERTIFYING FAMILIES FOR CARE.
THE DOCUMENTATION REQUIRED TO
DETERMINE NEED AND ELIGIBILITY
IS EXTENSIVE AND COSTLY. OUR
CURRENT REIMBURSEMENT RATE DOES
NOT COVER THE TRUE COST. THE
TRUE COST OF CERTIFYING
FAMILIES. I'M ASKING THAT YOU
PROVIDE AN ACTUAL COST OF CARE
REIMBURSEMENT. THANK YOU. THANKS
GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS KEN
HERRON. WE OPERATE FOUR
PRESCHOOL CENTERS IN SELMA,
CHAIRMAN ALVAREZ AND JACKSON
YESTERDAY WERE VERY SKEPTICAL OF
THE TIMELINE OF THE COST OF CARE
IMPLEMENTATION. JACKSON DOCTOR
JACKSON WANTED TO HOLD A MEETING
IN JULY TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS,
AND I HOPE THAT YOU WILL STAY
CONNECTED AS OVER THE NEXT THREE
MONTHS, BECAUSE IT'S CRITICAL
THAT WE GET THIS RIGHT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HELLO, CHAIRMAN
JABBAR AND MEMBERS, MY NAME IS
ANNIE SUDAN. I'M WITH FIRST FIVE
LÀ AND WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE EQ COALITION. WE ALIGN WITH
OUR COMMENTS, AS YOU HEARD
EARLIER, ONLY 11% OF ELIGIBLE
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
ACCESS TO EQ PROGRAMS IN CLOSE
TO 2 MILLION ARE WAITING TO
RECEIVE CARE. SO WE THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOU DO, AND WE HOPE THAT
YOU PRIORITIZE THEM IN THE
BUDGET. THANKS. THANKS GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR. AND
SENATOR ROTH, KELLY O'BRIEN WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. WE ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
MANY OTHERS IN OPPOSITION TO THE
PROPOSED CHILD WELFARE BUDGET
CUTS, IN PARTICULAR, THE CUTS TO
THE FIRST PROGRAM. THANK YOU.
ARE YOU NEW? I DON'T THINK I'VE
EVER SEEN YOU. I'M NEW. IT'S MY
FIRST TIME. WELCOME IT'S NOT SO
FUN HERE. ALL RIGHT. GOOD
EVENING. MY NAME IS ELIANA PENA.
I'M IN ITS NÓ THREE NØ, MY NAME
IS ELIANA PENA. AND I'M FROM LOS
ANGELES CHAPTER OF CALIFORNIA
YOUTH CONNECTION, A YOUTH LED
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS TO
TRANSFORM THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
AND INTERSECTING SYSTEMS. I'M
HERE TODAY TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR THE PROPOSED RATES
INTRODUCED BY BY DSS BECAUSE OF
ITS COMMITMENT TO FOSTER YOUTH
FROM PERSONAL EXPERIENCE DUE TO
LACK OF AVAILABILITY,
AVAILABILITY OF ENRICHMENT
ACTIVITIES. I DIDN'T HAVE
HEALTHY OUTLETS, RESULTING IN
DANGEROUS BEHAVIORS SUCH AS
FIGHTING, WHICH LED ME TO BE
DETAINED BY LOS ANGELES POLICE
DEPARTMENT, MULTIPLE TIMES BY
JUST THE AGE OF NINE YEARS OLD,
THIS NEW RATE PROPOSAL WOULD
HAVE ALLOWED ME TO UTILIZE THE
STRENGTH BUILDING AND
MAINTENANCE DOLLARS TO
PARTICIPATE IN ENRICHMENT
ACTIVITIES AS A HEALTHY OUTLET.
THIS RATE PROPOSAL IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BETTER SUPPORT
THE NEEDS OF FOSTER YOUTH. SO
SORRY TO CUT YOU OFF, BUT THANK
YOU. I JUST HAVE ONE MORE THING.
LASTLY, I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
MENTION THAT CIC ALSO STANDS
WITH ALL CUTS TO FOSTER CARE,
INCLUDING CUTS TO FIRST. SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH. SUPPLEMENTS
AND H AND MP FUNDS. THANK YOU
FOR THE TIME. AWESOME. HELLO,
CHAIR. AND BOARD, MY NAME IS
CLARISSA PENA. MY PRONOUNS ARE
SHE HER SORRY HERS. AND I AM THE
STATEWIDE MEMBERSHIP CO-CHAIR AT
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION,
TODAY I COME TO YOU ALL IN
SUPPORT OF THE RATE PROPOSAL AS
HEARD UNDER ISSUE TWO. THIS
CRUCIAL OR THESE CRUCIAL
PROPOSAL OR THIS CRUCIAL
PROPOSAL WOULD PROVIDE YOUNG
PEOPLE IN FOSTER CARE WITH
ACCESS TO VITAL ENRICHMENT
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS ACTIVITIES
THAT EMPOWER THEM, TO EMPOWER
THEM TO EXPLORE THEIR PASSIONS,
DEVELOP THEIR TALENTS, AND BUILD
CRITICAL LIFE SKILLS. BY
INVESTING IN OUR YOUTH'S
WELL-BEING AND DEVELOPMENT, WE
ARE GIVING THEM THE TOOLS THEY
NEED TO THRIVE AND SUCCEED. LET
US RECOGNIZE THE POSITIVE IMPACT
THAT THESE FUNDS WOULD BRING TO
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE. THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HELLO.
HELLO MY NAME IS EZEKIEL AND I
WAS IN KING GAP, AND, AT THE AGE
OF 16, I HAD A REALLY BAD,
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS TO DUE TO
UNRESOLVED TRAUMA. MY SYMPTOMS
RANGE FOR FROM SEIZURE LIKE
ATTACKS TO NONVERBAL NESS. AND I
WAS PUT I WAS HOSPITALIZED
BECAUSE I WENT TO SCHOOL WITH
THOSE SYMPTOMS. AND, WHILE I WAS
HOSPITALIZED, THERE WAS THIS,
LIKE, CONVERSATION OF I SHOULD
BE IN CONGREGATE CARE. BUT
BECAUSE ME AND MY SISTER TRIED
TO HAVE VERY EXTREME LIKE, WE
TRIED SO MUCH TO STAY TOGETHER,
BUT BUT, LIKE, AS I WAS GOING
BACK TO SCHOOL, THEY REJECTED ME
AND MY NEEDS BECAUSE I WAS LIKE,
HIGH NEEDS. AND SO, SHE HAD TO
PAY OUT OF POCKET FOR MY HOME
SCHOOLING. SHE HAD TO PAY OUT OF
POCKET FOR, LIKE, SOME OTHER
THINGS. AND EVENTUALLY THERE WAS
RESENTMENT AND OUR RELATIONSHIP
DETERIORATED AND I RAN AWAY, AT
THE, AT THE WHEN I GRADUATED AND
WENT HOMELESS AS A NON-MINOR
DEPENDENT. ALL THESE GAPS IN MY
LIFE, HAPPENED UNDER THE CURRENT
RATE STRUCTURE. I'M HERE
EXPRESSING IN MY SUPPORT FOR THE
NEW PROPOSED PLAN. THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS JESSICA FUENTES, AND I'M
REPRESENTING THE ALAMEDA CHAPTER
OF CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION,
AN ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
EMPOWERING YOUTH AND IMPROVING
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM AND ITS
INTERCONNECTED SYSTEMS.
REFLECTING ON MY OWN EXPERIENCE
IN FOSTER CARE, I UNDERSTAND
THAT IT'S CRUCIAL IMPORTANCE OF
ACCESS TO SUPPORT SERVICES. HAD
INITIATIVES LIKE THE RATES
PROPOSAL BEEN AVAILABLE DURING
MY TIME IN CARE, THEY WOULD HAVE
PROVIDED INVALUABLE RESOURCES TO
ENSURE A SMOOTHER TRANSITION
INTO ADULTHOOD. THE RATE
PROPOSAL STANDS AS A TESTAMENT
TO SIX YEARS OF ADVOCACY EFFORTS
THAT PRIORITIZE ESCALATION OF
FUNDS TOWARDS ENHANCING THE
WELL-BEING OF YOUTH AND
FACILITATING THEIR PURSUITS OF
PERSONAL INTEREST. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND WE ALSO STAND
AGAINST THE PROPOSED CUTS FOR
SILK. THANKS. HELLO, NANCY
WYATT, I'M A LICENSED FAMILY
CHILD CARE PROVIDER IN THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY. Ó AWESOME.
NAZARIAN I'M A BLOCK AWAY FROM
YOUR DISTRICT AND I LOVE YOU.
AND ANYWAY, I'M WITH PUBLIC
POLICY CHAIR FOR CALIFORNIA
FAMILY CHILD CARE NETWORK, AND
WE HAVE SEVERAL FAMILY CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS HERE THAT ARE
COMING TO SUPPORT THE S¼
COALITION. ASKED AND WE ALSO
WANT TO BE ABLE TO SERVE ALL
THESE CHILDREN NUTRITIOUS FOOD.
SO THE FOOD WITH CARE HELP US
GIVE THEM THE BEST. AND I DO
PUBLIC POLICY CALLS WITH
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF
PROVIDERS EVERY MONTH, AND WE'RE
GOING UNDER. IT'S A CRISIS. WE
CAN'T WAIT, WE CAN'T WAIT.
PLEASE DON'T LET ME GET PAID
LESS. IN JUNE. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR. AND
SENATOR AND COMMITTEE MEMBER. MY
NAME IS BENU CHHABRA. I'M A
FAMILY CHILD CARE EDUCATOR IN
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY FOR 24
YEARS, IN THE FIELD FOR 35
YEARS. I'M ALSO A PROUD MEMBER
OF COALITION. MY ASK IS, PLEASE.
PLEASE, YOU KNOW, AS YOU KNOW,
THE CHILD CARE IS ESSENTIAL. WE
ARE THE WORKFORCE BEHIND THE
WORKFORCE, AND WE CANNOT ASK OUR
PARENTS WHO ARE ALREADY, YOU
KNOW, ON THE LOWER INCOME AND WE
NEED WE'RE HAVING LIKE HARD TIME
FINDING EMPLOYEES. SO WE NEED
PEOPLE WHO CAN, LIKE, HELP US,
YOU KNOW, SO WE CAN HAVE MORE
CHILDREN IN OUR CARE WHO ARE
STILL ON THE WAITING LIST. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS JAMIL. I'M A FAMILY
CHILD CARE PROVIDER IN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY. I'M WITH THE
COALITION AND I'M HERE TO ASK
YOU TO SUPPORT, SUBSIDIZE
PROVIDER PLUS FAMILY, CHILD
CARE, PRIVATE PAY, FAMILY CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS. WE ARE UNDER THE
RUG AND WE'RE REALLY SACRIFICE A
LOT TO SERVE THE CHILDREN. AND
THOSE CHILDREN GOING TO BE ONE
DAY IN YOUR CHAIR. HOPEFULLY YOU
KNOW, SO PLEASE HELP US. YOU
KNOW, CHILD CARE IS IN CRISIS. A
LOT OF PROVIDERS ARE GOING ON
OUT OF BUSINESS. WE ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORK WITH YOU GUYS
AND THANK YOU IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS NGUYEN Kò.
I'M A FAMILY LICENSE PROVIDER.
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE
ESCALATION. WE NEED MORE MONEY
SO WE CAN PAY FOR OUR
ASSISTANCE, AND WE'LL BE ABLE TO
SERVE THE LEADERS OF TOMORROW.
WE GIVE THEM THE BEST CARE.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIRMAN JABBAR. AND COMMITTEE,
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIRMAN JABBAR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME
IS RABAB SABE, AND I'M A
LICENSED FAMILY CHILD CARE. I'M
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA FAMILY
CHILD CARE NETWORK. I AM ALSO I
WANT TO ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH
THOSE OF MEMBERS OF THE
COALITION. I WANT TO JUST SHARE
THAT WE ALL HAVE THE SAME
STRUGGLE FINDING ASSISTANCE TO
SERVE BEST QUALITY CHILD CARE
FOR KIDS. WE GIVE SO MUCH LOVE.
WE GET SO MUCH LOVE. BUT WE NEED
MONEY TO KEEP GOING AND
SURVIVING. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF. IT MIGHT
BE THE MAGIC TOUCH. I THINK
THAT'S WHERE WE NEED. YEAH,
KELLY BROOKS, ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA,
THE RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE BOARDS OF
SUPERVISORS OF RIVERSIDE, SANTA
CRUZ AND VENTURA, ALL IN
OPPOSITION TO THE CHILD WELFARE
CUTS. YOUR PANEL DID SUCH AN
EXCELLENT JOB. THERE'S NOTHING
TO ADD TO THAT. AND THEN ALSO,
ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OF SANTA CLARA
COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF THE CAL SAU
GUARANTEED INCOME PROGRAM TO
ASSIST UNHOUSED HIGH SCHOOL
SENIORS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HI. GOOD AFTERNOON, JACKIE RUTH
HEIZER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CAREGIVERS. REALLY
QUICKLY, I JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL SO MUCH, BUT I WANT TO
DO A SHOUT OUT TO THE DEPARTMENT
. IT'S INCREDIBLE. THIS PROPOSAL
IS EXCEPTIONAL. IT'S WHAT WE'VE
ASKED FOR YEARS AND YEARS. AND I
WANT TO GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION FOR
FIGHTING FOR EXTRACURRICULAR
ACTIVITIES FOR YEARS AND YEARS
AND NEVER GIVING UP. SO
CONGRATULATIONS. IT'S FINALLY
HAPPENING. I ALSO DO OPPOSE THE
CUTS TO FURS AND SILKS AND THE
CHILD WELFARE CUTS OVERALL, BUT
I JUST WANT TO SAY WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE NEW RATE PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HI, MY
NAME IS ASHLEY LARKIN. I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF TRANSITIONAL
CHILDREN'S SERVICES AT FFA. I AM
A SOCIAL WORKER AND I AM HERE TO
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND THE FFA
BRIDGE FUNDING. WE DO A WE
PROVIDE A LOT OF SUPPORT TO
YOUTH AND FAMILIES, AND WE WOULD
LOVE TO JUST MAKE SURE WE CAN
CONTINUE GIVING THE CAREGIVERS
THE SUPPORT THEY NEED SO THAT WE
CAN RETAIN THEIR PLACEMENTS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS GABRIELA
BATTIATO. I'M THE EDUCATION
COORDINATOR AT THE CHILDCARE
CENTER. I'M REPRESENTING S¼
VOICES AND EVERY CHILD
CALIFORNIA, SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE
NEEDS HELP. WE'RE ASKING FOR
HIGHER PAYMENTS BASED ON REAL
COST. ONE RATE FOR ALL,
SIMPLIFIED SIGN UPS. HELPING
KIDS WITH SPECIAL NEEDS AND FAIR
WAGES FOR EDUCATORS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
MENGIBAR AND MR. RICHARD ROTH.
MY NAME IS SABRINA ABONG. I AM
HERE WITH THINK OF US AND I AM
HERE IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE NUMBER
TWO AND SUPPORTING FOSTER YOUTH
WITH ENRICHMENT ACTIVITIES
INSTEAD OF DOING THERAPY OR
BEING PUT ON MEDICATION INSTEAD.
I COULD HAVE DONE VOLLEYBALL OR
BADMINTON, WHICH IS WHAT I
ENJOY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RICHARD. GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I'M CONNIE
DOHERTY WITH THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF CHILDREN
AND FAMILY SERVICES,
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. I'D
LIKE TO SPEAK ABOUT ITEM ONE
CHILD WELFARE CUTS, I JUST
WANTED TO SHARE A BRIEF STORY
ABOUT A YOUNG LADY, A 13 YEAR
OLD, WHO I MET WHEN I WAS A
SOCIAL WORKER WORKING ALONGSIDE
MR. SKYDANCER, WHO YOU MET THIS
MORNING ON THE PANEL,
UNFORTUNATELY, FIRS DID NOT
EXIST WHEN I WAS A SOCIAL WORKER
AND THIS YOUNG LADY HAD TO SPEND
HER 13TH BIRTHDAY IN SHELTER
CARE IN A COLD HOSPITAL, NOT
WITH HER FAMILY, FIRS EXISTS
NOW, AND IT WORKS. THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW, IT WORKS. SO I URGE
YOU TO CONTINUE FUNDING IT AS
WELL AS MILK AND HOUSING
NAVIGATORS. THANK YOU. HELLO,
YOU. HI. GOOD AFTERNOON, YVONNE
PEREZ WITH CHILD CARE RESOURCE
CENTER. I WANT TO ALIGN MY
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF MEMBERS
OF THE EC COALITION, FAMILIES
AND CHILD CARE PROVIDERS ARE
STRUGGLING CHILDREN, FAMILIES
AND THOSE WHO CARE FOR CHILDREN
SHOULD BE AMONG OUR HIGHEST
PRIORITIES. AND THEY NEED OUR
HELP NOW. THANK YOU. CONGRATS.
THANK YOU. HI GOOD AFTERNOON,
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS BETH
MALINOWSKI, THE SEIU CALIFORNIA
WON'T ALIGN MYSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS MADE BY OUR COLLEAGUES
AT CHILDREN'S NOW AND WWDA AND
MANY OTHERS WHO ARE CONCERNED BY
THE DEEP CUTS HAPPENING IN CHILD
WELFARE. WE REJECT THOSE CUTS,
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED BY THE
LOSS OF SERVICES TO FIRS AND THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSING PROGRAM. THESE ARE VITAL
PROGRAMS. LASTLY, Dð WANTS TO
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATIONS
HAPPENING AROUND FOSTER RATES.
WE THINK THINGS ARE GOING IN A
PROMISING DIRECTION. LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE THESE
CONVERSATIONS. THANK YOU. HI,
I'M. DON'T TOUCH IT. THANK YOU.
I'M ZACHARIAH KENDA, SENIOR
POLICY ATTORNEY WITH ALLIANCE
FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS, FIRST I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
YOUR PASSION TO THIS COMMITTEE.
A LOT OF US SHARE THAT. I ALSO
FELT THE EMOTION, TODAY DURING
THE MANY OF THE PANEL SPEAKERS,
WE OPPOSE THE CUTS TO THE
SUPPLEMENTAL, SUPPLEMENTAL CUTS
PROGRAM, CUTS AND THEN THE, THE
FIRST PROGRAM ELIMINATION AS
WELL, AND ALSO WE'D LIKE TO WE
SUBMITTED A LOT OF TBL COMMENTS
THAT WE HOPE ARE CONSIDERED OVER
THE SUMMER RECESS, BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT FOR THE RATE
STRUCTURES THAT, WE STILL HAVE
TO WORK THROUGH IN TERMS OF SOME
OF THE DETAILS. SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. PAUL
GARCIA HERE REPRESENTING RANCHO
SAN ANTONIO BOYS HOME AND
STRCPY, LOCATED IN CHATSWORTH,
CALIFORNIA, WITHIN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY, WE ARE AGAINST THE, RATE
CHANGES FOR ISSUE NUMBER TWO,
AND FOR REASONS THAT THE SUCCESS
STORIES OF THE YOUTH THAT HAVE
BEEN, YOU KNOW, HAD SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAMS AT RANCHO SAN ANTONIO,
AND WE NEED MORE MONEY TO, YOU
KNOW, FACILITATE THE SERVICES
FOR THE STAFF. AND I HAVE HERE
91 OF OUR FORMER RESIDENTS AND
CURRENT RESIDENTS IN OUR PROGRAM
TO TALK ABOUT HIS SUCCESS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HELLO. MY NAME
IS NATI JATANA AND I'M HERE TO
SHARE MY SUCCESS DURING MY STAY
AT RANCHO DE ESTÁ. HTTP PROVIDED
ME WITH THERAPY SERVICES TO DEAL
WITH MY ISSUES AND FIND MY
STRENGTHS TO REUNIFY WITH MY
FAMILY AND A HEALTHY WAY. IN
ADDITION TO HELP ME GET THROUGH
A SUCCESSFUL BRAIN SURGERY, I
WAS SUPPORTED THROUGH GRADUATING
THROUGH HIGH SCHOOL AND
ENROLLING IN COLLEGE. I'M HAPPY
TO SAY THAT I WILL BE GRADUATING
WITH THREE ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE
FROM A COMMUNITY COLLEGE, AND I
HAVE BEEN ACCEPTED TO FOUR èC
UNIVERSITIES TO CONTINUE MY
EDUCATION WITH PLAN TO ONE DAY
BECOME A LAWYER TO HELP AND GIVE
BACK TO YOUTH WHO ARE ALSO IN A
SIMILAR SITUATION I WAS ONCE IN.
THANK YOU. I'M SUCCESSFUL TODAY
BECAUSE OF THE SDCP PROGRAM.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. SENATOR ROTH, DYLAN
ELLIOTT, ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTIES OF KERN AND HUMBOLDT
AND OPPOSED TO THE SILK, FURS
AND HOUSING PROGRAM, NAVIGATORS
CUTS. AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
RELENTLESS LEADERSHIP. THANKS
HI. MY NAME IS KATE. I'M WITH
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION AND
OPPOSING THE CUTS TO CHILD
WELFARE AND IN SUPPORT OF THE
RATES PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. HELLO. RICHARD RICHARDSON
DAVIS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AGENCIES HERE TO OPPOSE
THE CUTS TO FORS. AND I ALSO
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
CONVENING AND YOUR VULNERABILITY
TODAY. THANKS HI, I'M AXEL
PIZARRO WITH CALIFORNIA YOUTH
CONNECTION, AND I'M HERE TO
ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT ON THE
RATES PROPOSAL PLAN. I BELIEVE
IT GREATLY BENEFITS FOSTER YOUTH
IN ALL SETTINGS BASED ON THEIR
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS, ALL WHILE
PROMOTING KINSHIP CARE INSTEAD
OF AN AS A TRAP ENVIRONMENT.
BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T NEED IT AND
YOU NEED LIKE THE SERVICES BUT
DON'T NEED TO BE THERE, KINSHIP
IS LIKE THE OPTION. YOU KNOW,
LIKE I WAS RAISED IN KINSHIP. I
REALLY DO LIKE IT. I CAME OUT
GOOD, YOU KNOW, LIKE, YOU KNOW.
SO THAT'S JUST I THINK YOU
SHOULD DEFINITELY SUPPORT IT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MY GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR. YOU
COULD AT THE BOTTOM, TOUCH AT
THE BOTTOM. LIKE THE BOTTOM OF
THE. YES THERE WE GO. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR. AND
SENATOR ROTH, I WANT TO ASK THAT
YOU PRESERVE FIRST FUNDING FOR
YOUTH IN CRISIS. AND
SPECIFICALLY WANT TO SAY THAT
NONE OF THE SERVICES MENTIONED
ARE INTERCHANGEABLE WITH FERS.
THEY'RE VERY DIFFERENT AND DO
NOT SERVE THE LEVEL OF ACUITY
THAT THESE CHILDREN NEED. I ALSO
WANT TO REITERATE OUR SUPPORT
FOR THE PERMANENT FOSTER CARE
RATES PROPOSAL. AND, JUST WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT THAT OVERALL, IT'S
AN EXCEPTIONAL, AN EXCEPTIONAL
PLAN AND WE HOPE THAT WE CAN
WORK OUT SOME OF THE CONCERNS
EITHER IN TBL OR ESPECIALLY
IMPLEMENTATION. THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR, THANK YOU. AKALA. WITH
EVERY CHILD, CALIFORNIA. AND I'M
HERE REPRESENTING 120,000
CHILDREN UNDER THE AGE OF 18 AND
29,000 CHILDREN UNDER THE AGE OF
FIVE IN THE ANTELOPE VALLEY,
WHERE WE HAVE 12.2 SUBSTANTIATED
REFERRALS PER 1000 CHILDREN,
WHICH IS TWICE THE RATE OF THE
L.A. COUNTY, WHERE WE HAVE LOWER
RATES OF SERVICES SUPPORTING
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES IN THE AV
WELFARE SYSTEM. I URGE YOU NOT
TO CUT ANY OF THE PROGRAMS THAT
YOU SHARE THAT WE HEARD ABOUT
TODAY. IN ADDITION, IN THE
ANTELOPE VALLEY, NO ZIP CODE HAS
SUFFICIENT ACCESS TO CHILD CARE,
BOTH CHILD CARE AND, PROGRAMS
LIKE FORS AND SOAP ARE VERY
CRITICAL TO OUR REGION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
HEIDI KAISER REPRESENTED CHILD
ACTION. I ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH
THOSE OF THE COALITION. IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE CONTINUE MOVING
TOWARDS AN ALTERNATIVE RATE
RAPIDLY SO WE CAN ENROLL THE
OVER 4000 FAMILIES WAITING FOR
ACCESS TO CHILD CARE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATOR ROTH.
ROSANNA CARAVAGGIO ELLIOT HERE,
ON BEHALF OF THE EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION CONSORTIUM, I'D LIKE
TO ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH THE
COALITION AND ASK THAT WHEN
WE'RE HAVING DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
THE ALTERNATIVE RATE METHODOLOGY
, THAT ALL PROVIDERS ARE
INCLUDED, NOT JUST THOSE THAT
GET TO BE AT THE BARGAINING
TABLE. THANK YOU. THANKS OKAY.
THAT CONCLUDES BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE ON
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES